this college algebra course is different
than other college algebra courses like
many other ones you will be learning all
the concepts from an experienced
University Professor but in this course
the instructor Ed pratowski will also
show you how to implement all the
concepts in Python this course is for
everybody but especially those
interested in computer science
hello and welcome to the algebra with
python course my name is Ed and I'll be
your guide on this adventure so we're
going to learn about algebra and how to
write python code to do all of your
algebra because there's so many
different things that you can do with
formulas you know you learn these
formulas hey anytime you have a formula
you can write a you can write code to
use it so that's what we're going to do
we're gonna we're gonna write some code
using the Google collab notebook
and that's uh python a Jupiter notebook
essentially in your Google Drive so one
of the next things we'll do is look at
how to set that up and we're going to go
through each unit we're going to look at
the math we're going to look you know in
the actual lessons I'll be writing
things on the board and we'll look at
you know the concepts how to how to do
the math on the board and then we'll
look at then how to write the code to do
this
and you know you'll be able to create
your own codelab notebooks in fact I
hope you do create your own notebook or
two along the way you know building your
own resources that you can use
you can also you know once we set it up
you can also actually download the
codelab the Google codelab app and you
have access to each of these notebooks
on on your phone
so you know you can make your own like
you know super calculator that you have
access to on your phone you know solve
all kinds of things
um you know and that's great you know
what you know
building these resources but also
understanding how to use them so that as
you go further in math and in writing
code and eventually leading up to you
know working in data science that you
really understand these Concepts and you
know how to use all the formulas that
you're creating so that's that's really
that's the idea that's what we want to
do
and
each unit is going to be a lot like this
I'm going to talk about the math you
know we'll do some things on the board
and then we'll we'll flip it and we'll
look at how to do that with code
I'll include all the resources for you
and then in addition to the Core
Concepts in each unit the next thing
then what we'll do is I'll have another
uh video or two of extra working working
through the problems so you know
you know how to write the code you're
building your resources and then we'll
just work through a bunch of extra
problems you know putting this into
practice
and it'll be really great
you know you'll learn algebra you'll
learn code and you'll have all these
skills under your belt that you can use
for a lot of other things and we're
going to build upon these in future
courses so I hope you enjoy okay so
let's look at how to set up Google
collab in your Google Drive so in your
Google Drive hopefully you have it
organized in folders and you know you
have a you'll set up a folder for this
course that way you know you can have
all the documents and notebooks and
everything
there just let just like I have here and
you you will have access to all of these
documents you see you know soon enough
so if we take a look at the little
yellow infinity symbol that's the Google
collab
and
you know if you want to create a new
Google codelab you're in the folder
where you want it to be click on new and
it won't be here and you go to more and
then it'll be down here
so Google code laboratory now if you
don't have it already if you have not
yet set it up then you go down to
connect more apps
and you know it's it's begins with c it
might show up you know here but if not
then you can search you know and look at
this like code lab
even if you just do Co it comes up but
if you type in collab
then
it'll come up
there we go and again mine's already
installed but if if it wasn't you'd see
it there you click on it and this blue
button instead of saying uninstall it
would say install
and then you'd have have it available
and there we go then when you go to New
and then you can go to Google code
laboratory and it loads there you go
so
um as you see I I like the dark theme
for collab so that's just the one that's
just what I picked
um you you know you can
change that
so this little block here this is where
you're going to write the code um you
know it's set up to write a block of
code and in addition to that you have
the ability to add more code or more
text so you see you can add another
block of code you can add more text and
if you click up there it just adds it in
line
and you know if you type text now if I
hit enter that just gives me a new line
I have to click somewhere else to get
out of that
so there you go you can add code or text
by doing that also if you want to notice
this up here if you hover around the
middle you can add code or text and that
works anywhere you see so you can add
you know text right here
um
in between these two
and there we go and that text actually
besides writing text you can actually
use some a few HTML tags to you know
make new line breaks or some things like
that and then if you get really fancy
you can use the latex math notation to
uh display different math formulas but
we'll get to that soon enough all right
so you have all these different things
you can do you know your code your text
and one of the other things you want to
do first like any document give it a
name and you'll notice the familiar
setup compared to other Google Docs you
can there we go
um
uh we'll just call this week one example
all right so
you know give it a name you know you
don't want to leave all your stuff just
Untitled it might be you might forget
and it might be hard to find later and
you can write your code there
uh
whatever you'd like to put in there
print
okay and you know there we go it just
sits there as code until you run it and
you can click this run button or if
you're familiar with the jupyter
notebooks you can hit shift enter
that'll run it also
and
there we go this
this is the output here
notice you can also do a lot of math
right there in the print statement so
if
you just put in math formulas
you see hit enter it just gives you a
new line
run it
you can do all sorts of math formulas
and remember the add subtract multiply
divide that all works that's built in
the um
the exponent
would be
this asterisk two of them
so
there you go so that would be 3 to the
fourth power
and you see it'll it'll do the math
right there
if you wanted to do something like
square root you have to import something
and we'll get to Imports as we go
through a lot of this but notice you can
you know you can have your text you can
have uh do your math for so for a lot of
simple things you can just do that right
in the print statement one of the other
interesting things you can do
is and if I make this
I'll just make that b for a certain
reason then
you have a table of contents here now
this has nothing because I don't have
any headings or sections so that's what
the table of contents looks for if you
click on a new section
then you can I'll just leave it as a new
section and call it good right there
you see it shows up in the table of
contents
and if you double click now this B is
underneath that section so if I click on
this Arrow
it becomes minimized within that section
and then here a
if I want to make this its own section
then
take a look at the section editing if I
double click on it it's that hashtag
that would be normally used for a python
comment but we're but we are in the
comment
it would be normally used for a python
comment but since we're in the text part
then you would just use it to indicate a
new section
so I can go up to here this text and I
can
make it a new section you probably don't
need the space but I like it and again
click somewhere else to get out of that
so now I have a
and I have my new section here
so I can do some different things I can
put some I can put some code here and I
can
in this code I can move it up see the
arrow over there I can move it up and
then maybe I'll make B
double click on this and maybe I'll make
B its own section
I'll click somewhere else
and so I can have all these sections
and now B is its own section that kind
of didn't matter because I don't have
anything underneath of it
um there we go
put text in here click somewhere else
and then I can collapse it so you see I
can have these different sections
collapsed and then they all show up in
the table of contents a new section B
so if if you give them
names More Than A and B it becomes
useful because you can find them in the
table of contents and then you just
click to expand each section in whatever
else and you could have within the
section you can have a code
text you know and as many of those
blocks as you want and that section goes
until you create a new section
so some good useful things you can do in
building your own
Google collab notebooks you might decide
that that you might like that as an
organization as a way to organize them
you know keep them in sections
so that helps also the Google collab
like everything else in the Google drive
it does save automatically but it
doesn't do it as often so
you do have a file and you do have a
save
here and also the normal shortcuts Ctrl
s
or command s
so you that that does work and
that way sometimes you know if it goes a
while in between saving
uh if you try to close it it might
actually prompt you to say that you
might you might need to save it so
that's just something to think about you
know you actually do uh say you do
actually make an effort to save things
here in the Google codelab so we set up
our code
we can do math right there in the print
statement we set up our sections table
of contents and all these sections you
know within the view you can actually
expand or collapse them all at once if
you want you know that's kind of
interesting
and
throw all the code we're going to work
on
you know you also have down here one of
the other things that looks like you
know XML or HTML tags and it's a bunch
of code Snippets
that you can use you know copy and paste
try these right in your right in your
Google collab right here
so
some pretty cool things to explore
and
there there we have it you're going to
be building your Google collab notebooks
um
you might you might want to build one
for algebra and you know just
continually add to it in this in which
case definitely make sections because
that's going to be helpful table of
contents to find what you want
so you could do that you could make a
different notebook you know for each
unit or each week or however you want to
organize it
um but then the idea is You're Building
these resources that you will have
access to and as well as installing it
on the Google Drive
you can also download and install the
app so that'll be useful have it on your
phone that when you first run it you
need to do a few things to go through
um
setting it up you know
um authentication and such but you know
it doesn't take that long
all right so we have this you're going
to be building your stuff in your Google
in your Google code lab and
it's going to be exciting we'll get to a
lot of a lot of interesting things so
yep we'll Let's uh let's get into the
math next
so we can't talk about proportions
without talking about ratios and a ratio
is another word for a fraction so this
two out of four I can write that as well
two out of four but I could say
two-fourths I can call it a fraction but
it's also a ratio and then a proportion
is two equal ratios so if I know that
these are equal then there's other
things I can do with this and one of the
things that works and becomes very
useful is cross multiplying
so if these two are equal ratios then I
can cross multiply multiply the
diagonals I can do 2 times 10 equals 4
times 5.
and that's another way to write this
so then I can get it out of the
proportion mode
and
I can use this to double check or I can
solve for things so 2 times 10 we see 20
equals 20 and then that's true so you
know we confirm that that works we can
always do this if these were other
numbers I can check to see if this
really is true cross multiplying because
if that doesn't work then that wouldn't
be true and
I can also use it if one of these
numbers is unknown so if I have 3 out of
6 equals x out of 4. now there's other
ways to solve this but this is the go-to
way because it works every time so when
I do my cross multiplying
then I can do this 3 times 4 is 12.
equals 6X so there we go 3 times 4 is 12
and then 6 times x is 6X and then I know
that the next step I'm going to do is
going to be dividing by 6.
so then I get that x equals 2.
now in doing that we can jump ahead and
say okay let's I know that when I
multiply this diagonal I can picture
this step it's going to be 6X so the
next thing I'm doing is dividing by 6.
so a lot of times we just put this in
one step so I multiply the diagonal but
I can divide by the other number because
I know that's the next step and then my
answer is X so we can really make use of
this in in writing code I can see the
proportion and I can then just put this
all in one step to solve for x and again
that's it's the go-to way it works every
time so I can write code to then prompt
for these numbers cross multiply and
then and then solve for x one of the
ways this is also useful is some of the
other applications if I have
let's say I'm converting something like
miles to kilometers so if I have you
know one mile
is you know about 1.6 kilometers
then
I can set this up this is the ratio that
I know so as long as I have miles
and then kilometers
then if I know one I can figure out the
other this unknown can be either place
so you know if I have you know two miles
then how many kilometers is that
you see we can make use of this I know
that I'm cross multiplying 2 times 1.6
divided by 1. and then so there we go so
X would be 3.2
and again I'm multiplying the diagonal
that I can 2 times 1.6 dividing by the
other number which in this case it's
convenient that it's 1 so then I can
solve so this is what we're going to use
and we're going to take a look at how to
put this into code and so prompt for
you know these four numbers or three of
them and then figure out the fourth one
so let's take a look at how that will
happen so let's take a look at the code
so we're going to see here how much
easier it is to
write some code to solve some of our
problems and just like proportions we
have that cross multiplying that we know
works every time so I'm going to put
just a display here to remind us that
we're setting up the proportion and
here's what it looks like N1 D1 equals
N2 over D2 so and for numerator D for
denominator and if I have a proportion I
would know one of the ratios so I would
know let's say N1 and D1
and then
N2 or D2 one of those I would not know
but I would know the other one so I have
my comment here in the code
put a zero in for the unknown value
because realistically none of these
values would be zero that would just you
know you wouldn't even need to think
hard about that that zeroes everything
out or if it's in the denominator it's
undefined so that would never occur in
in something that we're really trying to
solve
so I would know N1 and D1 and I would
just change these numbers put in my
numbers that I know and
I'll put a zero in for the one I don't
know and then I'll put two if statements
so I have if N2 equals zero
and there we go notice this the setup of
the if statement in Python if N2 the
double equals because I'm testing it I
have a colon
and then
the indentation afterward is one two
three four spaces
I would hesitate some people use a tab I
would hesitate to not use a tab
they don't often give you the right
number of spaces so indent four spaces
and then
I have the answer is and I'm going to
just do that cross multiplying
so you see D2 times N1 divided by D1
that cross multiplying that we that we
know and then we'll print out the answer
and we'll do the same thing here if it's
D2 that I don't know so my if statement
if D2 equals zero
colon four spaces indent and then this
answer notice the cross multiplying
so D2 is what I don't know so I'd be
doing N2 times D1 divided by N1
and then I'd print out that answer
so there we go and then given these one
over two equals what over 16 and then if
I would run this
and it will output the answer right here
there we go and 2 equals 8.
or if I had this
uh I'll keep this and maybe I'll put
this one to zero
there we go and if we run it there we go
really straightforward we want to get to
this point that we know these we know
these formulas and we can just put
something in here maybe even display
something to set it up and
cross multiply solve any proportion this
way
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
the use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
we're going to work through some extra
problems here
relating to some things that might come
up in working with proportions
ratios and one of the things that comes
up you know we work with mixed numbers
and in math I might write it like this
but then you think how could I do this
in Python and python remember you can
even do math in the print statement so
you could put this as one and two-thirds
becomes one plus two-thirds and you see
two divided by three notice I didn't
even sometimes I use parenthesis extra
parentheses but we really don't python
knows the order of operations so you
could have one plus two-thirds
plus three and four-fifths so it would
be plus three plus four divided by five
and you know you can change it up minus
seven you can put that all in a print
statement there and it would output the
answer now later on
in I think the third unit we're going to
also talk about
converting that output if it was a weird
decimal into a fraction or mixed number
but we'll get to that so you you can do
this but even also at this point you
could if you wanted to instead of print
and you don't need the parentheses but I
I'll just keep them there you could
store them as a variable
so if you had something that you wanted
to store as a variable and then use that
later on
or any one of these you know converted
mixed numbers stored as a variable
because some of these like two-thirds
that will come out as a mixed number or
that or one and two thirds that will
come out as that repeating decimal
well
later on you might want to keep as many
of those decimal places as possible and
storing it as a variable will do that
for you without you having to write down
all the decimals so really that's the
whole thing we're trying to build you
know for all the different times you
might use a calculator hey might as well
use Google collab because you can have
all these formulas in there store
variables and everything so
for all the different times you might
need to work with mixed numbers yeah
print it out store it as a variable and
continue on and work with the rest of
the problem
so if this comes out as a repeating
variable let's let's take a look at one
other thing here
if this comes out so let's just say I
have that uh one and two thirds so we
know the one but if I look at the
two-thirds
you know that would be you know 0.6 and
it keeps repeating
you know it'll keep repeating
if you get output like this how would
you know that that would be two-thirds
well one of the ways you can do this is
we can throw in some other variables
here let's call
let's call this x so X is all these
repeating decimals so
if it repeats each
um each place then I just need to
multiply it by 10.
you see and that keeps going because if
this keeps going and then this keeps
going
then if I subtract them
10x minus 1X
so that would be 9x
equals 6. now notice I did not rewrite
it but I am subtracting this bottom row
minus the top row because then all these
decimal places line up and it would
subtract
so multiplying it by 10 moves it over
now I have six point something and when
I subtract 10x minus 1X is 9x
then that all cancels and
if I
have 9x how do I get to X divide both
sides by 9 so we get 6 over 9 which we
know then mathematically we can reduce
divided by three is two divided by 3 is
3.
and actually this works any single digit
that repeats
is a factor of nine
so if I have
um
if I have anything else and actually I
might use the same
same formula but if I have anything else
like if I have
um point
or
and it's a 4 that keeps repeating
so then 10 times that
would be four point and as many fours as
you want
so then when we subtract
10x minus X is 9x
and then when I subtract this everything
after the decimal subtracts
and so your answer is 4.
and divide by 9
x equals four over nine
now so this works for any number one one
through nine but this is kind of
interesting then
um how
what if you get a 0.9 repeating
because
would that be then nine over nine yes
maybe so if I have 0.9 repeating
and so then 10 times that would be 9
point and as many nines as you want
we'll do the same thing so 9x equals
so you see if this is 0.9 repeating
this still follows 10 times that and
then when we subtract
it all lines up it becomes nine
x equals 9 over 9 which is 1.
so you see some algebra acrobatics how
do I show that 0.99 repeating equals 1.
and these are kind of things that we
want to bring in
um some of the other things that we can
do
you know this works out nicely just
seeing it on the board but later on as
we do different things to convert
decimals to fractions you can see that
it'll work in the code too
but yeah some math acrobatics this is
kind of what we want to be able to do I
want to also sometimes use the code to
show different ways to get to Solutions
and when we see it get to a solution in
different ways it kind of like reproves
hey this works this is the true solution
so these are some of the things that we
can do with proportions and
um
you know some of the other things we'll
do you know we could look at like
converting
um
convert converting uh money like
yeah so if I have you know let's say
um you know one
US dollar is right now I just looked
this up it's 1.29
Canadian dollars
so if I want to convert then I can set
up my ratio and proportion as long as
you know I know one of these so I know
the ratio and then as long as I know one
of these I can figure out the other
and in the code you remember we just add
it whichever one I want to figure out I
put a zero there because either way 0
over anything is zero so that would not
apply here you know the if zero in the
numerator the answer is zero and zero in
the denominator would be undefined you
know you could look up different uh
images of divide by zero online you know
things like going into the abyss and all
kinds of fun things like that but yeah
we don't want to divide by zero so
if I know one of these and neither of
these would be zero that just really
would we we would never arrive at that
situation so you know we saw that that's
why we would put a zero in for the one
we want to know
and there we go as long as we have it
set up you know then I can figure out oh
okay well in that case you know
um how many
I'll put the question mark here since
we're not in the code you know okay if
one US is 1.29 Canadian then what's one
Canadian dollar worth and then you see
cross multiply divide by 1.29 and you'll
get that exchange rate
so that's how we can change it from unit
to this one one U.S
to how many Canadian we can change it to
one Canadian to how many U.S
you know because very often you find
exchange rates and they'll give you it
in One Direction and maybe you want to
find it in the other direction
so these are some things you can use
this for
we can also do things like miles to
kilometers or or whatever
you know other unit conversion you want
but you know if you have one mile
is 1.6 kilometers
um
it's that exactly 1.67 you know there's
like you know another nine meters or
something but
okay and then there we go if I want to
convert then as long as I have miles and
I have
kilometers
then
it'll work out and we looked at how to
put that in the code so now that you
have these tools you can convert
anything as long as you have that ratio
of
one aspect of it then you can
you know plug in one of these two
numbers and figure out the other
so you know here you know some some of
the good things and these are some of
the things we want to do in in the extra
practice section you'll see this come up
in every unit that you know we're going
to get to the core
core skills and those units are going to
build your ongoing
collab notebook so you have some
resources and then we'll have an extra
practice
um extra practice extra problem section
where we then use some of the things
that you've created and let's apply this
and let's solve a bunch of extra
problems
so there we go
um
and we will uh
we'll go on to the next unit
here we're going to look at
four different ways to solve for the
unknown number and in algebra we often
call this x just because X Works nicely
x marks the spot so
if I have I'd put four different
situations here add subtract multiply
divide so I put simple numbers because
you might be able to do this in your
head
to see the answer but the algebra
explanation is you want to see what
you're doing and do the opposite
so then if these two sides are equal
both sides of the equal sign if you do
the same thing to both sides then they
stay equal so that works what am I doing
I want to do the opposite to cancel
things out then the next thing is do the
same thing to both sides of the equal
sign I'm going to show this with the
four different
algebra operations here so if we have X
plus 3 equals 5. so in each time the
goal is that I get x equals something so
I would like that X by itself
on that side on the left side of the
equal sign so what am I doing I'm adding
3 so I'm going to do the opposite
subtract 3 and then I'm going to do the
same thing to the other side and 3 minus
3 is 0 I don't have to write plus zero
five minus 3 is 2. solved
x equals 2.
so it's like Sherlock Holmes eliminating
possibilities and then we get to the
answer
so
the next one if I'm subtracting I'm
going to do the opposite so again my
goal is x equals something so x minus 2
if I add 2 that cancels that's why I add
2 and then I do the same thing to the
other side
so negative 2 plus 2 is 0. don't have to
write plus zero and then 10 plus 2 is
12.
there we go solved
we go to multiplying very similar also
notice in writing
math most textbooks you won't see the
fact that you won't see a multiplication
symbol at some point just the fact that
they're next to each other means that
I'm multiplying now we have to remember
this in Python syntax you have to put
that multiplication symbol but here
3x means 3 times x so
to get X by itself I'm multiplying so I
have to want to divide and notice I'm
going to write that like a fraction
divided by 3
and then divided by 3 here
now here's something else about the
notation 3 divided by 3 is 1 but I don't
have to put 1X you could but you don't
have to you and most places you won't
see it you know One X any other number
there I'd have to write the number but 1
we often don't write that so then 12
divided by 3 is 4.
and
we go here x divided by 4 somehow
whenever I teach this everybody's like
get it get it get it
confused it's the same thing I'm
dividing so I'm going to do the opposite
which is multiply now in this case I
might write it you know how can I write
multiplied by four I might even just put
it in parentheses
just saying it's next to that so that
means I'm multiplying that's one way to
put it and so here I'll put in
parentheses
so so divided by 4 times 4 cancels out
so it's 1 and then that's 1X and then
here 2 times 4 is 8.
so with some simple numbers that you
know we see these methods here add
subtract multiply and divide and the key
is no matter what the numbers the no
matter
um what what else you encounter like how
complicated the numbers are it's the
same method so we recognize this method
then whatever number comes up then we
can figure this out because this
I can do in my head but supposing I have
instead of X plus 3 supposing I have you
know X plus you know 7.2
um you know equals 11.1 or something
like that
so supposing if I supposing I have
something like this
how how could I how could I solve it oh
I have an algebra method what am I doing
I'm subtracting in this case 7.2 from
both sides
and so then I get x equals and even if
it was something more complicated I know
what I'm doing on the calculator I'm
subtracting 11.1 minus 7.2
and then I know what I'm doing on the
calculator there we go so
we can also
use this
anytime I have a you know a two-step
equation
and in the two-step equations
it's more like
you know order of operations in reverse
because the addition is the easiest so
if I have something like you know 4X
um plus 6 equals 22.
so
two steps I'm still going to combine
those same four steps we were talking
about I'm just going to do one than the
other and I'll look at the addition like
I said like order of operations in
reverse the addition or subtraction is
going to be the easiest to do first if I
then subtract 6 from both sides so if I
have minus 6 minus 6 so then I have 4X
equals 16.
and now I get to my second step divide
by four
divide by 4 divide by 4
then I get x equals 4. so we have our
two-step equation
and in all this
you know some of these are you know
you're going to get quick enough at this
that it's not even worth trying to write
code or anything to solve this but some
of these as they get more difficult than
it will you know and there's other
factoring and you know uh more elaborate
problems then it'd be worth it to write
code because we'll I'll show you now how
we can just put this in in Python right
out the equation and it'll output the
answer
so let's take a look at the code
so it's a lot easier to
solve for x
in Python because we can just import the
simpi library here and that's the
symbolic math Library you don't have to
install anything you can just import it
Google codelab works nicely behind the
scenes like that and then from SIM Pi
we're going to import symbols and from
symbi.solvers we're going to import
solve so we can import symbols to use X
as a math symbol and solve for that and
solve is going to be the function we use
so we see here then I'll Define x equals
symbols X and that's defining that X is
the variable we're solving for I just
put this comment here but then the next
thing we have
I defined this variable EQ equals x
minus 2. and this is the the function
set equal to zero so it's x minus two
equals zero is what we're solving for
and then that's the equation so then I
just put it in a print statement
print x equals and python syntax then
print that exactly comma and then our
answer and here's where we see solve
EQ the equation and use x as the
variable so we're going to solve that x
minus 2 equals zero
and you see it outputs x equals 2.
it will print an array of whatever your
answer is this just had one answer
but if I had something like X
squared
oh
x squared minus 2. now that'll give me a
square root answer
kind of interesting how that'll show up
you see
the square root of 2 rather than try to
make that a decimal but if we make this
yeah something that works out nicely to
an integer and we've run that See it'll
give me an array of
you know my two answers x squared minus
four equals 0 is the equation and
negative 2 or positive two either one
works
and remember it then if I have
something like 2X
I can't just write 2x I have to put
I have to put 2 times x because
that's python syntax
2x minus 4 and then if we run that
there we go that'll solve that
there we go much easier and all this
stays the same you just put your
equation here
and run it and you can solve anything
you know just make sure it's set it's
that equation set equal to zero
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the collab notebook so
you can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
that use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
all right so let's go a little bit
deeper looking at different ways we can
solve for x here using python code and
here is the code that we were talking
about before so we import Senpai so we
can use our symbols and then we're still
from Senpai import symbols and some some
Pi dot solvers
and here I'm just going to Define that
symbol X
and this is the simplest thing we can
have all this code and I can just put my
equation right here here's my equation
and then I can solve
that equation and I'm solving for x
notice I don't even really need a print
statement as long as this solve function
is
the last thing there and then when we
run it
we see it will give this negative
one-half and notice the brackets around
it because it's a finite set
nice solve pretty easy
and if I have something that solves for
even you know something more complex
like 2x squared
plus one
now this is setting this equal to zero
so 2x squared plus 1 actually won't have
a real solution we can actually take a
look at that
you see
the negative square root of I and that
is I the imaginary number
so it will give us this there's other
ways to
make that square root display in a
better way but we'll get to that later
and there we go but we see you know it
gives us two solutions as this a finite
set of these two and if I were to make
it you know minus one or I could even
make it minus you know four
we'll have two real solutions there but
there's still going to be square root
Solutions
there we go different ways that this
will output but you get this you can put
the equation in there and see the answer
it'll solve pretty much anything you can
type in there
all right
but let's let's start making this a
little bit a little bit fancier what if
we prompt for input
so let's say I want this to be you know
somewhere else and rather than somebody
going in and finding that correct line
and putting the code there we can just
prompt for the input here
and notice the function is input and
then
it's going to display this enter
equation
and I even have it as 0 equals to remind
the person that it must be equal to zero
you could add another print statement
saying make sure X is the variable you
know if that's what you'd like
and this input does come in as a string
but the fact that we are using these
symbols
it will be able to interpret that and
here then we're solving
and just putting that into a print
statement
there we go so
we have this prompts you enter the
equation and
maybe I just make it 3x
uh minus
six how about that
there we go something good
one solution
3x minus 6 because if x is 2 then that
works
okay that's great
um but again if uh you know I have
multiple Solutions or maybe if I just
don't want it to look like this maybe I
want it to be a little bit fancier so
again this solve stores this as a finite
set so we can do more
all right we're going to import all the
rest of these now here knowing that it's
a finite set I'm going to store that
answer
as this variable called solution
and then
this particular equation I know this has
one solution so I'm just going to have
it display solution index 0.
and that's going to be the first
solution which in this case is going to
be the only solution so when we run it
there we go
and again this is pretty useful if I
want it a little bit nicer output just
like having that nice user interface you
know
having it display zero equals and then
waiting for the
prompt so you know some some other ways
we can do this
and
you know here saving this okay that's
great now what if I have multiple
answers
and what if I don't know how many
answers I'll have
so I'm going to put this here
so if I enter the solution now maybe
I'll just put the first one here we'll
get we'll get to this one next
soon enough
so I'll just take the same solution that
I know has one solution
and just like we were doing before I'm
going to solve it and store that as a
solution now
notice my Loop here and python has this
great
method of iterating through
everything in that list so for s in
solution
so there we go every item in that
solution set
whether it be one whether it be however
many
it'll iterate through that so s is that
solution and then it'll go through it'll
be the next one the next one and each
time I'm just going to print x equals
and then I'm going to print out s
so you know we make use of the Python
shortcuts there we go so
2x minus 4 the solution is 2 and we went
through and did this
so what if I have something like
something that has multiple Solutions
and so
at also supposing I want to
prompt for this all right so what if I
just plug in something like this
now this
I know is going to have three solutions
because the three possibilities that
would make that zero so let's see what
this does
again Loops through and it will output
all three solutions
very nicely
so we see we're building some of these
things behind the scenes that will
output one or multiple Solutions and
output it in a nice way
so we see you know if you're going to
copy some code that you're going to use
this is the one to do it
because you know you could even like you
know take out this this was my
demonstration
but
there we go and
you really don't even need these so this
could be your code
and
that will work for anything because it's
going to prompt anybody you or you or
anybody else using this to enter the
enter the equation
so there we go you see we're building
some tools here that we can use to solve
all right what other ways can we do this
now some interesting things we're also
this time we're going to call it VAR for
variables and we're going to use X Y but
we'll come back to the Y
and we have this one first
you you can because you can use this
from multiple equations but I just call
this one first so there you go 2x plus
10. all right now we know that this is
set equal to zero that's kind of the
go-to way of of doing this but then this
Senpai syntax we're actually going to
spell it out and Define it EQ first
comma zero saying that this is set equal
to zero
because then
I can solve
for x
that's great and this solution I just
called Sol
and since I have this one I know that
the solution is
you know there's only one so I just put
salt you know that's my finite set and I
want the first index zero
so this is it and actually these are
factored results but this is actually
going to give me a nice actual answer
because I can get that answer X is
negative 5.
all right now here's where y comes in
now I have to have y
there if I define y as a variable
now down here I can say supposing
this is equal to y
and you see that works
so spelling it out here that it's the
equal to y
but now I now I'll solve for x
so that's kind of interesting and then
when we do this
you see python could actually do some of
this factoring for you
you know rearranging an equation
algebraically so now let's solved y over
2 minus 5.
pretty cool so we can do some things
like that we can rearrange things and
then
if I have this
you know I could I could change it
around a little bit or whatever but some
some different things you can do the
default is make this equal to zero make
this equal to zero but this gives you
this other flexibility you can call it
equal to y
and then you can do some other things
you can solve for it
so pretty cool
um
as you do this as you incorporate this
into you know some of the notebooks that
you're going to create Tinker around
with this and you know try some
different things you know that's the
idea you go we go through some different
uh
some different formulas or different
equations in a textbook and say hey can
I try this like we could take a look at
this and say all right let's see solve
for y now what about if I have
um 2X
then Okay then if if I want to solve it
for and you can even include Y in here
so there we go and if that's included in
y then I still might then go back down
here and say that this is equal to zero
because that's kind of the default way
for that to go
and I I can still go back and solve for
x and it should end up being
very similar
because whether that was
you know without this minus y saying it
it's equal to y or with this minus y
saying it's equal to zero you see
algebraically very similar
and
you know we could even
just to show you we can even
say this
2x minus y
and we can run this
there we go X is y over two all kinds of
different things you can do if you need
to rearrange this you can put
that in this setup here and then you
know what is it what is this set equal
to now
and what am I solving for here
and in this case it pretty much will be
index 0 for that solution set each time
so these are some cool things you can
get the code to do all the factoring for
you well here's some other factoring
supposing I have something like this you
know we can divide out common factors
now
you might see this 2x 2 times x
10 times y plus 4
. now supposing
this is another thing in Senpai I can
just Factor it
you know I'm not saying that's equal to
zero or anything I just want to take a
look at this I don't want to factor it
look at that n simpi also does the nice
display on the output too
so you see there was a common factor of
and that worked now supposing I had this
and let's say this is three
which then doesn't Factor at all
so when I run it
you know it will just output that
because it's not factorable
all right now what's really interesting
is if I have
something else like x squared
and let's say x squared minus
four
now
you may or may not be familiar with that
factoring but I can Factor something
like that too
I look at that it'll factor that out
that's that's the correct factoring of
that x minus 2x Plus 2.
so we will do a lot of really
interesting factoring for you
so pretty good here's another one that
we can you know just to show you that we
can even take it to the next level
at x to the third minus 2x squared minus
five X plus six so we have that and if I
factor that
there we go look at that it breaks down
into into these factors
so so some of these really good things
you know
um knowing that you can set your
factoring calculate you can make your
own factoring calculator here
all right so
let's take a look at some of the
functions here
so when we have you know we have that we
can Factor
and then
you've been doing some of this practice
with with these functions
so I want to show you you know looking
at these
uh and there's a different input how we
can how these functions are working that
you know remember you were doing the
practicing the one step functions
um One Step addition One Step multiply
there we go
now that first one I want to show you is
because you can't
do string to a fraction this print this
works out just fine
but when we take this input
now other inputs if it's actually a
number or a decimal you can do this and
you can cast it as a float so that's a
number that could include a decimal but
if you know that it's going to be a
fraction
this float won't work because that slash
for the fraction doesn't parse nicely
so then this will give an error now just
because it says fraction here that's
just a display if I just disobeyed that
and put in a number then it wouldn't
give me an error but if I as soon as I
use that divided by
I need that so that's our first function
here
is how do I convert the string input
including fractions to a float so
this is the way python functions work
I'm going to use this def to Define it
and then once I Define that function
um I give it the name of the function I
need the open and close parentheses and
this particular one will also have input
so I Define this variable in the
parentheses that's going to be the input
and then colon at the end
so once I Define that
then everything under this is indented
four spaces
yep and I recommend don't use tabs use
indentations
so then I have an if statement
and if and then here's the condition
if this is true colon and then that's
indented four spaces
Okay so
I take this input string and I'm testing
to see if this fraction bar is in there
and notice if this exact character in
in string
because that's what I called it that's
my input if it's in there then
we have this split
each string has this split function
so
you can split it and say all right at
this point I'm going to split it and
then that creates two different arrays
now this was all based on string input
so it's going to be two string arrays
or two or one array with two elements
and so it's going to be ND I call that
for numerator denominator so then
nd0 is going to be everything before
that
and nd1 is going to be everything after
so
if this was a fraction if somebody put a
fraction in there then nd0 everything
before that would be the numerator so
I'll cast it as a float store it as n
for the numerator
and then nd1 is everything after that so
I will cast it as a float store it as D
for denominator
and now
see we had to split we had to detect
that split that string
and then each of these two elements
individually
cast them as float numbers
and now these are numbers n and d and
now I can actually do that division n
divided by D
so you see because that slash doesn't
work for
for parsing numbers I have to like work
around it and now I have ANS as this
answer
and then I have a return statement so
this this function doesn't have a print
statement just returns this and we'll
see where how that comes out but it just
you know wherever this function is it'll
out it'll put that answer
so that's if it has that and if it
doesn't because I want to be I want to
use this either way so anything else
colon indent then
I won't have a problem so I'll just take
that in string cast as a float
that works so anything else you we put
in we're good
and then again return
ANS
now where this comes in
I'll come back to that one
is in the one step multiply
so here's this function
One Step mold and I put this comment in
here to remind myself or anybody else
using this that it uses this function so
we need to make sure that it's in the
same place
all right so
here's here's what I did to generate you
know some practice problems for you
import random
and then here I'm going to get
random.randint
from 1 to 11. so that's going to be a
random integer and I'll store it as
variable a so that's going to be a
random integer
including one but not including 11. so 1
could show up 10 could show up but 11
won't so that's that's the way the
random integer works it includes the
first one but not the last and then B
I just wanted to make this 2 to 24.
so given these two random integers
notice what we're going to print here so
a x equals B so
we see it's always going to be something
times x and I just want to display this
so I didn't need to worry about the
python syntax with uh to show the
multiplying
all right so ax equals B and then you
would know what do you want to do you
want to divide both sides by a
so
you know that and we're going to take
your answer
input
you know x equals and whatever your
input is we'll store it as ants in
and then the actual answer at this point
is going to be we know divide both sides
by a so the actual answer is going to be
B divided by a
so then
this was the actual input note it's
still a string and that's where we're
going to
use that in our function that we created
earlier string frac
so see it's going to take that answer
run it through that function and return
right here
that answer
so that way we can easily compare it
because this function will return that
answer and then the double equal sign to
compare and we're going to compare it to
the actual answer
so there we go so that's the return
statement wherever I don't have to
print or output anything it just returns
that value right here where I have the
function
and if it's if it is good we're going to
print correct if not try again
but then print out the answer
so there we go and now it'll Loop
through this well this will do it once
and then you know we can create a loop
to have as many of these as you want
practice one step equations
so there we go and then test them each
time
so
you know we have the simplest One Step
addition
is another very similar one there we go
import random
display the problem
random integers and yes you can go
through negative numbers if you want
all right and
what are we printing out here
X plus a equals B
because then
you know that to solve for x subtract a
so
we'll take your input what do you think
x equals
but also we're going to calculate
exactly B minus a what is it really
and then down here we don't need to do
anything else we just say if A and S
equals answer
there we go
and here see we can cast the float cast
the input as a float right away because
we we're not expecting any
um
anything fancy
you see the other one knowing that I'm
going to divide
you know I need to
address all the other things that could
come up
and there we go if it's correct there we
go if not and then we print out the
answer
cool so some different things you can do
and you know one step addition with
negative numbers just
we just did in a slightly different way
so here's a bunch of things that we can
do
just practicing your own ability to
solve
but we'll also get more into some other
functions later but you know
good to see see these functions but yeah
yeah here we go just some of the things
you can do Factor
or solve
so these are the things that you want to
be able to do and
you know set up you know start again
start building your own so your own uh
collab notebook
so by now you might have some things
that you know solve for proportions you
might have some things to
you know solve for x and you know maybe
you can even copy one of those you know
convert fraction input to something you
know feel free to you know copy it copy
these tweak them make use of them on
your own
and you know you see you're building
your library
as well as really understanding the code
as you're building this
and you know hopefully your
understanding of the math understanding
of the code gets deeper and deeper as we
as we go on here
all right so I think we're ready to go
on to the next unit
so let's talk about
fractions and decimals and how to
convert from one to the other well
fractions
when I say out of like this could be one
out of ten if I say out of that means
divide so any fraction numerator divided
by denominator you can do that on your
calculator and it most likely is going
to return your decimal there you go so
fractions to decimals you know pretty
easy calculator do the division and
then you know you have your decimal but
what about doing it in the reverse
process so when we look at this this I
would read each of these
one out of ten I could call it one tenth
or 0.1 is what you would get if you did
that Division I would still call that
one tenth because that first decimal
place is the tenths so that would be
one-tenth
or then if I had one out of a hundred
then
there we go two decimal places so tenth
the second one's the hundredths so
whether I write it like this or like
this I would still call it one hundredth
with the th then
you know I just wrote it one more you
know third decimal boys would be
thousandths so and it would keep on
going so knowing that we have that you
know tenths hundredths thousandths then
that would be our denominator if we want
to convert it back the other way so if I
would if I had something that
I would
you know point two three four so
something that that I wanted to convert
then I would take this as tenths
hundredths thousandths that's where it
ends so then
I could make that
234 out of a thousand
and I could reduce that but that that is
that still is the fraction that I'm
looking for
so
234 out of a thousand or if I had
something you know like point
four
one place that's one-tenth so that would
be four out of ten
and again I could reduce it or I could
leave it as that you know that that's
converting my decimal right to a
fraction
and when we get into the code we're
going to look at how to see here I'm
just looking at this and remembering
these tenths hundreds thousands Etc it
could keep going you could convert any
decimal but I'm looking at these
remembering the place values and then
saying oh that's three so I'll have 10
with one followed by three zeros
you know one decimal place so my
denominator is one followed by one zero
and we get into the code we're going to
look at how to do that
in a different way rather than just well
there's a few ways you can like take it
as a string and count how many places or
we're gonna you know uh one of the
lessons we'll look at the logarithm way
um probably the the string and just
counting it that's probably a little
more straightforward we'll do that one
uh but there we go converting these you
know how do I get this and then you know
how do I reduce it okay so we think we
have it all worked out but what about
if I have a repeating decimal
so supposing I have
0.3333 and it keeps repeating
and mathematically if I was writing this
you put the line over
one of the the the what part that
repeats so I really could just keep it
as one but I want to show you three
repeats just put it over the three so if
that keeps repeating okay so we were
just talking about you know how many
decimal places and then put it over that
but if it keeps repeating where do I
stop
so let's take a look at a trick how to
do this we want to get to the end of the
repeating so if it only repeats once
then if I multiply this let's let me
call this X and actually I'm going to
write this down a little bit further
this is that's going to make sense in a
second here so if I say x is my
0.3333 repeating
all right so if that's my value I only
need to multiply it by 10 to move the
decimal place once and then that cancels
out so if I have 10x
then that's 3.3333
Etc and the you know these keep
repeating
now the reason I do that is because of
all the repeating decimals everything
that repeats now is going to line up and
so if I subtract these
what can I do
on the left 10x minus X is 9x
equal sign still there and three point
all this minus zero point all this that
cancels all this however many decimal
places you want to go it all cancels and
my answer is 3.
and then one step of algebra solve for x
divide both sides by nine so I get x
equals three over nine
because nine divided by 9 is 1 so that's
one x three divided by nine and I could
reduce that as one-third if I wanted to
now keeping it as three over nine you
know that's nice like bonus math Insight
if I have a single number that repeats
it's that number over nine that's the
fraction
so if I had four
um if I had you know very similar type
type of question but if I had
something like uh if I had 0.4
repeating so then 10 times that would be
4.444
Etc they both keep repeating
do the same subtraction 10 minus 1 is 9
X
and when I subtract these all the
repeating decimals cancel so four point
this minus 0.4 is exactly four and when
I divide both sides by 9 x equals four
over nine
so there we go and uh so one more bonus
here if I had nine repeating
we could do the same thing
and you would think 0.999 that's not
exactly one
and well
later on in
calculus we can look at limits and how
0.9 repeating if it keeps on going for
all practical purposes that is one but
if we did this it would be nines
repeating and we divide by nine and you
get x equals one
so it kind of works out nicely but
this is this is how we can do this you
know notice we're not looking at code
here uh we're just taking this and
um if we have something that repeats
then that's what we need to do we need
to find out where it repeats if I had
something that repeated
um you know three two two places over
and over again let's do that one
and just to give you an idea of a
different way if I have something that
repeats then if I have uh so
x equals
0.090909 something like that and it's
the 0 9 that repeats
so I need to multiply it by a hundred
to line it up so 100 x
because that would move the decimal
place twice and that makes it 9.0909
0 9 Etc
so when I do that now same method If I
subtract these that's 99x
equals 9.
because the net cancels so then x equals
99 9 over 99.
and find perfectly acceptable answer but
we can reduce this divided by nine so
that's one out of 11.
we'll get into reducing fractions and
also the code for that too
but you see this is a this is one way if
you have something that repeats and
maybe you're right the way you write the
code it might seem to break it if if you
don't uh if you don't find some way
around it
this is the way around it so we can
convert any repeating decimal but now
we're gonna what we're gonna do is we're
gonna get into the code and how to take
any decimal just here's the decimal
input how can I find a way to count how
many spaces that is
and reframe that as a fraction so that
given the decimal and then we turn it
into a fraction
related to that is percents because
remember the first is tenth hundredth so
the first two digits are the hundredths
and that's really what percent means out
of a hundred so percent is all the same
thing
and then just I'm always looking at the
first two decimal places that's my
percent
so you know very similar but just the
first two decimal places so let's take a
look at the code and we'll see how to
convert any decimal to a fraction
all right
so let's talk about how to convert
decimals to fractions with code and
first we'll get some background here
because this is going to be useful so if
I have 10 two different exponents let's
take a look at the positive exponents so
10 to the first Power we see this
first one 10 to the first Power 10 to
the second 10 to the third we'll see
these come up what happens when we take
10 to a positive exponent
10 or anything else to the zero exponent
and then we'll take a look at 10 to the
negative 1
or negative 2 or negative 3.
so this will just print these out but
let's take a look at what
what this does
so we see 10 to the first second or
third
becomes ten a hundred a thousand ten or
anything to the zero
is one
and then the negative exponents
are how many decimal places 0.1 0.01.001
so these are the things we're looking
for and we're going to make use of the
make use of this as we convert our our
decimals to fractions
so
the next thing we'll take a look at how
to get user input
and
we have this formula here user input
open parentheses and in quotes here this
is what it will display and then you'll
see that in a box
you know than asking for input and then
here we're going to store that as text
as that's the variable
for our purposes here we're just going
to show you that you can enter a number
and we're going to print it out
I call the variable text just to remind
you it comes in as a string we can't do
any math with it yet but one of the
things I can do any string I can figure
out the length of that string
so we're just going to print that out
and I just have again this comment here
if I tried to do math with it then there
would be an error so let's take a look
so you see enter a number and then if I
had a number with a decimal like 0.123
I hit enter
you see 0.123
the length of it is 4 because there's a
string these are four characters the
decimal point counts as one character
so
different things I can do with this so I
you know if I wanted to enter a number
now
if I have if I
cast it as a float
now I can do math to it
and I can cast it as a float or an INT
for integer
so just keeping in mind you know things
I might want to do with this a float can
have decimal places so that's usually my
default cast but you know if you
definitely know that you want it to be
an integer we would use that but we're
going to enter a number cast it as a
float and store it as the variable
number num now I can do math to it I'm
going to print out num Plus 4.
so we'll see
there we go if I enter a number
um there we go and if I have uh 0.123
then hit enter
you see now I can now I can add
all right or whatever other math
operation you want once you cast as a
float or an INT then you can do math to
it
and the float because it can handle
decimal any math operation that there
might be a chance of a decimal use float
okay so we're going to put all this
together
so converting this input which will come
in as a decimal
so I'm gonna
take this input and here's what I'm
going to print out enter a decimal
number to convert
there we go so we know that that's input
and that's going to be stored as digits
and we know that that's going to be a
string
so to get the number of decimal places
the next thing so I'm going to use this
the length of that input digits
and
I'm going to cast it as an integer first
so notice that happens first then I'm
going to subtract 1 because remember as
a string that decimal point is going to
count when I do the length of that
string so
I want to subtract 1 because I don't
want that decimal so now whatever
decimal enter minus the decimal point
itself that's going to be an integer
that's going to be the exponent
and now here I go back to digits
that
is still a string now I'm going to cast
that exactly as a float number I'll
store that as n
so now I know how many decimal places it
took to make that and the number itself
is a float so
let's talk about our fraction my
numerator is going to be
n
times
tend to a certain exponent 10 to that
exponent
so in my previous example 0.123 then
it's going to be you know that that was
four the length of that was four
so
minus one so the one two three
becomes my exponent and then when I
multiply it by that exponent it makes it
a whole number
and since I know it's going to be a
whole number I will cast it as an
integer so that's going to be my
numerator
and then the denominator is going to be
10 times that exponent
so you see that that is what we were
doing before we were doing the code you
know how many digits how many decimal
places and then
you know my numerator is that times 10
to
that many deaths 10 to that exponent and
the denominator is just 10 to that
exponent
so three decimal places would be
that times 10 10 to the third and then
the numerator denominator would be 10 to
the third and it gets you that decimal
place
now that's numerator and denominator for
any fraction percent is just the first
two decimal places so whatever n is
I'm going to multiply it by a hundred
because then that just gets the percent
that decimal
move it over to move a decimal place
twice which is multiplying by a hundred
so
now we'll see the output the decimal
there we go we just repeat the decimal
again the fraction numerator and I'm
just going to print this out to show you
its numerator over denominator and then
the percent
and then I'll print out the percent
symbol
there we go this remembering in math
means something else but here I'm
putting it in quotes so it'll just be
the percent symbol
so we're going to enter a decimal number
to convert and there we go Point uh one
two five
enter
there we go the decimal
0.125 and then the fraction is 125 out
of a thousand that's correct and the
percent is 12.5
and we can run this again and do this
for however many decimals we want
um you know
0.2
enter so it's 0.2 2 out of 10 or 20
percent
and there we go the same things we were
doing and and this is we want to get
look at throughout the throughout this
course you know the the steps that we're
doing
in math
we can break this down and we're pretty
much doing the same steps
but then now now once we have this Inc
written in code then you know you have a
formula that you can reuse okay I'll
bring up this bring up the script here
and I'll be able to convert any any
decimal to a fraction
there we go
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the collab notebook so
you can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
those use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here so
now I want to show you how to
put together your own calculator you
know this is what we're talking about
here you're making resources for
yourself
so
in all the things that I'm showing you
and you'll have access to all these
different uh resources here but you're
going to put together yours so you're
going to click on new
and you would have already added the
Google codelab so go over to Google
collaboratory click on it
and now this is going to be yours so
actually I will call it that
I'm gonna put the underscore it accepts
spaces though your calculator
and you can just hit enter or click
somewhere else and there we go so this
is what you can do to put together your
calculator
based on things that we've been doing so
far and then things that we do further
on in the class then you can add to it
so you can go through and
go to let's say the week one notebook
where you solve for proportions
and here's some things you can do so if
you click on
this text here
to set up the proportion let's copy that
first so you click on that text and go
all the way over the three dots this
looks like copy but it actually doesn't
do what you're expecting it to do
click on three dots copy that cell
and when you go back to
your calculator
I'm just going to click in the open
space here and
paste it
Ctrl V or command V
actually it's kind of cool so you know
control V for the Windows command V for
mac and collab accepts either one
and then we can go back that's your your
proportion setup there
and let's copy this
again all the way over the three dots
copy cell
and
your calculator and we're gonna
paste it
so you can have this you know we don't
we don't need this if you have an extra
one that one the trash can over there so
there we go now you have your text set
up proportion and then it really is then
self-explanatory
you know you see the setup and put in N1
D1 and 2D2 and even the comment there
put the zero in for the unknown value
so we can you can go through each of
these
then if we look at week two now we were
doing a lot of things for solving for x
and maybe you don't need to do the
simplest one
maybe you like the prompting
you can include that
um doing more with the solution how we
split it up
now I personally I like this one so that
might be the one that I copy as one of
them and what you can do is
you know click on here because notice
this one it I personally like this one
it prompts for the input already showing
that it's something equal to zero you
know there we go we already have X as
the symbol and then this also prints out
multiple Solutions if you have them
so this is nice we can copy this
and when you go back into yours
now if I just paste this
that's great I actually don't need that
and notice it didn't paste where I
wanted it to be so watch what we can do
here I'm going to click in here and use
these arrows I'm going to move it down
and actually down one is just fine
now we wanted some text in there so
right above it you hover there
add text and
solve for x
maybe I'll just add that text there
so
there's more from that week
so we have that that's nice now this
solvent other ways that was pretty good
and then notice there's also factoring
so you could include something like this
solve in other ways or factor
you know Senpai dot Factor now I might
include this because you'll see we'll
come back to the one of the other ones
so if we copy this
and this is just Factor when there's you
know nothing else to solve
you see so maybe we'll copy this cell
and paste this down here now maybe I'm
going to add text and just put
Factor
and down here then
I will paste it
oh didn't show up where I wanted to I
can use the arrow move it down
so
you know there we go we have set
equation equal to zero ready to solve
but
um
we can even make this you know equation
to factor
and see you can put this
um
however you want
there we go
and then you know you can Factor things
so we have these
we can go into the next week
now notice to put it all together
because when we went through and looked
at some
some of these leading up to
converting a decimal to a fraction
so
this was putting it all together you're
prompting the person to enter in this
and then we're going to convert that
output the decimal to fraction the
percent
so that's nice
maybe we copy this
and the factoring we'll get back to
so then we go down to here
maybe I'll paste that here
and that's good so we just want some
text ahead of it
decimal to fraction
so you see now you're putting together
your resources here
and we don't need that output right now
now we have one more here
factoring and solving for a variable
and
notice it's
I'm when I when I paste this I might put
it with the other one but we see
remember we did this then you have the
left side which could be equal to zero
and the right side of the equation which
could be anything
you've you know this would be about the
only thing that you would need to change
here change the variable you want to
solve for
and
I put all these as your basic common
variables that you would use but
you know you could always change that
too if you want but you might not need
to change that line and then this one
will solve it
even if it is something that you can
just you know
um solve for a variable
um if it doesn't come down to an exact
number here
so that might be a nice one and then we
keep this example in here
you know
um
copy this now we might put this in here
with Factor solve for x and
Factor solve for a variable
maybe we put it in here somewhere and
notice you can just click and add code
I'll click right in here and paste it
[Music]
and
this will be pretty much right where I
want it to be
then I might delete this
add some text Solve for a variable
now these are just some examples here of
how you could put this together
so that then you have your resource here
proportion
um
there we go solve for x
Factor solve for a variable
convert decimal to fraction to percent
and then things that we do later on you
could add
more into this here now supposing you
want you you want it to put a lot here
and then you add all this that's this is
a lot of scrolling so one of the things
you can do is now I'm going to start
with proportion
um
I like so what
right around here
you could
um there's there's multiple ways to do
this you could insert you go up the top
insert
um
a section header cell
so I'll do it one way this way I'll do
insert section header cell and actually
I want that above
so
and notice
this when you double click on this you
see some of this
these text boxes except
HTML look at that the BR to split split
the line and they accept latex which is
how to format
various things fractions formulas all
kinds of things
so
um
in this new section
and you see because it's in this text
part that's not a comment in Python it's
the new section and I might just make
this proportions
Okay so
now you see it takes that and all these
cells become a part of that section
I don't want that
but what I want to do is
if this next one I want to make this
the section and I don't need another one
I think that'll be the section header
there we go so I'm just going to put
this
here
now that's a new section
so we see proportions now just has the
two cells
the text about setting it up and then
the code and solve for x has just one
cell because that section said it all
and
then
we have the code
um
there we go Factor
and maybe you want to say something more
than just Factor but you can make this a
section heading
solve for a variable
there we go
and in seeing all this together so you
see solve for a variable
convert decimal to fraction
you know that probably I didn't need
anything else here solve for a variable
all the rest was explained in the
comments
and convert decimal to fraction
so now this
just has the one cell and the advantage
of doing this is over here you see these
lines
now we have the table of contents here
there we go and I could change you know
if that that's long enough I don't like
it when it goes on the two lines but
that fits so that it's a longer title
but that's okay and you can have your
table of contents that you can actually
go through and you see jump to
proportions
jump to solve for x
you know different things and in the
view you could change the view to
collapse sections
you don't have to but you could and then
you see you have all these
so these are some things you can do in
putting together your Google collab
notebook you know I wanna I want this to
be your calculator your building so then
you're learning how to do all this but
then you also are building your
resources here
that you can then refer to oh what do I
need to do click on it
enter what I need to enter and solve it
you know you're essentially making your
menu here
so
that that's that's what I want you to do
for this
for for this unit is take a look at what
we've been doing so far and put it
together in your own notebook
some of the things we'll do later will
even get fancier and we'll you know make
some of these into act into functions
that you can use in different places but
this will be a good place put together
your notebook of resources here's one
way to do it but you know you can tweak
it to
the way you like it
all right and now we're ready to learn
the next thing
so what does it mean to be a function a
function means it in math and in code
that you're taking some input and then
doing something to it and actually there
are some functions in code you don't
have to take input but in math we will
so
like we were talking about our unknown
number being X the output will be y so
each function we want to take
X as the input and then we're going to
say that the output is y and here we're
dealing with all numbers what am I doing
to X
and then outputting y so you see we have
like solving for x we were doing before
but now we have a second variable
and we still want the idea that just
like in the alphabet X comes before y
in science and in research we can call X
the independent variable because that's
what changes first and then Y is the
dependent variable because it depends on
what x does so
if I want to solve this or do anything
to it then I'm going to plug in a value
for x
and I can pick any value I might start
with zero so I'm going to Define it over
here my input X is 0. and then what
happens when I plug that in so that
would be y equals 2 times 0.
and you see I'll just
put in 0 in parentheses where I plug in
this number because
it highlights that that's what I just
plugged in and also the fact that
they're next to each other I'm still
multiplying so when we do this 2 times 0
is 0 plus 3 then that would be y equals
three and
my output is y
and if you remember then that's an x y
coordinate on the graph
x 0 Y is 3 and I'd be able to plot that
point and I can keep going what other
points can I what other numbers can I
plug in and I'm even just going to keep
this so supposing I have
x equals
x equals 1.
plug in 1 2 times 1 is 2 plus 3 is 5 y
equals five
foreign
and then we'll plug that in and I can
plug in as many or as few I don't have
to have integers I tend to do that so
you can see the numbers a little bit
clearer but
you know you don't have to worry about
doing any other calculations in your
head but if I have this I can put in
whatever numbers I want
as many or as few I can put decimal
numbers in there and we can plot these
on the graph which we'll talk about a
little bit later but this is the essence
of a function that X comes before y I
plug in an x value and then output the Y
value
so
another function notation that a lot of
people like is instead of using another
variable y
and this connects a lot with the way the
code is going to look
we call it f of x and F for function
so 2x plus 3. so if you see these these
are the same thing y equals 2x plus 3 or
f of x equals 2x plus 3. this notation f
of x and that's we read f of x f for
function
we solve it the same
and
this connects a lot more so with with
your computer science so if I have the
output call f of x
one of the advantages when we get into
writing the code is that in
algebra we tend to just say f for
function but in writing python or other
code you could actually give your
function a name and it doesn't have to
just be f for function you know it can
be you know add divide
calculate the area you know something
you know really even a long phrase like
that as long as there's no spaces so if
we have this and then sometimes then
let's say if I wanted to plug into 2
I could write in F of 2.
and so again the usefulness of this
notation is because I see what what am I
already defining as my input
and then I know what am I doing next I'm
going to do two times two plus three two
times two is four plus three is seven
so F of 2 is 7.
so now I know that answer and when I see
that
X is 2 Y is 7.
and we'll see how this you know really
relates to the code and how we can write
even a little bit more elaborate
functions with code and how we can
Define the input there
then we'll look at graphing it all right
so let's take a look at the code so with
the code and functions
we can do very similar to what we would
be doing by hand writing out the math
here I'm just going to Define One X
value as an example and here is the
function that y value y equals 4 times X
plus 3 and you see python syntax have to
make sure we put the times so
I'm just going to plug in that y x value
become you know substitutes in for this
x value so it's 4 times 5 plus 3 and
then I'm just going to print out
my solution X
comma y so we see that
and before I print that out so that's
one thing one x value but I can Loop
this so I'm going to print out this line
here which is
X and then I'm going to put a tab y so
that's defining my columns here X and Y
and then what I'm going to do is Loop
through all those values so for X in
range 11 so X is going to go 0 through
10.
and then I'm going to take that same
function and each time then I'm going to
plug in
that x value
solve for y and I'm going to print out
the X Y values in this case again I'm
going to put the tab in between so this
is the essence of what we're doing with
a function each time I get an x value
plug it in
solve for y and then I have an XY value
and this is going to print this out as a
table so when I run this
we'll see It'll come out
first of all we'll have that that one
solution
you see 523 5 comma 23 that first
solution and then we have our table x y
and all of our X Y values if x is 0 Y is
3. if x is 1 Y is seven
Etc
and we also have 523 that shows up on
the list two so that's defining a
function
now python has a lot of other functions
Beyond math you can do things with and
we can still use that same type of
python function definition
for our math here we can on this line
Define the function So Def space and
python I can name my function anything
but I'm going to use the classic math
notation f of x and then here I have the
colon so this is going to define the
function everything underneath is
indented four spaces
and I have y equals my 4 times X plus 3
that's the function and what am I going
to do then I'll return the Y value so
whenever I run this
that'll return the Y value so you see
this in use if I print here if I print 5
so I already know I want that to be my x
value comma and then I'm going to call
this function right here F of 5. and
it's going to take that and run it
through there we go same type of thing
um
same type of thing then we'll
Define this and when we run this
it's just going to print that 523.
and next we could put this in a loop I
could just take the same Loop here
and I'm going to copy this
and I can just take that same Loop if I
wanted to
and in this case
I'm going to print because I already
have that function defined I don't need
this
and
I could really just put put that here
f of x
you see so I could I could just have
right here
um since I defined that function x f of
x and I don't have my headings here but
I think we can use our imaginations
there we go so printed that one
value but then in the loop just went
through and looped
so these are the ways that we can
illustrate a function
in code and
you know what we can do with these
functions you know is
almost Limitless you know you can have a
function do anything and you can name it
anything more complex than this you know
give it a word but I wanted to show you
the connection with the classic math
notation and functions in Python whether
I actually just call it y equals that
that still works as a function or rather
I Define it
and next we're going to look at graphing
functions
so now when we talk about graphing
we'll use this equation y equals 2x Plus
3. and I'll use the X and Y notation so
we have our input and output you know
all the different X values and what y
values match up so if you ever come
across something like something like
this you can see that if I plug in both
of these X and Y that should make the
statement true
and so we have a few of our points here
and then now we're going to see how that
matches up with the Cartesian plane our
x y coordinate plane that's Cartesian
because Renee Descartes invented this so
we have
zero zero at the center and how much
I count for X positive to the right
negative to the left and it comes first
like X comes first in the alphabet then
my y value positive up negative down and
by coordinate pair would be
by X Y so this 0 3
would be
zero so I'm not going left or right at
all up to three
plot the point
now I don't also need to write this but
I'll show you so then that would be the
point 0 3.
so x y
and then 1 5 so I would go over 1 up 5
plot the point and then that's one five
two seven
plot the point
now I just plotted three points but I'll
tell you if you really wanted to try
many in between points decimals or other
numbers that are in between
you could bet that
each of these whatever you know one
point something two point something they
would all end up being on this line
it's continuous there's no x value that
can't go into this well whatever weird
fraction or decimal you know mixed
number anything so
all the numbers would be on this line so
with this type of function we're going
to call it linear and we'll get into
other types of functions but that's
where we plot a few points and then we
want to look at these patterns what type
of graph does this end up looking like
so what we're going to do now is look at
in the python code how to create a graph
and plot points to make a basic blank
graph we're going to import this Library
matplot live
dot Pi plot and that's a lot so we're
gonna we can import this as PLT so I can
reference this whole Library as PLT from
here on out
and here's what we're going to do the
first line is these are standard
variables that we use fig for the figure
X for the axis so these two variables
and that equals
plt.subplots
and then that sets this up and we'll do
plt.show
the base there you go import set this up
and then show
and then that gives a basic graph these
are all the defaults nothing else going
on there
and
you know
we have this set up so we're going to
build upon that now let's define the
dimensions here notice that was all just
the first quadrant everything's positive
and even a good one goes up to one
so again import
matplot Library dot my plot
we set the same two first lines but now
let's take a look at these Dimensions
now I have that PLT so it's plt.axis and
I'm going to set
this axis
all right and it gives you the range of
X values and Y values I'm going to show
A Better Way in a second but you can do
this on one line here's the dimensions
and now when we show it
I want it to go from negative 10 we see
across the bottom the x-axis negative 10
up to 10. 0 in the middle and on the
y-axis negative 10 up to 10 0 in the
middle
that's great but I have no lines I have
no axis
and
you know not the clearest so here's
first of all here's a better way to set
the dimensions
is I'll Define them right at the
beginning
as variables X Min x max y Min y Max and
that way all right I want it 10 in every
direction and I can set them here
easy to see it and change it if I want
to and now when I do all this this is
really what I'm doing when I set the
axis size X Min x max y Min y Max
that's really the argument that it's
taking and it becomes a lot clearer when
we set it up like this
so then I have this and
I can set this and then if I wanted to I
say oh for this one this y value goes
really a lot higher so maybe I want that
y maximum to be 20 instead of 10.
and then when I run it
now notice the the size of this still
looks the same but it adjusted
accordingly and on my y-axis it goes up
to 20.
I know my x-axis negative 10 to 10.
so let's display axis lines here
if I have my Dimensions defined and now
when I plot the axis well that's the one
we already did here the window size but
I'm going to just plot them as lines so
this line here
I have X Min x max
as
my array of X values see notice it's
plt.plot
and I have my array of X values and then
my array of Y values
and the default is to make this a line
so it won't just plot two x values and
two y values it'll draw the line from X
min
0 to x max zero and this B in quotes
makes it blue
so we're gonna do the same thing with
the Y
plt.plot and my X values are going to be
zero at zero y Min zero y Max and then
you get make that a blue y-axis
just because I like blue
and there we go so now we have this
that will give us our
x y axis
so from everything we do now we have an
axis we have a point of reference
so
everything that we plot is going to you
know start with this now to find the
dimensions
set all this up we might not even need
to change any of this
and that's going to give us our graph
with an X Y axis
all right so how do we plot one point
so we see that axis the default is a
line
I know I made it blue
be in quotes So how do I plot a point
well I make this line here
I have
an array of one value which is five
for the x value one value which is 4 for
the Y value and then
the r makes it red and the zero makes it
a circle
actually that's o so there's some other
options you can do you can do a dash you
can do different symbols but for right
now I'm going to make this a red circle
and that's how we make make that here if
I have these two
and so when I run this
it'll still plot those
as an axis and then we'll do five four
and then that's going to be a red dot
all right so if I wanted to plot
multiple
now connecting with what we were doing
with
the functions
here
I'm going to set up my graph and here in
rain in my range I'm going to have the
range from 10 so I'm going to go from
this
from this value
my y value y equals 0.5 x plus 1.
and
in this case instead of making it a
table I'm going to do plot
plt.plot and I'm going to plot that X Y
value
as a DOT
so this range and I'm going to plot
these X Y values and again that's the
essence of graphing a function I have
all these different values and when I
plot all these points
I'm going to see this nice pattern
emerge
that this all lines up and I'll tell you
if I plotted points that were in between
whatever X values there would be they
would also line up that's why it's a
linear function if the graph of it's
going to be a straight line and then
every point on this line every X Y value
if I plug in this function it's going to
work
so my Loop to grab graph a function
and here then we'll
create a loop to do the function and the
table so like we were doing before I'm
gonna
build upon this basic graph that I have
I'm going to print the X tab Y for the
heading of the table and then in my Loop
I'll use the same function here I'm
going to plot the point and I'm going to
add it to the table
and all these it it actually won't plot
all the it'll kind of save these points
and it won't plot them all it's really
just going to add them all to the table
and display the table because it really
doesn't show the graph until the last
thing outside the loop here is going to
be plt.show when you have graphs um I
think python just likes to have that
plt.show last so do your other stuff
first and then show the graph
so then we have
this and we have our table of Y values
notice if I just put one number in the
range it'll do zero to that number but I
can have
um negative 5 comma 10 or I could even
just go back to those original values
that I defined up here and make this x
Min x max
you see
and then but as you know you can put any
two numbers in here and it'll do the
range between there
and you see it just abruptly starts here
and it probably ends here
but I could change that to make this
x-min
and I can make this
x max but remember I want to graph that
last point so I'll do X Max Plus One
and I can have that range
and now it'll give the full table of
values
and it'll graph
the full dimensions
so there we go we see
what we can do with a function I have
whatever math function I have plug in
different values and see the results see
the numerical output see the graphing
output
and now we see the connection of graph
the table and the functions
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
that use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
so let's talk about more ways to graph
and more things we can do with the graph
because we want to be able to display
our data our functions so we did look
already at how we can Loop through
inputs
it I can Define My Graph and we already
did this
the X Min and Max y Min and Max and we
talked about how we can Loop through
I get X in a range and then each time
I'm going to plug this in and plot that
value and that's the idea of the
function
that each time I get an x value in this
range plug it in for y plug it in here
get Y and I plot that X Y point in this
case as a Red Dot
after doing all that then we show the
graph
but what if we didn't have to do a loop
for our input
what if we could use an array and we'll
revisit this again in other units but we
have
this numpy array and
it's not that long of a word but it just
seems to be the convention that we
imported as NP and so you'll see a lot
of examples throughout the internet that
NP dot this or that so that's what we're
going to do
and again defining X Min x max so given
this numpy array here's what we're going
to do
then given these values I'm going to
Define how many points I want in my
array
and in this case it's going to be 2
times x max minus X Min I feel like
that's probably enough for our purposes
but that number two you can up that to
10 or whatever you want
and then we see so then
we want to make as many things dependent
on these values as we can that way if
that changes if I change my window
everything else will change accordingly
and I'll have to go through and find all
these variables so yeah I get the full
range times 2 so that's two points
through that you'll see that that's
actually going to work out just fine but
you can always increase that so now that
I have any points this is how I Define
my array of X values and since I really
am only using this once I'm going to
just call it X because that is my array
of X values
and so numpy we have NP dot linspace so
we have this function here which is
going to set up our array you know space
for linear graphing so it takes the
argument where do I start where do I end
and how many points do I have
so we see we just make all this
dependent and then I get my x value so
this
saves us the time of having to do a loop
uh python would do this for us
here's all the
graphs and we're going to talk about how
to change some of this stuff too in a
minute
so now I'll justify I like to Define my
x value up there right where I have
number of points in the range so I have
my y value and for our purposes here
we'll just call it you know call it y
equals but
you can graph multiple things on the
same axis and
you know you can have y1 Y2 whatever
you'd like so I just Define this
relatively simple
linear function here
so then
when I plot I'll plot X and Y and if you
remember before
we were plotting X and Y each as an
array in this case with only one element
but here
you see I defined my x value as an array
of X values and therefore y becomes an
array of Y values so I can just
reference these variables X Y because
they each do represent an array in this
case then
I decided to make the line red so I put
it R in quotes
so there we go
and when we graph this
then we can see
I have my graph and yeah that looks
about like that would be 2x Plus 1.
with the red line
all right so let's talk about some other
things we can customize here
now
yes uh r g b work well you know I just
have to put B for the blue line r g for
green
and if I want it to be a black line then
I will put k
so you see RGB CMYK those all work as
you know simplified ways to define the
color of the line if you don't put
anything python will actually
assign a color to each line and it'll
cycle through so if you plot a few lines
they each get a different color
but if you really say you know okay I
want it specifically to be this line for
this color you can Define this and then
other than those major colors you can
actually just write in colors then
you know there's no one letter
abbreviation for pink but if I want my
line to be pink
I can write in the word and
I can't say like every color that will
be acceptable here but it's gonna be a
bunch you know if you want to line up a
particular color type it in try it
and there we go so we have all these
different ways to define the color of
the line because remember this plot
when this plot graphs the default is
that it's a line
so if I wanted to be a point
then I would have to Define these
definitely not as an array but
um as each an array of one value and
then
uh the letter but then something like o
for a circle or the carrot for a
triangle or something like that
so or a dash so you know we could Define
if we just want it to be a point we'll
see that in a second here so there we go
so we have our axis and our line
but we're you know we're not done
customizing it first of all let's take a
look at these tick marks you know zero
and then every 2.5 maybe I don't want it
exactly like that we'll change some of
these things and maybe you know this
seems kind of blank maybe I want to see
the grid lines
so here's some other things we can do
all right I'm still going to import
certainly matplot library but I'm also
doing numpy because we use that for some
of the things for graphing
and same thing I'll Define
you know the window up here and the X
values based on that window
so
for now I'll keep this
you know the same axis I I just like
blue so we'll keep that
now
notice when we do up here figure and
axis so
the labels
would be in the X variable so
x dot set X label x dot set y label x
dot set title
there we go X values y values in some
graph and I didn't mean that some graph
like whatever I meant more like you know
like from Charlotte's Web or some graph
um
so
anyway so we have these and I commented
these out we'll get to these later
and I have a few other things here
so
I still have one y value
and then I'm going to plot that
now notice this I'm going to Define this
as a label
you know it can have a label rather than
a color but notice no color I can also
do a color
but since I don't have one we'll we'll
see what color python assigns to us
and then I decided to plot a point
and in this case it's red and c0 right
or that's actually o the lowercase o so
it's going to be a circular point and
then this one's going to have a label
too
and I'm going to plot something else
here's same X values and then notice I
can Define the Y value up here and then
say y right there or
I could put the Y value in here directly
either way which whichever you feel like
doing I don't want to show you the
different options here and again we have
this label also
so let's just take a look at
the X label the Wiley set X label y
label and the title and then we'll see
these different these different lines
so there we go and
you know we get nice orange a different
shade of blue and I Define that as a Red
Dot
so there we go but what if
all right so let's see
what if I want
the
axis to show the grid it looks kind of
plain what if I want to see the grid
so when I comment that out and this one
notice true is a capital T
it will actually show the grid lines and
you see it does line up to
the tick marks that are already there
every 2.5
but there we go so if we want to see the
grid lines and we have this and now we
have our X you know our labels X values
of Y values some graph
you could actually put the graph and in
one of the later units we'll we'll look
at some details about how to even
automatically
if I wanted to graph one line and have
the title the graph be that line but you
know you could always just type that in
you know instead of some graph you could
actually just type that in as a string
you know the equation of the line
okay so let's take a look at numpy again
and in this case
let's say the 2.5 in each direction is
not really what I want so again we have
x dot and we're going to set X ticks and
set y ticks
so setting these tick marks on each axis
so it's a different sort of array I'm
going to do num mp.arrange
and what do I want to arrange very
similar to the way we did X values I get
my minimum my maximum and then this is
how often do I want to tick mark every
two numbers
so that's what we're going to do from
why I'm into y Max and you see again
basing it off of those original
variables if the window changes then all
this will update automatically
so there we go so let's just take a look
at that supposing I change the tick
marks
and we see then now every two
and maybe that's a little bit better
instead of 2.5
and we see these
now if I wanted it every one then
I'm going to change that just to one
and notice this is just for the tick
marks along the side but up here when we
do x dot grid true that's going to just
follow whatever tick marks we've
assigned
so now we just change this every one and
now we get
this sort of graph where I definitely
can count the boxes and see you know
let's take a look at the slope of each
line let's see these and python still
does it around the edge so that way it
doesn't get in the way of anything
that's in the middle of the graph
all right there we go so we can keep
this that's that's pretty nice
okay so what's one of the things we have
all these labels but we didn't see them
anywhere
so
if you have all these labels then we add
this other PLT dot Legend
here we go and
we can see these labels
so I wanted to show you that each of
these labels we can have you know this
line we labeled with the equation
the point I just wrote the word point
but you could put anything
and the other one labeled with just some
words steeper line
so we could always do this and in the
same way you know even if python assigns
it you'll see the matching you know
which line are we referencing which
point are we referencing so
some good things that we can do with
these we can have the tick marks or not
we can change how often they come up we
can have the Grid or not we can change
these labels
right and I encourage you just to get in
and you know Tinker with this
you know take a look at all some of the
different ways you can
you know match up uh different graphs
you can you know set different things
and we will get into even more graphing
but
that's going to be when we get to you
know
um systems of equations
and some other more complex graphs so
then we'll revisit this and then we'll
you know go a little bit deeper try a
few more things with the graph
but I think I think this will get you to
be able to display
any function you have and you know
hopefully display in a way that you say
yeah this is exactly how I wanted it to
look there you go customizing your graph
all right
so
yeah get in there and Tinker with this
and see see different ways that you can
change the graph
so let's talk about slope how can I
describe this line that's on an angle
using you know describing how it goes up
and over
so that's what slope is picturing these
lines that have a slope to them that
they go on some sort of angle but we're
going to describe them going up and over
like Steps how much am I going up and
how much am I going over up and over up
and over like Steps
so if I have
two points and if I have the graph that
I'm looking at that's great I can just
count you know looking at two nice
points that work out as integers that
makes it easier to count so I can say
from this point to this point I'm going
up three one two three and then over one
so up three over one well then my slope
is three
and I can do the same thing you know
from that to the next point I can go up
three over one plot a point up three
over one
plot a point Etc and it would be the
same slope
anywhere on the line because it's a
linear equation it's a perfectly
straight line
so
that's great I can count if I don't have
the boxes or you know just to have
things like this but if I have the
points that counting that how much am I
going up that's the change in y because
y tells me if I'm going up or down so
if I look at this I'm going up
I just counted three but I could also
subtract taking a look at the Y values 4
minus 1.
or then how much am I going over and
it's always over to the right so I can
look at the X values so from 1 then to 2
2 minus 1 how much am I going over so
it's always over to the right in this
case it's positive because left to right
it's going up if it was left to right
going down then my second y value would
be less and when I subtract then it'd be
a negative number so it's always going
to the right but y would be positive
it's going up or negative if it's going
down
and so if I had these and I I can count
but looking at this I know I can
subtract so what's that formula look
like well I can write out the formula
here slope m equals
and that's right
M for slope because it's how much we
move on the graph so somebody started
using M and it caught on so we're going
to use M for slope it's how much we move
on the graph and remember I said it's
how much am I going up so that's the
change in y and I can subtract that Y2
minus y1
and so I would use a little subscripts
you know Y2 y1 and that indicates my
second y value minus the first one
then the change in X would be very
similar X2 minus X1
and again the subscript for the second x
value minus the first one
okay so now that I have this formula
let's plug in these numbers and see so
we'd have 4 minus 1 4 minus one I'm
subtracting my y values and then 2 minus
subtracting the X values and what do I
get 4 minus 1 is 3 2 minus one is one
and three over one
any whole number over one you know
divided by one it's a whole number I
don't have to write over one so I can
just write three
so that's where anytime we see anytime
you see a slope that just is a whole
number it's that number over one
and there we go so we have counting if I
have the graph
subtracting if I just have these two
points and you know I'm using that
formula
so this is great it's the same formula
you know anytime we have slope for a
linear equation so let's take a look at
how we can turn this into code because I
want you to get into this mindset that
anytime we have a formula you can write
write a program for this and you know
there we go input the numbers and output
in this case the slope so let's take a
look at the code and we'll see how we
can do this now this part is going to be
brief
because I just want to show you that you
can connect any formula if you know here
we we're going to Define our X1 y1 X2 Y2
and put that into the slope formula
slope equals Y2 minus y1 divided by X2
minus X1
and really then
this is a useful formula and others you
can just Define your variables and run
it through the formula here we're just
going to out output the slope
there we go all you need is the two
points
next we're going to work on developing
the full equation
but then let's take a look at how that
comes together on the graph first
all right so we've already figured out
that the slope is three
in our two points but let's say we have
this two points and we want to figure
out the equation of this line we know
that this is linear and
I have these two points that we've
figured out that the slope M because
moving from one point to the next we
went
um
up three and over one
or I just subtract four minus one
over two minus 1 and then four minus one
is three two minus one is one so three
over one we figured out that the slope
is three
and we want the full equation of of this
line now knowing that it's linear we can
imagine here that it would cross the
y-axis somewhere and that's what the
y-intercept is The Intercept is where
does it cross
so
we have a nice formula slope intercept
form and that slope intercept form is
y equals
MX plus b
now we called the slope M because that's
how much we move from one point to the
next and we'll call the other one B
because that's where we begin on the
y-axis so many things happen in this
first quadrant where everything's
positive so we picture that we begin on
the y-axis and then move in that
direction of course you know we can go
in different directions but
so I have this y equals MX plus b
now
what we have is our slope is m
the X Y comes from
any of these X Y points so
I'll pick one of these points and then B
would be the y-intercept it works out
that way
so if we take a look at this I'm going
to take one of the X Y points how about
I take
um this this first one here because it's
1 1 that that'll be nice and easy to
calculate it works for either one so
when I plug in this the Y value is 1
and then the slope which we just figured
out was three
and then the x value is also one I'll
just put that in parentheses so notice
MX you know in my math notation I don't
have to write that I'm multiplying just
because they're next to each other so
I'll do the same thing when I plug in
You Know M and then plug in for x and
now B I don't know so that's where I
have I plug in slope that I know one
point so that's four things I know three
of them I can figure out the fourth one
and we'll do this multiplying one equals
three plus b
and remember our one step equation
subtract 3 from both sides so I get
negative 2 equals B so now that I have
this
I figured out that the slope is three I
figured out that b is negative two then
I put it together
leaving X Y open because any X Y point
on this line will work in this equation
and my final equation is y equals
3x
minus 2.
so there we go we've
figured out this slope intercept and so
now I know that minus 2 it crosses down
here so that coordinate point would be
zero negative two
and we can see we can see why this is
what B and why it shows up like this
because when X is zero whatever I plug
in as an x value it's good it's going to
Z zero out so three x three times zero
it zeros out
and then when x is 0 that drops out and
then I have minus two
so
we see that that works out so this is
our slope intercept equation and we can
when we see this now if we know the
slope we can generate the equation slope
in The Intercept if I had this line
I could generate that equation we're
going to pretend that that's a straight
line but if I had this but if I had this
line I could generate that equation oh
where does it begin at negative two oh I
know that that's B and then I can count
for the slope up three over one so that
I know that the slope is 3.
and I can go the other way if I had this
equation but didn't have the graph I
could say oh I'm going to begin at
negative 2 0 negative 2 plot that point
and then the slope is 3 I would go up
three over one plot a point up three
over one plot a point
and if I was doing this by hand you know
paper and pencil I'd probably pop like
three points and get out the ruler and
connect the dots
but what we're going to then do here
what we're going to do here is take a
look at how we can write the code to
develop the equation so all I would need
is two points
and I'm going to do more than calculate
the slope I'm going to figure out the
full equation
so we're going to look at how to take
two points and develop a slope-intercept
equation so now we're going to put it
all together and develop the equations
so like before we're going to Define our
X1 y1 X2 Y2 from two different points
and we're going to calculate the slope
which now we're going to call M that's
been the go to
variable for slope M for how much the
line moves so
same formula but now it's going to be m
equals Y2 minus y1 divided by X2 minus
X1
then I'm going to define the y-intercept
which is B and that's because that's
where we begin many things happened in
the first quadrant where everything's
positive so we begin on the y-axis
somewhere where X is zero
so
we'll connect this with the algebra that
we we looked at you know how if how do I
if if I know
a point and an X so an X Y value and a
slope and a slope how can I solve for b
couple steps of algebra so then B is you
know y1 minus M times X1
now I have m and b
solve print out the equation so this
will just print out the equation and
we'll see
that
it'll display nice y equals three X plus
four and I still it it will still by
default give it as
a float variable so 3.0 it's not worth
trying to cast it as integers because
this is going to work for any number and
then that way it does not have to be an
integer
to to make this work
so there we go
knowing these calculate the slope
calculate the intercept and then put it
all together in the formula so then
let's graph it
same thing here
defining my X and Y points and I just
kept these same points here so develop
the equation m equals b equals
just because we want to print it out so
there we're going to print out the full
equation and now we're going to go back
to the graph that we were doing before
to find our X Min x max now
how do I want to display this line I can
graph I can find two other points so I'm
going to take the X minimum so we see
here in the first line Y3 I'm going to
take the X minimum
and I'm going to convert that times M
plus b that's going to be my y value and
then I'm going to take the X maximum
times M plus b that's going to be my
other y value
so now I have these other two points
basic setup for the graph same as we
were doing before
and we have now I'm going to plot that
that line
plot.plt.plot and my X values are going
to be X Min X Max and my y values will
be these new y values
and I'm going to plot this as a red line
so if I part if I put an o in here that
would put these as two separate red
points but just R makes it a red line
and now when we run this
there we go we
calculate the
equation and we graph the line
Good Times
so I can change anything else I can have
any other two points there we go
um
there we go to
three and
if I kept the same x value we know this
actually
some of this would break but it might
still graph it but we know that that's
not a function there so
there we go six and I'll make this one
eight
just to show that we can just change
these and all the rest of this will work
solve for M and B get our equation plot
them here and
when I run it
there we go
so
1.25 x plus 0.5 and we see that it must
cross the y-axis at 0.5 and then that
slope up 1.25 over 1.
there we go
all right so now we can
graph and
do whatever you want with the two points
you find
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the collab notebook so
you can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
the use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
so we're looking at how we can apply
some of the things that we've been doing
to real life situations and
use this information to predict things
to figure out some trends
and in real life or things that show up
in a textbook that hopefully are
realistic enough
so let's take a look at some examples
here
and we'll work through these so if we
look at 25 a Town's population increase
at a constant rate in 2010 the
population was 55 000 by 2012 the
population had increased to 76 000. if
this trend continues predict the
population in 2016.
so we want to notice
that these are two X Y coordinates time
and population
and time if you have it it's going to be
on the x-axis almost all the time
so if we look at this so 2010 55 000
2016 76 000.
or 2012 76 000.
so when we when we do this we have
um I could make 2010 the x value but I
could say hey this is the beginning of
this situation I'll call it Time Zero
so in Time Zero it and 55 000 These are
nice even thousands so I just might call
it 55. so Time Zero the population was
55 and 2012 is when we have the next
year so that's two years later so two
and then 76.
so we want to take notice that we're
recognizing these as you know X Y
coordinates that we can put on a graph
and we're going to use that we're going
to predict 2016.
so
let's take a look at how we would do
that now hopefully you've already been
putting together some things
that you know that you can use to graph
you know your collab notebooks so that
you would already have this something
like this set up
you know graph you've already done the
Imports this is the only thing that
we're changing remember this for the two
points and then we're going to calculate
the slope and the intercept and
everything so X1 0 y 1 is 55 X2 I would
want that to be
to
2 and Y2 is 76. so you see that that
matches up 055 2012 76 000.
and
these this would then be the only thing
you needed to change
is your two points because all the rest
of this you'd have this you know already
set up
um developed equation so you know we're
going to calculate the slope we're going
to use that to calculate the y-intercept
now we happen to know because we have X1
is zero
so we know that the y-intercept is going
to be 55 but that's okay we're going to
print out the equation and then our
classic graph now
I would normally have this set at you
know Negative X Min negative 10 x max 10
y minimum also negative 10 y maximum 10.
so this is the other thing that we would
change because we look at this graph and
an X minimum of negative 10.
so in time
that would be 10 years ago but
you know we're we're not going to worry
about going in the past and making that
negative 10. so
I'll just keep it at zero and we can you
know look at it from there
then X maximum 10 we can keep that
that's probably just as good
you know we're looking at the most six
years for this situation and
why minimum I'll also make that zero
um actually
because why is population so why minimum
being less than zero would just be weird
negative population they're not going to
be in the upside down or anything
all right or Y maximum and I picked 150
because we already started 55 and then
we're going to 76 and we're predicting a
few years in the future so I wanted to
go up a little bit 100 didn't seem like
enough so we could always change these
so all we need to do is change these and
notice all the other things for the line
that we're going to graph so notice even
though I'm printing out this line I'm
still just using
these uh
X Min and Max and then two more y values
to calculate this line and we're just
doing the line that way
um there's other ways to do this but we
can keep this for how we're going to
display this line
this this works for linear equations
and we still keep our basic setup now
here's where we also add the details so
again hopefully you have these and you
could also comment these out and then
use them as needed like I have these
commented out about setting the X ticks
and the Y ticks we'll see if we need to
we'll see if we need to change that and
you might have the default X label as X
values or Y labels y values but we can
change these here time and population
and
I like I like seeing the grid especially
for this situation so I'm going to put
that in as true
so we have these details that you see
you could you could have your setup and
have these all commented out that all
you need to do is uncomment them as
needed
and then there we go we're going to plot
this linear function
and then here's what it looks like when
we run it
so we figured out the equation so it's
going to be there it is 10.5 X Plus 55.
so we see this trend and we see it
starts at 55 increasing about 10 500
every year
so
year two we see
here I'll estimate that as 76 year four
and then year six this is what we want
now
this might not be
exactly 120
we could uh
we could plug that in and see because
now we have the equation you know what
what is the value at six years
but also this is enough and that's why I
didn't worry about changing the tick
marks because the default that it gave
us I think that actually ends up being
pretty good so
there we go
as a good enough estimate I would say
120 000.
for you know population estimates you
know you know the fact that it might be
you know 119 500 or something like that
you know our rough estimate is going to
be 120 000 and that works so you see and
then we have our nice labels time and
population
the grid marks help so this is how we we
want to do this we can you know we can
set up this equation and see the graph
and that helps us answer all these
questions
there we go we see the trend and we can
predict the population in 2016. oh it's
about 120 000.
all right now here's another one the
number of people Afflicted with the
common cold dropped steadily by 50 each
year since 2004 until 2010.
okay so we'll look at our keywords here
so dropped steadily then we're talking
about a subtraction
and then I'll make time 0
2004 since
2004 is the first not first year we we
mentioned this now also a lot of these
in real life yes they wouldn't be
perfectly linear but a lot of times that
linear Trend gives us a decent enough
approximation and that's that's the idea
for some some of these it's enough of a
prediction
so
now we have in 2004 875 people were
inflicted I noticed even with the comma
there you can definitely see there's
your XY value year and then
Afflicted and then in 2010 it keeps
dropping
so one of the things that we can do here
while this is find the linear function
so one of the things we can do is I can
make 2004 times zero
and then that's 875.
so
if we take a look at this
I'll make that time zero and then this
one I'm going to make 8.75.
all right so
now
if it
drops steadily by 50 each year
all we have to do is just we just need
one more point if this is linear so
we can just do the subtract you can do
the subtraction in your head here then
if we have
Year One
then
it drops 50 so then that's going to be
8.25
and you see that's it's all all we need
two points and we'll be able to do
everything else calculate the slope
calculate the intercept
and display the equation
I might even well now the time and
population will
mean anything so you know number of
people afflicted
you know um
Kate how about how about cases
number of cases of the flu there we go
so there we go time cases and
you can hit control
uh or you can hit shift enter or click
this
and we see this trend negative 50
was still in the y equals MX plus b
negative 50x plus 875. and a lot of
times you would see this they'd put the
h75 first
um and then subtract but that's okay now
also this
notice that you know my x y axis
I'm not going to show anything why
because it started 875.
and you see 140 doesn't cut it so we
have to go to x minimum and maximum
that's fine y minimum that's fine but y
maximum it can't be
150 maybe I'll call it like 900.
so now we can see
the graph
and sometimes you know you graph it and
you say well why didn't it show up and
then you look and see oh it's the window
well I'm out of bounds here so there's
875 and we see this downward trend
so there we go and we can use this to
predict
you know in in any year
now there's other ways to get the exact
amount we can you know for any any year
we can actually plug in that x value
and then solve so that works
and
remember that even works within a print
statement
so if we have
no so the interesting thing is
um this plot dot show
um that needs to be last so if I do
another print statement I could I would
do it later
but I could right under here
you know the same place where I print
this I could print
so
what if the question was how many you
know what's how many people had the flu
we might say oh look at this two years
later you know we had the now we we can
do the subtraction so let's say like
five years
and you see given our graph here
you know we see this trend we can
estimate it but we don't know exactly
you know it's not detailed enough to see
it so I can say oh about in about five
five years how many people were
Afflicted with the flu and supposing I
want that exact number so I can go back
to this
and then X is 5.
so one of the things you can do is in
the print statement
you can actually just do do the math and
you can have like a more elaborate print
statement if you want but we can just do
our math here negative 50 times
Plus 875.
so we see
you know our negative 50 times 5 plus
875 and that would give us the Y value
what would be the value what would be
the number of people afflicted after
five years
and again you could have a more
elaborate print statement
to say something but
since we already know what that question
is now that that's 625 that that means
something to me when I see it there
so
you see that that might be you know
could I estimate it exactly oh that's
625 not necessarily but I can plug in
the number and get it
so we see you know some different things
we can do see the graph we can answer
some questions do some math for you know
some specific
uh some specific questions related to
this
now
all right
all right linear function so
here's another question when will no one
be afflicted
so we want to know looking at this graph
when is the Y value the number of cases
going to be zero
now
rather than ex now one of the things you
could expand the graph
until it gets to zero we'll come back
and do that in a second but
one of the things that we could do is if
you already also have
your
setup to solve an equation
so you know you have this and remember
this was the whole setup to solve an
equation and print the solution
and so the only thing we needed to do
here we keep this equation variable the
only thing we need to do is put your
equation there
in this case I'll put it here 875 minus
50x
and remember
um
it's remember the python 50 times x so
that's by default set equal to zero so
when we run it
so the answer is 35 over 2.
interesting that it gave us a fraction
but there you go it said 17.5
so 17.5 years
um it's going to be zero
yeah now again fictional numbers I feel
like you know in 17.5 years from now no
but it's not going to be that
nobody had has the flu or something like
that but we can actually take a look at
this and we can change the X maximum to
18.
and then we can see this trend so we
look at that
you see then
according to this trend
you know time zero and
that would be
you know it
17.5 years and in this case
according to these numbers
um who knows it may in some particular
town but in 2004 so 17.5 or 18 years
that would be like 2022 and
um
yeah I feel like that would it's not
that there's nobody Afflicted with the
common cold
all right but anyway you see the trend
though we see you know
these are realistic enough that we can
use these to take a look at how we would
solve these and this is what we want to
use this math for predicting trends
given the information that we have
so here's another one where they even
give you the partial line based on the
graph they have
all right so this is showing profit
so this figure one's showing profit in
thousands
of a company in a given year X
and they also do X represents years
since 1980.
so there we go if x if time 0 is 1980 so
then 20
so so 20 that would be
two thousand
and 30 that'd be 2010
we see you know there we go now given
these
we want to find the linear function
all right so let's take a look at if I
want to look at these I just want to
find two nice points that I feel
confident that I'm not just estimating
the points so I like this first one at
year five
it was ten thousand
now
it it's interesting because it says why
in thousands
so therefore ten thousand would be 10
million
you see
so if Y is in thousands then
10 000 would be 10 million
in which case they could have just said
it was in millions but that's okay
um and then we have so five I'm going to
shift it to millions and just make the Y
value ten so 5 10
and then let's find another nice point I
like this 25
4.
so we can go back and
we can plug in in these so I don't have
that zero value and we're probably going
to want that at some point so
five years then we're talking
10 million and then at 25 years
then
we were talking
is it two
four
Okay so
there we go we have that point five
years 10 million 25 years
4 million and
since we already see this graph
um since I made them 10
I really could
now we could we could take a look at
this and say oh yeah 12 is probably fine
as far as a y maximum and we could
continue this to 30 or
um
you know we can take it further so
when I go to graph it zero
X maximum 18 is not going to be enough
um maybe I'll just make it a nice round
50 why minimum fine y maximum 900 that
would the scale will be so much it would
this would just be in the tiny corner of
the graph so maybe we'll just call that
15 or something like that
all right there we go and for this one
we could
just delete this
like the space in there we could just
delete this and we have I'm going to
print out the graph the equation
so when we run it
so here's our equation
negative 0.3 X Plus 11.5
and we see this downward trend
over time
and here's another one where
if I wanted to
change these tick marks
Maybe
I could change this
to the X ticks
is two enough
yep
yeah maybe
and then I can change the Y ticks is two
enough
yeah maybe we'll see
and we'll run it
so we see we get much
many more lines
all right and with that we see
that
the uh this is 38. now
just because these end up being
rectangles more I might change my y text
to one I think I just like that better
and
you know in doing this you can
you know change some things and go
there we go so with this then we can
really see the trend
there's your 11.5
and then we can see this downward Trend
down 0.3 so
it should go you know
over 10 it just went down three to eight
point five
here we go and then 38 years
later then they would have no profit
because that's the trend we're saying
um there we go so whatever this company
is
this is their profit since 1980
and then
and then there we go
um
38 years later
then they would have no more profit so
who knows what company this is but you
know our fictional company
is you know something would have to
change but that's where the prediction
lines
you know the
the the the simplest prediction is okay
these would go in a straight line
whatever Trend would continue in a
straight line unless something changed
but we know then in
uh normal business normal day-to-day
life things do change and that's why our
lines aren't always perfectly straight
but this gives a often enough of a
prediction
oh and you see then time and then cases
then we would change that to profit
okay
just just to make it official here time
and profit
so there we go another another situation
and
we can see where it would start and
then
profit declining
and that's enough years that you know
11.5 million was a lot more money in
1980 and then profit declining and
yeah so this this company is definitely
whatever they were doing that you know
they were in the in sad shape
all right and we have the y-intercept
and all that okay so we see another very
very similar we'll do we'll do one more
here
so consider this scenario 2004 School
population was 1700 by 2012 the
population had grown to 2500.
so all right and again assume assume the
population is growing linearly
all right now how much did the
population grow so this
a is really just the subtraction
so 2500 minus 1700 is 800.
so it grew that much and then the
average per year
you see
anything per year the rate that's the
slope
and
we can divide that but we're also going
to then just plug these numbers in and
you'll see that we can see the slope so
2004 maybe we'll call that time zero
2004 1700 2012 2500.
and I might even leave the hundreds
because
we want it to be you know
more exact we know that the population
would be continuous it wouldn't just
jump hundreds so
um 1700
and then
why minimum and then we have 2500.
so then
after this if I wanted to graph this
then
my y maximum
on the oh
I put in the wrong so there you go Time
Zero
and
so in
so
time zero and then in 2012 so that's
eight years later it was 2500.
so eight years later then it was 2500.
hurry up
okay so we'll have that and
X minimum and then the X maximum
so
let's just make it a nice even 10.
um and we could always change that if we
need to Y maximum
um 2500 but we're going a little bit
further
so let's make it 3 000 and see if that's
going to be enough
there we go
and
do I want the ticks for right now see if
you comment them out the graph will as
we saw it will still give you
the
um
it will still give you the tick marks
it's just that the default whatever
python wanted to calculate and where you
you can force them into
however often you want
there you go and
for School population
yeah
all right
so we see it's growing by about a
hundred a year
and maybe that's you know depending on
what you wanted to estimate
these tick marks might be fine the grid
might be fine
and
you know if you wanted to you could
always
um add more or change it you know I
think that works out
so
growing by a hundred every year
and we can use that to predict
so the average probably growth per year
was a hundred
there we go
100x so the slope is 100
and there's the equation for the
population for T years after 2004.
so we see you know we've done a few of
these I think I I think we don't need to
do another population model
but there's some other form there's some
other
uh practice problems that we see
in other Tech all these all these are
coming from that uh textbook the second
textbook Algebra and trigonometry
because there's a lot of good business
applications in it
so you know here's the idea that just
the notation
um g equals F of P the amount of garbage
G
produced by a city with a population P
so we can call it g equals F of p and
that's how we would read that so it's a
function of population
and what that tells us is population is
the independent variable
and then garbage is the dependent
and
population very often is an independent
variable that causes a lot of other
Trends so we look at that and we see the
same type of thing the town of Tola has
a population of forty thousand and
produced
13 tons of garbage
each week
Express this information as a function
so
now
if we have this
um
one of the things that we would guess is
that
if it's a function of population
then no people would mean no garbage
so in our y equals MX plus b scenario
B would be zero
and notice we because we only get
exactly one point here
forty thousand thirteen tons
so
if we wanted to set this up you know we
want to look you know we know that we
have the
the Python scripts to solve this but if
we want to set this up
we want to take a look at
how we're going to set this up forty
thousand is going to be the population
and who knows maybe I might just call it
in thousands
and then 13 tons same thing I'll just
call it 13.
um
and
then we say well that's one point where
do I get the second one but we have to
look at the situation would I think that
it would start at zero zero and if
that's the case
then we could go back and say
so here's zero zero
and then remember our X values are going
to be population so we'll call that 40
and then
that's going to be 13.
because it's in tons
and therefore the X minimum zero fine
but X maximum
um 40 is probably
not even enough because we start with
that and we can expect that it increases
so then
let's say the X maximum
would be I don't know let's make it 100
and we'll see
y minimum zero now
um
maybe make it like 50. we'll see see if
that's enough of a y maximum
so there we go and
we can just write this in thousands
and
we can make this in tons
so thousands of people tons of garbage
so
we have this trend here
there we go forty thousand
generates 13 tons of garbage
and we can see
this trend here
so
there's the rate here
0.325
X so
remember the x value is in thousands
so every thousand people
according to this fictional scenario
makes
300.325 tons
so
that would be
about tons two thousand pounds so that
times two thousand would be about 650.
but then if that's thousands of people
so
that's each person
making
less than a ton of less than a pound of
garbage
Maybe
so again this is
this is not the you know
um latest research this is you know a
couple of numbers that seem realistic
and then what's the meaning of this and
we read this as F of five
equals two
so
notice that the function like our
functions in Python that five is the
input and then the input or
independent variable that's X
or you know
um even though we call them PNG here
so that input 5 and then output two so F
of five is two so we would expect then
that that means that
when we're talking about 5 000 people
than the 5 000 people would produce two
tons of garbage
so that's the meaning of that you know 5
is the input 2 is the output so
in our XY scenario here that that's what
that would mean
5 000 people would produce two tons of
garbage
all right and
so let's go over here to 89 and another
one
you see don't get caught up in the
alphabet soup of of this as people use
different notation
notice the trend of
I would read this as G of a so it's a
function of this input a
so the number of cubic yards of dirt
D is needed to need to cover a garden
with a square feet
so D for dirt is G of a
and we would read it like that g of a
and
the common notation you'll see
in just general math is f for function
and then often we just go through the
alphabet fgh for other functions we want
to talk about
in Python and pretty much across
computer science your function Canon
should have a much better name
so you know that's something that
computer science has an advantage of
but nonetheless you'll see this all the
time you know G of a so again we notice
the trend a is the input that's the area
and then given that area
then how much dirt would it be
so
we have five thousand
square feet
area requires 50 cubic yards of dirt
so
that 5000 requires 50. now we're not
even going to do any calculations to
this but I just want to show you that
that would be G of
five thousand
equals 50.
so that's just how we would write that
given that input
you know area that we would know first
then therefore how much dirt we need and
that that would just be how we would we
would write that there's we don't need
to do any math to that right now
and the same thing G of 100 equals one
so 100 cubic yards or 100 uh square feet
of garden requires one cubic yard of
dirt
all right
and
number and question 90 we'll see
just another situation F of T so there
you go some function the number of ducks
in the lake after T years after 1990.
so F of 5 is 30. so we know 5 is the
time years after 1990 so in 1995 there
were 30 ducks in the lake
and then F of 10
. so here's a so in 2000 there were 40
ducks in the lake
and given these you see we can X Y X Y
we can find the overall equation plot
the points graph it you know make some
other predictions but that's the
notation here and this is what that
means
all right now 91
um the interesting thing is for just
answering these questions
it this won't matter but this is not
going to be linear
but we can still answer these questions
because each of these is still going to
be the same now notice h of t
and now in this case h for height but
you know again another way of expressing
this so
as X Y values X is 1 y would be 200. the
H the H of 1
is 200 so
that x value is T for time in seconds so
after one second it's 200 feet up
after two seconds it's 350 feet up
and again this is not linear so
um the same things that we've been doing
actually won't work for this but we can
still get the meaning of each statement
here
and 92
um the one to one is this is still a
function but that each x value like each
x value and Y value pair up like the
neither of them show up again but this
is a parabola because we see x squared
and we'll talk about parabolas later
but the one to one
uh that there's actually positive X
values
and negative X values that might still
have the same y value
so that's why it's just not one to one
but it's still a function
I don't want to talk too much about that
we'll get to these uh these types of
functions later but I just want to
mention that in case you're looking at
that and saying well what does this mean
one to one
so in number 60 now this is also not
linear and you see the height of a
projectile is more like something like
this
um after T seconds here's the function h
of T equals negative 16 t squared plus
96t
so that's showing that you know it isn't
linear
in fact it's a parabola because it goes
up turns around comes back down
okay so the domain anytime we talk about
the domain that's the the X values
so the domain is all the X values that
are possible here
and then
the range this doesn't ask it but the
range is all the Y values
and
this actually has a limited range
so uh
because this is a parabola that goes up
and then comes back down there's a
maximum y value
so after that y value there's no like y
values beyond that are not a part of the
range because it'll just never get to
those numbers
then the domain
mathematically the domain is all real
numbers
but realistically
um in the context of the problem
times zero would be the first part of
the domain so you see mathematically
these other numbers exist and they don't
break this problem but realistically if
I'm launching something
it starts at Time Zero
and yes I know that we can talk about T
minus whatever and talk about negative
values because
were awaiting the launch you know
um and this is second so if it's like T
minus 10 then it's you know
T value is negative 10 and that's 10
seconds until the launch
but realistically we're we want this to
be time zero and then the other one
would be
it does go up and comes back down so
there's a time where it hits the ground
again and beyond that it's not really
within the scope of this problem
so let's take a look at how we can solve
this
um just because even though that's
beyond what this is asking
I want to find out what that t value is
when does it come back down to the
ground
all right so negative 16t plus 96t
we can go
into this where we're going to import
our symbols
and instead of T we're going to make it
X just because I already have X as the
symbol so you could always change it and
make a t that's fine so negative
and again we're going to use x
squared
minus 96
X
and
that's always the this is the equation
set equal to zero and that's what I want
what x value makes the zero
now
negative six
would not be
Plus 96t
oh because I put minus
yeah all right
so it only gives us zero
um
what if
I have
so I was doing this with things that
only had one solution so storing this as
a finite set and I just printed the
first one but this does have two
solutions
you see and I mean I could get re I
could get really fancy here and then
actually just make another print
statement but see this is my finite set
it's not zero six as a coordinate it's x
equals zero or x equals six
and I could then put this
zero and I could
I have another print statement
there we go to show the first one
and but this is just a matter of you
know how you want the output to look
and we have these at you know we also
have the you know
um which we looked at before you could
you know Loop through this
um to get solution to get multiple
Solutions but there we go yes x equals
zero it's on the ground and then x
equals six
so that's another way that we could you
know that we could graph this
um
and
we see that it back on the ground at six
now this is a little bit ahead
because we'll talk about quadratics
later so
yes we will we will not worry about
graphing this because we'll get into
this with quadratics
but this gives us the solution that at
six
um
at six seconds later it's back on the
ground so some projectile launched it
went up and turned and I'll tell you
this that you know halfway through these
parabolas are symmetrical so halfway
through it's
um
halfway through its uh
at its maximum point
so we could even print here
what is that maximum point and we can do
that math
um negative 16
here's what I'm going to do
so halfway through that so that would be
three
would be X
and you see that's really the idea that
you know we set up the situation where I
have X and then I can plug in my value
so 0 6 it's back on the ground so three
seconds later
it goes 144 feet up in the air
so
realistically then the
domain for this function as that that's
practical not just like you know
mathematically it exists but related to
this situation the the only number the
only X values that mean anything for
this are anywhere between zero and six
including zero and six
because everything else doesn't really
mean anything for this situation you
know
um
after this then if it keeps going down
like it doesn't go back down into the
ground and the Y values here are between
0 and 144.
so that's my domain between 0 and 6
including both and the range between 0
and 144.
so you know these are some things we can
look at you know solve when does it
equal zero and plug in some various
numbers
all right
so if we look at 61 just again reading
reading these these we might not even
need to do any code for this
we have this situation the cost of
making X items is 10x Plus 500.
and the fixed cost is determined when
zero items are produced
so find the fixed cost and remember zero
so then if x is zero that 10x drops out
and then we're left with 500 that's why
it's begin it's B for begin
you know when you know before we produce
anything you know the fixed costs are
500. now maybe this is some sort of
business and 500 is like rent and
utilities and everything that even if
they're there they didn't make anything
they still had to pay all that and then
they pay ten dollars for whatever you
know for whatever they're making
so then the cost of
making 25 items would be
10 times 25 we just plug that in 250
plus 500 750.
all right and supposing the maximum cost
allowed is 1500.
what is the domain in the range
so
if we have to set this equal to 1500
now
if we take a look at this
and I'll just again write this here so
if we have 1500
equals
10x
plus 500 and notice I'm not this isn't
python syntax because I'm not worried
about doing anything with this yet
but then what do I want to do I want to
put this equal to zero so if I subtract
1500 from both sides
then I get 0 equals
10x
minus a thousand
because if I subtract 1500 from both
sides and so that's set equal to zero
10x minus a thousand then
that's where I could plug this in here
so you see you can work out the math
before you get to the python code
so 10 and then here I do need
10x minus
a thousand
so if that's the case
now
with this one I know there's only one
solution so if I keep the other one
that's going to give me an error
so whatever it is we know that we could
only make a hundred
because
you know maybe they only have that
budget you know whatever they're making
they make 100 of them
their total expenses were 15
total expenses were 1500 and then
you know then we have to go out and sell
whatever they are I don't know
t-shirts you know
uh whatever whatever else they're making
all right
okay so we and we see these same types
of things I just want to look at the
setup of this that
um at the number 44 at the start of the
trip the odometer on a car read 21 395
at the end of the trip 13.5 hours later
the odometer read 22 125.
there we go assuming the scale is Miles
so average speed we want to take notice
that that anything like a rate like that
that slope and we have two values times
zero and then the miles
21 395 and then
time 13.5 and then the miles and we can
go through and plug that in whether I
care about graphing this or not it still
will output the slope which is the
answer to this question the average
speed
and that's where average speed it would
be a linear function whereas
realistically we know
especially over 13.5 hours the speed is
going up and down you know sometimes
stopped sometimes faster sometimes
slower
but we get that average speed we know
that whatever that answers we're not
going to that exact speed the entire
time
all right and 45.
um
the driver stopped at the gas station to
fill up his tank and he looked at his
watch the time right exactly 340. this
time you started pumping gas in the tank
at exactly 344 the tank was full now if
I was filling gas for four minutes
especially with these prices these days
I would be expecting it to be
a lot a lot more money but
he noticed he had pumped 10.7 gallons
so
surprisingly not that many not that many
gallons but what is the average rate of
flow of the gasoline
so again time is going to be X so if we
want to call it minutes
we can call it four minutes
and then 10.7 gallons so we could
calculate to gallons per minute
or and again same thing plug it in
um
you know 10 well actually this one
because we already did that subtraction
is just 10.7 divided by 4.
so some of these you know you have these
scripts and everything available but
some of these you might be able to solve
even before you look at those
or you could break it down into seconds
how many seconds in four minutes and you
know
um the rate of flow per second but
that's just you know other possibilities
gallons per minute is probably fine
so we see all these situations we want
to see like the recognize how we can set
these up
and the things that you're building that
you already have to be able to solve an
equation
even if you know the equation is
something else and you can just do one
step of algebra
you know because that's it you want to
get it equal to zero so
keeping in mind from
from earlier that one step of algebra so
then you have it equal to zero and you
can solve it so you'll have these things
set up solve any equation
or
you know graph a solution
find the rate all that so you know if
all you needed was the rate
you know everything else here would be
bonus but it'll still also answer that
question for you
so you want to see that you know
different ways that we can interpret
these questions and
solve solve the problems graph them take
notice of some of the keywords and
hopefully you see how you can apply some
of this to different situations that you
come across
yeah look look for situations in in your
day-to-day life and how you can apply
these
all right so hopefully that was pretty
useful for you
so when we talk about factoring in
algebra then we're going to talk about
dividing out
something so any Factor is something
that we're multiplying and therefore I'm
looking for things like when I see a
number what am I multiplying so when I
see a number like
six
then
I can say oh what are the factors that's
2 times 3.
and here I'll put the dot for
multiplying to separate the factors
so you know when I when I look at a
number you know like 15
then what are the factors oh that's five
times three
and it's useful to be able to think
about numbers and what are the factors
because that helps us reduce fractions
and simplify other other terms so for
example if I had since I'll use these
two
numbers here supposing I had a fraction
that was 6 out of 15.
and I said oh well I want to reduce that
fraction to lowest terms there's a
better way to write this so then if I
remember that they both are divisible by
that 3 is a factor of both of these then
I can say 6 divided by 3 is 2
and 15 divided by 3 is 5. and so this is
that reduced fraction
and I got this by factoring I recognize
the common factors and I divided out
those common factors so just like other
parts of algebra if I do the same thing
to the left side of the equal sign and
the right then it's still equal here
with a fraction if I do the same thing
to the top as I do to the bottom but
that has to do with just multiplying and
dividing adding or subtracting doesn't
doesn't work
so if I have these I can reduce you know
reduce my factors I can even keep going
supposing I had
something like
um
6 out of 24.
and supposing I didn't recognize that 20
that 6 was a factor of 24 but I at least
saw that they were both even
so I could
then divide by 2 6 divided by 2 is 3 24
divided by 2 is 12.
I could start reducing again recognizing
that common factor or then I could take
it further oh
3 and 12 both divisible by 3 and then I
could say 3 divided by 3 is 1 12 divided
by 3 is 4.
so again I factored things out and
therefore reduced the fraction
now a lot of times you know we see
things and we don't we see fractions and
we we can't you know especially bigger
numbers we don't right away think about
the common factors and we can always do
long division
um in a couple minutes I'll show you how
to how to do this with code to set up a
loop to find the common factors that way
even if you don't see them or if it's a
lot and you know how do I go through all
these possible factors I'll show you how
to write the code to develop a loop to
do that find those common factors but
this is one of the big uses of common
factors another use
and this is more related to other
algebra topics
um we might not need this as much as far
as writing code but if I have something
like
you know 4X
um
plus 16 something like that and
I say oh these two the four and the 16
have a common factor
which is a 4 and I can divide that out
and we can divide out like this way so
this is another use of the word term
factoring because I see these common
factors and I divide it out 4X divided
by 4 is 1 is 1x so I'll just put X and
then 16
divided by 4 is 4.
so and again this has more to do with
other algebra applications but I want to
show you this because this is also
factoring out
then you know if I have this I see the
common factor and I can divide it out
and it looks like this or I can
distribute the 4 4 times x is 4X 4 times
4 is 16 and get back to that
so that's another use of the common
factor
one of the other things we're going to
do is talk about factoring out square
roots
and that also I'm going to show you how
to do this but then we're going to look
at the code you know how to find common
square factors and then Factor them out
but let's take a look at this if I have
a square root
and sometimes that we have square roots
that don't work out evenly they're not
perfect squares but I can Factor them
and sometimes that helps because that
those factors cancel out with other
things later so
if I have
let's say the square root of
24.
now square root of 25 is 5. that's great
square root of 24
almost 5. it'll be some long decimal
because it's an irrational number
but if I can factor that out
recognizing these common factors and now
in this case I don't want just any
factor I want a square Factor so
if I remember the 24 is 6 times 4.
that helps because 4 is a perfect square
and then I can say so I want to identify
these factors but I'm interested in the
ones that are square factors and 4
Square so the square root of 4 is 2.
and then since I took the square root of
4 I still have that 6 underneath the
radical
so even if I can't square root the whole
number I can square root part of it and
factor that out
so sometimes then even if I can't factor
out something like the square root of 24
I can get it down to something like this
and that's the simplified square root
this factored square root and sometimes
that's really useful
now again bigger numbers
things that you can't often think about
oh is this a perfect square we'll talk
about how to write the code to find
these perfect squares and divide them
out and even use the simpi library to
display it in a nice way
so that that's really the essence of
what we want to do with factoring
recognizing factors of numbers and this
is where even if you're going to write
code the more you remember your
multiplication tables the better things
will be it just makes things
you know come together a little bit
easier
but you know we're looking at numbers
thinking about what factors made that
number and then we're looking at common
factors that we could possibly divide
out
and so let's take a look at that we'll
take a look at the code so here we're
going to do the same thing we were doing
with uh working it out by hand finding
the common factors dividing them out and
it's going to work a lot better with
writing code because it'll go through
and easily find all the factors for you
and to do that we're going to use the
modules operator so modulus that is the
percent symbol so on the keyboard it's
the shift on the 5 key
so what that does is that finds the
remainder so I already ran this so if
you print five modulus three it's like
five divided by three but the whole
number answer doesn't matter we just
want the remainder 5 divided by three
3 goes in there once with a remainder of
2 and that's what it'll print out the
two
and if we want we'll just comment this
one out and uncomment this just to show
you another one so 31 module is 10. so
31 divided by 10
is 3 but that part doesn't matter it's a
remainder of one so when we run it
it'll output one now that's going to be
important for finding factors because
a remainder means that it's not enough
the number is not a factor but if the
remainder is zero
then it's a factor and that's we're
going to do use the modules to find
factors so I just picked this number 12
and
we're going to put this up in a loop so
in our Loop so I I made this variable
just called test Factor
so
we have for test factor in range
to the number plus one because I'm
dividing so I have to make sure I start
at one if I start at zero it'll give me
an error and I want to include that
number itself so I have to do plus one
otherwise it won't do that last number
so for test factor and range and then we
go to this line here
if number modulus test factor is zero
then it must be a factor so then I'm
just going to print out the test Factor
so that's what this is going to do
given my number 12 here it's going to
run through that and
try
each number and see if it's a factor and
print it out if it is so then when I run
it
see it prints
there we go one two three four six and
12. all of those are factors of 12.
so how can I reduce fractions to lowest
terms
so let's take a look at this and I'm
defining more variables here my
numerator let's call it 12. denominator
24. now we know that this is going to
reduce to one half
and I'm going to Define a variable
called factor which is 1. that will be a
factor and who knows for some things
that might be the greatest common factor
so now once I have my numerator
to find the greatest common factor all
right so for test factor in range one
denominator plus one because that's
really it I want to you know I want to
go up through everything in the
denominator
um beyond that
um the numerator it's not going to
really work out
so
now if the numerator module so we'll do
this line here if the numerator modulus
test factor is zero and denominator
modulus test factor is zero so
for each of those if it's a factor of
numerator and denominator now that's
going to be my variable Factor
and then once I have that
now I'm going to divide that out
so
I'm going to do numerator
divided by factor and I want to cast it
as an integer because that's going to
look nicer when we do you know the sense
of this is that they should be integers
if they're factors so this is going to
look nicer when we display it so once I
find my factor and you know it could
stay at one or it's going to get you
know the largest factor I can find
once I find that numerator divided by
Factor cast as an integer and I'll just
call it n
denominator divided by that factor cast
as an integral call it d
and then
we're going to print out the original
numerator
divided by denominator and then the
reduced fraction n divided by D so let's
run this
and we see that the original was 12 over
24 and the reduced is one half
so there we go we can reduce
any fraction and you can even copy this
code and use it within something else
you have or you can put this as a its
own function and deal with it that way
we'll talk about creating functions out
of a lot of this code uh later on in the
course
so
the first thing I mentioned about adding
it
let's just do this so we had the decimal
to fraction code
and
you know this one we already we had an
input rather than just have the number
here I have this input
I asked the user to enter a decimal
number to convert
and remember then that input
um gets stored as digits but it comes in
as a string
and we've done this before converted to
a fraction so I go here you know the
length of that input
you know how how many digits
um minus one
um well convert it to an integer because
I wonder how many n minus one because
that it that will come in as a string
and that will include the decimal place
so there we go then that becomes my
exponent
and then
I'll still
also cast that as a float number which
is n
and
then as a fraction my numerator is going
to be
the my numerator here will be n times 10
to that exponent so what that's doing is
taking that value and moving the decimal
place
so
there we go so the a so n has all those
digits including the decimal place then
this line for the numerator moves the
decimal place and then the denominator
is 10 to that exponent so now I have an
integer for the numerator this will end
up being an integer for the denominator
and now what we're going to do is
just like we were doing earlier I want
to reduce that fraction
so
same thing Factor equals one everything
else I already had that same Loop
finding the greatest factor dividing it
out
and
there we go importing the decimal which
is the original number that the person
entered and then print the fraction so
when we run it
enter a decimal number to convert so
let's convert something like 0.125
there we go
and
it does it took it and it reduced it to
1 8 which 0.125 is 1 8.
and we can run it again just to see that
if I have a point zero
two
there we go
the decimal and then that's 1 50th
as a fraction
so we can apply that code into other
things that we've been doing
all right now we're going to take it to
the next level factoring out square
roots
so
this is all good to reduce the fractions
but remember when we square root
something
now this one if I just print math.
square root
there we go uh Square you know the
square root of 25 here is 5. great but
what if I have something like the square
root of 24
. now that doesn't work out nicely
and
by default it'll just give me that
decimal answer but what if I want to
factor it
and
this is how we want to factor it I use
square root of 12 as an example
square root of 12 because underneath the
radical 12 is 4 times 3
and then four is a perfect square so the
square root of 4 is 2 and that comes out
and then I have a three left over
nothing else I can do with that so
that's the factored square root we want
to find our Square factors and divide
them out the square root of that
there we go
so here we have number to factor you
could make a user interface but I just
put it here n equals 12. and
Max Factor I just made that one that's
the one that will change and here's I
put this as the key ingredient because
this is how we get you know if I have my
Loop where do I start where do I stop
so the upper limit math.floor
of
math.sqrt of n so I'm going to take the
square root of that
then that's going to be some weird
decimal number now I just did this
math.floor and then I added one I
probably could have done math.sealing
also
but I just did it this way
so take the square root and whatever you
know that's a floor so drop all the
decimal places you know not round and
just drop them all and then add one so
that's going to be the upper limit
and now we want to go here
so
for maybe factor in range again starting
at one
uh zero would give an error to upper
limit
if
n
modulus maybe Factor squared so you see
I'm running through those factors and
you know each of these is the square
root Factor so
if I Square it n divided by that factor
squared
if that's zero then
now that maybe factor is now my Max
Factor
so we go through and we're going to
cycle through all these you know divided
out does this work and once I get some
Factor
that's what's going to be on the outside
so then I have the results my original
number the square rooted Factor
Square factor and there's a reason why
I'm printing all these out here like
this because we're gonna
build upon this and make it look nice in
The Next Step but to show that square
rooted Factor Square Factor
Max Factor squared and then the integer
that's left over so for 12
since we had that example earlier
we see that n is 12
and the square rooted factor is 2 square
factor is 4 and the integer is three
even though I called it integer that was
just text it actually comes out as a
float
so
um
what we have is
that this gets to that factor 2 on the
outside
you know four
was a part of our in-between step and
then three and that square rooted factor
and then the integer that matches up
with
two coming out that's that square rooted
Factor that's the greatest one and then
three is the integer still in there
so
like I said we're going to use Senpai to
make this look nice import math import
senpai
and from Senpai import symbols
so now
I have this
there we go and
same variables I had before upper limit
there we go and it's Square rooting it
but then
you know find you know one more uh to
see where the maximum is going to be
that like the greatest Square factor I
could possibly have
so then I have all these other factor
and then Square they're all starting out
as one and I'm going to overwrite these
so slightly different variable strategy
so if maybe for maybe factor in the
range
if n modules may be Factor squared
then
we have the Max Factor is maybe Factor
squared
all right
and then the other Factor
is n divided by Max Factor
so we see here
then
this
becomes the factor that I divide out
because I'm squaring it here
and then I have the other Factor
underneath the radical is that original
number divided by Max Factor
so then the output variables and to make
this look nice we cast them all as
integers so
the square root of Max Factor because
that's what I want the square root of it
casted as an integer and then that's the
square root that's my variable square
root
other Factor cast it as an integer
there we go it I mean it essentially
will be but we need to cast it as an
integer here other factor and then the
output
this is this its own variable output and
we see it's square root
times Senpai dot Square sqrt other
Factor
that's what that output looks like in
senpai
and
this
a presentation here we don't need a
print statement in fact that uh that
might not make it look as nice but this
Senpai output so I store all that as the
variable and then when I output it here
we go it factored out as 2 root 3.
and
if I
put it back to my other 24 that we were
talking about before we know that that
doesn't work out
and so
it factors that to 2 root six because
it's six times four and then the square
root of four is two and that's what
we're doing is the types of things that
we would be thinking through we just
want to translate that into code
you know I'm thinking through all the
factors of that number
and which ones are square perfect
squares so the 24 I want to find all
these factors that are perfect square
and
I find that it's 4 and then the square
root comes out
and then
the Senpai makes it nice so we can do
this to factor square roots and
there we go so we have this we can
divide out common factors we can reduce
fractions we can Factor square roots and
these are a lot of the things that you
know we often do by hand in math and
now you have the code that you you can
do this
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
the use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here so
we're going to do a walk through of the
first certification in foundational math
now each of these notebooks there's five
of them will do three of them for this
course and then two of them in the next
course
but they were I also designed them to be
Standalone you know the directions would
be enough that you could walk through
and be able to
do all this still though I'm going to
give you the walk through uh maybe you
already did this and you want to check
some things or maybe some of it didn't
uh turn out as you expected or you're
stuck somewhere so you can always jump
to that spot in in this video and and
see
so each of these steps leads you towards
a certification and you know we build
upon each thing so
the first thing you're going to do is
make a copy of this whole notebook this
notebook is read only and this is what
gets shared out to everybody so you make
a copy and that copy is going to be in
your Google Drive
up and it will be in a folder called
collab notebooks by default but if not
you can put it in whatever folder you
want it to be
wanted to be in and this is the ongoing
theme for this course you're building
your resources so you're going to put
the stuff in your Google Drive uh
especially if you have other collab
notebooks or something you could make a
different folder for everything uh in
foundational math one
you know or algebra with python if you
want to call it that so
you make your own folder you're putting
all these resources in there that you'll
have so you walk through
as you work through these you'll
understand how to do all these things
but then you also have some code that
you can reference
so you have this in your in your drive I
already did this and then each of these
I have as a different section heading
and then you can click on the triangle
here to expand the next step
and with each of these being section
headings
then up here you have a table of
contents
that you can go through so later on when
you build yours you you can jump to
whatever part you want
you know you can add the table of
contents by just making each of these a
section heading
so
you do need to acquire the testing
library because this is actually
self-contained you're going to write the
code and then it's going to test the
code that you wrote and see if it's
correct or not
so this cell you don't need to do
anything to it maybe for other things
you might do in the future you might
take notice of you know how we import
this other Library
as this raw dot py file in GitHub and
really save it as a library locally here
and then you'll be able to access it so
this I have the note here you may need
to run this at the beginning of every
session and the only reason I said May
is because maybe if you walked away for
two minutes and come back don't count
that as another session
um
but these collab notebooks they do time
out the run time will time out after 30
minutes of inactivity and that doesn't
mean no typing that means no running any
cell
or even if you are really active all day
it'll time out at 12 hours
so then you you know you might say wait
I haven't I've been active all day and
why did it time out they have that time
out too all these are security features
so you don't just like leave it open for
you know look indefinite amounts of time
all right so
you're just going to get this library
and you're going to run it
um
and we'll take a look at this so
click run
and as this is going yep it'll save the
library locally and then that's what
it's going to reference
so
it'll say requirement already satisfied
even though it said that don't think
that oh why did I do this I already it
was already okay that's just what it
prints out and then when you see this
test pass go on to the next step then
you know you're good
so it Imports this and you know now we
have this Library available and
each step will use that to test it so
these first four yes I do have added
subtract multiply and divide I know you
know how to do these you probably even
know how to do them in Python but it
kind of walks you through just gradually
getting familiar with the notebook
you might be already familiar with it
but so you know we'll take a look so
we go through just you know two
variables and then you're gonna have
one thing here
with the comment change the next line
now this was just add so there we go I'm
just going to do a plus b
and I'm going to click run
and you see two plus one is three and
then it said Code test passed go on to
the next step
so we go to the next one subtract
7 minus three so I'm going to do c minus
d
and I could hit run or I could hit shift
enter which I'll do that time
Code test passed
so this is just getting you familiar and
then each of these Imports the test so
you'd run that first cell and then you
have the test and
that's what's going to check your code
and tell you
um
one of these steps in a little bit
I'll do one that that gets it wrong and
you'll see what what it'll tell you so
here we go so we'll expand multiply and
again remember multiply in Python
um like a lot of things
is the asterisk
um same key or most keyboard same key as
the eight so just hit shift and it's
about the eight
there we go e times f
all good
Code test passed and then we divide
now
when we divide here G and H now they
happen to be integers and this happens
to work out but if I had them as
numbers that didn't work out
if they were definitely defined as
integers then I would have to do
something else because if I divide the
answer and if I divide it won't work out
the answer will be a float but python
gets pretty flexible with this you know
I just Define g equals H equals n when I
divide
it's not going to give me a hard time
about whether they're integers or not
H just going to divide
and there we go
so you can and a lot of things that you
might work through here if this is your
your notebook you might just have things
where you define your input or your
variables right there in the code
but you could also
actually just prompt for input
and so in that case
you don't have to change the code
because then when you run it it will
prompt for input and then that could be
the different numbers that that you want
that way you don't have to worry about
changing the code so in this case enter
a positive integer
it actually could for what we're doing
here it could be negative but I just put
that there
and then we just cast it because the
input always comes in as a string and
then I need to cast it in this case as
an integer to do some math to it
all right so I need to do an integer or
a float and then
the only thing you need to do here is
following that model
I have
string B
and a lot of these have
you know some code that something there
that won't break the code but you do
need to change it all right it's not
just zero it's going to be this and
you absolutely could just copy this
and paste it
there we go
now
what if I just change this now that's
really all you need to do but what if I
just said oh
just for me I feel like you entered one
I want to say enter another
um oh and I copied the wrong one
I want to cast it as a string as
I want to cast it as an integer
so string B
okay so if I have that now suppose I
don't need to Tinker with this at all
so I I might not but if I wanted to
change this to another
um
or something like that that
you know you'll see
all right so under positive integer
and another one eight
there we go
so
what I was saying is if I wanted to
change you know some little little
things that might not be Central even if
it gave an error it shouldn't stop you
all right but this case yeah yeah
casting is an integer and adding it
we're fine
if I cast each as an integer and then I
went to divide it would give me an error
oh
but
I didn't want to worry about that for
right now we're defining those integers
we're just adding we'll cross that
bridge if we get to it
and we can
get input and cast on the same line
so notice just open parenthesis
there we go and
I'm going to do the same thing here I'm
going to copy this whole line
because that's really what I want to do
all right
now here's one where I really don't need
to do anything else but supposing I just
change that to another
now just the way I have it
see
it actually just tested a bunch of these
things because
you know that's part of the line and you
know I really didn't need to change that
word
it so it'll tell me hey you're into your
input should be this now
my point here is this will not prevent
you to go from going on to the next step
so you know maybe that's it maybe
there's some something little in there
that
um you're like why why did it say it was
never it looks correct or something like
that and maybe you're watching this
video because that's where you were
stuck
it should not prevent you from going on
to the next step and in fact you know
that's fine you can say all right I see
what what was different I'm not worried
about it on to the next step
but if you wanted to you say oh okay
well maybe I just should have just said
this
you know you could always go back
through and check it and then see
there we go and then and then you can
make your change
so the whole thing is that this is
supposed to be just you know a teaching
tool check your code and then you know
move on but
you know not to get you caught in
something that you know
uh is preventing you from moving on
all right now
as I was mentioning about dividing
casting things as a float
so the float number allows for decimal
places
and
most the time I'm just going to cast
things as a float anyway because just in
case somewhere along the way I need the
decimal places there's only a few
situations where I might definitely need
an integer
um
certain Senpai things to display we'll
get to that soon enough and Counting
but
other other numbers that I'm going to do
math to it I'm going to cast it as a
float
Okay so
again prompt and then cast as a float
we're really just gonna do the same
thing and that's okay
um you need you know if you copy you
need to know what line to copy and need
to know exactly where to put it
but there we go
and we don't need to change this enter a
number enter a number and see now we
will divide so I definitely want them to
be floats because I didn't even say
integer I just said a number
so this is going to work no matter what
somebody enters in and then when we take
a look
then you see it's waiting for us so
I will do
enter number three
editor number four and
0.75 which is perfectly fine because
they're float numbers
there we go
Good Times
all right so order of operations and yes
python knows order of operations
so in case you forgot
you know here's the acronym PEMDAS
uh parentheses exponents
multiplication and division addition and
subtraction
so
you could and then remember the python
Syntax for
exponents is the two asterisks
so in this case
what I wanted you to do is test your
knowledge of order of operations we're
not even worried about actually writing
code here
then
you're going to put your answer here but
don't don't really think about the go
see if you can do this in your head what
would this actual answer be
and then you're going to put that here
well you're going to put that here for
your answer and then when you run it
python is going to calculate the actual
answer and your answer and then you'll
see
all right so let's look at order of
operations everything in the parentheses
first
and then
multiplication and division as they come
up
so
uh
four times two and then we have 14
divided by 2.
so you can actually go back and forth
multiplying and dividing all day
so as they come up 4 times 2
is 8
and then 14 divided by 2 is 7.
so then we're going to have one
plus eight
minus seven
and so one plus eight is nine minus
seven is two
so then we take two now we're done the
parentheses
to the exponent 2 to the third power is
eight
and so there you go put your answer in
there
and there we go actual answer is eight
your answer is eight Code test passed
Okay so
all these things and
remember you can just like the other
ones you can do all this you can put
print statements you know all whatever
math you want just straightforward math
in a print statement
python will do that for you so those are
some simple calculator tricks you can do
okay so remainder remember when we
divide something that does not work out
evenly we have a remainder
and the modulus operator
looks like a percent sign but if I'm
using it in the code it tells me just
what the remainder is
there we go so as I have the directions
here
10 divided by 4 is 2 but with
um
but as a remainder
so two and then two left over so 10
modulus four
would give me 2 because that's three
major or 14
divided by 6 will have a remainder so if
I do 8
my a modulus B
and against the percent sign
on most keyboards it's on the same key
as the five but you have to hit shift so
14 divided by six now let's take a guess
14 divided by six
is two with a remainder of 2.
so that's what we're expecting to see
the print out
there we go
now
actually
we could we you don't need to do this
but we could you know show well
supposing if I had
um 15 divided by 6
so
6 times 2 is 12 so there'd be three left
over and so a modules B would be three
if you wanted to you can test these out
because this particular code is testing
did you do it correctly here
so if you wanted to go back and try some
different things
um whereas then if I go to 18 that works
out evenly so
the modulus would be zero there would be
no remainder
and we can use that
to find factors
so we'll have an if statement here
so
if I have
20 modules five
so that's 20 divided by 5.
is 4 works out nicely so
20 modules five the remainder would be
zero so if that's zero
which it is then that means 5 is a
factor so you see we're using the double
equals to test it
so
that's what we're going to do here we're
going to walk through this and we're
gonna
cast this times we do want integers
because
factoring really only works with
integers if you know we can divide a lot
of things but
you know if it's a factor there's going
to be a nice integer
in there so
I'm going to just enter an integer
so input cast it as int and that's going
to be our number
and then here next one enter an integer
to see if it's a factor
and again cast that as an integer and
that's going to be test Factor because I
don't know if it's a factor yet
and
in the if statement I just have if
number now remember
whatever this is if it's true it's going
to do that so if number exists which it
will
then it's going to do this
but
we're going to change the next line so
what do we want number modulus
test Factor
and then now
if that divided by that
gives you zero
then we can say true it is a factor
and then or else it's false
so there we go and
enter an integer so
let's do one that doesn't work so if we
have 11
and
five
false
and we can run it again
and let's say make it 12
3 true
so there we go showing how we can cast
things and we can use that to test if
something is a factor
that that itself might be useful but
we're going to take that and we're going
to build that into other things
like this finding factors
all right finding all the factors of a
number
so very similar to what we did but we're
not asking for second input here we have
the first input
and then we want to find all the factors
so
now I have a my for Loop
four
test factor in range so I'm going to
take this range
let's look at this backwards here
I'm going to take this range and if I
just had one number in there it would
start at zero but I can't have that
because that'll give me a divide by zero
error right away
so I'm going to start the range at 1.
and then end the range at number plus
one
because normally the range it won't do
that last number so I have to add one
and now to make sure whatever that
number is I want to include that
all right so now for test factor in in
this range
it's going to Loop through everything
every number in this range
and one at a time like test factor is
going to be one and then the next num
next time through the loop test factor
is going to be 2. so it will just Loop
through for that many times
yeah for every number in that range
all right and this is what we're going
to change the if statement
so
we want to say if it's a factor
number is our in is the original number
we want and each of these test factors
what do we want to do with it we want to
say if number modulus
test Factor
equals zero just like we were doing
before we're just kind of putting it in
an if statement now
so I get this number and I'm going to
Loop through all these factors from 1 up
to that number
and then if number divided by test
Factor
gives me a remainder of 0 then it is a
factor so then I'll print it out
all right so we run it and
we have let's say 12 12 is a lot of
factors
and you see it'll print them all out one
two three four six and 12.
and we can run it again
enter an integer supposing I enter like
17.
117 because it's Prime
so that's what we're doing just showing
all the factors here
this type of thing we will revisit this
at another time to reduce fractions to
lowest terms
okay now
what about prime numbers
so a prime number
is a number that the only factors are
one in itself
so we're gonna and then anything that's
not prime is composite
so if I have
you know 5 is prime because
the only way you can multiply to get
there is one times five
but six as one you can do one times six
but you can also do two times three so
because you have those other factors
it's composite
so here now we're going to have
um same input and again integers because
we're looking at factors
and
I'm going to start out with this
variable prime or comp
being Prime
and then
same thing range now
notice I started the range 2 because 1
will go into everything and that's not
what I that's not what I want that does
that won't tell me anything so I'm going
to start at 2 up to an including number
again not including the number because
this this this time it won't include the
number I didn't add the one there
because again same reason I didn't have
one one and the number itself
yeah we know that those are factors
but I want to find out from 2 through
any of the other numbers if it's a
factor
and very similar then if number
um
we're going to do the same Loop and you
could always
go back if number divided by
test Factor equals zero
there we go because we have the same
variables here
you know always double check
just in case the variable names change
or a slightly different way of doing
things
but yes if that test Factor works oh see
because this is test number
so this would have given me an error
and and that's the thing with with
reusing code yes we know we're all going
to use a lot of copy and paste
because that helps you know if it's a
whole block of code but be really
careful that it is exactly the variables
and everything that match up correctly
so you know a lot of times people
do too much copy and paste and then
they're lost because things don't match
up
so this one we called a test number so
if number
divided by test number if that has a
remainder of zero then that means that
is a factor which means all it has to do
is happen once and that means the number
is composite and it's only Prime
starts out that variable is Prime and it
stays Prime only if it goes through and
we never get a factor here
throughout the entire thing
all right so let's take a look
if we have
this
and enter a positive integer so let's
enter one
let's say four
composite right because I can always do
two times two and then let's enter one
that we have seven
Prime
and that way you do you can check all
kinds of other things you know oh some
huge number is it Prime is a composite
there we go
and you know now that you have this
you don't have to change any of the code
when you run this it'll
you know it'll uh
test it for you all right
other interesting things reciprocals so
writing it in math
it's the number flipped so I have this
reciprocal of two-thirds is three over
two you see it's just flipped
and then any whole number the reciprocal
of five is one-fifth because any whole
number it's understood that it's a
denominator of zero
or sorry denominator of one
so that'd be five over one so then
that's why it's one-fifth as the
reciprocal and you can multiply a number
by its reciprocal and get one there we
go
pretty good
so
and
there we go zero has no reciprocal
because it'd be divide by zero
so we can write the reciprocal
whatever the number is
we can just actually flip it one divided
by n
that's actually all you need to do to
find the reciprocal
and some of these might be decimals but
nonetheless this will find the
reciprocal for you
and we see our output here enter a
number and
what if I have the number as
five
say 0.2 but that's the decimal
equivalent of one-fifth
all right so
just putting this in there showing you
what you can do with finding reciprocals
other things we can do with the input is
supposing I wanted to have an output
like this enter two numbers separated by
a comma
oh well now but I want to test each of
these numbers
so I can split it so this I'll store it
as the variable nums
still didn't cast it as anything and
then here
this is actually going to be an array in
this case with two elements it's going
to split it at the comma
and then now this array SP
has two elements so I have sp0 the first
one I'll cast that as a float
and then I have sp1
so that's it you know
asking for it to be separated by a comma
split the input
and then then cast each of them
separately
so sp0 and then sp1 and notice the code
here just says cast it as a float so
float
remember to close the parentheses over
here
there we go
and then what do we want to do and that
the directions here are then divide the
two numbers
so that's why we cast them as a float
divided by the two numbers and we have
a divided by B
all right
so there we go split it cast it
and in this case then we're going to
divide
okay so energy numbers separated by a
comma and let's see how about we do
um
this one will be a repeating decimal
up 8 comma 9
. there you go and notice if you have
just one number repeating
the fraction equivalent is that number
over nine
so
0.1 repeating would be 1 9.2 repeating
would be 2 9 and this one eight over
nine
so there we go
okay now this is building up to
something here
is building up to you being able to
factor square roots
but let's talk about square numbers
first so Factor multiplied by itself is
Square
and it is kind of like the area of a
square
um you know both sides would be the same
or all sides would be the same so when I
do length times width to get areas of
the same and so
is that number times itself and we would
use the exponents that to the second
power
okay so all we're doing here is
you know we're taking a number and then
getting the square so in this case
it's going to take the input
as n and
we're just gonna Square it
there we go
okay there we go numbered Square all
right five
output 25.
okay
so let's go the other way square root
function
so anything to the second power it's
squared but what if I knew the result
and I wanted
to square root it so if I knew the area
of my square yard but I want to know
what's the side side measure
so we have sqrt and that's the first
thing we're encountering here that is
not built into python
so we have to import the math Library
and this is where collab really helps
you out because
a lot of times you might have to go
through some other things to install
things
you know in other notebooks
the collab notebook import math
and you don't it's behind the scenes it
works you just have to have the import
statement all right so a number to find
the square root
definitely going to cast as a float
all right and how do we get the square
root of that once we import it it's
going to be math Dot sqrt
and we call it a number n
especially you know think even if things
don't come up automatically just you
make sure open parentheses one two close
parentheses one two we got it
so we're going to enter a number
and we see here
and remember to find the square root so
we'll do one that works out evenly how
about 16
square roots four
and we can do another one that doesn't
work out evenly
um how about 21.
and it'll give you a bunch of decimal
places
I remember yep so 4.5 yeah about
there we go
okay
other cool functions the floor function
this is another one
we have to import math to use it so the
floor function so we have the floor
function which just drops any decimals
um
and there we go drops any decimals and
sometimes called integer part
or the greatest integer
so
even if it's like 3.9 it's going to drop
and just go down to three
the uh
we have the floor function we have the
ceiling function which as you can
imagine if floor drops all the decimals
ceiling is no matter how many what
decimals are even if it's 0.1 it goes up
to the next number
and then round
the one we use possibly most often round
remember
um 0.5 and above rounds up and point
anything less than 0.5 0.4 and down
rounds down
so we're going to look at the math.floor
function here
all right enter a number decimal in
place and we're just going to practice
doing the math.4 function here math Dot
floor of n
so
enter a number with decimal places so
I'm going to call it 5.9999999
and when I hit enter
yep that's the four function even if
it's 0.99
drops down to five
so there we go and remember supposing
you you went back and said oh wait floor
you know I'm upside down
ceiling function
supposing I wanted to do that
then
all right so
um 7.1 because that should round it up
to eight
and so that code works but because that
wasn't what these directions are it'll
tell you oh you should include
math.floor
and again if you end up trying different
things it doesn't prevent you from going
on but if you know I don't know if you
spelled it wrong or something or you did
something different it'll tell you
there you go floor
and here we go
9 point
three
all right
good
drops it okay so we're gonna put some of
this together finding square factors
all right so a few things we've already
done
we're going to import math
and what we're going to do is we're
going to
enter an integer to define the greatest
Square Factor
so
I'll call that Max Factor and right now
it'll be one
and then the upper limit
so notice we're
stacking on these functions here
uh the math.floor of math. square root
of n
but then we're going to add one to it so
we want to find the greatest Square
Factor so whatever number you enter it
in we're going to square root it
that's going to of course have a bunch
of decimal places and so we could do the
math.floor
and then add one to it now I realize
that I could have just done math.cealing
and then skip the plus one
I
for whatever reason I did this I like it
so I kept it
um but there we go that's why
yes uh
so that gives us the upper limit
square root of that number and then but
we really want the next number now
what do we have now my range from 1 to
upper limit
so
and remember this upper that was the
square fact the square root factor I
square rooted it first so for maybe
factor in that range
so it's going to go through and maybe
factor is going to be 1 and then it's
going to be 2 that's going to be three
you know up to this upper limit
so
if
n modules maybe Factor squared
equals zero so that's it these these
factors if I Square them
is that a factor can I can I divide that
out
and if that is then
Max Factor you see it's not going to be
zero what's it going to be
you know that's and that's the idea with
some of these change one line so if you
go through and think about what you're
doing then we see yep I'm Rick going
through this range and maybe factor is
it and then
finding square factors
if n divided by maybe Factor squared if
that gives a remainder of zero then Max
Factor equals
maybe Factor
so that's what we change
there we go
and again
knowing that these were
the square rooted so for our purposes
here we're just printed out squared
so we'll see this here
so if I have something like 12
greatest Square factor is four
because
two you see it prints that squared 2
squared is 4. that and that's a factor
of 12.
3 squared is nine
does not work out
to be an integer
okay
so here
we're going to build upon that code
and then we're going to have
all of this
because
when we look at factoring out square
roots that's kind of what we're building
up to here when you have a square root
that doesn't work out perfectly but yet
you can Factor it a little bit that's
what we want to do here
so
I still have
get the same integer same upper limit
and I just put all these variables equal
to 1 because we'll change those square
root Max Factor other Factor
all right and then take a look at what
this is doing same thing
um
because I still got that same upper
limit
and so
still maybe factors going through that
range
check for square factors just like we
did before
and then
there we go and in this case
Max Factor equals maybe factors squared
there we go and then other factor is n
the original number divided by Max
Factor
so
there we go so what we have is
the result is going to be
that original number n equals
this times this
and we're just looking at how that
divides out
so in this case
you don't need to change anything
because I I thought that this was a
little bit you know I a little bit
complex to try to follow like what what
I was thinking through so I didn't
didn't want to have you have to change
anything and just take a look at what's
going on here
how we're dividing that out and then
when you run it
so if I enter an integer to factor maybe
I'll do the same 12 here
see 12 equals 4 times 3.
or if I do this again let's say 50
equals 25 times 2 and again that first
part is a square Factor
so now
there we go the last four steps prepares
you for this
so factoring out a square root this is
kind of what we want 12 if we look at
square root of 12 is 4 times 3
. so then since 4 is a perfect square
the square root of 4 comes out and it
becomes 2 root 3. and that's what we're
kind of building as we're building this
code to do
is this whatever is that square root
number
I'm finding the greatest Square Factor
and then that comes out because the
square root of 4 is 2 2 is on the
outside now
all right and in doing this we're going
to import math because we have square
root and for our final output we're
going to import Sim pi and symbols
because that's going to give us a nice
output at the end that looks like this
so that's the thing you know python
outputs a certain way and then if I
wanted to Output the looks more like
math symbols
that's we have symbolic python
using our math symbols so
more input without the radical and our
square root Factor
using those same variables
dividing these
same type of thing
where we're finding maybe Factor
and then Max Factor
now in this case I kept it like this
maybe factors squared so the Max Factor
is squared
because and then we divide
so now
we do the output so
I am going to square root it again
yes and I realize that up here
is maybe Factor squared and then down
here I'm Square rooting it again
and the key is casting it as an integer
because this will be an integer at this
point oh
did not want to do that there we go
because this will be an integer
at this point uh casting it as an
integer
Okay so
that's the square root
and then
remember other factor out here was my
original divided by that Max Factor
and if there's anything left over other
that's other Factor
down here I'm casting that as an integer
and
you know that's it I'm just taking this
other Factor but casting it as an
integer and you see that you can do that
with variables
so now it's now it's an integer and now
the output
is square root
which was this variable up here times
Sim Pi so
this Senpai dot square root is different
than math that's square root
and using this simpi output
I want that to be my last
uh
I want to be that to be my last thing is
this output so
down here
after it does
this for the test that's why output the
word output shows up here we stored as
this here but notice it's not a print
statement it just says output and the
last thing just says output and it will
display it
so these types of senpai displays
sometimes you just need to put that
there output as the last thing
okay so what do we have uh let's take a
look at our
um
let's take a look at 50 as we were
talking about before
so
and just because this came first that's
why it says test passed here
and then we see the output but 50
factors out to
5 root 2.
and if we run it again
then we have you know go back to our 12.
12 is 2 root 3.
and we can see
how we can factor out these square roots
so
there we go this is now one of the
things that you can do
and this would be a bonus we could do
this later is
we already talked about functions you
could put all this in a function
you know all you know you don't need to
the testing part but the output
you could put this all in a function
that would Factor square roots for you
so just like you have math.square dot
sqrt to Output the number which may be a
decimal you could actually make your own
function that would do all this and then
output a radical
you know like this
so some interesting things that you can
do and that's kind of I wanted you to
see the build up of this and how we can
use these you know loops and factors and
do this to factoring the square root
which is something that's
you know pretty interesting in math
useful for some math you get into and
that you can write code to do it
all right
um here's some rounding just interesting
things so if I just say round it'll
round it to a whole number
if I have something like this if I round
comma and then have a number that'll
tell me how many decimal places
and if I have this round and it's a
negative number that'll be for big
numbers so there will give me that many
zeros
so there we go
so
first number rounded to the millions the
second number round to the six decimal
places so
and I do need to go back to my print
statements print
ground
and the first number
six zeros so I have to make it negative
six
and then the second one
print
round
B and I wanted three decimal places so
it would be three
there we go and we could print
so that there's my six decimal places
and you see then
you know I don't want it around to the
next integer it already is an integer
but I want
uh
14 million
500 000 rounds to 15 million and then
the next one
yep rounds to double 07. of course
all right
there we go
and
fractions decimals and percents
so we could see here and we've done some
things like this before
that
here we're going to take the input
as a string
you see I'm going to import math for for
later take the input as a string and as
a string every string has this built-in
l-e-n which is the length of that string
so I want to take the length of that
string
and then I need to cast it as an integer
now remember the person who enters this
in is going to put a decimal place so
that's why I have to subtract 1 because
I don't want that decimal place I just
want how many decimal places without
that dot
all right so that's going to be the
exponent
and then
now that I've done that now my input
digits I'm going to cast that as a float
so
the numerator is going to be
n
times
to that
exponent
at a radiologist to make it clear what
we're talking about here so
anything with three decimal places it's
going to be times ten to the third and
doing that is going to move the decimal
place over
and then my numerator is actually going
to be an integer
and the denominator is that
to the Third
oh 10 to the exponent
there we go
so there's my fraction
and this is really what we're doing
anytime we're converting fractions but
now we're just writing code to make it
easier so how many decimal places that's
really what this is essentially doing
here how many decimal places am I
talking about and then
that number times 10 to that those
decimal places
10 to that exponent and the denominator
is 10 to that exponent
so then the percent
because now that I've have it as
um
numerator denominator now I actually
really can just go back to n if I want
or I could put numerator times the
numerator divided by denominator
whichever one but I could do n times 100
which it's always times 100 because it
moves the decimal place over
and so that's it that's the first two
digits are there are your percent so n
times 100 gives you the percent
and we can run it
so if I have somebody enters in
something like .125
there we go
so the decimal is 0.125
the fraction is one two five out of over
a thousand
and the percent is 12.5 percent
so there we go converting
any input
fraction decimal percent
and this is where I was saying that you
could
you could Define
this font you can define a function here
where you can execute a block of code
with one command so
here's the function definition
Def and then the name of the function
open and close parentheses that may take
input but they don't have to
and then input indented four spaces one
two three four
So Def name of the function colon
anything in the function it can be as
many lines as you want and it can have
comments
just indented four spaces
and then there you go here's one
something outside the function and then
that function is defined and then it's
it's then caught it won't do anything
until it's called here
so I could have this function definition
and if I
took out this line it wouldn't do
anything
so now it'll have this is outside the
function
then it'll print this is in the function
and then back outside the function
there you go now change the name and
remember to call it so
there we go and then we want to run it
then change the name to fun
because can't spell function without fun
so if I just change the name I'm going
to call it fun
and now I'm going to call the function
so that's what is the function call is
when I you know when I tell all right
let's run that function now
there you go same thing
show you how to define a function and
then call the function
and then here's one with input
so it can take input any input we're
going to call it argument
so
there we go
um
now right here it's telling me that it's
uh you know called function called
greeting it's going to take this input
which will stores variable name
that's within the function here and it's
going to print hello whatever the name
is
now here outside the function so notice
at the end of your function
skip a line at least one line so then
that's the break and now this is
definitely not in the function
and then the input
and casting it as a string which is f it
is a string and we'll keep it that that
way what is your name and notice inside
the quotes that slash n will indicate a
new line
so now when we run the greeting you see
it's passed you know I take that
variable and I'm going to pass that into
the function so now that function takes
input
and then it's going to be this variable
and it'll do the greeting
so
there you go what is your name
Ed
hello
there we go
and now
now that you see this working this is
just changing the this because
it's like remembering where these are
so
you know greeting and then when we call
it
I'm going to change this variable here
there we go
so we see you know where these variables
are especially in a small simple
function like this so then we see you
know this variable how do I pass it to
the function as an argument there and
then in the function definition
it's expecting input and doing something
with it
but the function of this should actually
be the same
go
yep see
all good
and these functions which is kind of
cool you could have more than one input
so we have this
so
I can have multiple input in this
function
and then
in this case you know do something with
it well we're just going to add them all
but you could use this for any formula
you have
you see like I just made this ad but you
can use this for whatever formula you
have make a function out of it
so notice here
the third I'll leave this as three
and then it's gonna expect three inputs
a b c
and then a plus b plus c
and
now down here
I have to call it with all three
variables so
now notice this variable existed before
but then it just stay there floating not
doing anything
and then we have
here you know now that we have have this
I'm going to call the function with all
three inputs because the function is
expecting three inputs and then it's
going to do something with those
and so there we go
so we see enter a number
and
I'll enter a number
and another number six another number
seven oh because
there we go five and six is eleven plus
three is fourteen
so there we go
they fund with functions
now
all the this function and the ones we
had so far they included a print
statement
as a way to show output and that's good
but we could also have a function with a
return value
so
notice this function here
then it just returns that
that value
and what that does is it returns it
right where you call the function
so notice this
if
we're going to take this enter a number
you know there's our input it's the
float I'm going to store it as variable
a
so now
what I print
is your number multiplied equals
and then right here
it's going to be
that function I call that function with
variable a
and that's what this is
and it's just going to take it times two
there we go
all right so
notice some of these you run it and then
we're going to change something and then
run it again so enter a number all right
um
there you go 16.
your number multiplied is 32.
so
all we're doing here is changing the
return statement
multiply it by three instead
everything else we actually can keep the
same
there we go and our number
16.
and it's 48.
so that's the return statement is
right where you call the function
that's where the number shows up your
number multiplied equals and then
returns that so that's pretty useful
sometimes because we want that to just
be where you know where do I want this
output to be right there and so we put
the function call there so that's the
return statement's good useful
statement here
so we have all these different things we
have all these functions we you know
we're looking at factoring we're looking
at solving some things you can even just
solve for x
and
there we go X as the classic unknown
now notice here we're importing Senpai
again for our symbolic math
and we're going to take it even further
from Senpai we're going to import
symbols and from Senpai solvers we're
going to import solve
so all these now
I'll just Define it here
x equals symbols and notice it's just X
in single quotes so that's telling us
that we're going to use X as a symbol
in math
and the way that simply solve works is
the equation has to be equal to zero
so
at what I'm going to do all right well
we'll see
here's the output solve for x and I even
have this here zero equals and then
you're going to enter it in
now
what this does
Senpai has this built in solve
and notice
the output is going to be right here so
that solve we know that behind the
scenes it has a return value so solve
that equation using the variable X
and this is just like a subtle thing
that
we will talk about at another time but
this returns a
finite set and for this we're going to
say this is the first answer that we
want
equation zero
so
enter an equation and then this is going
to Output the answer
there we go
all right I wrote an equation and so if
I have let's let's do like you know
2 times x
um
minus 8.
so
we could see that X must be four
and it'll output it there
now if I didn't have this
I'll do I'll do the exact same thing 2
times x
minus eight
it just the way it displays it because
it's a finite set now that also opens up
the door to possibly if I put in
something that had more than one answer
I could do that and that works too
if I have
uh let's see if I'll run it again
so supposing I have now this will work
even if it doesn't work out to a nice
integer but I'm going to make this work
to a nice integer
um x squared minus 9.
you see negative three and three it does
have two answers and it'll output both
of those
so
this one
yeah
and
enter an equation
x minus four so
there we go
if you didn't get a syntax error you're
ready for the project
so different things you can do so this
is where we now can make
make your own functions
and this is where I leave it open to you
how you could do this you know make your
own functions like you could take
um one of these functions here
like the factoring the square root
yeah so you could take this factoring
square root and copy all of this
on
all right so as an example of something
something you could do
and down here you could make this a
function
so
you could do
this now what's interesting is you as
defining the function here
uh
you could Define it
Factor
sqrt
and we definitely want input
um
and I'm going to make it n
so
we could do this
that
it factors the square root and you could
make each of these
then you have to make sure
you
indent everything
now
since
or fact and skirt and we don't need that
input
then we can actually delete that
and
here we go use
you know we can keep all these
and this is the thing with a function
is you do want everything
to
be and you can take out things like
notice what it's doing in the loop
there we go
then this has to be indebted
and all of these divide up we can even
keep these
and we see
that we have output
okay
all right and this part we don't need
um
and
what do we want to do we want to
we can backspace that
okay
yes the staff does not have a test
because this is so what you have is you
can Define that factor square root and
then down here later
we could try to call it
Factor
square root and you know uh let's see
um
20.
here we go and
oh maybe I have to return the output
it's actually kind of funny that just
popped up but there we go
so you see the output but because it's
in a function we have to include that as
a return statement
all right so
this is you know this is not the part of
the function but everything else is and
these are some things you can do because
then you can
you know different ways you can
just Define them in your own you know
collab code cell with some text
ahead of it you could
you know you can make them all functions
um but that's the idea and then you
could create a menu if you wanted to
where you just have
um
which one you know what function should
you run
you could do a table of contents there
too and then that's the that's the
project you're building this
multi-function calculator you're putting
all these things together into a collab
notebook that you're going
to be able to use and it's going to be
your multi-function calculator and then
as of making this video
um I can't tell you exactly where to
upload that that code but hold on to it
and then you'll see where to put it
together for
you know officially uh
getting the credit for passing this part
of the certification and then
maybe on to the next part
all right so hopefully this was useful
um
you know how to work through this and
you know how to
um
put all this together into this
certification project
I you know we wanted to be you know that
there's more than one way to
do all this
so find find a way that works for you
you know
making your own calculator
all right and we'll go on to the next
project
so with graphing a system of equations
we're looking at really just graphing
two equations on the on the same x y
axis and
we want to see where do these two lines
cross that's going to be the solution to
our system of equations
so as an example here we have two
equations and this one's y equals 3x
plus 10 and this other one is y equals
4X so let's say I don't know it's
um
place you like to go let's say costs you
know four dollars admission so four
dollars times x which is every time you
go then y would be the total cost and
then they have a deal oh well if you pay
ten dollar membership fee then your
admissions three dollars
so there you have the the decision like
okay well with this membership fee my
admission is lower but when would these
be the same price you know how many
times would I have to go for these to be
the same price so we want you know
that's that's just one example of the of
you know the the use of this so I put
these both in y equals because we're
going to get into some other ways to
solve this but we're looking at just how
this graph plays out here so if I graph
that y equals 3x plus 10 so without
numbers here we're just going to
estimate let's say 10 is here and
you know that's how we plot begin at 10
and then Up 3 over
1 and let's just say you know it's
something like this
and let's just say that's the line and
then we have y equals 4X so there's no
beginning it begins at zero but it's a
steeper slope
you know be it zero steeper slope and
then let's just say you know it looks
something like this and then
they cross somewhere where do these
lines intersect that's going to be the
solution to our system of equations and
let's just imagine that there are
numbers here and it was you know
somewhere around 10 so
um you know let's just say that that
would be like 10 you know 40 something
like that
you know I see the invisible numbers on
there so you see where these cross and
depending on what you're using to graph
you know it might be clearer to see
might be harder to see but we can then
always test it oh if I see it looks like
that's where that's where these lines
intersect we can plug that in does that
work for each one so if x is 10 so it
would be 3 times 10
plus 10 and then y would be 40. so our
question is does that work 3 times 10 is
30 plus 10 is 40 yes that does work
and then it would be the same thing you
know 4 times 10
and
Y is 40 and then that works so that's
how we would confirm it and if we were
doing this you know old school plotting
a bunch of points I could always put you
know my X Y table and plot a bunch of
points if I was using graph paper
and what we're going to do though and
the reason why I didn't worry about
getting this you know these exact
details this is not drawn to scale
is because I want to just you want you
to see you know the the way that this
comes together two lines on the same
graph my question is where do these
lines intersect and then next we're
going to look at the code how can I set
up a graph how can I plot two points on
the same graph and you know for whatever
the answer might be however
um you know minute the fraction or
decimal might be how we can find the
solution each time
so now let's take a look at the code
so if you remember graphing one equation
on a on a Cartesian plane this isn't
going to be that much different one of
the big things though is we're going to
use the numpy library instead of a loop
so I will talk about that more in a
second but the first thing we need to do
is import it here import numpy now you
know this PLT that makes it a lot
shorter instead of writing matplotlab.pi
plot numpy we shorten it you know it's
just a little bit shorter but NP seems
to be the you know the common
abbreviation so we're going to do that
and you'll see NP dot this and Dot that
throughout throughout this code
so like before we are going to Define
our range X Min x max y Min y Max there
we go and one of the things with the
numpy array is instead of
creating a loop like we were doing
before what this does is this defines an
array of X values and the first thing we
need to do then is to find how many
points I want to plot so I'll take these
X values no notice x max minus X Min so
how many
values I have there and that should give
me an integer number but I'm going to
say 10 you know 10 times this number
that's how many points I want
that's actually going to be for linear
equations you really don't need that
many they it displays very nicely for
anything with a little bit of a curve on
it that's probably plenty and for some
more complicated graphs you might do
more than 10.
so that gives me the number of points I
have and just again based on these so if
I change the window then this updates
automatically and then here's where I'm
going to define the array of X values
once so
using the library np.linspace
and it gives it takes the arguments X
Min X Max and then how many points so
there we go it's just going through
these where am I going to start and how
many points in between
and I'm just storing that as X because
I'm going to use that as my X values
hopefully this is looking familiar
setting up you know the window size the
axis for x and y and here's where we're
going to plot line one
so in this case I have y1 equals 2 times
x there we go and what it does is that
will take each of these X values rather
than me needing to create a loop it'll
go through each of these X values and
plot them
and then I have
plt.plot X and then y1 so here we go I
have
this and the second line I'm going to do
the same thing Y2 equals and this one I
took it Beyond linear I just made it x
squared minus 3 just to change it up a
little bit and so there we go that's my
second y value and
here we go what do I want to plot here
X the X values and then Y2
so there we go to find the X values and
show the graph so
when we run this
there we have it we have our each axis
that first y1 is a linear equation light
blue line and Y2 was the parabola
now that's a pretty good Parabola just
to show you that if I had
fewer points let's just say even two
times this
yeah that's probably low enough that
you're still going to see this become
choppy
ah wasn't that bad
but if I really only have
one times this
then it really becomes a lot choppier
because I'm only plotting every integer
and there's a lot more going on here
but you see how that linear
equation yeah straight line worked out
just fine but this one yeah
so that's why
just as a default
I'll do 10 times that
and
so there we go and then to graph
anything else all we have to do is
change these y1 okay well how about if I
make this like negative
negative 3x
I'll just leave it at that
oh because
three times x there we go
if you write it by hand you know doing
the math off to you know you forget the
multiplying so that's the key python
syntax you have to remember there you go
um
and let's take a look at this and maybe
we'll make this one
um
there we go just to the third power how
about that
so there we go another linear equation
and this one here cubic
and we'll run this
there we go and we see
you know even this yep the curve looks
nice
so there we go all you have to do is
change
y1 and Y2 and you actually can graph
more than more than two but a lot of
times we're going to do linear equations
and have two lines on the same and our
question is where do they intersect
so there we go
numpy and
use that
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the collab notebook so
you can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
those use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
okay so I want to show you just a few
other things you can do with graph with
graphing and one of them is shading in
between lines or just in general above
and below so if you have an inequality
you can shade above the line or below
the line
we see we don't need to import anything
different this should look familiar from
the graphs you've been doing set up X
Min and maximum how many points and then
Lin space for your array and we've been
doing this before here's the line and
then we're going to plot that now this
one if you're doing an inequality you
could also add the other argument of
making it a dashed line
but this might be hard to see this line
but here's the twist here the fill
between
so we're going to say
from X
still the same X values and then the
fill between is between these two y
values
from y1 up to 10. and you could Define
that as a definite number 10 you know
we've already set our maximum or you
could actually say up to Y Max
like that's another way to do it and
this one we call it you know we want to
make this red so that takes the other
argument python will give you a default
but you know you can Define these and
that makes a lot better so there we go
the fill between same x value and then
you have the range of Y values that's
the way that's going to work
and we'll do a few lines here we'll make
make some art so line two I can see
again The Familiar Define the line and
then plot
there we go but then we're going to do
the fill between between that X and Y2
and y1
so you see you can Define it even you
know this one I'm going to go up to the
top this one I'm going to go up to the
other line
and here we go so fill line three very
similar
and there we go each of these I'm
defining a different face color
and this one's going to be green
where am I filling between and be
filling between this one that we've
defined up here Y3 and Y2 so that's so
these are just these two line two and
three are just going to be a band and
here we go
I can do this one between
uh graphing another one and notice all
these are just simple linear equations
to show you this
and we're graphing between these two so
what happens when we run this
so we see we get the first one from that
line up to the top and then from there
to there from there to there
and there we go
so
if the second one if we had
let's say all right we see this red we
see this yellow so if the yellow one
instead of ending it there I went up to
y Max
it would just overlap
and I know you might be you might have
been thinking hey might have might turn
orange you know yellow yellow and red
but actually it's the order of things
that
it graphs this that was red but then
then it graphed this and then it
overwrote the red
and if I wanted to
I still call it a line one but
if I wanted to move that down here
so now this is yellow and then this
whole thing would be red
and remember because the yellow started
down lower so the red will go on top of
that but it didn't go down this far so
the red didn't cover this
so we see you know that's it
um
you know the yellow line
was X plus 3 and then the red line was X
plus six so you still had that little
Gap that you know when the red went on
it didn't totally cover the yellow
all right but then we can you know y1
and now this one I definitely need to
put this one back because y1 wasn't
defined yet so you see it gave me that
little error there
so just I'll move it back and
make this official before we go on to
the next thing
and we can see
so since I moved a few things around
before we run it let's let's change
something else here I was saying that we
need we could do the dashed line so
we'll make the red line and the yellow
line the dashed line
and it might be hard to see but we we'll
hope we can always hope here so single
quotes and then I'm going to make it a
dash
and I'll do the same thing with this one
the other argument single quotes and
I'll make it a dash so that those two
would be dashed lines instead of a solid
line
it's hard to see
it's a little bit
but you know there we go
um
and because these you know with the
shading sometimes you might not even
need to plot the exact line I mean
mathematically you might just be in the
habit hey I want to also show that line
but the way it shows up on the graph
you know it's the you see the dividing
line it you know it's nice but sometimes
you might say oh okay if I'm making some
sort of art sometimes I might not want
or need that extra line
so there we go so there's some different
things you can do you know
um
draw lines shade above and below and you
can be you can get creative with this
and make all sorts of all sorts of
things and this is essentially you know
what vector graphics are
you know not you know defining each
individual pixel but defining the lines
that you draw based on equations
and then that way you can scale things
because
let's say I wanted to scale that if I
just change the
dimensions of my graph
I could scale this line with the same
code and the same equations so that's
the advantage vector graphics
you can make larger things but with not
much bigger file size because it's all
defined on equations anyway
so there we go some some cool things you
can do with that other cool things you
can create an interactive graph
all right and with indirect interactive
we're going to set up some sliders
um this one's called interactive if you
might come across some python code that
defines sliders that actually uses the
word slider that you know that works too
but here's we're going to import
there we go inline
um and the inline part is going to get
us to be able to adjust these sliders
and see the effect on the graph right
away
so there we go and then this interactive
widget
so I'm going to Define all the graphing
notice is going to happen within this
function
so I'm going to Define this function
so
again I made it a simple slope intercept
so I'm going to define the function of m
b and then I put another variable for
zoom
so notice all of your Dimensions here
are based on that variable for zoom
and then we solve the points
and
the plot that's my y value MX plus b
so now this function takes these inputs
and here's the slider
it's really the most of it is right here
on this line
so
interactive plot now I can make that
whatever variable I want I just decided
to call it that and interactive open
parentheses so the first thing is what
function am I going to run
and I made it f and the main reason I
made it f is the line this line of code
was not that long
but there you go what function am I
going to run
and then let's define some ranges here m
will go from negative nine to nine B
will go from negative 99 and zoom will
go from one to a hundred
so notice the zoom I could make it
really small and X min max you know I
could zoom it all in it's
still going to be square
but I could zoom it really into just one
in every direction or I could zoom it
out to 100 and I could change that
number as I see fit
so there we go so what we have is this
and when we run that interactive plot
it's going to take the input from these
sliders and then run this function
so let's see how that works
so a lot of times the default
puts everything right in the middle
so
my slope is zero and B is zero so you
might be able to see that the axis is
black but this line this blue line is on
there because it's a slope of zero
because zero what happens when I move
that up
see look at that now I have a slope of
three
and as I move up B
then it crosses the y-axis at a
different place it begins right there
now
we see it starts right in the middle at
50 so I could bring this down
and you see I can zoom in
pretty cool
and see this is what I zoom if I'm so
zoomed in one ever Direction notice B
was five so that's off the graph now I
have to move that back now you start
seeing it on the graph
and these are some cool things you can
do with your graph you can add this
interactive even if you you know you're
graphing all kinds of things you just
want to change the zoom this is a nice
way to zoom
and you know you might see some things
on other calculators where you can zoom
and here's how you can write the code
you can have your own graph that Zooms
in and out and you can adjust some other
things
so there we go some cool some cool
things you can do and I just want to you
know it's a good way to illustrate you
know
slope and intercept as they change how
does the graph change
you see and then I can make B negative
and therefore across the y axis down
here
and I can change the zoom
you know all the way
so now I'm really zoomed out and it it
looks like this might even cross at zero
zero because it's so tiny it only
crosses at negative three
and my graph is so zoomed out
but there we go some interesting things
you can do with zooming
and you see the just you make that
interactive plot and then your function
all the graphing happens in that
function
okay so here's another interesting way
to graph we can actually because all
this math is going to lead you to
working with data science so let's just
get a little taste of it here that
somebody else created this Library this
Medio stat Library
for
getting just some basic weather
information
here's you know the weather information
that they take time average temperature
minimum temperature maximum temperature
precipitation snow wind direction wind
speed this is
the wind gusts
the maximum wind gusts air pressure and
the amount of sun
so there you go planning setting up your
solar panels you can calculate the hours
of Sun at a particular place uh planning
to set up your wind turbines you can
calculate wind speed at different places
and
here's how this works this one you do
need to install this
and so we're going to run pip.install
and I just made that its own separate
um
it's a its own separate code block and
there we go we just see that this
stopped running and
that installed this so there's a lot of
things already built into collab you
might have noticed we've imported some
things but didn't need to install
anything
this is a newer library and therefore
it's not already built in so some of
those newer libraries
the install I mean it's really pretty
straightforward pip install video stat
done
so install that library now we can
import it
date time
that was our I was already at python
library but we just do need to import
that and then now
we still need to import this because
we're going to plot this this data so
that's why we import that and then the
install enabled us to do this import
these I've included the link here
you know for all the documentation
all right so here's how it works
start we'll Define these variables and
they take this date time year month day
year month day so I decided let's do
like the first half of 2022 and
so we have uh
create a point now the point you create
this is latitude and longitude
so they don't have really built-in like
type in the name of a city
you want to have an idea like you know
where you live you can find it like an
exact latitude and longitude of where
you are you can
find latitude longitude you know
somewhere you know if you want a
particular City somewhere in the city so
the example that you might see if you
look up look this up you know somebody
uh did this for British Columbia so I
change it and did this for Philadelphia
so there we go so here's a point in the
middle of the city
and
we can just get the data here so from
that point so
there we go data daily and then
um there's my data point Philly and
start and end
so there we go so we have this you know
start date and date location and then
collect the data
it seems like this would over write it
but
this does work using the same variable
data equals this data equals data.fetch
so
there we go it works out and this one I
just said hey let's just plot the
average temperature so notice it looks
very similar
data Dot Plot
and then down here we have plt.show
but there's nothing else we need to do
it actually all the rest of it the
dimensions and even some other things
the way it labels the graph happen
automatically
so there we go we just have y equals and
then we're going to plot these three
things
so when I run it
we see the average temperature
there we go average min max
so all these things
you know
in a previous video we were talking
about you know how to create a legend
how to label the axis and everything
this already does all that for you and
it'll just graphically what you have
here
all right so there we go um and notice
the temperature is in Celsius so
there you go if you're in Philly you're
like hey it hasn't been 30 degrees here
in a long time but yes this is Celsius
so notice it's going way above that yep
June July pretty hot
and then we can just change this
um
we can have
temperature average maybe we'll we'll
keep that and maybe we'll do one of the
other ones uh precipitation
prcp
there we go
so
we'll graph this
and we see
so average temperature
and then precipitation
there we go
pretty cool
and we can see and of course then you
know there there is another one here
snow
now what you can see is all right if
there's average temperature below zero
and then
precipitation then you'd expect hey
maybe there's going to be snow
but we can
add that and we'll see
so
there we go snow is in green and
you'd think look at that average
precipitation there's precipitation and
below average temperatures but no snow
precipitation below average temperatures
but no snow or below zero temperatures
and yep it's kind of weird but it
happened
but just there you go here beginning
January
some snow
February some snow and there we go
that's it
so interesting things you can do and
you know even we were talking about
having this on your you know having the
collab app on your phone you could have
um
you could have something you know
related to uh you know write write an
another line in here to get you know to
get today's date or yesterday's date and
sort you know use that as the end date
and
you know have your app and click on
click on something run it and you know
see the historic temperatures or
snowfall or wind up till now if that's
interesting you could do some other
things with this so
just some good things we can do with
graphing and you see just getting a
little bit of taste to how this is why
python is so good for data science
because a lot of people make these apis
that you can just
write a few lines of code and get the
get the data you need and automatically
graph it it's pretty powerful like that
and you see the the graphing that we end
up doing is the same you know
matplot Library
so
pretty good some some cool things you
can do with graphing
and
uh we'll continue on the theme that you
know next we'll look at solving
equations and graphing you know all
together which ends up being tricky but
we'll show you how to do it
okay so yeah take a look at this Tinker
with it you know set up some
you know some you know weather weather
weather report code for yourself
all right
now we're going to look at how to solve
a system of equations even without the
graph
and you can still picture the graph the
idea that that's that's what this is
these are two systems of equate these
are two equations two functions that you
could graph but I don't need to see the
graph to get the solution and sometimes
for solutions that it might not be easy
to see on a graph then you know maybe
it's you know not a nice integer
solving this this is going to work each
time so we're going to look at how to do
this
just on paper or on the board and then
we'll look at the code on how to do this
and set it up to be able to solve
anything just change the equation so if
I have these
two equations one of the ways to solve
this and this is some version of
substitution is if we notice if this
equals y and this equals y then they can
equal each other then 3x plus 10
equals 4X
so we see that if that equals y and that
equals y then these must equal each
other 3x plus 10 equals 4X and that's a
little bit of the logic that's inherent
in in all of math
so now we can solve these
what can I do to solve for x I can
subtract 3x from both sides
and then I get 10 equals x now once I
solve that X is 10
well I want a point so that's my x value
I need my y value and I can plug this
in to either equation so I would take
this and let's say I want to plug it
into here so y equals 4X then I could
take that and Y equals 4 times 10.
and that gives me y equals 40.
and then that's how we would get the
solution we can set these equal to each
other and then solve solve usually for x
and then plug that in either one of
those and then get our y value now this
is very similar to how this is going to
work out in the code
one of the things that makes uh Sim the
Senpai library and solving this with
python a little bit better is this works
out nicely when they're equal to Y and
you know that looks but if I had
equations
that were not equal to y or something
like that
um with the python code what I would do
and we would do the same thing with this
is the idea that I would make out of
what each of these equal to zero
so
I would end up subtracting y here so I
would get you know 3x
plus 10
and I subtract y from both sides equals
zero and that's the version I'm going to
want this in when I solve it with the
code and then the same thing here you
know 4X minus y equals 0.
and then with each of them set equal to
zero
then you we'll we'll see how that that
plays out using the Senpai library but
that's that's kind of the method that
python uses to solve
so
one of the advantages of this is that
they could be in whatever form they want
whatever you have on the other side of
the equal sign just subtract it over and
then now you have two equations equal to
zero and you can solve it
so you know and there's many other ways
to solve systems of equations but that's
kind of a couple ways I want to show you
you know this this type of factoring
where you can set these equations equal
to each other solve for one variable and
then get the other one
and then we'll take a look at it now so
let's take a look at the code
so let's start with the simplest way to
solve a system of equations and now this
is especially for linear equations so
you want to set each equation equal to
zero
but as far as algebra steps go that's
fine it you know it doesn't have to be
simplified just as long as it equals
zero so here we're going to use Senpai
or symbolic math library and I'm just
importing everything from Senpai import
everything so that's the asterisk there
and we're going to Define X and Y as
symbols
so we see this there we go X Y symbols
and
now
here's the equation set equal to zero so
first one here and second one here then
I just defined it as first and second
and here's how we get the solution
so this is the
Lin solve is the is the formula
from Senpai Lin solve and it takes
notice the extra brackets first comma
second so it takes this as essentially
an array of two different equations
and then the next argument comma X Y in
an additional parentheses so it's using
these symbols so linear solve these two
equations
um because if the reach set equal to
zero we can set them equal to each other
and use these symbols and when you run
this
I already ran it we see it comes out as
a finite set now
again the simplest way is there we go we
set these and here's the one line that
puts it all together
you can just change you know change
these two equations and run it and
either you see your answer it's pretty
clear
it's a finite set X is negative one y is
three
supposing I want it to look a little bit
nicer
so still importing everything from
senpai
and these symbols still have the same
I'm going to use the same equations
first and second
now
here
where I have this solution here
that's the same line but now I know that
this solution variable
is going to be a finite set but there's
things I can do with that so I'm going
to create another variable X solution
here
and I'm going to take this solution.org
zero zero notice it behind the scenes
it's a two-dimensional array so I want
the first thing and then the Y solution
also a two-dimensional race
solution.arg01
so having this
I can print
a coordinate pair so there you all print
the parentheses x solution comma y
solution the closing parentheses and
then when I run this
there we go
it will print you know negative 1 3 in
parentheses and I can do other things
with that now
um
there we go so what if I also want to
see the graph now this gets tricky
because we can't graph the same way
that we would
otherwise because
going through loops
doesn't really work with Senpai of going
through numpy doesn't really work with
Senpai but Senpai has its own plot that
we can use
so there we go if it doesn't work with
the others but it has its own so from
SIM Pi dot plotting I'm going to import
plot
and so this is the Senpai plot and
slightly different way I declare these
variables here
VAR
um X Y here
then
this one
is similar to what we were doing set
equal to zero ready to solve
that looks pretty similar to what we
were just doing same with the second
equation
and so this part I'm still going to go
through the same thing
you know get the solution
um
get the solution get the X solution the
Y solution
and print so this is what I J this is
all the same who we just did before but
one of the other things that we can do
is now that I have these and I know that
these are equations set equal to zero
now Senpai syntax
for something set equal to zero if I
want to get it ready to factor
so my y value for the first equation I
called it y first so in Senpai we're
going to Define this is an equation
first and then comma zero means that's
that first equation
and I'm just spelling it out that it was
set equal to zero I kind of need that so
now y first is that set equal to zero
and then
y1 I'm going to make this variable y1
which solves that first equation you see
y first
comma y so
I'm going to take that here
spell it out that it's set equal to zero
and then do my algebra factoring I'm
going to solve for y
and solve for y and then store it as
this variable y1
I'm going to do the same thing for the
second equation so set it as an equation
second the second equation is comma zero
y second and then I'm going to solve it
y second comma y I'm going to solve it
for y so now that I have y1 and Y2
I can print them because that might be
interesting
so it's just going to give me these so I
have
y equals that I will display exactly
comma and then here's the variable y1 0
and Y 2 0. again because you know the
index of the array
so we have
these that I can show factor of what we
were talking about
graphing this so let's do that next but
now I have I will display the solution I
will display
these
you know y equals equations and now when
I plot the solution
I didn't just Factor it to see that as y
equals though that is really nice I
actually usually like that but to plot
the solution here
see now I'm going to just reference X as
a symbol
and then
take a look at this I'm going to plot
but notice nothing Dot Plot this is just
plot within Senpai plot
and what am I plotting this
y value y 1 0 and this one y two zero
so
there we go so when we
factored it into y equals that helped us
not just display the solution but put
this into here that this is what I'm
plotting these two y equals equations
and then the x value
notice also a little bit different the
way we display X comma negative 10 to
10.
I could you know make these other
variables but that's going to work out
just fine for us
so then when we run this
I see the solution
I have it as y equals I have that one as
y equals and then I see the graph and we
see where the solution is negative 1 3.
there we go
so
we can do this for you know any other
ones here
um
there we go let's just change it up
maybe make it negative 2x you know I
know minus two and maybe this one make
this like
2 times x
and I don't know like plus eight
change it up a little bit and so we have
our first ones and we'll solve it
print out the solution
Factor it
shows a y equals equations and then
graph it
and now we have this new one two six is
the solution here are my two equations y
equals 2 times X plus two and Y equals X
plus four
so we see these two and
how do we know which one the two times x
has a steeper slope so that's got to be
this one that's the bottom line
and then the X plus 4 the slope's only
one so that's got to be this Top Line
and we see that they intersect here at 2
6.
all right so we see how we can solve and
we can solve and graph
there we go and this works for linear
equations for
uh equations Beyond linear we'll we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it
which is going to be in the upcoming
sections
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
that use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here so
here again is where we're going to put
together all the
newer functions you've been learning
into your calculator so that you'll have
these as a reference and remember we
already have or you should already have
the proportions set up so the text to
show the setup and then the code to
enter it in and solve your proportion
and remember we made this a heading so
we can minimize that there we go
and we already did this converting
decimals to fractions and percent so
again all the code there
and that's also section heading solve
for x
so each week you know you're learning
and we're building and then we're going
to take like the final product
all of it put together so here's one
if you just have a uh an equation that
you want to solve for x pretty
straightforward we'll have that there
and
factoring so we can solve or we could
Factor you know factor out a common term
or something like that we have we have
that and each of these you don't need to
use your interface because you just have
this the solving solving for x we did
put a user interface in there
it's going to prompt for the input and
then you see that the equation set equal
to zero
whereas the factoring one it's just this
equation that you know there to put put
it there and then
Senpai dot Factor
okay so that's also a section heading
then
recently we were doing things like
solving for a variable so
not just set sell for X but even if it's
not a definite number to actually
rewrite it you know like y equals A over
B or something like that where you don't
even have numbers this will do that for
you
and
we defined
a lot of our basic variables that we
might use it's not going to be an error
to put them in there and not use them
but you could always if you change what
variables use you could always edit that
part and then whatever it is
whether it be involving numbers or a
bunch of letters
and variables you know left and right
side of the equal sign and then we have
this then we're just going to define the
variable
so that way you can pick what variable
you want to solve for
set it as an equation remember we did
this and then we're going to solve and
this Loop runs through all possibilities
for S and solve for solution
so we have that that we can
solve for a variable like again it's
already
heading and we have that therefore in
the table of contents so we're going to
add the other things we've been doing
slope intercept from two points
because this in itself is a very common
thing
to need to do so we're going to Define
the two points
there we go
X you know X and Y and
then using just our slope formula solve
for b we're going to get m and b and
having those two we're going to print
out
the equation and then we're going to use
that for the graph
and you can keep this at these numbers
if you want
you know you could always change this x
min
negative 10
and we could leave the others as is but
you could always change them to 10 in
every direction if you wanted to
and having those we have
have these
you know for the graph
and the setup the details I could always
add other details or change these and
you see for things that we might use we
might want to see the tick marks
so we have them there so you don't have
to really think about you know the exact
syntax hopefully the more you do this
you remember it but it's just there and
it's commented out so you can use it if
you want
and then that way here we just plot the
function as a red line
so even if you end up changing some of
these you have a lot of things that are
there by default that if you really
entered in two points you could solve
whatever you wanted to solve and graph
it
so we have that here let's make that a
section heading then we can double click
and remember it's
this hashtag because it's in the text
not in the code now that became a
section heading
and
shows up in the table of contents
so we have that now the section heading
goes all the way down to the next
heading or the bottom so that one we can
minimize now this one
if we minimize it that's all the rest of
the
document here
so
besides that I might just want to graph
something
and remember in
you know we use this the other code as
you're building it remember the slope
intercept stuff came from week five and
then
other ways to customize the graph came
from some of the extra things we were
doing in week four
where we have you know again all the
different things we want to do with the
graph the labels as well as setting the
tick marks
and
this one you know we even customized the
labels down here
you know and added a
remember we customized it and added this
whole legend here but in copying this
for yours
we're going to put all these as well as
the zoom that we were doing all in one
thing so
this function
then does all the graphing and I'm going
to skip down here for a second
the slider remember that interactive
plot we're gonna
run this function f and the only slider
we're going to have is to zoom
and that's going to be our multiplier
from 1 to I just picked 100 that's good
and then taking that
so whatever that multiplier is that will
Define
what we have for their our X Min and x
max
and then once we have those we can
Define the points
for our np.lin space to graph
and there we go and
I just put this you you could do the
same just two lines as by default you
know maybe you want to have two lines
and then you you know you want to see
where they where they intersect so this
graphs two different lines and notice
does not have to be a linear equation
as long as you're using python syntax
whatever line you want to graph
and we I commented this out but again
you could have it if you want to fill
between shade above or below and I just
happen to have this one
fill between same X values so the Y
value goes from y1 up to Y Max so that
would shade above and that would make it
green
and the next one
fill between same X values from Y2 down
to Y Min and make it blue so that would
shade below
so again you could have these here in
case you need them you're making these
default
uh notebooks that you can use and you
say oh okay I do want to shade above or
below uncomment it
and then we have the labels General
labels you can change
now for this one I kept this the tick
marks in there and the grid
and notice because a lot of this is
based on the zoom so then how many ticks
do I want and what I did is I got the
difference
the how you know from x max to X Min
divided by 20
um I tinkered with this and that seemed
to be a good number to display nicely so
we're going to get that divide by 20 and
then round it
and then cast it as an integer
so the number of ticks has to be an
integer
so then that way no matter what the zoom
is you'll see that we can adjust the
tick marks and show the grid
so this will give us a few things that
we can graph you know this default and
then let's see given these
equations that we have in here a lot of
times I like to keep an equation in
there rather than just make that line
blank so if you run the code it works
and you see something
so here we have this graph
and we see the default Zoom goes right
to the middle but I could move this back
down
and you see everything adjusts
tick marks adjust
the graph Zooms in and then you can see
you know or we could zoom out
and we see
so yeah pretty good
I like kind of for this particular graph
I like it zoomed in
and then you can see you know about
where they
where they cross
so sometimes you just might want to
graph something and there there we have
that
and
there we go we could put more directions
and you could have the whole ever all
the directions don't have to be uh The
Heading you could have that and you
could put an HTML Break
um right after that
if you wanted to and then more uh words
underneath that would not become a part
of the heading
but for this we can just put the heading
here
we go
I remember there's really no entering
would just put it on a little line you
just click somewhere else and now that's
also a part of the table of contents
so we have that
and then
solve and graph a system
and this is nice it brings it all
together solving it and graphing it
so here you can put in as long as you
have python syntax whatever you have
there as your first
and second equation
and I even have an extra one here just
to be able to uncomment and you can see
this will even work if you have a square
root
just to have different ones to show you
and we've used the Lin solve before
to solve uh using Senpai the Lin solve
to solve two equations and this is
actually another one non-line solve and
I like this one because it can be lit I
just put the comment in there it can be
linear or non-linear it works out so
just because you have non-line solve
does not mean that you have to have
linear you know
something different if one of your
functions is linear
but there we go the comments just so you
know here's where you enter in and then
you already have the code that you would
have copied this one would have been
from
from eight uh yeah from
the recent week to solve and graph you
can just copy these and then
Tinker with them a little bit you know
as we went through and built up to
these important
um
blocks of code
you know take the last one that brings
it all together
and then
put it over here you know that's what
you're doing you're building your
your library here so solving graph the
system of equations and then this will
work
solve and graph pretty much anything and
just want to show you some of these
so even if it's non-linear
and you see
it'll give you the solution
X Y this one happens to have two
solutions notice because we had the uh
the loop the for Loop here
to account for multiple Solutions so
it'll have the two solutions then also
show the two y equals equations and then
graph them
so that's pretty complete that's a good
good one you want to have this as this
type of thing in your toolbox
double click and let's make this one a
heading
there we go so we have that
and I've added one more thing here
um
and we could still make this a heading
notice this code isn't complete
but I put one thing in here that give
you a reference point so you certainly
you would recognize that that's import
so that would go first
and then
you see this
you would also it would be something you
already graphed so the PLT would already
work
but notice you have this Dot savefig and
you're going to give it a name dot PNG
that's a good file type to use
notice that'll come before the plt.show
and that actually works if you put it
after I've tried this if you put this
after it actually will save something
but it'll be a blank graph and what's
interesting is this download can come
after so that's okay
I mean you could put it first that'd be
fine too but it can come after because
it doesn't interfere with what this
shows
and this is a way to download this to
your computer or your phone
there we go save the output because
sometimes you might have have something
that you wanted to save
so
therefore you take this and you would
put
if you wanted to up here you'd import
that and then
and then definitely you know you would
just do
save fake and files download
so there we go and we have this now we
have all of this
and one of the things you can do is
in the view you can collapse all the
sections
all right and now you have all these in
your table of contents and you can just
jump to them if you need to
there you go you have all the sections
collapsed and oh do I need to solve for
x do I need to solve for a variable
you know
um I I like I like shorter uh headings
so I might
and down
save graph and download it
there you go because that's what it does
is it downloads an image
so
already we have so much of the core
algebra they're able to do and you and
you can write the code for it
and now you have
this at the ready so one of the next
things we're going to do is get to
quadratics and more complicated graphs
um we kind of hinted at that last one
you know you might if if you haven't
seen a lot of these and you say oh wow
okay now this graph has a curve now it's
getting interesting so we'll get into
quadratics parabolas you know where all
the graphs do have a curve to them and
things beyond that
so
we'll add more to this
all right but
well well on your way to
being able
being able to solve a lot of algebra
problems
in Python
so when working with word problems
not just here's a math formula to solve
it we're good with you know word
problems with some people call them
story problems that's when a lot of
times people have trouble Translating
that into a math equation that we can
solve so what I want to do is help you
with some keywords that you can find in
the word problems in the sentences
that'll tell you what math operation to
use
and this is not all of them but this is
a lot of the main ones and you know you
you get the trend with this these are
the things you're looking for
and then after we look at these keywords
we'll go through a bunch of examples in
the code and how to use these you know
translating sentences into math
equations but let's take a look at these
keywords
so how do I know if I'm going to add
well some of the words are going to be
if I just actually see Plus
some number plus another number
more so
if I have something and then I got more
how much do I have now you know the
amount of money I had increased
it might even just be and I you know I
have you know these cards and those
cards how many cards do I have received
because a lot of times that's something
added to what we have up
um something goes up and a lot of times
uh calculating elevation up we're adding
it might even just come up and say added
to
some also and sum means the total when I
add up so we might see some of we might
see these you know the sum of three and
four means I'm going to do three plus
four so these are some of the ones if
you're looking and you see these then
you know you're adding
okay and a lot of this it's not so exact
that you could write a program to find a
number find one of these keywords and
then automatically translate it to a
math equation so you have to use a
little bit of your human intuition there
but it it's very much in that direction
see these numbers what which one of
these words are around there and that's
going to give you an indication of the
path operation so let's take a look at
subtraction so subtract yeah it might
just say minus less anytime I have less
then I'm subtracting or it decrease the
amount of money in my bank decreased so
I subtract gave because a lot of times
things if I receive something that it
becomes added to what I have or if I
gave then it becomes subtracted from
what I have
um down and that also goes again with
looking at elevation
um it might even just come out and say
subtracted and then anytime it says the
word difference or I know I want to find
the difference between two numbers
that's subtraction
you know we just find the difference and
you know that might be a negative
difference might be a positive might be
absolute value but if I if it says
difference or if I want to find the
difference then I'm going to subtract
all right so with multiply
so how do I know that I'm multiplying
obviously things are increasing like
they are you know we want to look for
that General Trend things are increasing
um and just right away if you have that
sense things are increasing you know
it's multiplying or adding so how do I
know that it would be multiplying by
just the word buy because if I'm
calculating an area of something three
by five and then I want you know also
then just seeing the word area but three
by five means the area would be three
times five
of
so just the word of is going to be
multiply
percent of something you have the
percent and then you multiply times
whatever that something is
uh Factor because two things you
multiply together are factors
times so yeah three times four
you know it might just come out and say
times
and even if it doesn't have these it
might just give dimensions and say
what's the area and anytime I'm
calculating the area of something I'm
multiplying
so there we go again not this is not all
the numbers that lead to multiply but
this is a lot of the main one all right
so divide out of so notice of would be
multiplying but out of is divide
so you know
um four out of five
that would be a fraction four divided by
5.
per
same actually per pretty much means out
of but that's another way to think about
dividing uh miles per hour I would
divide miles divided by hours or
kilometers per hour kilometers divided
by hours
quotient we don't see this word that
often but that quotient means that I'm
quotient the word means that I'm
dividing and actually that's the answer
when I divide
um any rate
and as I was saying you know you know
kilometers per hour or something like
that but anytime I have a rate it's
going to be some sort of dividing
something divided by something else uh
usually divided by something related to
time but it's not always
so anytime I have a rate I know I'm
dividing something and again it might
just come out and say divided by
so you know some of the key words here
now I put the word each here because
that actually could go for multiply or
divide
um it's the sense of it you know if I
have
um if I have 20 students in the class
and I want to give them two pencils each
how many pencils do I need
so then that's multiply because I do 20
times two but if I have if I know how
many pencils I have
and then
you know I know and then I have 20
students and I you know how many can I
how many can each of them get
you know if I already know that I have
and then I have 20 students how many can
each of them get I'm dividing so each
can go either way we have to get the
sense of it and dividing like some
subtraction if I get the sense that it's
getting to be a smaller number then I
know it's dividing or subtracting you
know and then we we can look further you
know what's the sense of it am I is it
something you know each you know I'm
dividing It Out Among different things
or is it just a subtraction
okay so these are some of the main
things and the one that carries over a
lot is or some version of is
R was but is translates to equals so
that's where we get the equal sign
coming into our equation
and so if I have these then
I can translate you know this is was
will be something like that becomes the
equal sign so looking at these keywords
you know we get the numbers from the
from the situation as well as these
keywords and we can put together an
equation
and so I wanted to give you these
keywords and then in the code what we're
going to do is we're going to look at a
lot of you know some sentences
um and translating them into math
equations and then of course solving
them but that's what we want to do we
want to be able to translate this you
know you're not always in life going to
have like here's the math problem it's
going to be you know some words and we
have to translate that to a math problem
so let's take a look at how to do this
let's let's apply these
um translate some sentences into math
problems all right so let's take a look
at the code
so now let's put some of this into
practice some of the math we've been
talking about with the linear equations
slope intercept especially and some of
the Python developing equations finding
slope graphing all that let's put all
this together and use that to solve some
problems here
and first let's look at how we can see
that y equals MX plus b pattern for a
linear equation show up in slightly
different ways
you know sometimes we just change out
the letters a little bit but be able to
recognize that pattern
so if we take a look at number one
and this all comes from the textbook
um
the one that I have listed as textbook 2
algebra and trig
um so you know there we go page 304 you
can find it
find these because we're just going to
pick a few of these and I want to
highlight you know what what we can do
with these
so if we take a look Terry is skiing
down a steep hill
Terry's elevation e of T that's how I'd
write that that's the function
instead of just y equals what we'll call
it e of t for elevation
as a function of time
Terry's elevation
in feet after T seconds is given by this
so e of T equals three thousand minus
70t
and we see then you know instead of X
we're using T because it's time and we
have 3000 minus 70t and then our y value
is e of T that's the function
and
so we see the slow The Intercept come
first that's where we begin she Terry
begins at three thousand feet up and
then goes down the slope at 70 feet per
second
so we see that that is the slope the
slope of our equation on the slope
and
negative because that elevation is going
down
there we go so we can see the slope we
can see where Terry begins 3000 feet up
um and there we go just
uh finding that slope we just look at it
if we take a look at number two now we
have Jessica walking home
from a friend's house after two minutes
she's 1.4 miles from home
12 minutes after leaving she's 0.9 miles
from home
what's her rate in miles per hour well
right here we have distances in miles
but the times in minutes
so if the question asks for miles per
hour we definitely see also that we have
two points we have time and a distance
and then another time and distance
so we'll you know X will be time y will
be distance
and
having these two points
we can go to our calculator now
hopefully this lines up with something
that you've already created
um you know remember we might have
called it like your calculator
and then hopefully you know then you
would have created the table of contents
for the different things that we want to
be able to do and we can jump to here
slope intercept equation from two points
because even though the that question
didn't ask for the full equation and
everything we're going to do more
um but the first thing it's going to do
is find the slope for us and hopefully
you know that's it you know we have
these formulas
you made these now we can make use of it
so you would have had all this and then
we would just change X1 y1
so the Y value is 1.4 but that x value
is 2 minutes and we have to remember so
I already put this in here
it's two minutes
and there's 60 minutes in an hour so
it's 2 out of 60.
you could reduce this if you want but
you don't even have to python will take
care of that in the other in between
steps
and the Y value 1.4 miles so the second
x value 12 minutes
so same thing 12 minutes we want it in
hours so it's 12 out of 60.
again that reduces but you don't you
don't actually have to
and then 0.9
so having all this you can just put in
these
uh four values here calculate the slope
intercept we'll print that out so you
see the equation
and then we'll also graph it I mean
we're going beyond what the question is
but this will give you an idea of some
things you can do you already have this
and all you need to do is recognize what
these values were put them in here and
then we run it
all right so this I absolutely would
take this slope as 3.
so sometimes just the way python
calculates things
it might be this 0.9999
it's three and if you really wanted to
seeing this you know you could always go
back and put a round function
in in your code you know round it same
with this you could always round it to
two decimal place to one decimal place
um which would be 1.5
but either way we see that remember our
first point was two minutes after she
left
so
at Time Zero at two minutes she was 1.4
miles from home but at Time Zero she's
that little bit more 1.49
or 1.5 it might round
so we get our values here
and you know again you could put a round
function in there but I'm not worried
about that right now and also python
it gives us this warning but it still
ran occasionally that happens just the
the way it calculates some things
um
you know we get uh a warning you know
some value maybe not even related to
what we were working on
um
gives us this warning
but it's still raining still gave us all
this and then we also have this graft
now
if we have
you know the X values or the Y values so
this
is her time
from home
so this y value
notice it seems like this graph
is completely irrelevant
because the Y value only goes down to
net 9.6 we want it down to zero and then
we have negative time values what you
know what's that all about
so
remember mathematically a lot you know
all these things already exist these
values exist you know we make this
equation here
negative 3x plus 1.5
but that whole equation exists so we can
actually change the graph
and one of the things we have
you know
later on in this document is you know we
can graph
you can always graph and zoom
but we can just change the graph here
and our X minimum if x is time
we can just make that zero because
negative time
you know she was still at her friend's
house so that won't affect the The
Walking
and the X maximum I mean we can really
zoom in
um now once we figured out that she was
going
three miles an hour and she only had
half a mile to go like we can make our x
value really small
um
I don't know I'll maybe I'll just reduce
it to five for this one
and the Y minimum
is zero
and the Y maximum I don't even need that
to be tan
um
I can even make it I'll make it five but
we don't even need to that much we can
really zoom in on this because it's a
relatively short distance
all right so now when we have this now
we have
a graph we can zoom in on
and you know this is the only part we
needed
so
we could look at this that you know
about one and a half miles away
and so therefore
you know she's walking about three miles
an hour it takes her about a half hour
to get home
and there we go we see
you know the rate you know the slope the
whole equation we see the graph and then
we can graph the
trip home
we could also always you know change
these
you know if you really needed to explain
this you know to someone
else you could always put you know X
values you could change that to time y
value can make it distance from home
so
there we go so we have these calculators
that you know we're talking about it
here or I'm talking about it here a lot
now but if you had this at the ready you
might even just
um
you might might even just you know see
this oh I see my two values plug them in
click run
and you have your answer
yeah move on in a few seconds here
so
some things we can do here
notice number three very similar and
maybe we'll do number three you know a
lot quicker a boat is a hundred miles
from the marina sailing directly at it
at 10 miles per hour
so now we already know that equation
because
it's a hundred miles away so that's
where we begin at 10 miles or an hour
and if we want the distance from the
marina
then it's a negative 10 100 minus 10.
X so we could always go here like that's
the equation 100 minus 10x and we could
always go to something else and we could
graph that
uh and see you know just the trend how
long does how long will it take
for the boat to to get to the marina
uh they're 10 miles an hour you might
even be able to do this in your head
that it's 10 you know 10 hours to get
there and that's the thing we have the
setup for when the numbers get more
difficult but sometimes you can just
calculate it yourself
all right and we take a look at some of
these
and remember a linear function we'll get
into the other functions quadratics and
things beyond that but a linear function
has no exponents
so there we go no exponents so we see 6
is linear seven is linear eight is not
because we have x squared 9 is linear 10
is not we have x squared 11 we have y
squared so that's actually
not even a function like the ones we've
been doing so that's another story 12
yep actually not a function
like the ones we've been doing
and certainly not linear
um 13 you if I had X in the denominator
then that would not be linear but
with just a 5 in the denominator we're
okay
so there we go and increasing or
decreasing we would just look at the
slope if the slope's positive it's
increasing if the slope's negative it's
decreasing and remember the slope is
that X coefficient so slopes four it's
increasing 15 slope is five it's
decreased it's increasing
and 16 the slope is negative 2 so it's
decreasing 17 is negative 3 it's
decreasing so we see that
and just like we were doing with these
other problems you just
like number 24 there you go you could
just plug these in 2 4 4 10
there we go run it and have your
equation and see the graph
so
a lot of these you know when once you
have the code down you know it becomes a
lot easier
there you go same thing a line if we
have two points then
you know we put this in there
um
all right now let's take a look at 37.
so these two lines now we get into the
system of equations are they parallel
perpendicular or neither well one of the
things we can do then is we can look at
one of our other
uh notebook sections and we can graph
these two and see so let's take a look
at this 4X minus 7y equals 10. so let's
take a look at this
and you would have this you know how
about this graph lines and zoom in or
out remember you would have ate
something like that too
and
we defined our function
so that we can zoom
in or out
and we have two lines so
line one
I could
just graph this now
also so one of the things we can do to
graph these
if you wanted to
is put it and this would be something
that you would do you have to put each
of these in the y equals version
because
they're not in y equals and that's how
we have it set up to graph
you see it's it's going to be y equals
and they are going to be functions
so we have this
but let's go to another one
solve and graph a system
because this one does not have to be
equal to Y in fact we just make it equal
to zero
so I actually already put this in here
four four times x minus 7 times Y and
the only thing we need to do is make it
equal to zero so that equals ten
subtract 10 from both sides you see much
quicker much easier to do
and then the second one
7x plus 4y equals one just subtract 1
from both sides and that's what we have
here
so it underlines these but it won't run
it'll be fine
so that works out really well because as
long as you have to set equal to zero
just anything on the other side subtract
it over and remember you would have
already made this hopefully and you know
your first equation your second set
equal to zero
and
remember we're solved
then we solve it and we're going to get
that solution
and then we're going to also convert it
to y equals here
and then graph it
print the Y equals version
and
when we run it we see we have the
solution and it's not even you know this
is again more than the question asked
but if we already had the code you know
we can do this the solution and yes
these are two very weird
fractions that you know it would be a
little bit tedious if you were
calculating this by hand
we get the solution
and so
we also see the graph
these are not parallel or perpendicular
and we see where they intersect
at this value
um
negative 66 over 65 so all you know
almost negative one a little bit off and
then a fraction there
and then we see the Y equals versions
4 times x over seven minus ten over
seven
so we see this one has a slope of four
over seven and this one has a slope of
negative
seven over four oh then they would be
perpendicular despite what this graph
shows
so
let's try to change this because the
slope here
is four over seven you see even though
we're multiplying by X that coefficient
is four over seven
and then over here it's negative seven
over four and that's what makes them
perpendicular the negative reciprocal
four over seven negative seven over four
that if you multiply them together they
would be negative one
so if we change the scale on this we can
probably it'll probably look more
perpendicular
and
so this just naturally scales it this
way
all right so we have
but that's why because in this same
window the Y value goes up to 15.
so the you know it the perpendicular
this intersection would be at a right
angle
and
that you know we just can't see that
right angle because of the scale of the
graph
all right so
that work that would work for any of
these
now
you know 38 yeah pretty easy I would
just add y to both sides you know
subtract 12 on the first one and they're
equal set equal to zero and we can use
that same thing
same with 39 maybe we'll do
another one here
um
so
if we get
yeah if we have this let's just do yeah
we'll do one more here 3y plus X
equals 12. so if we go back to this
then I'll make the first equation
then we'll have three
times y
plus X
minus 12 because that I would have to
equal zero three
over python syntax you have to put the
three times y whereas algebra you won't
see that multiplication symbol in there
so 3 3y plus x minus 12 equals zero and
then on the second one 8X plus 1 plus y
so on the second equation we'll have 8x
8x
8 times X plus one plus y
and see I don't even for these aren't as
bad but you know for other ones you
don't have to worry about
factoring it
as long as it's set equal to zero
we will get the solution
and then we're going to show the Y
equals version and then graph it
so
yep these do have
a solution we're a point where they
intersect and notice
they are not perpendicular because the
slope is negative one-third
you know 1X over 3 and this one the
slope is negative eight
so a steep slope at negative eight and
also a negative slope but not as steep
so they will
meet at this point
there we go
so pretty cool solving a more
complicated system of equations solving
it factoring it graphing it remember if
you have you know
build build these calculators for
yourself then you have it you can answer
all these questions and
do some other things
and so we see you know the similar
things
um
lines passing through and in any of
these
you could build for yourself
um
you know a notebook section of code that
will do this for two for
two point uh two lines
or you could actually go back to the one
you had and you could use the
slope-intercept equation
for the one line
and then write it in
later and then you could use the slope
intercept equation again for the second
line and then write it in
so that's what we have here like this
one you know you have this slope
intercept and you always could then take
it and
you know copy that and
write it in here as
you know
line one go back and do the other one
copy it as line two
so that you know that that's one of the
things you could do if you wanted to
um
yep take take something like that and
have it actually do two instead of one
but nonetheless
you know right now as I have it it was
it was two separate things you can get
the equation and you could if you wanted
to copy it into the next one so all
these yep same thing
two points
um
you get the equation two points get the
equation
and there we go just looking at that
you know parallel they'd have the same
slope perpendicular then you could
multiply the slopes together to get
negative one
and neither is anything else as long as
they have different slopes
so we see all these different things you
can
calculate and I'll leave this to you if
you want to you know go through and
practice some of these
um see some of these you don't have to
have the
full equation
or you don't have to have the the nope
uh Jupiter notebook or collab because if
you remember the pattern
that slope intercept equation here
what's the y-intercept it's five you can
see it and then for this particular one
you can actually count
you know oh wow look at that you know we
go down five over four so the slope
would be negative five over four
so it would be y equals negative five
over four X plus five
or if you wanted to you could just take
these two points and plug you know go
back to the notebook plug them in and
see it generate the equation but see
that that'll work for any of these
you know having this you can count the
slope like in 58 so
B is one and then from that to the next
nice Point looks like you go up two and
then over three
there you go there's your slope
so you can you know work on these
so some of these again any of these you
want to see a graph
we could just plug any of these into
that other notebook section where you
see the graph
all right sketch a line
good
and again you can practice all these if
you want
the tables
so really just remember X and then
whatever you want to call it g of X
that's the Y value and so if I want the
equation
then what we want is we can just take
the first two points
and
get the equation
so that's you know
X of 0 Y is 5 and the next One X is five
Y is negative 10.
and we can get that equation
but then also if you wanted to you get
the next two points and see if it's the
same slope
so that's how we would determine if it's
linear I mean we could always just plot
any of these points
and and see what it comes out as
so that's another way we could just plot
these points as their own array and see
if it looks like they line up
yeah that's another interesting way to
do it
and
there we go so
uh
so yeah let me let me just show you how
to do that on
on one of these and
so if the X values are 0 5 10 and 15 now
what you can do is
in
one of these where you're going to graph
so
if we have
yeah here and we'll even keep the zoom
in so one of these where you're going to
graph we we have all this for the zoom
but what you can do
is
you could make
an array of the X values
right so we could get x equals and
make it um you know zero comma five
comma
and you see
0 5 10 15
and we can just make that the array
and then
you could
now
we could just oh
comment out all this because we don't
need these
and
take this and
this first one we could put you know
comment out this
and
we could have y1
and put your y values
5 negative 10 negative 25 negative 40.
so there we go five
negative 10.
negative 25
negative 40.
so remember that you know that that Numb
by essentially does give us an array of
values
and we could just put our own array and
if you wanted to
um in here
we could also then put
you know make them make them dots
I'll say Ro
so we'll make them red dots
for the points so we could have the X
array have the Y Ray and then that's
what we're plotting
there we go we just commented all these
out
and
so we have this looks to be that the
line and we can
change the scale
I like to keep
you know yep it definitely looks like
they're in a line
so
we could you know there we go we could
say that yep that's that would be a line
and
you know that works that is linear
so
some some of these you might just notice
okay does the slope change in in that
table
but also I wanted to show you
for this or for you know
this might seem like a lot to do for
that little question but also just
showing you what you can do if you have
you know more complicated sets
because all of these that you know this
this is designed to be practiced and
just a few values just to show you but
remember this is this is going to lead
you toward data science if you want to
continue following this path
and instead of having like four values
you might have like you know four
thousand
and so we want to know hey how can we do
this we'll have other ways rather than
having to you know write our own array
rather to grab those values if there was
like a thousand of them
and then store that as an array and same
with the other y values but then you
know can I do this can I just take this
and plot all these points and see what
it looks like
you know these are the things we want to
be able to do
so you know there we go
some some things
you know and and it answers a very
simple question is it linear
because otherwise you know they might
get some of these that
the plots all over the place and I could
not say that they all line up nicely
so that's it
um you know here's some of these you
know missing values of a linear function
and remember you can graph and actually
introduce a table of values too if you
wanted to
so you know those are some other things
you can do
so we have these
um
if you go
and some of these
we would have to put the slope formula
um
so remember the slope formula
is you know without looking at the code
you know find the equation of the line
goes to the points here without looking
at the code
the Y values B plus 1 and then the other
y values B so when we subtract that
it went up one you see the Y value went
from B to B plus one
but then look at this the x value is a
and that didn't change
so
a minus a is zero so we have it's
actually not a function but it would
just be an x value x equals a
so these are some of the things just you
know plugging in these values
first uh in the slope
and you could always do some of this
with um
you could Define all of these values
if you look at the the other one that we
were doing here
um solve and graph
now the you might have to comment out
the graph probably wouldn't do too well
but
taking these and so you know you you
know you if you define more variables
you could still take these and Define
these values
um again a solution might not be
uh really possible but you could take
those values and then you could actually
solve and this solves it for zero but
you could actually solve it for
um
you know solve it for y or whatever
value you want
so Senpai will do that for you
so that's it you know you could have you
could have make another section in your
notebook that just does all that
interesting factoring
all right
so there we go
and
so we have some other ones here
so so here's one
um now this we have at noon the Barista
know she has twenty dollars in her tip
jar and if she makes an average of 50
cents more from each customer
so remember that's an average so you
might have customers tipping more or
some tipping less and then it averages
out so
these are good estimates because we
would right away see the equation we
begin with 20 and then it's
um
an additional
because we know she's getting something
more 50 cents from each customer so it's
20 plus 0.5 x
so we see that equation then we you know
right away we have that 20 plus 0.5 x
and we can do something with that we
could like graph it we could find values
um
this particular question we just says
and more so it would be 20 plus 0.5 n
you know we just change that variable
and then at any point
she can plug in a number for n
figure out you know how many tips she
has
all right
and there's 115 these are some of the
things that you know you can calculate a
gym membership with two personal
training sessions cost of 125 while gym
membership with five personal training
sessions cost 260.
what's the cost per session
so we take it as the membership itself
is just one thing
and then you could have like you know
each of these so
really we have our x value would be how
many
training sessions and then the Y value
would be the cost
and so that's it even though you know we
don't it's not asking us to graph we
absolutely could go back to this and
two sessions was 125
and then five sessions
was 260.
so we could go back to this and back to
the earlier one
you know slope intercept from two points
and we could say you know there we go
two sessions
Plus 125.
you know how many sessions and then
dollar amount and then we have five
sessions
would be
than
260.
and
oh now
this we need to change this that
X minimum now that's probably fine for
five but let's take a look at this and
you know have
um I don't know let's go up to 10 y
minimum zero is probably fine
but the Y maximum and
there we go maybe we'll make it like you
know 500 we're gonna go beyond that but
that's fine
and
we see the graph
so we see the equation 45x plus 35
. so
the membership itself must be 35 dollars
and
each session must be 45 and so we see
this graph
then
you know there we go
you know and we see where we see the
cost 45 you know almost halfway there
and then we see the increase okay
somebody wants to plan you know what
it's going to cost how many training
sessions do I want maybe this isn't a
month the person wants like two in a
week so it might be about eight in a
month
and can calculate oh there we go eight
training sessions that'd be four hundred
dollars
or you know do I want to just try
to
here just pay the 35 dollars
and not get any training sessions and
you know there we go then it's somewhere
around here at the zero value and that's
what we want we want to you you know use
these to
be able to calculate some different
things you know the
cost like 116 here
so the for linear relation clothing
business finds there's a linear
relationship between the number of
shirts
it can sell and the price
uh Price p that it can charge per shirt
so there you go selling and shirts
if the price is p
and this is you know things that people
want to find out because then that helps
people figure out what price you know
they definitely start out like can't you
know go below a certain price because I
have to make money I can't lose money
but then beyond that we see oh wow this
is shirts
um
all different prices are possible so
somebody says that finds this historical
data so finding data from somewhere else
some other people selling shirts oh okay
I can sell a thousand shirts
if the price is 30 dollars
but three thousand shirts if the price
is twenty two dollars
so there we go
again that classic y equals MX plus b
but we just change the letters
P of n
you know the price based on N sharp and
shirts
is MN plus b
so
there we go we can we can look at this
you know n shirts
um
now
something like this I might take that
the price is the independent variable
because that affects how many shirts you
can buy
and so we might you know do something
like that and then we'll get into in uh
later units here we'll get into other
things where we can then based on that
price
you know given this
we can find that that Pro you know that
equation for price and then based on
that price we can take it a step further
and say what would be my profit
because just as an example here
so a thousand shirts at thirty dollars
so it'll be thirty thousand dollars so
they sold a thousand shirts thirty
dollars each
but
three thousand shirts at 22.
so
22 times 3 000 is 44 uh uh sixty six
thousand dollars
so just lowering that not just you know
selling more shirts but the price that
it had to lower uh reduce to twenty two
dollars not that much different
and so it sells 3 000 shirts so instead
of thirty thousand dollars sixty six
thousand dollars look at that all uh
more than twice the profit
for
a little bit less and some people who
don't look at the math of this
would say that
you know what is is the you know
reducing it eight dollars is that gonna
double my profit actually it does
or at least the revenue we don't know
the cost of making the shirts but it it
more than doubles the revenue
she's lowering that a little bit because
it reached so many people
and so that's what people are looking at
you know and again in further units
we'll look at the math behind you know
how to how to get this how to find that
maximum profit value maximum Revenue
value and you know
what you know what are we looking at
here
um how can we find that
you know ideal shirt price
so there we go
um
there we go all these others
uh same situation
linear equation we're trying to maximize
things if we look at number 18 if a
farmer finds a linear relationship
between the number of bean stalks she uh
she plants and then the yield
that each plant produces so 30 stalks
each plant yield you know how many per
per acre
um so 30 stocks
um each plane yields 30 ounces of beans
but then 34 stalks
reduces it to 28 ounces of beans you
know they're all competing for some of
the same resources
so we can definitely get that linear
equation
and then we can try to find
so what would be the maximum
you know how what would maximize the
bean yield
so you know it would be really
interesting
so
then we get this
um
yeah so notice this uh
and the yield would be
30 ounces that many beans times 34.
oh no sorry
30 stalks times 30 ounces
you see then 30 times 30 so that's 900.
or then we have 34 times 28.
and
I'm not going to do that in my head but
we we can see some different values and
then we'll look at these in some of the
other business applications
later on
so some more things if we if the town
population in like number 120 drawing
linearly
we can write an equation for that
you know here's another one where
we often do this all the time converting
temperature from Celsius to Fahrenheit
and we have these two values zero
degrees Celsius is 32 degrees Fahrenheit
so
then we know
um 100 degrees Celsius is when water
boils and the corresponding temp is 212
Fahrenheit
so what you can do is we could just take
these
um
now we could also use this to make
another
function
but we could also take this
slope intercept from an equation
equation from two points
and
yep
3-0 uh a little bit of sub equation from
two points
and
we can say
all right so we have zero and then 32.
and
Celsius would be a hundred and
Fahrenheit would be 212.
there you go and see the
see the graph
now the graph in this case okay and I'm
not even worried about changing the
values because the main thing we wanted
was this equation here on 0.8 x minus
32.
some people like that 1.8 is a fraction
it's 9 over 5.
so there we go that's and remember then
the x value was Celsius so that's how we
can convert
Celsius to Fahrenheit times 1.8 Plus 32.
and so
if we look at the increase you know 1.8
is almost 2
so
you know
each Celsius
um
degree increases almost two degrees
Fahrenheit increase
so we can see that change
so if we take a look at this you know we
you could always you could always make
this that you know make another function
for yourself
that you could you know you could just
have like
um
you could just have
Celsius to Fahrenheit Fahrenheit to
Celsius you know that make another
section
add it
you know put a
heading to it because remember as soon
as you have the heading
you know
not a comment because we're not in the
code but if it's in there then it
becomes a heading and it'll be in the
table of contents
so you can always make some of these
things for yourself
and you know that's why I want to give
you some of these practice problems you
know if some of these are relevant or if
you want to combine some of the things
you know you have room to explore and
do some different things
so there we go and then once you have
that equation you can find you know
there we go that function of 28 degrees
what's that
we come in Celsius or in Fahrenheit or
negative 40 uh that's a good one
because negative 40 Celsius is negative
40 Fahrenheit
so
the one time where they actually agree
take it's got to be really cold but when
it's that cold they agree and anybody
not even having a thermometer would
probably agree to yes it's cold
so these are some of the things applying
some of some of these and hopefully
this is
you know if you find this useful some
some ways you can interpret some of the
word problems and use some of the
notebooks that you've been working on to
solve problems answer questions
and yeah you can continue you know add
more to what you have you know make make
it your calculator
anytime you have different formulas you
say oh this this might be useful make a
function make a formula another notebook
section
all right
ready to go on to the next thing
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the collab notebook so
you can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
those use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
for these extra problems we're going to
look at just ways to set up
some formulas
you know if you have different
situations word problems how can we
decode these put them into math terms
and then use Python to solve them
so
just here's some examples and all these
come from the pages in the first
textbook you have the link so let's look
at number 10 on average
um this uh happens to be full-time
Canadians work 39.5 hours per week
so if the typical adult requires eight
hours of sleep per day what's the
percentage of hours in a single week
left over for personal activities
so
we need a few things here 30 so we need
the number of hours in a week and
even just going through your python uh
collab notebook we have all these
different things that you can do I'm
going to click on solve and graph which
we're not doing yet but
in here
you can just put a
plank you know line of code here and
even in the print statement
you can do a lot of math so
first of all we can have the number of
hours per week
and that would be 24 hours times seven
days
and then
if we want to look at
the
number of hours that Canadians worked
we're going to subtract 39.5 from that
and
python knows word of operations so I can
just put in here I like the spacing but
you really don't need it 39.5
so there we go
uh 24 hours a day times seven days a
week
minus 39.5
and
then we actually can also subtract
eight hours a day
eight times seven
so we have
how many total hours in the week and
then
minus the work hours and then minus the
sleep hours
again all this in
in Python shift enter
and
we will have
72.5 hours
so there we go 72.5 hours
is you know and it works out look at
look at that you know work sleep still
have plenty of time
to go out and do things and we can do
all this just note knowing what we need
to do each step you can break this up
into different steps and put variables
but this is just one way to do this
all right
and let's take a look at another one
that number 14 housing starts in
Winnipeg for the first half of 20 2009
we're down
46.733 percent we'll talk about
converting that in a second
from 2008 when 1 500 new homes were
started
so from 2008 to 2009 if it was the same
amount it would be that times one or
times a hundred percent which would be
times 1.00
so
if it didn't change it would be that
times one but then since it went down we
want to think 1 minus that rate
so it's not the hundred percent it's the
100 minus this 46.733
and then the original was in 2008 it was
1500 new homes so
we can just go right back to this and we
have 1500 new homes
one
minus
that
46.733 as a decimal is going to be
zero point
four six seven three three
and you see that we have that that
decimal so one or you know one hundred
percent I mean it's not going to mess up
the code if I put
.00
we don't need to but so you know that's
a hundred percent so if it was that
fifteen hundred times one that would be
it would not change year to year
and since it went down it's times one
minus this rate you know this will just
overwrite this
and
these are number of homes so we're gonna
round it down and we're gonna say it's
799.
um you know that .005 is you know I
don't know that's what five thousandths
you know I don't know they put a few
boards there or something on the lot
said I started
um but there we go we're going to call
it 7.99 and that's how we get this times
you know one minus the rate since it
went down and in later weeks we're going
to talk a lot more about percent
increase and decrease so
uh this is not the only time you're
going to see this and in what in that
case we're gonna
skip some of these other percent
increase or decrease
but on page 73 I want to talk about this
percent change
so if 9.99 changed to 10.49 so the
amount of change
we would just subtract 1049 minus 999.
and we see you know we can do that you
can do that in your head it's an even 50
cents
but then the percent changes we take
that difference over the original number
so if it started at 9.99
that's the that's the difference so uh
that's the original number
and again we can look at percent change
so that 50 cents 0.50
divided by that original number 9.99
so that's we get that difference divided
by the original number
and as a percent
we're going to multiply it by a hundred
um because it's the first two digits
and even if I were to round it the next
number is a zero so it's really a five
percent change
there we go and if you really wanted to
sometimes people like to put that into
the formula times 100
and
you know there we go
as a percent I mean if it's just for
your own calculations you don't have to
make it fancier if you're doing this to
you know explain you know costs and
everything in some sort of business
proposal yeah it's nice to have
the extra bit you know have it display
nicely and people can see oh this is
exactly what you're talking about for
your own calculations you can put it all
in the print statement and you know see
see the output
and
there we go so if we have 19.99 lowered
by 10 percent
so we're looking at these keywords
lowered by and if it's a percent
we need that Formula 1 minus 3. again
might be uh new to think about it this
way and we're going to talk a lot more
about it in later weeks
but 99 lowered by 10 percent
so
we're not decreasing by an amount so
we're not subtracting
it's times
1 minus three and I can even you know
convert this as uh I'll I'll just put
this here one minus
10 remember zero point
10.
so I put that in there with the extra
zeros but you can see
that that's where we get this one minus
three if it didn't change it would be
that number times a hundred percent or
times one
but it's times one minus three and then
that's the new number
there we go
and this did not have any practical
connection it was just what's the number
if it's a dollar amount
then I'll take it to two decimal places
it's 17.99 so that'd be something like
you know
the
the shirt cost 19.99 and it was on 10
off so you end up paying 17.99
and knowing how to do these things you
know if you have a calculator so you can
do this you know right there on your
phone because you can have this app
you can set up different things for
percent increase and decrease and
you know you're in store oh what would
the actual price be and at that point is
it worth it
there we go
um
and here we have this what amount when
it increased by 40 is
3 500. now for this
before I even get to what
we're going to calculate I'm going to
put a couple comments here
because
I don't want the code I just want to
show you the math of this if I have some
amount which I'm going to call X
increased by 40 so if it increased then
it's times 1 plus the rate
and then that would equal that new
amount
so you know the the beginning amount
or you know X or we can call it the
original
amount times one plus three equals the
new amount and I just put this in a
comment we're just looking at this
formula
and so
if I have this
then the question is what amount number
six here what amount when increased by
40 is 3500 so that would be X
times and when it's 1 plus 3 that makes
it really easy because it's one point
4.
I put the zero if I wanted to
equals 3500 because 1 plus 0.40 is 1.4
and then in doing this we remember
solving for x I'm multiplying so I
divide and now really in the print
statement I'm doing this 3500
divided by 1.4
and we see how in setting this up you
know you could write your math in here
some notes for yourself the formula
you're using
and then plug in the numbers so then we
see what's the actual math that we're
doing
and then of dividing by 1.4 so we'll do
that
and that's the one thing
that will print the others or comments
there you go twenty five hundred dollars
so we have some of these
all right
um
and
I actually want to skip over to this
baseball one I skipped over that because
I think those others are more
straightforward now let's take a look at
making use of you know as you're
building these um
this notebook for yourself let's make
use of the system of equations one so if
we look at number 15.
a local baseball team sells tickets with
two price zones seats behind the plate
from first base to third are priced at
twenty dollars per ticket all the other
seats
down the baselines are ten dollars a
ticket
and last night's game
5332 fans were in attendance and the
total ticket revenues were 71 000. how
many tickets were in each Zone
so let's call X
um the good Zone behind home plate those
the 20 tickets
and let's call Y the ones that are
further out
so we have the two things we want we
want to know how many tickets in each
Zone
so let's think about equations for this
um so twenty dollars for the good
tickets ten dollars for the lower price
tickets
and the revenue was seventy one thousand
seven fifty
so if we go to our solvent graph and
again you might have this you might have
your
table of contents jump right to it solve
and graph
we'll call the variables X and Y and you
could even write some more stuff in here
and you know delete it later
so let's take a look at this if our two
equations are twenty dollars times
X number of tickets
plus ten dollars
times
why how many of those tickets did we
sell
equals that total 71 000. let's make
sure we get it exact 71 750.
so now we have an equation for the
revenue twenty dollars times this many
tickets the good tickets
plus ten dollars times this many tickets
that are further out equals this how
this much money that
there now I have two variables
I want to solve this I need another
equation
so what about that second equation
5332 fans were in attendance
so
X and Y were the number of tickets in
each section so X
plus Y Must equal 5332.
okay
so
in the way we have this set up here we
can just set this equal to zero
so let's take the first equation and
we're just going to put this 20
times x
plus 10 times y
and then equal to zero I'd just subtract
that other value
and then that would be that equal to
zero
all right and the second equation
set equal to zero so X Plus y so I'll do
X Plus Y and then minus
that would make that set equal to zero
and this is the idea you can you can add
other things here if you want
to factor and then just setting up these
equal to zero is the easiest way to set
it up because remember we already set
this up to solve
Factor it and then graph it
and the graph
you know just might help visualize it
and when we solve this
so there we go
um
see the solution here and
1843 and 3489
so that's how many of each
because when we add these up then that's
going to be 5332
and
there we go that now we know how many of
each each ticket so
1843 people
sat you know
from first base to third and three
thousand four hundred eighty nine as we
expect that's there's more room out
there in the Outfield and Beyond so you
know that's how many people sat out
there and now and now we can figure this
out
um
and we see the graph just to see the
comparison here
so pretty cool we can we can figure out
given this information how many people
sat in each place and who knows maybe if
it wasn't totally sold out we can get a
breakdown
all right and you know some other
applications we'll skip some of the
percent increase uh maybe we'll take a
look at this one here
so number 15 from page 84. so if
Gabrielle is famous for our trail mix
recipe
um let's talk about but the by weight
her recipe calls for 50 pretzels 30
Cheerios 20 peanuts and she wants to
make two kilograms
of this mix
so we could just calculate how much of
each she's mixing
so pretzels Cheerios and peanuts
and this one
we could just go right to right to here
and
before I even get to a print statement
we can just Define some variables
um
in Python we like to use the underscore
so maybe uh
pretzel
weight
maybe we'll do pretzel uh pretzel there
we go equals
um
0.5
times 2
because it was 50 percent
pretzels and she wants to make two
kilograms Cheerios is going to be 30
percent
and peanuts 20 percent
so
Cheerios
equals 0.3
times 2 and then uh
peanuts
equals 0.2
times 2.
now we have now we're gonna we know that
we have the weight of each of these and
you can put comments in there for
yourself if you need to
and now we want to talk about the cost
so
there we go um
if we have the the cost so all of this
pretzels times 9.99
and so if we have this
our cost
equals
pretzel times 9.99
because that's how many kilograms at
9.99 a kilogram
Plus
and we'll look at
Cheerios 6.99
and peanuts 4.95.
Plus
Cheerios
times 6.99
Plus
peanuts
times
4.95.
so now we have the total cost here and
that should be then the cost for two
kilograms
fine but
the question then asks what's the
average cost per 100 grams
so
100 grams compared to 2 kilograms
is divided by 20. and we could do the
comparison if we wanted to also bring it
up to
the proportion earlier on in this
notebook but knowing that this is two
kilograms 100 grams
and so it's
um we can just put this in the print
statement cost
divided by 20.
because that's the cost for 100 grams
there we go so
how many of each if we're making two
kilograms
but then the final question uh we need
to divide it by 20. we only 100 grams
and there we go 80 cents
which makes sense because if we take a
look at the total cost for each of these
yeah when we're buying this full two
kilograms you know given these rates
yeah that's 16 worth of Trail Mix
I mean you know hopefully two kilograms
of this this mix that'll last a while so
she just wants to mix 100 100 grams so
that's why she is just dividing it by
20.
100 grams you know so that people can
eat it before it goes stale
there you go 80 cents
all right not bad
so
some other things that we can look at
making use of these calculators that we
have
we can take a look at things like
various like options for things like
green energy
and so I I put in here you know just a
link to one thing you know one thing and
it was
I think I did one solar panel and one
battery so supposing you know you want
to buy this you know
um live Off the Grid or you know
supplement electricity for somewhere so
here's a solar panel charges up a
battery
and the cost was 245 dollars
and then the output is 110 watt hours
now
111. so
you can certainly recharge this as as
much as possible
um that's just you know that output
um I normally would then think about
this as using 111 Watts for an hour and
111 Watts that should be enough to
charge you know power your laptop charge
a phone
um
few light bulbs also
you know that's something
you know you could easily make use of
111 Watts like I said laptop charger
phone Power a few light bulbs
that'll be plenty
and then that way so what what this
would be is so
um
the uh
electricity very often is in kilowatt
hours because we use so much and that's
like 15 cents I think is about the
national average so 111 Watts that's you
know 10 percent of that
or a little bit less so
yes that is 1.5 cents so you know this
111 Watt hours
and I was thinking you know use 111
Watts for an hour
so that would save you
a 1.5 cents
okay now beyond the savings if you're
also doing this for the sake of being
Off the Grid or you know uh you want to
run run some stuff like out in the
middle of nowhere where you can't really
plug it in well that that's the value of
this but let's just say
you want to compare this to electricity
cost so
you know
that 245 dollars and if you run this for
all you're making full use of all this
for an hour then it'd be 16 000 hours
and dividing that out
um
rough estimate you know doing a little
bit of rounding here a thousand days
you know which is you know a little bit
less than three years
and
if you do that you could uh
you know pay for itself
in a thousand days which
for a lot of Investments that's not that
bad
and then after that free electricity you
know you paid for this and all along the
way
you know you're saving this money for
the thousand thousand days and then
after that there you go you've already
saved enough money to pay for it
and you get the free electricity
I I did another one just as another
comparison so this wind turbine
um I find all these you know it's kind
of interesting so uh
did that not click
there we go so this particular wind
turbine that can handle like low winds
and it's rated for you know 400 watts
but
um
the idea is that if it's low wind it
might be a whole lot less and
somewhere in here
you know it can say
2.5 meters per second low wind speed
which would be about five miles an hour
and even at that point it'll turn it'll
generate some electricity
so let's say we have something like this
and this one was 270 dollars 400 watts
but low low wind it may just be 40 Watts
that's okay
so let's just say
even generate 40 Watts for 24 hours
because not dependent on the sun you
know you could have wind blowing anytime
and we round that up to one kilowatt per
day 40 Watts it'd be like you know 960
Watts we'll round it up because this is
all just an estimate anyway
so that one kilowatt hour you know on
average costs about 15 cents so if you
have it somewhere where it's low wind
there we go that 270 dollars divided by
15 cents gives you how many days 1800
days
so this one would be if it was low wind
we're talking like five years to pay for
itself and then after that you know
free electricity again even five years
not so bad
as a return on your investment but I
just have to mention if you do live in a
windy area and let's say you can produce
a constant 400 watts you know there's a
lot of places it you know especially if
you're near like a body of water
um sometimes Lakes
um ocean Bay you know
wide river
you could definitely get a consistent
wind and if that's the case
there you go
um
and it would only take about half a year
to pay for itself because if you're
producing this 400 watts that's 9.6
kilowatt hours per day
or 1.44 and then just do that division
you know 270 divided by a dollar 44 187
days
just over half a year
and really then enough win in enough
space
by three of them and because you're make
it you know you're generating 400 watts
uh three of them is probably enough to
power you know somebody's house like
everything
so
you know your your state you would be
saving all that electricity you'd be
making use of the three of them and
power the whole house in about six
months
so
uh you know the same that would be about
that same
yeah so really interesting and this is
the thing like you can do these
calculations
um I just wrote them here but you can
also bring up the Google collab and do
these different calculations
um graph different things if you wanted
to see see it and
that that that's the idea with having
all you know all the math calculations
you know at your fingertips you can calc
you can calculate things and figure out
is it worth it for me oh hey if I spend
this much money and then you know
generate this for electricity yeah maybe
um or or you might say
um
it's not a priority right now and you
know that's it but you but you know
based on the numbers
so that's that's really some of the some
of the uses of of some of the math we've
been doing and you know also making use
of you know the collab
uh graphing some different things
or solving solving some problems so
hopefully this was this was useful and
hopefully this gives you ideas of other
things you can do once you
set up your your uh collab notebooks and
you have the ability to calculate and
graph some different things
um you know make use of it to see what
you can do to make money or save
yourself money
all right and we'll go on to the next
unit then
so let's talk about quadratics so the
word quad
means Square
so
why would we have you know quad square
but then it's and we call this x squared
but yet there's a 2.
so where does the square come from the
square in quadratics comes from the idea
and this goes back to the original
algebra back with alcorismi
um
so the if I have a square and you know I
don't know each side I'm just going to
call them X but then the area of that
square
would be x times x would be x squared
and that's where that's really where
this notion of quadratics comes from you
know as I actually tied to physical area
the area of a square
but there's a lot of other applications
and this comes up so often that we get
Beyond even the the actual measurements
and we can use this for a lot of other
things so we look at the
our equation y equals x squared so
if I were to graph this and we get into
the code we're going to get into the
graphing and we're going to look at some
of those applications too but what I'm
going to when I graph this anytime I
graph a quadratic it's going to be a
parabola
and you know it'll probably look like a
nicer Parabola than that but it'll be a
parabola so that means
you know and if we can picture this the
positive values for X give me you know I
Square them and give me some y value but
then the negative values when I square
that negative times negative makes a
positive so that's why it curves back
around
and so you know we keep going up and
then these two ends go on as long as you
want them to
um but yeah the the negative X values
are get squared so then the Y values
would still be positive
I still can get Negative y values
because if in My Graph I subtract
something
you know I can subtract you know five or
something like that so there's
definitely some X values there that even
squared or less than five so when I
subtract I get a negative y value so you
can still do that but you see the the
general trend of the parabola here
and they you know kind of look like a
smile
but if you have if you have a negative x
value
so any negative x value it looks like a
frown
so our coefficients here
um that one would be negative
so let's yeah let's take a look at this
if I had any general
quadratic and this is the general form
so if I have a general form of any
quadratic would be y equals
ax squared plus BX
plus c
and that covers all the possible
coefficients for any quadratic equation
so a would be my coefficient for the x
squared term B would be my coefficient
for the X term and then C would be the
constant
and if I look at these as long as a has
a number then I can have a quadratic B
and C can be zero like the original y
equals x squared oh well there's no X
term B 0 C was Zero
um and then the other one I I brought up
I put minus five so then C would be
minus five b would still be zero so
there we go
um the general form for any quadratic
and as long as a has a number to it then
it's a quadratic a just can't be zero
then it's some some other type so if we
take a look at this and you know a is
negative it opens down like a frown a is
positive opens up like a smile and the
other thing about these quadratics is
they're all symmetrical so the vertex
is the point at the bottom or at the top
depending on how it turns uh of where
the parabola turns around
so since it's symmetrical the x value
is going to be this definite formula
negative B over 2A
so what I have is
once I have a b and c
I can plug in my for my values for
A and B and get the x value for the
vertex
and then once I get the x value I would
plug that x value in to get the Y value
and then I'd have this point and then
that would be the point that if I had my
Parabola that would be the point
at the very bottom where it turns around
and also just looking at that x value
remember they're symmetrical
so that would divide the parabola nicely
um so we're going to look at um doing
this in the code
importing a b and c and then finding the
vertex
um finding a lot of other things so
we're going to make use of the code to
be able to do that
so I'm not going to worry about all the
factoring here
but what I am going to show you
is
one other thing that we're also going to
look at the code but sometimes it helps
to see this formula
is a lot of times when I graph this if I
were to graph a parabola you know here's
my x y and you know let's have a
parabola there I might also be
interested in The Roots where does the
parabola across the x-axis
and so when it crosses the x-axis then y
would be zero
because you know on the axis I'm not
going up or down at all
so if I have something you know we would
talk about solving for x but if I have
something like this yes I have equal 0
and I have one variable which is X how
would I solve it we approach it a little
bit differently than we we would the
other the other ones because when I
square root something and that's going
to happen as a part of the process when
I square root something the answer is
the positive there's positive or
negative possibilities
because if I had
um
if I had the square if I had let's say 4
and then the square root that it's
positive 4 or negative 4. because
if I had
um a positive two because if I had 2
squared that equals 4
but if I had negative 2
squared
that would also equal positive four so
if I'm going the other way if I have a 4
and I'm Square rooting yes it could be
positive 2 or it could have been
negative 2.
and so when I'm finding the roots for a
quadratic you know setting this equal to
zero one of the steps is going to
involve Square rooting which gives me a
possibility of a positive or A negative
answer and then that's where
we have
you know our two possible answers and so
that's how in one formula
you know many quadratics
you know the way they cross they're
going to cross the x-axis and touch it
twice so to find the roots I want to
find out those two values and the
formula will give it to us
so again knowing a b and c the quadratic
formula
all right so and notice it's that
that vertex plus or minus something
and then that's how we use plus or minus
square root of B squared minus 4 AC
all over 2A again
so this is the quadratic formula
that you know because I have plus or
minus
it will give it will give me two Roots
you know I I know and we'll see in the
code we would run through this once for
plus get that answer once for minus get
that answer here we go
but also send some Square rooting
something
uh we're just we're gonna stick with the
real numbers here and if I have a
negative value under this radical then
there's no real solution
so you know um
we can get into imaginary numbers and
you know that's not real solution but
why should we let that stop us but for
our purposes we're not going to worry
about that we're going to say that if
it's negative then there's no real
solution and we're going to just stop
there so in doing this I would often
test this we call this part under here
the discriminant and I would often test
this you know B squared minus 4AC
does the is that zero or actually that
can be zero which is fine because that'd
be plus or minus zero you know that
means it would have one root it would
just touch the x-axis
that's fine but if it's negative then
that means I have no roots and I would
have a parabola that
just never touched the x-axis
so that's that's perfectly fine it's
possible and
in that case I would test that first and
if I knew that then that would save me
some time you know not having to do all
this because you know if we did this old
school and just factored it all out you
know right right in the notebook you
know sometimes it takes a while we're
going to look at how to make this a lot
easier you know writing the code we're
going to put these formulas in and then
we're going to find the roots in the
vertex
oh you know maybe we'll even graph them
too so
this is the formula and notice in math
they're both have the same denominator
so I could
I could make this all over one
denominator
like that works out
you know do the adding or subtracting in
the numerator all over one denominator
and mathematically that works out you
know it's another way to write it so
this is very often this is the quadratic
formula as we would often see it just
like this all that all over 2A
and so for as complex as this could be
there's only a few formulas all right I
see this I get a B and C
formula for the vertex
formula for the roots
we look at graphing it and then we'll
you know then we can look at some of the
applications but this is where
um this is kind of the essence of
looking at quadratics here
and so now let's take a look and we'll
go into some other
um you know how to solve these formulas
and everything so let's take a look at
the code so solving a quadratic equation
is much easier with code because all the
formulas that we were talking about that
we would work out by hand we're just
going to put them all into the code so
you can just Define a b and c once and
then
run those values through all the
formulas you need and output your answer
Roots vertex and whatever else you need
so I just picked some values here that
work out uh nicely a b and c
and what we want to do let's first of
all just print it
so we'll print out what our
function is
then we'll calculate the vertex so
notice VX I call the variable and that's
the negative B over 2A that's going to
calculate the x value and python does
note order of operations but this 2A
does need to be in parentheses because
it is the whole denominator
so we get that x value and then we're
going to take that x value and plug that
in for the Y value
a times and my x value VX and then
Square it
plus b times VX plus c
so
I get I plug all that in get the Y value
and just like before I'll print it now
um
there we go just print the equation
now we have the vertex as a point and
we'll go on to the roots
and The Roots remember the quadratic
formula D it works on ABCD but it's
actually D is for determinant here
that's the part that's underneath the
square root because if that's negative
then I won't have any real roots
and so I'll just Define d as that part
of the square root B squared minus 4AC
and then I'll test it here if D is
greater than or equal to zero
because if it's not then I'm going to
print out no real roots
so if as long as it's greater than or
equal to then we're going to calculate
the roots
and remember it's the rest of the
quadratic formula so since I already
figured out D I'll make use of that so
negative B plus or minus so we're going
to run through this twice for the first
root negative e plus
the square root of D and then all that's
over 2A
and notice parentheses for the numerator
parentheses for the denominator and then
the second root negative B minus the
square root of d
and then all that's over 2A
so I'll print this out
calculate the roots printed out
or you know no real Roots if that's the
case and there we go so I actually
already ran this and what do we have y
equals
so X 1X squared plus 5x plus 6 and then
we have the vertex is this negative 2.5
negative 0.25 and then the roots x
equals 2 negative 2 and x equals
negative 3.
so there we go if all you need to do is
solve it
it's nice to have all these formulas at
the ready just change a b and c and run
it again
so if we want to graph it also
we can do everything we were doing plus
the graphing part
remember our Imports for graphing that
plot Library
numpy I'm also going to import math
for some things that we'll do
I'm going to define a b and c I just
pick different numbers here
and
I'm going to print out a b and c so this
part is very similar I'm going to print
this out
calculate the vertex print that out and
now we get into the graphing
so notice I didn't do the roots yet
um
and we just have X Min x max you know
all everything else we're doing for
graphing to find the X values
set up the plot
and now I can graph the parabola I just
called it y1 even though I probably
won't have a second y value here
ax squared plus BX plus C there we go
I'm going to graph that whole Parabola
and then that's y1 so I'm going to plot
X and then y1
then I'm going to plot the vertex as a
point
so I put this all down here for the
the plotting Parabola the vertex point
and then notice
um this one up here by default it's
going to be a line and here I'm defining
two
arrays each of them with one item and
then that's going to be
a Red Dot
so then we're going to find and plot The
Roots everything we were doing with
calculating the roots from before
but I'm going to add this one line here
Pi Dot Plot
and once I get the plot I'm going to
plot root one
root 1 0 and root 2 0. and remember you
know the array of my X values and then
the Y values
and this one is going to be a Green Dot
so that's why it's go it's going to be a
green circle
so I'm going to plot that and then I'm
also going to print out the roots
because I want to see that too so when
we have all this
and
then we run it
it'll have your equation here
there we go x squared plus 4X plus 1
give you the vertex and give you the
roots now these roots are irrational
you know that's why it gets this wacky
decimal we we could you know do quite a
few more lines of code to
get to the wacky uh radical answer but
uh we're not going to worry about that
now that that's that's perfectly fine if
you're writing this down somewhere you
might round it to a couple decimal
places
but here we go we plot the vertex as a
red dot The Roots as green dots you know
see where it crosses the x-axis and then
we graph the parabola
and so I can
redo this then let's just try these
numbers that we were doing before one
five
there we go six and
that's all we need to do change a b and
c
and it'll run through and calculate all
this there we go x squared plus five X
plus six
and here's the vertex negative 2.5
negative 0.25 and then the roots 2 and
negative 2 and negative 3.
there we go now there we go negative two
and negative 3 are where it crosses the
x-axis and see the Y value of that
vertex is negative 0.25 so it's just
below it but just barely
and there we go so we can
plot our uh quadratic formula we can
graph it we can get our roots and our
vertex and for most things when you're
solving quadratics that's what you want
to do
so let's take a look at
how a b and c actually affect the graph
so I'm going to show you some sliders
here and that's going to come up again
in one of the other notebooks
so how a b and c so the first thing is
we're going to import this and just that
way matplot live
in line and we're going to write that
first and then we're going to import
these widgets and
Interactive
the same and then the same other things
we're going to do with the plot
so the way that these widgets work is
we're going to put all the graphing in
this function so now we're going to
connect again with functions here
I still defined it just as F and that's
because later on I wanted that to be a
short name for that line but we'll see
so I'm going to Define this F but it's
the function of a b and c I'm going to
take those three things a b and c as
inputs
now you could always
um make this say quadratic and you know
do everything that you want to do with
the quadratic
um
Roots vertex we we could actually take
everything that we're doing before with
the plotting and with solving and put
all that in this function at that point
I would call it more than just F I'd
like to say quadratic and take the
argument a b and c and do everything you
need so kind of cool that you can do
that but here we're just going to focus
on the graphing so
my function there we go X Min x max all
those I'm going to Define all these
things for graphing remember a b and c
would be the input so we would have
those
and then
plot the parabola
plot uh the vertex as a point plot The
Roots as points
and
um
there we go this
all of this here is really just extra
for the sake of setting the equation as
the title of the graph
I did that instead of printing it out
which I guess we could we could have
done but I wanted to show you we could
set it as the title of the graph and the
title needs to be a string
so here I'm going to take a b and c
and convert them all to Strings
then I'm going to take all of this
um and I was you know this doesn't
necessarily connect with HTML but I was
thinking of that H1 for the heading so
I'm just going to combine all these or
concatenate all these that exact y
equals combined with sa that string and
I'm going to combine all these as H1
but if I just leave it at that it'll
still display in a weird way as the
title there'll be like extra quotes and
I don't like that so I'm going to just
find this other one H2 which just it's
just blank with quotes and that's going
to be a string and I'm going to Loop
through this for w in H1 you know W like
for word in H1 and then H2 equals H2
plus W so
I still had to convert these to Strings
put it all together as H1 but then I
still needed to put it in H2
if I do it this way combining these now
H2 is a nice unified string without a
lot of extra quotes
and so that's you know again it's a lot
to just It All Leads up to the sake of
for the sake of
putting this as the title
okay and you know we'll see hopefully
you know it looks nice and you know you
see how that was you say oh that was
worth it all right so here's where the
interactive comes in
so we have this interactive plot now
that's just the variable
that I chose
interactive plot but
here's what what's really happening this
interactive function so if we take a
look at this so it runs this function f
so that's where the name of your
function goes and that's where you see
how long this line got I wanted this to
be short so I just that's why I called
it f so it runs this function
and then that function and then it
defines a with a range from one to nine
B
with a range from negative nine to nine
and C also with a range from negative
nine to nine
um a I started at one because
if it was Zero
that's actually not a quadratic and I
want to illustrate quadratics and so
I'll start at one
so we just Define this interactive plot
and then notice this as the last line of
code then if I just say interactive plot
it's going to print it's going to run
that
so we'll see this interactive how that
makes the sliders here
there we go and it default shows them in
the middle
and see this is what I wanted it to be
that when it starts out you see the
title of the graph
y equals 5x squared plus 0x plus zero
you see that's it just and if I go if I
make that down to one
this is the parent graph the most basic
parabola
you know x squared and I don't have to
put the plus zero but in this case it's
going to write that every time
and then we can see what happens if I
move C
you see
I can move C and it'll adjust the graph
it'll adjust the title
of the graph
there we go
and then we can see what happens
if I move B
you see
it moves along here
and now
it got to this point that now where it
is I do have roots in the vertex that I
can display
and then if I have
I can see where b as I move that around
affects this whole graph
and I can see then how a
ffects the whole graph
so we see some different things that we
can do
and
all these are going to be
accessible to you can Tinker with these
but
this is all you know it was just I
wanted to show you this interactive that
you can set up sliders and in this case
to display the
um display the graph
see the roots in the vertex
you see and I move that down so we
display the graph see the roots in the
vertex and adjust it with sliders you
can see how a b and c affect the graph
so
knowing this and being able to have all
this code at your disposal you can
really see
you know most everything that you're
gonna need to do with quadratics you
know find the roots in the vertex see
the graph
and
you know adjust it and you know do some
other things so
there we go
um
this in some practice you'll you'll know
quadratics inside and out
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
the use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here
so here we're going to walk through the
foundational math certification 2. and
if you have not already done it please
give this a try on your own this is for
if you're if you've already done that
and you're stuck or if you uh just had a
question about one of the parts you know
we'll hopefully answer all those and
just like the other certifications this
one you're going to make a copy and put
this in your uh in your Google Drive
so you know file save a copy in your
drive and this one we're going to focus
on building Cartesian graphs
so most of this is going to deal with
graphing we're going to look at some
different functions and what you can do
with that
so you make a copy in your Google drive
it might be in your Google collab
notebooks folder where you can put it
wherever you want
and
now hopefully you know I already did
that so hopefully you're now working
from your copy and we need to acquire
the testing Library
so the code that you write just like the
certification one the code to your right
when you run it it'll run through these
tests to see if the code is what it's
supposed to be and then give you some
feedback
so this first cell you don't need to do
anything and you might just take note of
what you need to do here for future
reference in case you want to have your
own custom library that you know you
include in your
collab notebook so this custom Library
it's on GitHub and this code is going to
get that and save it here in a work in a
local working directory
so you will need to run this
for each new session
um as I mentioned before
it'll uh the session will time out
um because of inactivity after 30
minutes at the most or even if you're
busy 12 hours it'll time out so
each new session run this
and
it'll go through and import the library
so we click to run
yep
and see just a few seconds
um
coach has passed so there we go
so let's take a look at some coordinates
here
Cartesian coordinates and they're named
from Renee Descartes because that's part
of his name cart and
you know that's it you know you've
arrived in life when your last name
becomes an adjective so he among other
things invented this x y coordinate
system that we're familiar with
with zero zero in the center and then X
moving horizontally positive to the
right negative to the left and Y moving
vertically positive up negative down so
then
each x y coordinate
tells you you know how much you're going
over and how much you're going up
and we can plot all these points
our go-to library is going to be matplot
Library
and as we were talking about importing
your own personal Library custom Library
we needed
um to do that in a little bit different
ways a few more lines but a lot of the
common libraries
I say comment like you know
reasonably used been around a little bit
uh behind the scenes Google collab
already did that install part so you
just need to worry about importing it
so you know we have that nice benefit
you know things just work in the Google
codelab so that plot live uh dot Pi plot
and we're importing this Library yeah
that's a mouthful so we're going to
import it as PLT that way every time I
reference it
plt.plt dot I don't have to rewrite all
this
okay so this is going to be the first
thing is the basic
just here's a graph
there we go and
you probably could change these
variables but I don't this is what's in
the example uh in the documentation for
matplot Library so I keep these and it
does seem weird that you're assigning
two different variables to this but it's
you could have multiple subplots
um we're not going to worry about that
right here but you could have multiple
subplots and you know your one graph
could have like nine little graphs in it
if you wanted
or something like that but so that you
would put numbers in there but we're not
worried about that now this establishes
that this plot exists and then plt.show
that's always going to be our last thing
to show it
we run it and there's our basic graph
notice we didn't add anything else
um
so there's not nothing going on here and
zero zero instead of being in the middle
it's in the bottom left because we're
just showing the positive
quadrant here so just positive X values
up to one positive y values up to one
and that's it
and notice all these the
yeah
test and yes Code test passed if you
click the button correctly
so we'll go to step two
all right so now we have the standard
window
still not highlighting each axis
and we're still going to go through
import this establish this
but now we're going to add something
here
so this gives us the size of the graph
and
I just put this here we're
this would be better we're going to
modify this as we go on but that'll give
us the size of the graph 10 in every
direction
so when we do plot.show
so you see it does give us 10 in the
direction and if you follow these zero
zero exists in the middle here even if
you don't see the axis lines
and
zero you know positive to the right up
to 10 negative to the left down to
negative 10 and on the y-axis 0 in the
middle positive up to 10 negative down
to negative 10. so they could line up in
the middle here somewhere
all right and this one was one of these
that I ask you to change the values then
rerun so let's run this to see what it
looks like then change the window size
to 20 in each Direction so we go through
here and we can just move this
20 in each Direction
now we notice from this even the one
where we only went up to one the size of
this graph doesn't change
but we see the lines on the outside do
and the tick marks change so now we're
going up to 20 in each Direction
there we go Code test passed
so
more graph Dimensions now this is where
I was saying we're going to modify this
this is really what we were doing
in that last one plt.access
so what were those numbers it really was
an array of X minimum X maximum y
minimum y maximum
as just one group notice the parentheses
and then the Open brackets
so that was an array and that was that
defines the window size so that's why
it's plt.axis
so I think it just makes much more sense
to define those as variables up here
so this line here the plt.axis does not
need to change
and then it's really easy for you to
then change the window size if you want
you just change those numbers
so there we go and this one is not one
uh oh yeah this one is you could run it
notice it should still do the same thing
there we go and then we're just going to
change these to 20 in each Direction
20.
go
and
again we see 20 in each Direction
so this is going to be our go-to way to
set up the graph
and as we keep going
let's look at those
those axis lines that you might be
missing I know I was missing them
so how do we want to display these well
we have our basic graph and we have the
directions here if you're doing this on
your own that the B that we're going to
see here makes the line blue
so we have this Dimensions that we were
building upon
and
these first two lines there we go
subplots in the window size
so
now we have the plt.plot
and
that's going to get plot a line for us
or points
now in this case we have
this array here
from X Min to X Max and then this right
here what this is is
a
an array of the X values and then the Y
values
so we have
starts from X min
zero
and then goes to x max zero
and rather than plot to those two points
it plots a line from that point to that
point and with this the line is going to
be blue
if you don't put something like this in
here
python will pick the color of the line
for you
and then for the y-axis
then
we're going to plot 0 0 y Min y Max so
what is this telling us it's from
the x value of zero so the Y value of y
Min so from 0 y min
to zero y Max
it's going to draw that line and again
I'm forcing it into
B this this space here whether you have
the space or not doesn't matter
so there we go so these two plot
statements
these two these two plot statements
define whether you know to find that
it's going to be a line and then what
color and I even have the comments here
so then you see blue x-axis blue y-axis
so that's it we're going to show this
plot and
we see the X and Y axis
we also see again the the value of
defining everything up here because then
all the rest of these
the size of the graph and then where
these lines go
to and from
it's all based on this up top so if I
change the dimensions of this
then everything else will adjust
accordingly and the axis lines will
still go to the ends
so we run it and then change B to G
and
there we go change to G
and there we go it's green
so
you can make it wherever you want
um
I just happen to like blue
so there we go
changing these so now supposing I wanted
to plot a point like we saw that we did
that to define a line we're going to
plot a point
well
see as we continue to build this to find
these values Here and Now
we're gonna we're just gonna end up
keeping all of this
as the window size and then the X and Y
axis
and keeping it blue
so how do I apply exactly one point so
notice this array
of X values of which there's only one in
there
and Y values
so it's 5 4
. now here's what else we have it's r o
that o makes it a a point in fact a
circular Dot
so if I have just B with nothing that's
going to make it a line
if I actually just had r with nothing
that would make it a line but it
actually has nowhere to go 2 so that
would be weird but Ro
makes it a point
and we'll see we can
plot other things too
so
keeping all that the same and just
plotting this one point
there we go
one point
and it is five at five four
over five up four
we could put the grid lines in but
that'll be another story
so now change the location
so the directions run it then change the
location to negative 5 1. okay
so then we just change this
to negative five and change this to one
there we go and when we run it
so we see negative 5 1.
all right
so plotting a point
we indicate that it's a point this way
and
plotting a line
we have other ways to indicate that
so how would I plot several points
well let's take a look
all right so
arrays to plot each point
you know that's what we've been doing
and
we can still Define it as an array here
I'm just going to define the array here
an array of X values and an array of Y
values
so
if I have these X values and Y values
when we go down here so notice all
that's still the same and here
I can plot
x y
now I chose X Y because you know X
values and Y values and I did not use
exactly X and Y as other variables
already so we're okay
I mean you really could name these
arrays whatever you want
but there we go we have what am I
plotting the array of x i is the array
of Y values and then
here I have
red points for each of them
now right here
I only have one L one number in each so
we can add so that's the assignment for
this step add two numbers to each so
that also graphs one one and two five
okay so the x value would be one
and the Y value would be one so there
you go so I have 0.42 and then 0.11 and
the next one two five
so
x value would be 2.
y value would be five
and there we go
all right and
changing those arrays now I can plot I
still don't have to change this code
plot that array
and we see three different points
because each of them I made
a red point
so let's mix it up let's plot some
points in some lines
okay so that's it hopefully you are
noticing the subtle difference between
the points and the lines each plot
statement takes an array of X values an
array of Y values and a third argument
to tell you what you're plotting
so the default plot is aligned if you
actually skip that third argument it
would give you a line and python would
pick the color
RBG
indicate the colors
and CMYK actually also work as just
letters and beyond that there's actually
a few other colors where you can just
write in the word for the color
um give it a try you know I'm not
going to list all the possible colors
but yeah give it a try and so these are
the colors so then we have if it's a DOT
it's going to be r o the O indicates a
DOT r s you could plot a square
and then r with a little carrot symbol
would be a triangle so that if you have
different things you're plotting you can
mix it up and have dots or squares or
triangles
and then of course that combined with
the different colors you can plot a lot
of different things on one graph
so notice we've already defined these
arrays here
and I'll call this one line X line Y
point x point Y so
yeah not lining and pointy
and there we go so we have these
we'll keep all these defining the graph
the same way
and
let's plot so if I wanted to plot
so the directions are a lot of red line
and two green squares so
if I plot here
so line X comma line Y and we want it to
be red
and it's a line
so there we go
and
point x
point Y
and it's a green square GS
so you see if you're working through the
course hopefully this is a review
and if you're coming at this you know
relatively new hopefully it's even
pretty straightforward
but then the more you do this the more
you just get familiar with with graphing
everything and you know you'll be able
to do this right off the top of your
head
so we graph this
and we will see
so there's the red line from that point
to that point and the green squares over
here
so there we go
so we see how we can graph a line
and different points
okay so here's a scatter plot game
and I call this making a scatter plot
game
um but I kind of made the game
so
um
but we could take a look so this is what
we want to do we want to look through
this code how can I plot a random point
and then
you know you're going to
try to guess the point
I made the
I made this uh you know a smaller axis
for whatever reason
and
we'll Define this once
and here's what we're doing each time
if we are
um
we're going to get an X point
which is going to be a random number so
notice how this this is going to be good
for different games or different things
you do
import random
guess there's a whole library of
randomness
and random.randint
and it gives the range here
from X Min to X Max and actually the way
most ranges work in Python
X Min is a possibility but x max
um
is x max it will won't go to that it'll
go to the number before
so why point Y Min y Max
so there we go so you see again if I
change these Dimensions it will still
give me a random integer that's within
that
so
now if
X point is the random integer
then
I'm going to store that as my x value
store this is my y value
and you see essentially it is an array
with one element
you know
but then
and I might have been able to skip this
step but I I like really spelling it out
you know with what this is and now we go
here
allowed me to plot it
as a DOT
so
there we go this gives the grid now this
is we you know we had their axis lines
this is the grid plt.grid
so
that'll help because the game is going
to be here's the point you tell me what
the coordinates are
so
that's what this is yes and we're going
to prompt for input enter the
coordinates of the red point
and that's going to be an X Y with a
comma
so
we're going to split it at the comma
and that's going to be an array with two
elements so then
guess array zero so the first element
casted as an integer that's going to be
the X guess and the second element is
the Y value
cast as an integer that's going to be
the Y gas
and this is part of why I like to break
it up here
um
because
I have
this here these are the points
this defines it as an array
but this is the point that we wanted so
we test it if x guess equals x point
and Y gas equals y point then that's
going to increment your score
and there we go all this in the loop and
then the if statements in the loop now
the Loop's done
and
you know in range zero to three we
really because we're including zero we
actually don't need that zero
um the range will start at zero by
default
so
there we go for I and range
it's going to go through it three times
because it'll be zero one two and then
again python ranges if if it's range
three it won't do three it'll do zero
one two and then that's it
so
we go through and guess it three times
and then
print out the score
so the score
was way at the top
initialize it at zero and we'll see
see what happens here so you see with
the grid lines we can see
so zero and
look at these four five
so the coordinates of the red point
would be zero five
and
here we have zero
negative three
zero negative three
and this is why I made it eight in every
direction because it actually the grid
lines just work out a little bit better
so what's the coordinate of this point
so looks like 3 on the x-axis and then
down three so that would be three
negative 3.
all right and
there we go
you can try this out
it'd be a good way to
test your understanding of coordinates
all right and step nine so now if I want
to graph a whole linear equation
so this was nice if I Define these two
points and I can draw a line between
them but what if I actually just want
the whole linear equation
so
numpy is the library we're going to use
for that
so we're going to import numpy as NP now
that one I mean numpy is not that big of
a word to write but
as NP it just seems to be a common thing
so you will see np.this or np.net for
the different functions
all right and then we have the Lin space
function so that defines an array of
values
uh when we were talking about functions
we can you know Loop through but this
gives us that array
and we're going to plot the function
with two arguments
so
if we take a look at this all these so
after we import and on by
same setup for the graph
and then Lin space
we give this
now I purposefully made it a little bit
less you actually uh we'll get to some
other things that we can do
with this that'll make it even better
but I made it
purposefully a little bit less than
the maximum values here on the graph and
then the third argument so it goes from
it's the X values is what we want for
this so the x value goes from negative
nine to nine and in that there are 36
points
so believe believe it or not that's
actually going to be enough which is you
know four points
um
you know like every one-fourth is a
point
that's actually going to be enough
and notice then what we're plotting here
are X values
and you see that's the array of X values
numpy gives us that array
so that X values and then
given this I can just put this equation
in here
as that's the Y value each time so as it
goes through this array of X values that
y value
is gonna
it calculated each time and then that's
what it's going to plot
so
then when we run this
we see that it actually plotted this
point this this graph
there we go 2x minus three
and Yep looks like it crossed there
about negative three and looks like
about up two over one
Etc
um
Okay so
there we go
um
and
we have this run it and then change it
to graph Negative X Plus 3.
so all these can stay the same
now in this case
since this was cut off here we didn't
really notice that
but if we just then change this
to Negative X
Plus 3.
now we see the
the limitations of this
you know because
it cut off there
so what can we do here
well
we could in this just make this we've
already defined X Min and x max we could
actually make this go from X Min to x
max
and you'll see this come up in the next
things we do
all right
so we can create interactive graphs
so in this case
we've been talking about linear
equations
let's let's use these widgets to make a
slider so we're going to import all
these things here
now
you know numpy for our array of X values
that plot library for the
grip for the plot and then we have
we're going to import this in line and
then the widgets
so
we can make all the graphing happen in a
function
and we have
there we go function
and then B and
if you if you were working through some
of the other things in this course this
might be familiar and then we'll see
just you know what's the same and what's
different about what we're doing here
with this function
so if I have this function of m and b
everything happens in the function
defining the X values y the maximum
defining all this
and in this case we're going to give it
a title because we already know that
this is going to be a slope intercept
equation so we're going to give it that
title
all right and then we have
there we go np.lin space
and
we could always
make this now this time I also rewrote
the numbers but you could always make
this
just X Min X Max and
something else here so
what are we going to do here we're going
to plot X and then MX plus b
because
these m and b values are going to come
from the slider and then the function is
going to
take that so here's our interactive plot
I mean I could have made the variable
something different but the function is
interactive and then it takes
F what's what function
and then m equals so we give it a range
and b equals and we give it a range
and we run this interactive plot
so
we can use this
the plot now notice it default goes to
zero so as soon as I increase m
you see now I have a line with the slope
of two
line with the slope of four
and then B is still zero but I can move
this up
and
I can move it down
and we see
that I can adjust my graph
so it's nice to have these things that
we can adjust
a graph
all right and then if I'm graphing a
system
so
maybe you're already graphing a system
of equations that then hopefully this is
a good review
um if this is new then take a look at
here's one way to graph a system of
equations
all right same Imports
and
same defining these now here's where we
make it a lot better so
how many points do I want
I'm just going to take it also based on
this
x max minus X Min so that's going to
give me or X Min is very often the
negative so
that's going to give me you know this
range and then times two
so
that might be enough times 10 that might
be plenty for even more complicated
graphs so that's how many points I have
like the you know there's the range and
then times two
and then to find the X values once and
here we are defining this lens base from
X Min to X Max and then this many points
so we see again we're building these
um I have this comment in there for you
but you know
pretty soon then you won't even need
that and now we again we have our
complete uh our base of what we're
importing and then the basics for the
graph
so then I can plot two lines
you know Define y1 in terms of x
because
I just make my X values X because that's
convenient
and
what am I plotting
X and then y1
there we go
and in line two notice it doesn't have
to be linear this this plot works you
know x squared minus 3 and what am I
plotting the X values and then Y2
and we can see these
so there we go
all right change Y2 and rerun the code
um so Y2 we're going to make it negative
x minus 3.
so
we're just going to rerun this as
negative x minus 3.
and we see
there we go
and with these
you I could Define what color I want
these lines to be but without that
python gives me the colors light blue
then orange you know it'll go through a
few colors
and there we go defining
uh
two points so systems of equations
you know so there we go that was
graphing
two equations and you know you could
graph more if you want
systems of equations we're going to
import Sim pi
so the Senpai Library
um and
we probably don't need import everything
but I do
for this particular example so the
import asterisk is going to import
everything from the Senpai Library
and we're going to Define these symbols
so now I'm going to here I'm going to
Define X and Y as symbols that I'm going
to use to solve
so
I could Define these separately and
you'll see in other places that we do
but what do I have I have Lin solve
and then notice open parentheses because
that's the function for lin solve and
then what do I have I have this array
of these two equations set equal to zero
so that's what you know it would be this
2 times X Plus y minus 1 equals zero
and then the other one x minus 2 times y
plus seven equals zero
so
that's how we have to set it up if I
want to solve these two
it would be that was set equal to zero
and then I'm solving for the variables X
and Y
and
what happens when I run it
it gives me
this negative 1 3 as
as a point that's the solution there we
go
so one way to solve systems of equations
and if we change these to 2X
um
plus y minus 15 equals zero so
2x plus y minus 15.
we'll just change that and then 3x
so remember 3 times x
you know we'll write it as 3x but in
Python we have to remember to put the
multiplying symbol in there minus y so
we're going to flip that part
and
that's it just 3x minus y equals zero so
there we go and if we
run that there we go
3 9 is the solution
so there you go one way one of the ways
to solve a system of equations so
graphing a system of equations solving a
system of equations and
you may have already gotten to it
um
set writing the code to solve that graph
and output you know make the output even
you know a little bit nicer
so
um
if you haven't already gotten to that uh
you will
so now we can get the solutions as
coordinates
so as we saw there it returns a finite
set
but given that set we can convert that
into an X Y coordinates
so also here
I split out first and second
as two different as a way to put these
here so now when I have this solution
I don't have to change this code then
solve first second
and then we Define them up here
sometimes that's a little bit easier
now
we know that that solution is going to
be a finite set
so this is how we parse it out
I'll call this variable X solution is
solution dot args 0 0.
and then the Y value is going to be
solution dot RX 0 1.
and so there we go you don't have to
think through like all the different
ways that that's organized especially
since you know you think that okay
there's only one X Y solution but
there's a lot going on here
so now I have these as ex solution y
solution and I'm going to print them out
x equals y equals
and Just for kicks I'll also print it
out as a coordinate pair
so see Zero Zero
I mean yeah
it works out
because X Plus y and x minus y
so they would cross a zero zero
um
so there you go again another way to
then Elevate that and solve it
um
just showing you different different
ways that you can parse these things out
we can even get the system from user
input
so
I'm going to print
for anybody
you know this remember to use Python
syntax
and then
notice how each equation is already set
equal to zero because I'm going to
prompt for the input here
first
and the first equation and then second
and the second equation and I'm not even
casting these as anything
I don't need to because
then Lin solve works out like that
there you go first second and then parse
the solutions
so
let's do this as long as as long as two
things set equal to zero and I do want
an X and A Y so I will have
three times x
plus four
minus y so if you think about things in
terms of y equals then you could just
put a minus y here so 3x plus 4 minus y
okay
um
and
I just hit enter and it jumped down so
now the second equation and
we have
all right so
um what if I have five
times x
um
plus five
there we go and notice the space
um
minus y
here we go hit enter it jumps down
and there we go we have an X and A Y
solution
pretty cool
all right and then solve and graph which
in in this whole course
um
the solving graph we have the uh
you you'll see as we build and you know
you get more and more familiar with all
the different ways to solve and graph
then he you'll see that uh we can get
more and more elegant Solutions
here
we're gonna
import matplot library and simpi and
numpy so we're using all of these
so this one here
we're just doing this with linear
equations
and
knowing that it's linear equations
notice
I'm only asking for m and b separated by
a comma
so I'll call that input mb1
because then
I'm going to split that
and make that an array and from that I'm
going to take
the first one and that must be m
and then the next one
that must be B
so we see that you know take this input
um I wanted it separated by a comma so
then we're going to split it at the
comma
so that input is a string splitting the
string makes the array
and then now
that array
the first element
zero I'm going to cast it as a float
called M1
and then element one the second element
I'm going to cast as a float and that's
going to be B1
and we're going to do the same thing for
the second one
and then B
and then everything's going to be the
second mb2
split it at the comma
makes that array
and then that array the first element
casted as a float M2 second Element cast
as a float B2 and now that I have these
I can solve it so here we're using
Senpai to solve it because I'm going to
say
that first equation I'm going to give it
this variable first
is this because I know it would be
something in y equals MX plus b so it'd
be M1 times X Plus B1 and then minus y
that would be that set to zero
and then there's the second
and then
solve first second
I'm going to
just in case there's
mult just in case there's a weird
solution
I want to take that solution
to three decimal places
so I would take that solution cast it as
a float
and then round it to three decimal
places
for many things you know I might not
need it but I give that option
so that
you know whatever comes up
it works so there we go solution I'm
going to find these Solutions
um three decimal places around them
and now I have these the X solution and
the Y solution
so then to make sure the window includes
it rather than give it to be my normal
um
my normal window and this is a float
so if I cast as an integer
and then I can
add 20 subtract 20 you know I gave it
each of these so
that way each of these Solutions I cast
it as an integer and I know that my
graph is going to include that solution
and then given these you know points how
many points do I want
and then
graph x because I already used X in
other places so graph x is the value
for my X values so there we go min max
how many points
and here's my y1
is M1 times graph X Plus B1
and everything here for the white Y2 M2
times graph X Plus B2
so then when we
set up the graph
and line one
there we go graph x y one
and line two
and the point so now I'm going to plot
the point which is X solution y solution
as a point
so that way whatever equations we have
and then
print out the value
so
if we take a look at this ex solution y
solution
we run this
first equation
all right so let's see let's call it
three
five
and let's call this one
um
negative one
oh
because I didn't put the comma
so three five
and negative one
and
there we go
um six
so
we have these and
we see these
points this is the solution
even though it showed up as not a nice
integer decimal numbers but then we see
the graph and then we see the point
where they intersect
and these are kind of the things that we
want to build Upon This is actually one
good way
to plot and graph
where if you know that it's linear
then just prompt for those coefficients
and we can do that for other types of
types of functions
you know when we get to the
um
well when we get to all the parent
graphs and all the different types of
functions you see that this is one way
we can prompt for you know if it's that
type of function prompt for the
coefficients and then that works out to
solve use those coefficients to generate
something in Senpai to solve and use
them again in matplot library to graph
and then we can plot the point display
the answer
all right pretty good
so the next thing
we have is quadratic functions
when
it's not a linear equation anymore not
not a nice straight line
so
anything that involves x squared
is a quadratic
so x squared because it could be the
area of a square
I don't know the measure of the side but
I know that the area would be that side
times itself
so if I if I have x squared in there
there's going to be a parabola
and here's the simplest or here's the
the root formula ax squared plus BX plus
c
so
B and C could be zero they can be any
number including zero a has to be a
number because if a was Zero then I
don't have a quadratic
foreign
so then you know there's the simplest
one
so
now let's take a look at this
back to our graphing setting up our
points you know range our points Lin
space
all this to set up the graph and I'm
just gonna have a basic y equals x
squared
so there we go x y y equals x squared
and if we run this
that's the most basic parabola
so a in that case would be one and you
see it does touch at zero zero
all right the most basic parabola
so now
quadratic function ABCs
let's take a look at ABC and let's you
let's go back to our Interactive
and
we're going to use these widgets
so
this one here all right you have a and b
but we forgot C and we could have also
put the values on you know
in a different way but
just did it this way that's fine
now notice here
it's our interactive that we want a b
and c so
we're going to run this function f
and we see the function here of a b but
I want a b and c so
that's that's going to be your that'd be
your assignment add C to the slider
so there we go
out here comma
C equals
and then I'll do the same values
negative 9 comma nine
okay
so there we go so now I have
this interactive I'm going to have three
sliders one for a one for B one for C
and then
when
we Define the function a b c it needs
three as the input
and
the plot is going to be ax squared plus
BX
and then we have to remember we also
have plus c
so now when we run it
now it's all zeros that doesn't look
like anything but as soon as a is
something
now we have a parabola
whether it be one
now we can just take a look at what does
a do to the parabola
you see as a gets bigger the parabola
gets narrower
and zero we don't have a parabola
but negative values
it flips it
so positive like a smile negative like a
frown
and there we go so let's let's have a
positive so now what does c do I'm going
to skip over B for a second what does c
do
notice the parabola keeps the same shape
and C just moves it up
we're down
and could be zero that's fine it just
Touches at zero zero
so that's what C does it moves it up or
down the y-axis
and then B
is the most interesting
it moves it
down and stretches the parabola a little
bit
now watch what happens when we move it
so that was a very negative
but now when B
if B is zero it's symmetrical on the y
axis
but then
it goes around and then now positive B
value stretches on this side
so there we go some interesting things
about the quadratic the a b and c and
what they each do to the graph
so this bottom part or if it's flipped
over that'd be the top part where the
turnaround happens that's the vertex
so
that's the point where the parabola
turns around
and the x value
I'll give you the formula here
negative B over 2A
so
then given those inputs
um
then we're going to create the parabola
now this
um
I even have the comment here
because certainly I can print X
with the two asterisks for the exponent
but this is
um just another fancier way to Output
this and you'll see It'll come out as an
exponent it'll look like an exponent so
supposing then we just prompt for these
input values
you know we know we're doing a parabola
so we just prompt for these input values
all right then
what would be the vertex well the x
value was negative B over 2A
so
that's exactly what we're going to do
negative B
divided by and the 2A and both all that
needs to be in the denominator so I do
need the parentheses
so negative B over 2A because if I don't
it'll divide by 2 then multiply by a
doing order of operations now if I have
that value
then
given that value what do we have that's
the x value so we have a
times and remember the general form of
Parabola ax squared but what do I have I
have VX is my x value
squared
Plus
B
X so that'd be VX
because I want the x value of the vertex
plus c
so there we go so I use this a b and c
to get the x value of the vertex
and then I'm going to plug that in to
get the Y value of the vertex
and then we can plot it
and
then
X minimum so for whatever we enter we'll
just make sure that that does show up on
the graph
so counting whatever these values are
and
you know there we go take it as an
integer
and
plus 10 minus 10.
there we go and it's going to plot this
point so notice
just that x value just that y value as a
red point
and
I probably could have done this based on
X Min and x max but just doing this
anyway notice the Lin space just giving
us that
enough before and after it
um
and then here's the Y value so then we
plot x y
without the third argument by default
it's going to be a line and then python
will pick the color
so let's see let's take a look so it's
going to show us you see that's ax
squared you see that little two that was
the whole idea to get it to be that
fancy so ax squared let's just try this
one
a is one
and B is let's say
um
negative
negative five
and C is six
how about that
so
we see the vertex
and the vertex is 2.5 negative 0.25 and
we see the parabola and then we see the
vertex plotted
so pretty cool
and that's it just same formula so if we
just prompt for those
coefficients and run it through those
formulas we can plot this this graph
just like we did the linear equation
plotted for m and b we can do a
quadratic and plot for a b and c
so
you know we could we could do this again
and see some different graphs
so now let's take a look at how to apply
these parabola
qualities to projectile motion and yes
everything going through the air is a
projectile and they all actually make
the path to the parabola
pretty interesting it it can't not be a
parabola so
as we look at these the path of every
projectile
um
the graph of this that we're going to
look at is going to be for something
thrown up in the air
straight up in the air so in this case
the a value is going to be negative 4.9
each time because it accounts for
gravity and that would be in meters per
second squared
so we know that the a value stays the
same the B value represents the initial
velocity so that'll change depending on
how hard you throw the ball up in the
air or launch something
so that gets their initial velocity is B
and then the C value is the initial
height
so C would be zero if something started
on the ground
um you know like kicking kicking a ball
and if it was on the ground
you know the path of the ball is a
parabola and then in that case C would
be zero
uh the initial height in meters
so
we have our classic quadratic ax squared
plus BX plus C and in that case X is
going to be time in seconds
and then Y is the height at any given
time
so let's take a look at how this is
similar to what we were just doing but a
little bit different so
a stays negative 4.9 so I don't even
need to prompt for that if it's a
projectile that's going to stay the same
the initial velocity
I'm gonna
prompt for it and cast it as a float
because remember the input will come in
as a string so rather than just say oh
what's B I'll prompt it as initial
velocity and then C would be initial
height
now once we have those
you can and I already did copy the
VX and v y code from the last step
because the equations for the vertex are
exactly the same so you know once we
have these then we use these same
formulas
VX and v y
then
if I'm going to graph it I'm going to
change these now our default is always
10 in every direction just seems like a
good starting point but really we just
are going to be going to be concerned
about positive values here so I made X
Min negative one just that little bit
negative just so that you can see the
axis
um same with Y Min negative one just a
little bit so you can see the axis but
any negative values won't apply here
now because
these were float values up here
so how do I get these well
the x value
I'll tell you this all these parabolas
are symmetrical so the x value of the
vertex is exactly right down the middle
sometimes we call it the line of
symmetry
so it's symmetrical so whatever that x
value is and we know we're dealing with
all positive values here so whatever
that x value is of the vertex I'm going
to double it
so that's why I have 2 times VX
so there you go get that x value double
it I should be at the end but I just
added 20 just to be sure we see the end
of it to you know and maybe a little bit
more
it just gives a good perspective on the
graph so that's it
take that x value double it I decide to
add 20 but then we have to cast it as an
integer because the other ones came in
as float values and your Dimensions here
have to be integers
so there we go and then sit with the Y
value I'll take that v y and yep that's
the vertex that's going to be the
highest point of our projectile and I'm
just going to add 10 to it I figure
that's plenty just enough so that you
can see see this and it's not right at
the edge also casting it as an integer
because these need to be integers
so
this should look familiar we don't need
to change this I only I actually changed
this to four just to give you know four
times this just just in case to make
sure our graph isn't choppy two might
even have been enough but there you go
four should be a nice smooth curve to
the graph and there we go we Define the
X values
same function we've been using before
and then that that that will work again
we need these to be integers for this
um
okay and to find the Y value is our
quadratic ax squared plus BX plus c
so now we're going to plot that
same stuff we've been doing plot and
then we're also going to plot
you know a red dot for the vertex and
display it so all this is going to be
very similar but you'll see the
prompting is a little bit different and
then the graph the scale will be a
little bit different
so when we run it initial velocity let's
call it 40
and initial height
2. so this could be
something like a baseball that you throw
up in the air you know you could
probably throw it at 40 meters per
second straight up and then by the time
you release it yeah it's about two
meters off the ground
and
so we see these and you could always
round these I didn't for this but you
always could round these numbers
um
but we get the value of the vertex now
what this means in time is that just
over four seconds after you throw the
ball up in the air it will hit its
maximum height of a little more than 83
meters
83.6 meters
so there we go
um if you could throw a ball
you know that hard and you see the
reason I have the negatives you see the
blue for the for the axis so you know if
you could throw a ball at 40 meters per
second then
uh straight up and you know there you go
wow it didn't reach you know 83 meters
in the air
and then time wise
yep four set four seconds or so in is
good where it's going to hit its highest
point and then a little more than eight
seconds it'll hit the ground
so there we go we can see what our
Parabola would be and you can use this
to you know estimate different things
relating to parabolas
whether it be a ball thrown or rocket
launched
yep there we go
so see I I just broke this out as you
know see if everything else stays the
same C just shifts the graph
and here we're going to import all these
um to display this and rather than put a
slider
just decided to make this and I made it
a negative
so
we take a look uh
our X values
and then we plot we decided to make
create this C value
um C equals
and
if we take a look so what do we want in
in this range
I'm going to actually didn't use C
itself as a variable before this so I
can use that for C in this range
then I made it negative x squared plus c
and then what are we going to do we're
going to plot it
um
you know to find the X values once up
here
and here's the Y value plot it
C value and this just I did that just
for the sake of setting the title
you know there we go
so you'll see that you'll see how that
comes up in the title and we're going to
display
and
this little this little display here
um
you you'll see how that that just makes
it play out
um the
notice I don't have
the defining x-min Max y Min y Max this
uh PLT Dot uh GCF
will actually just make the graph fit
and each time so here's a python Sleep
Method
um the argument is actually just in
seconds sometimes sleep methods are in
milliseconds this one's just in seconds
so I wanted to display that and then
wait a half a second
then
clear the output and then
and then wait
so you'll see It'll display this and
then
clear the output
so you see
so all those different C values
we can see it grow and we can run this
again if you want to see this
so
all those different C values
and notice the
the
y-axis changed each time because it
accommodated the larger graph so we can
see that value all I have to do is
um
you know increment C and it's the same
shape it just moves up
there we go
Okay so
we found the vertex but the quadratic
formula since we're dealing with
quadratic equations what does this do
this gives you the roots
now if it was a projectile that would be
when it hits the ground
so you know that's a good way to think
about it you know ground level is the
x-axis and then you know the roots where
does it hit and then you know like roots
of anything growing you know wants to go
below
but we can call them the roots they are
the x-intercepts because it's where the
line intercepts the x-axis or we can
call it the zeros because y equals zero
so you'll see it come up as all these
different things
so now if I know a b and c
here's the formula if I were to write it
not encode
so that if I know you know what x value
makes y zero that's the question
so that x value would be negative B plus
or minus the square root of B squared
minus 4AC and all of that over 2A
and notice we have the plus or minus
because somewhere along the way deriving
this you do a square root and then the
square root you have two possible
answers
so that and that's what it gives you the
two possible answers here
but also notice
this is the common way you write it but
this it's the vertex plus or minus
something
so we often write it like this you know
all over one denominator but if you
split it up
this
is the vertex you recognize that formula
Plus
this and then the vertex minus this
so you see that's another just another
way to write it whether you split it
into two fractions or
put everything together over one
denominator but when you write it this
way
then you can see that it's the vertex
plus or minus something
and again we were saying that x value of
the vertex
is right in the middle so it would make
sense that that value right in the
middle and then plus something
and then that value minus something you
know that's where we get our two Roots
you know they're symmetrical
all right so given a b and c we have
this formula to be able to find the
roots
now
I have again here I'm just going to
import math because I need that for the
square root
and
I have it printed out like this where
I just have the comment to remind you
that that just prints to his exponent I
think that's just a little bit nicer and
so
I looked that up and found how to print
that out nicer so
you're going to print this and it's
going to be showing you all right ax
squared plus BX plus C equals zero and
given that then you're going to prompt
for a b and c
so there we go now here
this is where
you're going to check so
I just put these here we'll Define these
variables here they're zero but we're
going to overwrite them not here but a
little bit later
because
I want to Define these variables that
they exist outside of this if statement
but I want to run it through this if
statement here
now notice what this is B squared minus
4 times a times C
because remember that's what's
underneath the square root here
and if that was negative
then your answer is imaginary because
you can't square root a negative number
now
um certainly you know some
mathematicians you know years ago
decided Well why should we let that stop
us if they're not real but for our
purposes here we don't want a negative
under the square we're not going to go
into imaginary numbers
so we're going to test if this
is less than zero then we're going to
print no real roots
and this there's a word actually for
this stuff that's underneath the radical
here and that's the discriminant
because
if B squared minus 4AC if that was less
than zero then there's no real Roots if
that actually equals zero then this plus
or minus doesn't mean anything because
plus 0 minus zero it's the same thing so
if that equals zero then there would be
one root
and then any other number then it would
be two roots
and I think that still comes out the
most common it's going to have two Roots
but these other options come out often
enough
um no real Roots what that looks like in
the graph is a parabola that does not
touch or cross the x-axis
so you could have that you know
just Parabola and it opens up and
Crosses early you know at some higher y
value
so that's the discriminant and knowing
that tells us you know if it's negative
if it's less than zero then there's no
real roots
if it if we only have one root of equals
zero and there's only one root we're
just going to print that out twice and
not worry about it
so
how are we going to translate this
um this quadratic formula
into this well we're going to do x one
and two we're going to do the very
similar thing just one's going to be
Plus in the middle one's going to be
minus
so let's try this
so we have negative B
let's do the plus side first plus math
Dot sqrt
of B squared
minus 4
times a times C
all right now all of that remember was
in the numerator
so
I'm going to put parentheses around all
this as the numerator
and then
divided by
our vertex
2 divided by 2A
so
order of operations all this stuff
python will know
but then since I have numerator and
denominator I'll put everything in the
numerator in parentheses and then
everything in the denominator in
parentheses
and then the second root
I can really
just copy this
and paste it here but the difference is
it's going to be minus
there we go
so now a lot of things you can do you
know in solving a quadratic very often
we'd already do the vertex and that and
finding the roots these are really
common things that you need to do with a
quadratic formula
so
having this there we go showing that
display so let's just try numbers that
work out pretty nicely one
and we have to do five and six let's try
that
look at that the roots are negative two
and three
good
now
I picked those that works out as nice
integers but this will still work
if you have you know like one uh five
and let's say
five
you see
it does have Roots definite real Roots
but since it doesn't certain ones don't
work out and there's actually like a
more complicated square root answer for
this
uh that could be a bonus bonus thing to
do to Output that square root answer
so here we go the roots are this and
this and you could always also expecting
you know that you might have some weird
irrational Roots you could round it to
you know three or four decimal places
and I'll leave it up to you if you
wanted to to you can put it put this all
together and have something where
whatever the application you can prompt
for a b and c
get the roots and the vertex and graph
it
yeah as well as displaying the roots in
the vertex
so you know just to show you you know we
can put these two things together
you know some interesting things you can
try
so sometimes the graph I like the graph
but I know it's a parabola I'm much more
interested in just a table of values
so
in this case and just for the sake of it
um
I made this linear
so here we go we have this now notice I
didn't have
uh f i g dot oracama ax
I just have x equals so I'm not going to
need the figure
um the graph I just want this because
this plt.subplot
in matplot library
that's that's going to give us a table
and
access off right because I just want a
table
so here's our table we're going to we're
going to give it a title
we're going to run this and then change
it
and notice how this works I can Define
my columns
and I could use another variable but I
just made it c-o-l-s you know for
columns so I can Define my column
headings
and then each row
notice it's a tuple of values
so
in this case in the first row x is 0 and
Y is zero
and then what I can do
is in this case since I have this for a
in range
I just decide to make it from one to ten
here's what we do rows
dot append
and then I'm going to append my X and Y
values you see so X
is my a value whatever that's going to
end up being well it's going to be 1
then 2 then 3 and then 2A you know just
something simple for the Y value
so this is this is how you can get a
table of values rather than graph it
you can put it in a loop and append each
row
so
you set the columns
set the first row
and then append each row so now outside
of that Loop
ax.set title I've already defined it up
there and then take a look at this
plt.table
and it takes the argument cell text
equals rows column label equals calls
cell location
and you know I feel like that's uh that
location's you know
okay
this goes all the way over here and we
just close the parentheses there just to
show you
so
it's still this last Direction plt.show
but what we're showing is a table
instead of a graph
and you see how it looks now you could
always do both
so you know that would be that would
always be something you could do
um
you can do both table on the graph
but who knows maybe you want one or the
other and
it as this is leading to data science
this is like an introduction to some
things you can do to generate a table of
values or things like that but um
as you get into you know in the next
Math course and then certainly when we
get into the stats course
we're going to look at like all
different ways to make tables so this is
just one way and we'll see even more
ways but there we go so y equals 2x
there we go
and
you could always make this quadratic or
whatever you'd like it to be
again just for Simplicity to illustrate
the table itself I wanted to keep it
we'll just call it y equals 3x plus 2
and where do I need to put this well
this is just
because I wanted to display the correct
thing so
that's going to be the title
and here
I this is where I'm going to take it and
a is my x value so it would be 3 times a
Plus 2.
there we go
and let me run it
you know
and
zero zero
five
ah now 0 0
actually should because since this is
plus two
now one of the things you can do is you
could keep this
and then start the range at zero
and remember for the range at zero you
don't need to put anything if that that
would start at zero
or
you could just say oh I know what this
initial value is going to be let me just
put that here
so you know a couple different options
there
so there we go
we have our table
okay so different ways to display and I
just wanted to you know
have a nice an interesting uh mini
project here so we have quadratics and
we were talking about projectiles
so we could have
um
it we could you could make a projectile
game
so what this would be is remember
um knowing where you're you're starting
from
you could uh
randomize the height and location of a
wall
and you have a toy rocket that must
clear the wall
so you can you know the game would be
determine what initial velocity would
get the rocket over the wall
and you could take it even further to
both the bonus animation path or you
could
um
you know there's some other things you
can do so I left this here for you to
write but I'm going to show you here's
one thing you know one one way to do
this
so we imported
all the stuff and actually a lot of the
things I took from
uh one of the earlier steps where you're
graphing uh projectile so I took a lot
of things from there and I'm also going
to import random and import math
so
here I just now I I made this a
modification so this is the what it will
print out it just has to land so many
meters away
so
you could
um randomize also like H for the height
of the wall I just made it the location
of like a Finish Line
so here's this random integer
between one and a hundred
and then it's going to print that a toy
rocket has to land this many meters away
and then we'll go through so here we go
um
so input initial velocity
and
instead of it it's zero zero it could I
just put maybe C1 it you know just
because but it really could be zero
and then same things we want to
represent the vertex here
um
and the x-min
what I would do is x max now I just made
this 200 because I know that the wall is
going to be you know anywhere between
there and 100
and you know I just left it as that
so and the Y maximum I left it so that
you could see where the projectile goes
but we could always go back to what we
were doing before and
copy
the Y minimum and Y maximum
the same thing
where we get this that
where we get
X Min x max we could always copy these
because
that's what we want to do here
we want to
put these in
and that was that was the idea I want
you to you know make use of code you
already have that's these these later
steps that's really what what it is I
want you to make use of code you already
have and then maybe modify it a little
bit
um
there we go we could have now this would
be fine because wherever that wall ends
up being or the the Finish Line This is
still gonna it this will still print
everything and that'll be fine
um there you go path to the projectile
and then here we have the lot the line
for the distance and I'll just make it a
red line and so notice I just have I
just have to go all the way up to the
top here location
my two x values and then from 0 up to Y
maximum
so that's just going to be a line if you
wanted to also
make it a wall
so you could make you know H equals and
we'll do the same random integer
where do I want this to be I want this
to be I don't want
um
a hundreds probably plenty we could even
make it a thousand
um you'd be surprised you know these
Rockets
um
has to uh
clear a wall
so many meters away
and
there we go so if H would be the height
and then down here
the
height of the wall would just be h
so that's the slight thing
um
in looking at this a lot of times the
wall the scale of this the wall end up
being so tiny
but it's fine we'll uh
we'll keep that there so there we go so
the line and
plot the parabola now
notice I have
the roots and I picked just one of them
and as it turns out because of the way
you know a is negative the the negative
B minus is the root that we want
that's the one that's gonna for the for
our purposes here that's the one that's
going to be greater than the parabola so
notice you you could you know copy the
quadratic formula again and the way it
displayed I want it around this one
so round to two decimal places
so here we have if root 2
is greater than or equal to location I
wanted to print out the distance
and then tell you a success
and if not
missed it by that much
there we go
all right
so
this is it there is actually no test for
this but
you can see so here we go a rocket has
to clear a wall 85 meters away initial
velocity and you could say oh okay well
maybe I'll make my initial velocity
um 300.
and then
we see that
initial velocity is 385 meters away and
you see then
we're still we didn't clear it
so missed it by that much
and you can run it again now
other things you can do with this so 19
meters away
um
I'm still gonna just really increase the
velocity of 250 let's make sure we clear
it
you see and we see the wall here and oh
boy yes we did clear it
now some of the other things you can do
is
you could take this even further and
knowing that distance
take that as your x value of your vertex
and you could write a formula that would
always make a parabola that perfectly
that perfectly clears this
this wall
that'd be pretty interesting or
you could modify this game to say that
it has to actually get to a certain
distance
not necessarily that distance or more
but maybe you say all right you have to
hit a Target that's exactly 50 meters
away
and you don't want to miss
so that would be an interesting thing
because then you could you could
actually write the code and I'll leave
that to you as you know
as for something you could write the
code to
um calculate the projectile that will
land exactly at that spot
so there we go
um now for this
you know
um upward motion
one of the ways you could take half of
that you know whatever the distance half
of that and then that's your x value
um
of the of the vertex
and you can use that to calculate
you know but you can you could use that
to calculate some formulas
and as I said we'll get even better
formulas as we get into pre-calc because
we will do things to adjust the angle
and such to get it to be exactly a
distance but there you go so showing you
how to make a projectile game I think
it's pretty interesting
um
you know that you could and you could
even make it you know like Loop through
this and you know you have to how many
ones you get correct
but there you go the projectile game
now
continuing on this the this is going to
be more like the open-ended part all the
things that we've been doing you should
put this together in
a function that will graph or
um
that will graph or display a table solve
a system of equations now if you've been
working through everything else in this
course you might have some of this
already put together
and
that's where this uh this certification
project here is you know
hopefully you've built up to this so
you're you know you get to this point
you're like okay I know how to do this
and I have some of this stuff in place
so they kind of just put it together to
organize it use some of the code that
you've already made you know you want to
have all these different
um
functions because then you get to the
certification project too
and you're going to
uh display you know this is what you
want to do build the calculator that
does this display the graph add a table
for any y equals input
cool and you can make that prompt for
input or something just very clear in
the code that
you know here's where the equation is
solve a system of equations without
graphing
graph two equations and plot the point
of intersection
so there we go
um that's going to be pretty big you
know graphing the two
um solving and graphing
and given a b and c plot the roots in
the vertex
so that'd be some things you know we've
been doing some things with linear
equations do some things with quadratics
enter a b and c see the graph plot as
well as the roots in the vertex maybe
also print them out
you know solving and graphing systems of
equations
shown the table and then you have you
know these projectile games you have the
projectile game you have the scatter
plot game
um you can even modify that scatter plot
game and make it you know
something else that might be interesting
so there you go so you have the things
you've been working on you put it all
together to build this graphing
calculator and that's going to be the
certification project
and by now you're even deeper you know
what you're doing in algebra and
we're about to then
have some more twists and see some more
complicated equations some more we can
do with this all right
so what do we mean by parent graphs and
might have heard this in code the parent
or child that the child grafts have
everything that the paragraphs have plus
some other additions and so these
paragraphs are the basic patterns
that other graphs then add to or change
so let's take a look at this the one the
most basic would be y equals some
constant which I'll just call C here
and so that would be this blue line here
just a flat line no slope you know like
y equals three or y equals four or
something like that it could even be
negative but that's it nothing else and
whatever the constant is that graph is
going to have that same look
you know flat no slope
um you know nothing else going on just y
equals some number and that's why it's a
parent graph because that's like the
basic pattern now we were talking about
things like y equals MX plus b well the
paragraph for that is y equals x just Y
equals X so notice slope is one B is
zero
and just that basic it's not y equals a
constant because there is a slope to it
but
write the paragraph is just Y equals X
and then we can get like y equals you
know 2x plus 1 or anything like that we
can have other things so this wouldn't
add anything this could add two things
you know I have the slope or I could
have a different intercept
you know so there we go so that's the
paragraph
um another one I wanted to show here
because I I think the drawing of this
works better than somehow sometimes how
it plays out with python but this is the
floor function
and so it's this step function some
people call it step function floor
function greatest integer but the floor
is when you're not rounding you're just
dropping the decimals even if it's 0.9
doesn't matter we're just dropping all
the decimals so it's the same value so
here all these decimals it's zero until
I get to one now it's one and then 1.1
1.2 it's all the same until I get to 2.
so that's it there there are no
in-between points here it's just that
integer and then at the next integer it
jumps up so again that's a parent
function and the floor function the
ceiling function where no matter what it
is I go up to the next number or the
round function they're all very similar
looking graphs just shifted a little bit
so that's why that's a again a parent
graph
um we talked about x squared as a
parabola and I didn't worry about
drawing the even the axes for these
because I want to get the idea of this
General shape and then x to the third
it's kind of like half this Parabola
bends down
now the reason why I just have these is
because as you get into like x to the
fourth x to the fifth all the even
exponents if it's just the parent graph
look more like this all the odd ones
look more like this but then if I have
other things going on in that graph so
um remember x squared could have ax
squared plus BX plus C now if I had
other things going on it's still a
parabola but it's a little bit different
shape Parabola maybe it's like a little
bit narrower or a little bit wider or
it's moved somewhere else but it will
still be a parabola
the X to the third if I end up with X to
the third plus other things in there
then
that those curves get a little bit
deeper
you know that's you know again
paragraph and then
beyond that we get some other things and
we'll take a look at some of this in the
code too and the same with if I had x to
the fourth
so x to the fourth is going to look more
like this maybe a little flattened in
the middle but if I had x to the fourth
plus a bunch of other things in there
you know plus 3x squared something else
times x you know all these other things
that could have
three turnarounds at the most you know x
to the fourth could turn around one two
three times
and you know might not be always
perfectly symmetrical but if
all the uh if all the exponents are even
then it actually would be symmetrical
kind of cool how it works out that way
so these other graphs we have the
paragraph but then we could have other
things going on and
I didn't want to draw a lot of this here
because I want to talk mostly about it
when we get to the code because that way
we can see the graph and the way python
displays the graph is going to be much
better than my drawing we get the sense
of the paragraphs these are the basic
patterns
um the simplest pattern of that type of
graph and then we can look at what what
else we can change or add to to each
function and then how that affects the
graph
so let's take a look at the code so here
we're going to look at all the parent
graphs and the code to create them and
they're all going to start out with the
same setup we've had so far for setting
up any plot matplot Library numpy set up
our Dimensions our points set up the
graph so this simplest one is a just a
constant y equals five
or if y equaled any constant number
notice X is not even in there just y
always equals 5.
so when I plot this in the same way that
I'm plotting the
x-axis I'm just going to have
this plot minimum from the minimum to
the maximum and then Y is always going
to be 5. in this case I'm going to make
it a red line
and that's what it looks like
it's a flat line there's no slope
because
I don't have that whole part of the
equation
no x value
and Y is always 5.
and it would be the same if y equals you
know 7.5 or if y equals two or you know
anything flat line no slope so that's a
constant graph
and then the linear graphs we were
talking about linear graphs but this is
the simplest linear graph y equals x
so
anything else I do with that you know at
have a slope in this case
um it's y equals 1X so the slope is one
plus zero so the Y intercept is zero
again the simplest and then anything
else I do that is an offshoot of this
parent graph
so there's our simplest and notice
everything else I do to set this up and
how do I plot it my x value and then the
Y value is X so there we go x x
and there's my Y equals X graph
slope is one
and it just goes on the diagonal like
this
there we go so every Point here you know
three three four four five five Etc
so the quadratics we were looking at
quadratics this is this basic quadratic
graph y equals x squared
so before I do anything else to it
that's just enough to make it a parabola
and here we're plotting this
my X values and then the Y value is x
squared
and there we go
our parabola
so in this case you know
x squared so a is one B is zero C is
zero that's all we have
and then any other thing we do to the x
squared you know add other things x
squared plus you know
uh 3x plus 4 or something like that or
some you know whatever whatever else we
would have is uh an offshoot of this
paragraph so there we go and I can make
it negative and change that
and we see the negative
a
flips it upside down so we have you know
negative like a frown positive like a
smile so
I'll go back to the smile
there we go
again it's the basic paragraph x squared
and then a cubic graph
y equals x to the third so the quadratic
is x squared because it's like the area
of a square if I know the sides the
cubic
x to the third because it's like the
volume of a cube if I know the sides
so setting up the graph here
and the comment we'll talk about later
just start out with the basic x to the
Third
and we see the graph looks like this
so you know some of these you know I
could sketch it out enough to show you
um but we see it kind of looks like a
parabola with the left side flip down
but not exactly and this is the simplest
cubic graph
so what I wanted to show you is also
supposing
we have
supposing I just have other things so
plot the X values and supposing I had
like x to the third minus 2x squared
minus 3x plus 4. you see I can have all
these other things going on in the graph
and this is how it affects the qubit
graph
you see it gets these deeper turns that
were just kind of flattened out before
but x to the third is going to turn
around at the most twice
so there we go we see these
possibilities here
all right so again you know now this is
not a parent graph this is you know a
more complex graph the parent graph
still is X to the Third
so we go x to the fourth and yes they
have an aim to quartic
um so x to the fourth
and all of our even exponents so we see
I'm just plotting x to the fourth
all the even exponents look a lot like
this
so x to the fourth if I also had like x
to the sixth
notice how
it's similar
and I probably need more points to make
this look smoother but you get the idea
now this this is where it gets beyond
what I can graph what I can draw so I
like showing showing it with the code
but all these even exponent graphs uh
we might be able to do x to the eighth
and it look horrible that looks kind of
horrible
so x to the fourth is probably the last
good one
other than that then we have to change
um
you know how many points we're doing
to really make it a lot smoother but
that's where it kind of looks like a
parabola just flattens out more around
zero and all of the even exponent parent
graphs will look like this
and I also could have x to the fourth
plus other things and then the graph
would look totally different that could
go up and down as many as three times
I could have as many as three
turnarounds
and quintic he thought we were going to
run out of number names but nope x to
the fifth we have a name for that
quintic
all right so x to the fifth
and when we look at this there we go x
to the fifth
looks a lot like x to the Third
so
all the odd exponent graphs are going to
look a lot like this
but again just a little bit more
flattened out
and if it's just this if I have x to the
fifth plus other things then the graph
could be all all over and it could turn
around as many as four times
but there we go so all the even graphs
are like x to the second or fourth it's
symmetrical about the
y-axis
and kind of looks like a flattened
Parabola all the odd graphs look like
this x to the third the fifth all the
odd numbers look like this you know and
it would go back and forth and then with
you know as they get more complex with
other things going on you know you're
getting beyond the parent graphs then we
have all they can actually have the ups
and downs
so the absolute value graphs and there's
a lot of patterns with absolute value
graphs that are also the same as they
would be for x squared graphs
um the way the vertex can move around so
the simplest absolute value graph is
just this absolute value of x well like
the other graphs I could be multiplying
by something here
inside the absolute value or outside I
can add or subtract something
so this is how I would write absolute
value with the two vertical lines here
next to it not parentheses
and here's how I would put this in code
abs
and notice I don't actually need to
import anything that's part of the core
python Library so that's the absolute
value of x
so as I plot it
then it looks like this because absolute
value means
it's just the number like positive or
negative doesn't matter it's just the
number so
it would be like plotting Y equals X
and that would be in the positive
direction but y equals negative X
so for all these Negative X values
the Y value is positive because it's
absolute value so that's why instead of
continuing down like the Y equals X
graph it comes to a point and makes a v
so there we go so
um just like x squared whatever X is
it's going to end up being positive when
you square it
absolute value
just makes it all it just doesn't do
anything except make it positive
and so that's why there's there's
similar patterns to some of these but
there you go perfectly straight lines
come to a point that's the absolute
value graph
and then I can have square root graphs
there we go so here's how I write the
square root if I was writing it out
and if I'm plotting it
I'm going to use this now
there's math dot square root and there
you know and other ways to get a square
root but
I'm going to use numpy that's square
root because
we're already using the numpy library
for everything else so since I'm already
using numpy for everything else that I'm
graphing I definitely want to use NP dot
dot square root
so the the comment we'll talk about in a
second but here's the basic square root
graph
and
we can start talking a little bit about
inverse functions because this is the
inverse of x squared
and that's why I also included this that
if I uncomment that and now run it you
see
now just the square root it's just going
to be positive
because if I include the negative part
then that's not a function these X
values have two possible y values but
when I put them together I see that it
looks like a parabola on its side and
that's really what it is that's the
inverse of x squared because I want to
do the opposite I square root things
so
you know that just helps us see it but
the full
graph the true square root graph is this
because then it's still a function all
these X values have one y value
and then
there is just no y value Beyond here
Beyond this
all right so there we go so there's the
square root graph and another way to do
this
is with a rational exponent now overall
for this graphing python does not like
rational exponents
so I'm going to do this here and I'm
going to show you that this actually did
work
next to the one half exponent but
if you try this for any pretty much any
other fraction instead of one half it's
just not going to work it's just going
to give you an error of python doesn't
like it
but there you go that's the same vat
same graph
so
x to the one-half
in solving it if you weren't graphing it
you know it works out nicely
the denominator is your root so square
root denominator is two
or if I had a cube root the denominator
is 3. so I'm going to write it like this
here
x to the one third so that's the cube
root
of x
so it's what number times itself three
times gets me X so like the cube root of
8 would be 2 because 2 times 2 times 2.
is 8.
so we're getting a cube root
and I don't need to worry about the
rational exponent here because numpy
just like there's a square root there's
a cube root also cbrt
so that gets the cube root
and this one
I can have negative values
because if the factor shows up three
times I can have negative negative
negative
so that works so there we go I can get
the cube root of x
there we go so somewhere around here I
have when X is 8 Y is one
yeah there we go and then
we get the cube root
so the all these paragraphs just like
the other ones I could have other things
going on in this equation the cube root
of x plus something that would shift it
up you know I can move it around but
you know these are the basic paragraphs
these types of shapes and then other
graphs are just you know versions of
these
all right so the floor function
now there's the floor notice it kind of
looks like absolute value but the it
does have feet at the bottom that go
underneath kind of like an l and a
backwards L to show you the floor
the uh other function that's similar to
the ceiling function and the floor
function is the one where you drop all
the decimals
um so it doesn't matter if it's like 5.9
and it doesn't round you just drop it
and the answer is five
um
the floor function just drops the
decimals and just takes the whole number
other times people call it the greatest
integer function or the integer part
function same idea there's also the
ceiling function which no matter what
the decimal goes up to the next one and
we have round they all work very similar
so we have all these
and
to plot the floor function now I want to
show you this this
is actually
the function np.floor but there's a
reason why
I didn't do that first
because
I put all this in
in a loop to graph this as a bunch of
points
because I feel like this illustrates the
floor function a lot better it does give
these steps and sometimes on the graph
people call it a step function
so it's the same value until you get to
the next integer then it jumps up and
it's that same value until you get to
the next integer
so all these are just sudden jumps once
it gets to the next integer and it's the
same value it doesn't change
because if it was 3.1
the floor is three if it was 3.5 the
floor is 3.6 you know all those values
if the floor is three and then when it
gets to four boom then it jumps up
so
the re the reason why I went through all
of that
is that the
actual floor function
I feel like doesn't display well but
I'll show you
you see it gives these values
but these vertical lines really
shouldn't exist
because it's not continuous like that
and so it's just you know numpy just
wants to connect it but that's what the
floor function looks like in numpy but
truly mathematically that's not what it
looks like so that's why I wanted to do
the loop and show you so there we go so
that's the floor function
um exponential functions so now we go
from things like x squared to
X is the on is the exponent so what
happens when the base doesn't change but
then the exponent changes so that's two
to the first to the second two to the
Third
well we can right away see that that
value is going to get really big really
quickly
and
so here
to the exponent of x
so we have we see it gets really big
really quickly
and then
when we think about our exponent rules
when X is zero anything to the zero is
one
so all these exponential functions cross
the y-axis at 0 1.
and then for negative exponents that
flips it to the denominator so 2 to the
negative First is one half to the
negative second is negative is
one-fourth
and so the negative exponents for
Negative X values just really get
smaller and smaller
so
it has that curve but it's not at all
Parabola on the left here that just gets
smaller and smaller but actually it will
never touch zero
if you get on something where you can
keep zooming in
you'll see that it just gets smaller and
smaller but never touches zero
and then over on the right it just has
that upward curve and as steep as it
looks it actually is never perfectly
vertical it's just really steep
and so that's the look of all the
exponential functions
we use this a lot of times in percent
increase
compound interest things like that
but there we go that's a lot of the
exponential functions here
all right so there we go so these are
all the key parent graphs
all the other graphs you're going to
look at
um in algebra are going to be some
version of these graphs oh it's like
this graph but then with some
some other things that we that we added
uh later on when we get into or another
course in trigonometry the trig graphs
are different and one of the big
differences is they keep repeating these
are all you know they do one thing and
then that's it
but we'll get to those graphs but for
anything in algebra these are all the
paragraphs so when you look at a graph
and you want to figure out what could
the equation be that generated that
graph you you say well which paragraph
does it look like oh it looks like this
so it could be you know an exponential
oh it has that other sort of curve it
could be a different one so you know
that's why you want to get a sense of
the parent graphs it helps you
um develop equations to fit different
curves later on and we'll get into some
of that stuff
okay
so there we go and you will have this as
a resource too to consult as
you know take a look at the different
paragraphs
now that we've worked through the core
skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra
problems using the colab notebook so you
can see how you can apply these
resources that you're building and use
the use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in
day-to-day life so we're going to go
through some more extra problems here so
now that we see these parent graphs
let's let's do a little twist here let's
look at this these sliders we can add to
modify the parent graphs because that's
it that they're meant to be modified so
that first one
y equals a or any you know value just
it's that horizontal line
if we add a slider now notice the setup
for the slider that you know we're going
to import this inline and it's a widget
for the slider and then all of our
graphing is going to be in this function
that we redefined here
find
and I called it the function f because I
wanted a shorter function name f of and
then it's going to take a
for the slider and in this case we're
going to also also going to zoom so
all these values are based on the zoom
slider so you can zoom in and out
and we still have these points but just
all the graphing happens here within the
function
set the plot and notice all this same
thing but the zoom then would affect all
this
and
so mathematically you know if I wasn't
writing code I would just write you know
y equals a
but we're going to put it here I'm going
to have two y values because just this
perfectly horizontal line we kind of
have to do it this way and we're going
to plot this
horizontal line just like we did with
each axis
you know the X values X Min X Max and
then the Y values y1 and Y2 which are
both the same which is whatever this a
value is
so here's the slider you know run this
function f a goes from negative 9 to 9
and then the zoom
so when we run this
so there we go and as I increase the
slider
so we see our general graph
and I can zoom in a little bit
but that's we get like
y equals some constant and then I see
the slider that paragraph it's still the
same look
that horizontal line it's just that
from the parent graph to the child graph
it just it just changes where it is
you see
but then you know the slider and then
the zoo
that becomes even more interesting when
I have our classic slope intercept form
so now I have y equals MX plus b what
happens when I use sliders and
I'm going to change m b and I'm you know
I like to zoom in there so I'll just
keep that in there
so we have everything for the zoom now
here and these next few we can do the
normal you know numpy Lin space
and that's the array that I want to
graph for my X values so here
I have y equals MX plus b so look at
that m and b are still variables here
because that slider is going to affect
it and then that function is going to
take that input
so now I can have a slider
change the M value change the B and I
still have the zoom
and then this is what I have
so it's right here because the slope is
zero but what happens as soon as I make
the slope one
now I start to see my graph and I can
see the slope
and then as B increases
we can see it the y-intercept moves up
and down
there we go
and some of these
you know now we
have some more that we can see when we
zoom in
there we go and this particular one I
didn't put the Grid on there but just to
show you that
as that paragraph Y equals X
you know that's really just that's the
paragraph Y equals X because it does
have a slope but then I can change the
slider and say the negative values and
from that paragraph changing these two
values makes it its own graph but it
still is that linear equation because
that's the parent graph still has those
core features
but then we modify it a little bit I can
change the slope I can change where it
crosses the x-axis
and Sliders are a good way to illustrate
this
so we have
now three
variables for our quadratic ax squared
plus BX plus c
and so my function I'll take a b and c
and zoom in
so
then my y value is
which is this standard quadratic and
remember x squared is the parent graph
you know a is one and then just x
squared that would be the parent graph
the simplest quadratic it's a parabola
but then when I have these three it
still has that core feature of the
paragraph it's still a parabola
but then I change and we can see what a
b and c do to these so we have this
interactive I'm going to adjust a b and
c and as well as the zoom
and
so we see it defaults to right in the
middle so let's just put a
now that's one but we can use these
sliders to see what does what happens to
the graph
when
a increases you see it gets narrower
and then what happens zero it's not a
parabola anymore
but then as it's negative it flips it
down
there we go
so we can see how these affect
you know we'll bring it back up to
positive like a smile then we can take a
look at well I'll jump to C next because
that's the easiest it just
same shape it just moves it up
or if C became negative
same shape and it moves it down
and see each time I move this the it
runs the function again and then
recalibrates it with these new values
and then B I think is one of the most
interesting
because I move it
as B increases it dips down to the left
kind of interesting
and then I can bring it back
and then as B decreases
it dips down to the right
so
just some interesting things that you
know so this would be a b and c so this
would be x squared minus 5x minus five
that'd be the equation here
or then
x squared minus 5x minus 6.
and we can zoom in
and see you know
I I get I didn't put the
values on here so so exactly but you
know you could always do that too
so we see these sliders now the reason
why I like this and I want you to notice
with absolute value how similar those
patterns are to the x squared to the
absolute value because remember whatever
X is if you square it it's positive
absolute value also then just makes it
positive
but the core absolute value
function
so you see absolute value but
I'm taking in three different values
here for my absolute value parent graph
I still have three sliders why because I
have a times the absolute value
and then inside the absolute value I
could have x minus B that's where the B
shows off and that shifts it left or
right
and then plus C shifts it up or down so
we see that plus C shifting it up or
down
and
let's take a look at these
so again a is zero I've got nothing as
soon as I change it
now I have my absolute value and of
course the big difference is this is
linear each line is linear but then it
comes to a point
because again positive X values were
negative the absolute value makes it
positive
so
we see some of those similar patterns
though as a increases
because it's a times the absolute value
this gets narrower just like it did with
the parabola
and C
keeps the same shape but just moves it
directly up
or
moves it down
and
we have B this is this just moves it
exactly side to side so that's you know
this is where unlike the parabola
there's no other deeper curve to it it
just moves it exactly side to side
so
there we go
and even if C
you know C was more it's still it still
moves it side to side
so
B is negative eight so the if we see the
zoom here
so
um if B was negative eight
then we see that
that is the x value
um
so it's at negative eight
and then
because it's
B it's x minus B
is the is the
formula so if B is negative eight then
that means that's X plus b negative
negative makes it a positive that's X
plus b in the inside the absolute value
so negative eight and then C is three
then we go up three so we can see again
you know where is that point
and we see the basic absolute value and
then what each of these things do and
how it's very similar to the quadratic
but that has its own its own things and
we can do this you know
um those are the most useful I feel like
for a lot of algebra you know more
commonly useful but square root
functions can have a slider too
and this one
um it gives a runtime warning which I
just left in there and it still ran
because
the you can't take the square root of a
negative number
so
you know I still have all these
different Zoom values that I could you
know at some point I get a negative
number and it just does not compute it
won't show up but it actually that
doesn't break this it will give me the
error but then that's it
so here if I take a look at
B and I make B zero here
if we run this again
so
again everything zeroes out where is it
but if a is anything there we go
and we can zoom in a little bit
see this curve a little bit better
there we go so if a is anything and then
we see B
it moves it
but remember it's because
like the other one's x minus B is the
formula
so when B increases it's really x minus
3 moves it three to the right
and then C also
you know moves it up and again we're
looking at that point where this starts
where that
square root function starts whereas if B
was 0 and C was Zero you see that's
where we start at the origin zero zero
so we see either your basic square root
graph and again you have these different
values you can have
a times the square root and then square
root of what x minus B
and then I still have plus C outside
that can shift it up or down so we see
from the basic parent graphs all these
key things and restart hopefully you're
starting to see the patterns of how this
comes up and you can have these sliders
with all different so if we have x to
the Third
now uh four sliders and we can see
you know x to the Third
now for this one I just left it as this
to show this is what happens you know
a increases this
you know you can make it a little bit
narrower
but B is even zero C is negative D is
even zero across is it zero zero
but I just set up you know that's where
you get you know some deeper dips in
your x to the third functions here
so and it's usually some mix of positive
and negative coefficients that give you
these deeper dips
and you can do the same thing x to the
fourth and you can have
five sliders because
x to the fourth would also have
a times x to the fourth and then B times
x to the third c times x squared D times
x to the first and then the constant e
which actually would be times x to the
zero
so there we go and having these
yeah
we can adjust these uh they're not X
these are not always symmetrical
but I picked one that actually could
make it symmetrical and what that is is
notice where the zeros are
because x to the fourth
a is the coefficient I made that two
x to the third B is the coefficient I
made that zero
x squared
C is the coefficient negative six
and then x to the first
I mean that zero it's symmetrical
because all of the even exponents have
coefficients and the odd exponents zero
out so
these even functions happen only if I
have all even exponents
and notice I can have an e value because
e is X to the zero and we'll count that
as even
so
there we go
so some things you can see when we have
sliders you know same thing with this
four function this is just kind of cool
um
and
so what I did here is i z you know still
with the zoom but I made this floor
function I did this
um
to make these
a bunch of dots because I like how that
displays the fourth floor function
that's really like this is really the
floor function
and I made these dots you know to plot
the points instead of lines and you know
they're big enough that they connect so
you don't see spaces between but that's
really this is really the floor function
as we as we know it and we see that you
know if a increases it just gets steeper
and a could be negative and it could be
like that
but still has that step look to it
so and then C
it's almost I guess it's noticeable
there you go
but that's it so this is the floor
function we have the different steps and
you see we still can have that's the
parent function just the floor function
but then and the four the general parent
function would be
yes I would have
um a times this so I keep that as one
and then
you know nothing else going on that
would be the parent function and then we
can adjust things
so all these you know that taking it
beyond the parent functions you can have
sliders and you know all kinds of other
things for
um
you know there we go some some other
functions we can have
all right
um
oh this was the
uh exponential function
we'll we'll end it on this here that if
I have this so I still have my a
coefficient and then B to the exponent
of something c x minus d
now
nothing going on because a is zero but
if a is at least one
but still nothing going on because
I have uh B has to be a value and it has
to be one won't do it
it has to be greater than one
and then C
it's c times x
this won't do it because that would make
the exponent zero out so again it would
be a constant that has to be at least
something
is there we go we can zoom in a little
bit
there we go and you know D that could
shift it
and E could shift it up just like we
were doing before
but you see these
there's a few of these that needed to be
non-zero to make this show something
so we see you know again General
paragraph of our exponential function
and all the things we can do to shift it
so applying some of the formulas we've
been talking about in algebra we can use
these for business applications like
demand and revenue so demand would be
how many would I be able to sell so
imagine if we're selling laptop
computers and I find out that you know
um an average price of like six hundred
dollars
will
give me you know I might sell like 84
million
computers
so we do some research we find that you
know this might be the case and then
maybe I find some some particular
companies might say oh well you know
what
our average price is going to be triple
it's going to be somewhere right in the
neighbor of 1800
but then maybe they'll only sell like 8
million
and
then we look at this and we say okay
well what should my price point be
and
we can find this we can use these two as
you know an x value for
you know uh price and Y value for how
many sold and we can do the slope
formula and we can get an equation here
to estimate this as being linear and I
can take a look at what the demand might
be so I could do the slope you know 84
minus eight
over
600 minus 1800
so remember our slope formula from
earlier and so there we go so if we have
over and then the the denominator
happens to be negative negative 1200 and
I would get that into an exact decimal
that would be my slope
um
and you know some it's going to be
something like negative 0.06 so then I
could get that into a a a y equals
equation
um you know somewhere around there
negative you know
0.06 X
plus and I could have the
you know
what would be my y-intercept I could I
could go through that same formula and
in when we get into the code I'll show
you that we can just bring in these
formulas that we already know
getting a couple points getting our
slope intercept form and then I would
have that value here
um
there we go and
yeah it's probably you know
I'm gonna just rough estimate here
so let's let's just say that that would
be it and then that would be notice a
negative slope because as the price gets
higher you know we would graph this as
you know price
and you know number sold
and we would see that as the price gets
higher then the number sold would be you
know less and less and at some point
um actually the why are some somewhere
more like 50.
and at some point you know
we the price would be so high that
nobody would want it but we would get
that as the general estimate now let's
just say that's the equation here
now what so that would be the demand
equation and a lot of times economists
are looking for that you know
um
business owners too what would be my
ideal price point well then if I use
that how what can I do to figure out my
Revenue well my Revenue how many sold
um
would be the demand but then the price
as I was saying is defined as the x
value so at every point
I would get that the x value that the
revenue
is going to be the price
times the demand
and in this case that price is always
going to be X and if I figure this out
then it's x times negative .06 x plus 50
and you see that would be my y value
that I could that I could graph
quick distributive property we recognize
that this is
a quadratic with a negative
a value so that means it's going to open
down you know plus
50x
and so when we look at this
then
if I have you know the price but then
instead of the number sold
I want to have
um
Revenue
so of course
if the price is zero I have no revenue
and then of course there's some other
price that
is so high that nobody buys it so I have
no revenue and the shape of this graph
is going to be a parabola that opens
down
so then I see that there is some middle
price
that would maximize revenue and that's
kind of the thing that we want to look
for
you know using these formulas we're
using the slope formula as we're using
the formulas we've developed to generate
a slope-intercept equation then we're
using this like this would always be
true revenue is price times demand
so then we can use that to develop this
quadratic and we can graph these we can
find out what these what these Revenue
points would be
so pretty interesting then we could also
apply this to profit so this is just
revenue and then we could do this and
then subtract
um subtract the total cost we could get
profit
so this is really some of the
applications that we want to get to that
you know using these formulas and
determining based on some data
you know what should my price point be
to maximize my revenue or given you know
if I already established a price point
what would you know can I predict the
revenue you know these are things people
put in their business plans
so we see these examples that or this
one example
and I when we look at the code I have uh
two other examples so we can see how
this would come together that you you
know you can use your math skills you
can use your python skills to make some
business predictions and these are some
of the good applications of of all this
math and writing code so
let's take a look at the code
all right so I wanted to give you an
another example or two
to show how you can write code to work
with these formulas and for this example
I'm just
saying we're selling T-shirts and I've
made up these numbers hopefully they
seem kind of realistic
but you could Define the price here and
so these are all variables here so if we
Define the price
and in this case we're going to say
we're selling T-shirts for five dollars
each and then we have the demand as our
next variable
and we're saying that if you were giving
away t-shirts maybe you could give away
50 you know this is business you're not
really going to give them away but then
your demand decreases
as the price increases so every time the
price
increa increases now in this case
um again if the price if it was free
you'd give away 50 right here the price
is five and then so two times the price
is ten so then the demand would be 40.
but you see how it just Cascades we just
Define the price and then we'll use that
to talk about demand
and then Revenue
is going to be price times demand now
that is actually a goat uh standard
formula
the price you're selling it four times
how many sold so you see we can do this
we've you know once we've defined these
then we have these other formulas that
they can depend on them
and then the total cost
so this is another one that you would
have to know and I just uh made it so I
said four times the demand
so if we have
four you know the idea is that let's say
it cost four dollars to make each
t-shirt
all right and I'm sure sometimes
t-shirts cost less but I just said four
dollars so that's where the total cost
would be four dollars times
you know however many we sold
and then that's the total cost so then
we have profit
is revenue minus total cost
makes sense what's the Rev how much
money do we bring in minus the cost
and how you see how we have all these we
can just Define these formulas now this
is a standard formula for for profit
Revenue Minus cost and this is a
standard formula for Revenue price times
demand
and some of these then we could develop
these equations if we knew if we had
some other data so
um if you're making things to sell you
would definitely have this information
how much does it cost to make
but there you go all these then if you
define the price and some demand
equation we can calculate all these and
we would output
you know given this price the demand
Revenue because 5 times 40 and then the
total cost will be 160 you make a profit
of forty dollars
and then having these
this is where people can do some
research and they can test things out oh
well let's say supposing I decide to
make the price ten dollars instead
and we take a look at this
the price increases the demand decreases
as we expected but the revenue increases
and so given that cost
we still have a profit
of
that of more than double so the price of
each doubled I went from five dollars to
ten dollars but the profit more than
doubled it more than quadrupled
so just interesting things that we can
we can see here
and how does this happen well it might
be it might be helpful to see this on a
graph too
so
we're going to graph these things import
matplot library and I'm going to import
numpy
I'm just going to remind you here that
the price is X and the demand is y and
then we're going to change it that the
demand later is going to be the Revenue
now this is where
if you had data this is where you would
have you know if I have at what at a
certain price
what would the demand be
you see and
I had in mind here you know that this
was
um you know I don't know something else
you're you're buying
2.46 so
um
it would it might not be t-shirts that
might be really low but let's just say
you know
um I don't know bottle of water
and you know yes it's ten dollars but
maybe you hype it up and tell people
it's just this amazing bottle of water
and if it's cold or if it's really hot
that day and the water's cold you know
you still might have some demand so it's
something else that you might have
but there we go so we can Define these
price one and demand one so if it was
two dollars then the demand is 46 if
it's ten dollars then the demand drops
down to 30.
as an example if just having some of
this data from some other research and
we can remember these formulas we did
back with linear equations because this
is essentially two points price and
demand are X and Y so I'm going to
calculate the slope based on those two
points
calculate the y-intercept
and then this becomes a y equals MX plus
b equation
so pretty cool
again again if I have you know some
examples of some data that we have that
we can we can test
so given that equation that's going to
be my demand equation
and I'm going to go through there we go
X Min x max now notice this
X minimum and Y minimum I'm going to
make 0 because negative numbers for this
aren't going to really have any
practical meaning
I'll make the X maximum 50 and the Y
maximum 320
um
there we go the number of points that's
all fine
so after I Define everything here I'm
going to do a couple other things I'm
going to do the X label is going to be
price
and then I'm going to give my graph a
title so notice both these plt.xlabel
plt.title there we go
and then for this one line one I'm going
to have
so for line one here's my demand
equation y equals
m
the demand equals m x plus b
and so we
figured out m and b up here
and so I can use those but I'm going to
use x because that's the array of X
values that I've defined
so we have our demand equation and then
I'm going to plot
y labeled demand
so we see the X label is still going to
be priced but for this one y label is
going to be demand
and then we're going to plot X and then
the demand
I commented this out we'll get to that
in a second
so here we go so I have my graph and
then we see yes if I was giving them
away for free I could give away 50. the
demand decreases as the price increases
so at some point maybe like 25 dollars
um
you know whatever I'm selling here that
started out as two dollars
uh who knows maybe it's CDs or something
you know some people still want those
um if I have
25 you know nope too expensive nobody
wants it
and then somewhere in there we have the
ideal
um
now it's not always perfectly linear in
real life but this is a good estimate
so given these supposing I keep that
same demand equation
and as we were saying before I can build
upon that
and I can have
Revenue
equals x time demand because as long as
I keep that equation it will still use
that
and then so now I'm going to plot
my x value and then Revenue as
the Y value and I'm going to change my y
label to revenue
so we see that we have
a way to do this
and
when I graph this
we see that yes of course I'm going to
make no Revenue if the price is zero and
then we said that about 25 I'm going to
sell none so that'll make no Revenue but
this is how the revenue goes and it's
really interesting that I can have some
you know low prices and I think that
that's you know the the best
um I might sell the most
but the revenue actually there's some
middle number here
that gives me my maximum Revenue
and you see it looks like
um
now
if if I make new Revenue at zero and at
25 these parabolas are symmetrical so
it's exactly 1250 would be the maximum
Revenue
or if people like round numbers you know
12 or 13
. so there we go we can see how we can
use all of this
and
we can see that the you know the reason
why Revenue would be zero here this is
where the demand would be zero so
this is probably the more the line two
is probably the more valuable one but
having give it getting some research
of given prices demand price demand that
if I have a couple values here then
I could plot this out and I can plan oh
from other prices and demand research
that I've heard what should I make my
price
you know and this this is some of the
research that people can do
you know you have some new product how
can you determine what the price should
be
all right and
there you go also then if you're making
a business plan you could always then
download or export these images
you know you've written the code you see
the graph export the graph as an image
to include in your business plan
so there we go you know a couple
different examples of how we can make
use of these you know formulas the
graphs and you know gen generate some
graph or some image and some data that
we can really use
okay so let's apply
some of these graphs to some other
economic theories and see how you can
use
python your math to
plan predict you know look at Trends in
economics so you know we looked at Cost
Revenue profit and if we take on that
marginal cost revenue or profit if it's
marginal then that's the result when
making and selling one more product
and for some of our examples we were
doing some linear equations and for that
the marginal uh if cost is linear the
marginal cost is going to be the same
wherever you are but sometimes we have
costs or
we saw that definitely we have profits
or Revenue that are not linear and
therefore we have some times when oh
this is it makes more sense from uh cost
Revenue profit perspective to make one
more
and sometimes you know
it doesn't sometimes you know oh that
one more is only going to get me a tiny
bit of profit
not worth it
um
and costs sometimes it goes the other
way you know setting up everything
making one product might
be a really high cost but now it's all
set up so making two three four a
hundred thousand you know might make
that worth it
um
you know things like newspapers and book
printing and you know there's a big
setup for the printer and so the
marginal cost to make one
wouldn't be worth it now there's
definitely you know other methods uh
printers but for a lot of the big
printers like a newspaper marginal cost
it'd be a whole lot for one newspaper
but no they're going to print thousands
and thousands so the marginal cost after
they've printed you know a hundred
thousand newspapers printing one more is
almost nothing as far as cost
so these are the things you know what
what's it cost to make one more
and you know we might notice that for
revenue and profit the same thing
and so if we have
Revenue you know
um and this tone a lot of times comes up
but you know toward the end of the day
people say oh what you know what would
it take to make one more sale you know
maybe it's a store should I stay open
for a lot longer and everybody's tired
to make one more sale that might be you
know a lot more cost to
in a lot of ways for a little bit of
Revenue not worth it and so they say
okay these are the hours and we close
so these are some uh deeper analyzes as
we get into things Beyond linear
equations
um we can do even more than that makes
that even more interesting but just to
mention that you know as we talk about
this the marginal is that at any given
point what's the cost revenue or profit
to make one more
all right and let's look at some other
things that impact that supply and
demand and here again I'm going to give
some simple numbers and make it linear
equations the true supply and demand
graph it's not gonna you know and in
real life it's not going to be perfectly
linear
um there might even be a little curve to
it but even at that it it you know if
you get the data it might be you know a
little bit of a bumpy line
but
we have supply and demand and we know
these definitions are at Supply how much
are people making you know what's the
supply of whatever I'm looking for and
the demand how much will do people want
how much are people willing to buy
so you know if you're looking at uh
um you know a movie the movie theater
um if you wanted to see it in the
theater the suppliers there's only so
many seats you know only so many
showings you know a movie or a play or a
concert
only so many seats only so many showings
so that's this limited Supply and then
the demand could increase if it's
something really good that everybody
wants to see
so
a lot of times we see that you know that
affects the price and that's what we're
going to look at Supply demand and price
and we're going to graph supply and
demand on the same axis
so
we'll see some similarity some familiar
things here for the graph and I'm going
to have two x values as old demand and
new demand and I just gave them this
complicated variable name so that it
reminds you that it's an x value
so we have old demand and new demand
and yes I noticed I made uh the demand
um increase
um
and then I have old price and new price
so
now just looking at that well we'll see
this on the graph but the price is also
going to be the Y value
and on the same graph I'm going to have
Supply old Supply and new Supply
I made that you know two variables each
of these as I was mentioning you could
potentially get data from a table
um supply and demand data
um you could have one table that has you
know a particular price Supply demand
price
and you know make all these numpy notice
I did not import numpy for anything I'm
just
putting a few variables here and you
know to illustrate the graph but you
could absolutely get that data from a
table and you know make each of these
numpy arrays and graph them
um that would be really interesting too
and that's something that we'll address
later on in the course
so given these and then I have a basic
graph set up
adding a couple labels here I'm going to
make the X label quantity
just general quantity and the Y label
price
and I have this title which I already
graphed but we'll get to that
so here's the demand function
and I'm going to plot this as a red line
just because all right so
notice the X and Y at my old X I'm just
making this just like I do it with the
axis I'm going to plot
you know these two x values and these
two y values and make you know make that
a red line
so
so we see this you know I'm not going to
even put an equation to it I'm just
graphing this linear equation from these
points to this point
and I'm going to do the same thing for
Supply as a green line and same thing
I'm just going to use this data that I
had these numbers that I
came up with as an example
um
and this graph
we can take a look at this again it's
simplified but it really is the general
trend
of supply and demand so if I made green
Supply Red demand
then we take a look at the x-axis is
quantity
so the green that would be quantity
supplied and the red that would be
quantity demanded
and then on the y-axis we have price so
graphing them both on price we take a
look at this and we see if the price is
high
than the quantity demanded is going to
be low
and a lot of times we're used to seeing
you know
um an independent variable on the x-axis
and we think cause and effect but this
is really correlations so I'm not saying
necessarily one cause is the other
um but
you know
that goes together so uh at the when uh
X is let's say 1 and Y is 14. so we look
at this this this demand there's very
low quantity of demand when the price is
high
and then as the quantity see we see the
quantity increase as the price decreases
so
that's what happens oh you know what is
this oh it's 14 you know
fourteen dollars no I don't think I want
it but as the price gets down lower then
maybe you know the demand increases more
people would want this
now Supply wise
people making this
they have a different incentive they
want to make money so when the when the
demand is low
the
and when the price it and when the price
is low
then but then nobody nobody wants to get
nobody wants to get into this
so you see we have low demand but we
also have low um when when the when the
price is low here
then nobody wants to get into this what
you know why would I get into this new
business if I'm you know whatever I'm
selling is not going to be
you know that lucrative
but
the quantity in the green line the
quantity
supplied will increase as the price
increases
and we see that in different industries
that you know oh you know why why are
people you know getting into this
um
industry oh because they all see they
can make money oh this this is the hot
item oh I can get in on this and somehow
you know uh make money so that's what we
have the supply quantity increases as
the price increases so there we go so we
have these two opposite trends
and this is kind of like the core of
Economics because as you know I get
different data this is I just did these
numbers as an example but these graphs
could shift you know maybe there's some
something else that affects this that
maybe
um
you know instead of uh the supply
increasing like this maybe something
causes it to increase a little bit
steeper or maybe you know if we say that
you know the quantity supplied is low
here for this price but maybe
you know for whatever we're making that
the entry level was even at a higher
price and the whole thing shifts
so that's really what a lot of
economists are trying to do and then
if this is quantity
across the x-axis let's take a look at
where these lines intersect and then
that would be the point of equilibria
because what we're saying is the
quantity here
supplied and the quantity demanded would
be the same
and I mean that's ideal you know
um
you know let's say you have a bakery you
make fresh things every morning and then
at the end of the day you have it all
sold
nothing left over that's great
um here on the left you know and we'll
say let's say that you know for our
fictional numbers that happens at six
but let's say a little bit before that
so it's still to the point that the
price is too high so the demand's not
really there
the price is increasing but not
so good yet so the supply is not really
there
and we still have a gap between demand
and supply
so here on the left the red Line's
higher there's more of a demand
but not enough of a supply
and
then we have on the right side of that
we have more of a supply but not as much
demand
and that would be the one this would be
on the right that would be the one
that's dangerous for anybody supplying
whatever
uh product because you know they're
getting into this trying to make money
the price is starting to get to where
somebody's happy oh good the price is
going up I'll make more money but then
there's you know the demand drops off so
now they really have to scramble for
customers
you know that's trouble or the price
here or on the left for
the people who want this product the
demand is still higher than Supply
and that's part of what keeps the price
higher because the demand is there
not as much Supply well then the price
increases
you know things like you know stock
trading people argue about this stuff
all day anytime somebody wants to
too many people want to sell a
particular stock oh well then you know
the supply increases to me and we go to
the right too many people want to sell
this
um you know then other people notice
that you're oh you're really trying to
get rid of this and then the demand kind
of goes down you know what's wrong with
it
um and that affects price
and on the left then we have the price
is too high because there's not enough a
supply Supply
and you know that sometimes causes
um oh there's you know there's not much
Supply nobody wants to sell
that you know this must be good and then
that kind of increases the demand and
the hype a little bit so you see this
one simple graph describes all these
complicated trends
and if we see this that you know our
goal all around is you know finding
these points of equilibrium Supply meets
demand you know therefore everybody you
know making whatever products or making
money people looking for these products
or finding them you know and
you know fair trade people are paying
reasonable prices we're all trying to
get to that but we see all these things
happen all around there
and it's not just one direction of cause
and effect it's multiple things going on
as well as just general correlations all
things happening together
so
we look at this you know and and let's
say we say the trend is like as the
price goes down how does how does that
affect demand or it goes the other way
too as the price goes up how does that
affect demand
and
the word to describe that is elasticity
so elasticity
is
how quickly does uh demand change when
price changes
and we can look at this there's the
formula percent change in demand over
percent change in price
and this is again all these economic
formulas I'm just going to give you a
couple of them here that when you have
these formulas you can use this you know
get data use it to graph and then use it
to calculate these formulas to answer
these questions
you know how elastic is that price
because
if things change if the price changes
and then that really changes demand then
we can say it's a very elastic like it
like an elastic band or something that
bounces that you know it stretches and
changes easily
or things you know if price changes and
it does not change demand you know
things like gasoline
you know um we don't like to pay the
price goes up we don't like to pay it
but if the price went up a little bit I
still have to fill my car
so that demand would not be very elastic
the price could change and the demand
doesn't change
and you know we can so we can see that
if the percent change in price
let's say it's it's you know some
significant number but then the percent
change in demand is like almost nothing
we calculate that you know the total
value of that fraction is going to be
close to zero
um and we would say that's not very
elastic but maybe some other things
um
you know a uh concert ticket you know
there's ones I've seen where
oh I'd like to go see I'd like to go see
this but the price is too much no I
won't go and as the price goes down oh I
heard the price went down that would
absolutely change the demand
oh too much I will I won't go oh the
price went down now I want to go and
that really changed it you know things
that aren't essential
um and we would say that that would be
very elastic
so in calculating this and you know down
the road you could always combine all
these into
um one thing but I'm just going to show
you like just old demand new demand old
price new price and we're going to
calculate the percent change
so remember then that's
you know the new price minus the old so
there's their difference
divided by the old price and it's going
to get a decimal that we can convert to
a percent so you see again any we want
to get in the habit like
you you're so familiar with you know
collab that oh I have a formula I want
to use you know write write a quick
program to do it and then now all we
have to do is change these values up
here
and we can calculate everything that we
need
so price change and that's the ends up
being the percent change and then the
same thing with demand
the new demand minus the old demand
and that's the difference divided by the
old demand and that gives you a percent
it'll give you a decimal that you can
convert to a percent
and so elasticity number is demand
change divided by price change
so what I have is then it'll just print
that number and here's some of the
analysis so again
different things oh you what you know
what's the cutoff point you can always
just put these in
you know a nice little if statement and
so if the number is greater than one
then I'm going to print the demand is
elastic
and notice this is you know else if
so I just continue this on you know LF e
number equals one
then it's unitary or proportional
so sometimes you know we we do get one
that's there we go an increase
um
that proportional increase increases
demand but you know
um and then if it's less than one then
that's inelastic that's those are all
the ones that you know again it
the demand hardly changes based on price
and I just decided to attack one more
and so you see this is how you can you
know I I like to when I do my L if
statements I like to tag on one more
thing at the end you know for whatever
reason suppose you know this should
capture everything if it's either
greater than one equals one or less than
one I mean it's really but capture one
other like correct grab bag you know
what you know if something else happened
very often we'll have if and L if
without you know exhausting every
possibility and then you just easily
just put an else there at the end
so I have some sample numbers here and
then we can click and it would print out
so we get this
um negative 2.2 and then demand is
inelastic
so as that example
and we can do the same thing with Supply
so
remember you know Supply changes
um as price change because people say oh
hey I want to
um this is a hot industry I want to get
into this or then people say oh nope
it's uh you know this is cooled off I'm
gonna get out
um
so in uh you know in the United States
kind of recently the the real estate
market uh was hot and that's Supply like
okay not everybody necessarily is going
to sell their house or try to be a
realtor or try to sell some property but
when the prices are so good more people
decide to get into it like oh maybe I
will sell this
um
you know so that's the idea that if the
price is good and people see oh
opportunities to make money they get
into that so price elasticity of supply
answers that question how
how responsive is this Supply
to changes in price so very similar 400
percent change in supply of a percent
change in price
and just a few values to
sample and very similar formula
you know new price minus the old price
divided by the old price and
uh new Supply mine is old Supply divided
by the old Supply
and we're going to go through the same
thing elasticity number
and
very similar analysis greater than one
it's elastic
which remember as a fraction
greater than one is going to be that
this percent change in Supply
is much greater than the change in price
percent change in price
and we have to do percent change because
if we just do you know actual dollar
amounts or actual number of things
supplied that really doesn't always give
us a good example some things just in
general are low cost so a change of a
dollar might be a whole lot
some things are really high cost like
you know a change uh for a car
that a price change of a dollar is not
going to be much at all
so same thing with Supply you know what
what's what's the relevance you know how
is it relevant to the previous Supply
so that's why we do the percent change
so yeah if price changes
you know a certain percent but supply
chain is a lot more related to that then
we're going to say oh wow that's elastic
people are noticing these trends
and we can go through this and same
exact analysis either supplies elastic
unitary or anyelastic and I just you
know just had these so there we go
this number and
um it's inelastic because it's a tiny
decimal
so yeah not everything you know
Supply cannot always be you know elastic
and so notice we you can take this and
given the old prices and old Supply
you could always take these things and
combine them with something like this
so that therefore you could graph
and if you had you know
um other you know other numbers so
notice this I mean even though these
numbers might be fictional
if you had any bit of research that you
just had a few values here you can get
these you know and
with these you know
six things
um calculate
you know the graph and elasticity of
supply elasticity of demand
and really just get a handle on you know
where where you are in this graph and
what are the potential changes
um
you know is it you know I these graphs I
kind of made the linear and it's kind of
proportional but you know very often
it's going to be bumpier and you know
where are you on this graph and what's
what's going on
um
it if you really wanted to you could
even
um there's other plugins for
um other uh data especially things like
stock prices
and you could use this uh to calculate
um
elasticity for various stock prices you
could calculate some of the trends
and a lot of these it'll work within
collab there's a lot of things that will
work within collab there are a lot of
things that will work
um within your Google Drive and those
particular free tools tend to update
things like stock prices maybe like
every 15 minutes
at the at the most
but that's going to be enough to give
some sort of analysis you know for an
amateur investor take a look at
different things
um
you know that's kind of what we want to
take this and like these types of
formulas and build upon these
so that you know you can uh build data
pipelines and get information
at some reasonably regular level
um have all the formulas and calculate
and say you know okay now you know have
this output some sort of report for you
let's see the graph let's see it in real
time you know pretty much real time
let's run through some formulas and see
you know hey I'm thinking about
investing in this what's it looking like
oh it's it's very like you know the
demand is very elastic so you know you
really have to take notice of the price
um
or oh this you know
um I see this trend maybe you know a
supply of something that maybe I can get
into
all these things we want to you know use
this information to
uh make decisions about what we want to
invest in
yeah and you can do this all right here
in colab and right here in your Google
Drive so uh we'll get into some more
um
some some more math now and you know the
next step of our journey
so let's talk about calculating interest
and usually that's going to be money I
put in the bank or in some investment or
sometimes it's going to be money that I
borrow and then how much extra am I
paying
so the simple interest formula is
exactly that simple and it's good for
short term it's good for
um you know not a lot of money
if it's long term but the longer you go
with this the less accurate it's going
to be and we'll see why that is but for
short term principal times rate times
time
gives you the interest so if I was
borrowing something like you know let's
say you know I had borrowed you know a
hundred dollars and the rate would be
um
zero point uh zero five so the rate's
always a percent converted to a decimal
so the rate would be five percent and as
a decimal would be point zero five and
then the time would be always in years
so you know let's say I borrowed a
hundred dollars for two years
then what in what extra interest would I
owe on that so there we go
um that would be another ten dollars
so
what I would then say is okay well
you know given this rate if I needed a
hundred dollars now and it's going to
take me two years to pay it off
um you know maybe if it's going to take
me two years to pay off a hundred
dollars maybe calculating interest is my
biggest problem but the uh
if I if you know I could calculate oh
how much extra would that cost me in
interest now to figure out the total
amount that I would pay I would take
that interest and I would add it to the
original principle because I have to pay
that 100 back plus the extra ten dollars
so let's take a look at this
um you know if time is one like let's
say one year
and what that is is that's compounding
that's the notion of compounding that
I'm taking that interest and then I'm
adding it to the principal so let's say
the time was one year
and so
so this would be times point zero five
times one
then the interest would be five dollars
and then what am I going to do I'm gonna
I'm gonna add that together so I'm going
to say you know the principal
plus the interest
um is is going to be five dollars
now the reason why
um we compound it is because after let's
say a year so then I have that new
principal plus the interest but then
that new principle plus the interest
that's my new amount
and then that would then
generate another five percent in
interest
so you see that becomes my new principle
times five percent gives me my new
amount of interest and then I'd have to
add that so you see I would take that
you know times that 0.05
um there we go and then I take that
amount and add it to the new
new bit
so
that could potentially be a lot you know
every time I have to calculate the
interest add it to the principal again
and then recalculate it but let's take a
look in terms of algebra what what's
really happening here so if I have this
the original principle plus the interest
and I probably don't even need the
parentheses here so
the principle
plus but remember the interest was
principal times rate times time
so we're doing a little bit of
substitution there so the compounding
part principle plus the interest but the
interest remember that was this formula
so I'll just put that in here and notice
if I factor out P so you see the things
we were doing before with common factors
that comes around again then I factor
out p
times
1 plus RT
but supposing T is one
if T is 1 then that would be R times 1
which you know times one I really don't
have to write that and then I won't
write it in this step
so we see a nice algebraic way to write
this where I have the original
calculating the interest and then also
adding it now we're not going to stop
there what makes this really useful
because that is now
my principal calculating the interest
for that one year and then now that's my
new amount
what happens when I have to calculate it
for the next year well what did I do to
the original principal I did principle
is what I started out with
and then
I did times one plus three so if I had
to do it again for the next year it
would be times one plus the rate again
because that's what I did to get the
principal plus the interest and then
again times one plus the rate
and when we think about this in another
way it really makes sense because we're
saying that that
principal times one plus the rate is
that I'm saying you know this original
principle
um 100 or whatever it is if that rate is
five percent you know then that's 1.05
so you know what do I have I have a
hundred percent of it plus the extra
five percent
and then doing that you know that 105
every time we can even simplify this
that
that principle times one plus the rate
because if that's what I'm doing every
time how can I simplify that with an
exponent
and that's where time comes back in
I have that exponent of time
because every year then I'm doing that
times one plus three times one plus the
rate and so now we get from simple
which is nice principal times rate times
time to get just the interest and again
good for a short term but you see on
long term this is the formula that we
want that compound interest because that
accounts for every time it goes a little
bit I earn some interest but then that
becomes a part of that new principle and
then that's earning some sort of
Interest
and if this was my money in the bank
that's great that's good news for me but
then if this is money that I'm borrowing
then
the bank is going to be wanting to do
this sort of formula to make sure that
they get all the money that they that
that they deserve you know and then I
have to make sure that I pay that extra
interest so that's where we get the
principal uh simple and compound
interest and then we get to this so then
that's the you know that's the
formula and then that gives you you know
your new amount
so there we go a new amount and then
when we get to the code we're going to
talk about that new amount we're going
to call it annuity
um we're going to call it a maybe as a
variable a for amount but then it'll be
annuity which is a fancier word for the
amount that we end up with
so
there we go the connection with simple
and compound interest and we'll take
this a little bit further when we get
into the code so let's take a look at
that let's take a look at the code
so we're looking at simple interest as
the well as the name says simple because
it's good for short term and for some
things it might be good for an estimate
but we just get
principal times rate times time equals
the amount of Interest
and there we go again short term because
we're going to do some other things to
it
when we get to longer term and that's
what we'll get to here so the principle
if we just put some example numbers here
thousand dollars let's say I borrowed
money from the bank a thousand dollars
the rate five percent so it's always the
percent the annual rate converted to a
decimal and then time is always in years
so if I borrowed a thousand dollars from
the bank they said okay it's five
percent interest for three years I'll
pay it back here's the formula interest
equals PRT
and when we run it there we go we get
150 in interest I so I'd pay back that
thousand plus the extra interest but
right away then that tells me the cost
of borrowing that I need it now and I
don't have it so that's going to cost me
150 dollars
so then
I want to find out the total amount well
then the new amount is just that
principle plus the interest and there we
go I'm going to calculate the interest
just like we did before
and then
this new amount is principal plus the
interest
so there we go when we add that that 150
plus the Thousand makes it 11.50
so now I have that new amount
okay so most the time we're going to be
calculating the interest and then adding
it to the new amount
it's very rare that I'm paying just the
interest or somehow just the amount and
not worrying about interest so
here's what we were just talking about
that new amount is that new amount is
principal plus the interest and if it's
for one year that's principal Plus
for one year that would be P times R
times T which would be 1. so that won't
change it so that would be the new
amount principle plus the interest so
some algebra
that common factor P if I divide that
out I get P times 1 plus r
and if I do the distributive property I
get back to this so P times 1 is is p
and p times R is PR
now this is going to be very useful that
we factored out this P because now
I have that new amount
just that original P times 1 plus r and
the rate is always going to be some
decimal that it's going to be pretty
easy to add that to one one plus 0.05 is
1.05 you can do that in your head it
doesn't even feel like a step and then
this is what you're going to enter in
the calculator
so there we go one step that you
automatically would do in your head and
you're most likely going to have the
calculator for these so
that was what you would enter in the
calculator P times 1 plus r
now again this is for one year
n50 so
if we go back to that original
supposing the time was one year just to
show you that this works one year that'd
be fifty dollars in interest
and
for one year then
the new amount would be 10.50
so that what we're doing there adding
the interest to the principal that's
compounding
and compounding is exactly that adding
the interest to the principle and then
calculating the percent interest from
this new amount
so let's look at how this happens over a
few years so if my original amount is p
so then the next year it's p times 1
plus r
but now that's my new amount
so so again the next year so p is the
time zero after one year I have
multiplied times one plus r and after
another year I multiply times 1 plus r
again
and we'll just do this one more and
again B after one year
after two years after three years so
then
that's just the same as making this an
exponent P times one plus r to the third
power because I'm multiplying this
Factor one plus r three times
and now we have compound interest that
instead of having to go back and every
time
calculate the interest simple interest
add it and then do it again you know in
some Loop I have one formula that does
the compounding
and all I need to do is add the exponent
for how many years
so now the annuity from the original P
times 1 plus r exponent t
so that's 11.57 now it's not an error
that this is different and remember the
original was 1150.
when I did this by hand I just you know
calculated the interest based on simple
interest and then added it but that's
after three years it was eleven fifty
and like I said simple interest is good
for short term but the longer it goes
the less accurate it is
so when I have this come when I'm
compounding it every year notice that's
every year that I'm adding the interest
and then the next year so remember after
after one year it was a thousand fifty
so then for this for year two I'm
getting that five percent interest on
not on a thousand but on a thousand
fifty and on the next year I get that
five percent interest on that new amount
so that's the compounding it's like a
snowball that rolls down the hill and
accumulates more snow and gets bigger
and bigger as it goes down that's what
we're doing every time we're compounding
because I'm still taking that rate five
percent of a larger and larger amount so
compounded I get 11.57 just that same
amount over three years I earn an extra
seven dollars just because the formula
was better
so
time is always in years and that's
compounding every year
but we also have a formula supposing
compounding happens n times per year
so that gives us this more complicated
formula but that's okay
we see how it connects
P times one plus and instead of R we're
doing R Over N because
this is happening n times per year
so that rate isn't always an annual rate
so I have to divide it by how many times
I'm recalculating it but since then
every year was the exponent the exponent
becomes NT how many times a year times
the number of years so
then I'm compounding however many times
as an example here I put it as 12
because that's pretty common monthly you
know recalculate compounding 12 times a
year so then 1 plus r Over N what's in
these parentheses gets smaller but then
the exponent's larger and it still ends
up working out if this is money now if
this is money you're paying back it ends
up paying you end up paying more but if
this is money you're putting in the bank
earning interest then it works out in
your benefit
so that thousand dollars five percent
for three years but now this time
compounded 12 times per year
I use the extra parentheses for any
fraction
so there you go instead of just R here
it was one plus r Over N I put that in
parentheses also and you definitely need
the parentheses here to make sure
that stays because that is the whole
exponent NT
and remember the python syntax
you know in math we might skip the
multiplying symbol because we're they're
next to each other but in Python have to
put that asterisk there
so there's the annuity
um the other thing we're going to talk
about this instead of just amount that's
annuity and principle is the word for
the amount we start out with an annuity
is the word for the amount we end up
with
so now
the annuity compounded monthly look at
that 1161.
so
we go back from that simple interest
that was kind of off
to compounded annual 1157 much better
to 1161. because we're compounding it
monthly
and guess what it gets better but
first
I'm going to start talking about this
irrational number e now in the middle of
all these very practical
money in the bank things that we can
understand why am I going to start
talking about this irrational number e
and yes it's e but it's a number because
this is going to come up in the next
Formula
all right so just a quick note about e
we're going to import math because e is
a weird number
and so when I print math.e
this is the number
there we go and as a good estimate you
can just call it 2.7 but in your
calculations you actually want to use
this whole number so that's why I want
to import math.e I don't want to just
you know say 2.7 and call it good
um another interesting thing about this
is 2.7 and then we see it's 1828 and
then the 1828 repeats again I don't know
it's kind of interesting but
it only does that a couple times and
then it just all falls apart
so
math.e
use that
for the irrational number e and it's e
because it's Euler's number
um his name again with a knee but uh
John Napier who invented logarithms
and other things when he came up with
this number
um he named it e after uh another
mathematician that he liked Euler so
sometimes people call it Euler's number
but anyway it's e
now
if we're
talking about compounding n times per
year
we go from being irrational and talking
about e to being very rational well what
if I just keep compounding it many times
and that's where we get to continuous
growth
so in that previous formula
n could be
12. now in this example I made it a
hundred because we're going to do some
things with this
um you know it could be 12 every month
52 every week you know I just made it a
nice round number 100 it could be 365.
as n gets to be a bigger and bigger
number
than
we get the annuity becomes this formula
p e to the RT and that's why we we're
talking about e so I get this irrational
number e and then the exponent is RT
because as we get uh well I'll I'll I'll
just demonstrate this so let's say N is
a hundred
and if we do that
um
actually let's even make it 52.
so compounding every week
and then here I'm going to compare these
two formulas so this one I call the
variable n times so there's there's our
other formula P times 1 plus r Over N to
the NT
and then we're going to compare that
with our continuous growth P times math
dot e exponent RT
and then we're going to print it this
one or this one
so
n times we remember that from before
that should be the same number
and then
The Continuous growth
1161.83 so it's pretty close but it's a
little bit more for the
1161.75 1161.83
it's pretty close
but the continuous growth gives us even
more
and if n gets to be a much larger number
like a thousand
you'll see it gets really close
1161.829
or 1161.834
so we see if we took it to two decimal
places they actually round to be the
same
um
and that's the idea with continuous
growth you see it it's not that it's
always going to be more than this it's
that as n gets larger it approaches this
value so if I have anything that's
compounded a lot or other things Beyond
money in the bank or things like that
that I can say are continuous growth
applications you know population
increase or things like that then
I'm going to use this
and you know I can call it annuity I can
call it the you know the new amount but
I'm going to use this formula so
it's very useful for anything continuous
growth it comes up a lot I mean
throughout math and calculus some
version of this
um comes up a lot
so I have this continuous growth formula
if I want to calculate this
all right now
for really large amounts
the mortgage formula and the mortgage
payment formula
is if I have a really large amount of
money
and that's usually a mortgage you know
as an example I think this might be you
know pretty close to the average
mortgage these days 240
000. so that's a large amount of money
and then time is 30 years that's a long
amount that's a long time
so for such a large amount of money over
such a long period of time
then
it actually really makes a difference
how like if I'm paying just a little bit
you know every month the fact that I'm
paying you know a little bit and then
that principle reduces just a little
then the next month I'm earning interest
on that slightly lower principle well
that really makes a difference so if we
use any of the other formulas to
calculate mortgage payments
it's going to be
a lot more than you know you would
expect you'd be like oh my gosh how can
I afford that but when we use this more
complicated formula this accounts for
the fact that we're paying it off
gradually and
looking at all that then we can take a
look at for that given amount of time
what would my monthly payment be so that
it'll work out nicely you know if I'm
paying over 30 years times 12 months
that's 360 payments so I can calculate
it if I borrow this amount of money
after exactly 360 payments
um my balance is zero
and it works out
so just given that I can figure out the
payment and then we'll look at you know
how that plays out
so this being a complicated formula if
we want to write code for this and most
of the time you're going to you this you
don't even usually enter this into your
calculator you're going to make a
formula that you can plug in the numbers
here so that's what we're going to do
and here's how I decided to break that
down I just took the numerator that R
over 12 1 plus r over 12 12T and just
that numerator I made it a variable and
we see R over 12 times 1 plus r over 12.
to the 12T
all right and then the same thing with
the denominator
so just the denominator and I have
1 plus r over 12 so the exponent 12 t
and then minus 1 separate from that so I
have numerator denominator two separate
variables so then the payment see I
didn't forget about that P for principal
there the capital P for principal so
um I'll talk about the so I'm going to
round this because this is going to be a
weird number
and the first part is p times numerator
divided by denominator so there's my
mortgage payment
so P times numerator divided by
denominator and then I'm going to round
that because that's going to be a very
long decimal I'm going to round that so
it takes the first argument and then the
second one how many decimal places
there we go
so
when we take a look at this and when we
run it
mortgage payment 1362 and 69 cents
so given that then we know that's the
payment
that will make this work out that after
360 payments of this
so each time you know we're still
accruing interest and we're still making
a payment and it's going to work out now
to see how that plays out we call it the
amortization
schedule so and that's it that's the
mortgage payments schedule and yes all
these
um
have the word more in it
um uh which means death you know
um kind of like you know what's what's
true in life you know death and taxes
and I guess mortgage but yeah it was
very morbid when people first came up
with this word but it's stuck
um we will end this after this with
something much more positive so you know
don't worry I don't want to leave you in
the more morbid state
so the mortgage payment schedule if I
take this
there we go given these three things
um I just rewrote I just rewrote all
this how we're going to calculate the
payment
all right so I'm going to print this
payment just like I did before so that's
all the same as what we just did but the
more amortization schedule is I want to
have a loop to show the interest amounts
and we can also do this in the
spreadsheet that's pretty common and
later on in the course we'll talk about
that so
I can I'm going to have a loop so
I'm going to set this new variable
called balance and the starting balance
is going to be that original P principle
okay then I'm going to print this which
is going to be my headings
um month I'm going to put a tab there
balance
put a tab and then interest so that's
what I want I want the number you know
what month am I talking about what's the
balance at that point and then what's
the interest that I'm paying for that
month
so
here's what what we have in my loot for
a and range and how many months 12T
okay so the interest
um is
round
so again I'm going to round these
because calculating these you know it's
going to be a lot of weird decimals I
want it to be two decimals dollars and
cents so the interest that we're going
to pay
is this is simple interest again because
that short term this is only for one
month
and then we're going to manually
compound it here in this Loop so I do
want simple interest it still has
usefulness balance times
so that's my P for that month
times R and then T is 1 12. so I'm not
just going to multiply by one I'm just
going to divide by 12. but that's what
it is this is the original simple
interest PRT the balance is the
principle for that month
rate and then time is 112 so I'm just
going to divide by 12. so there we go
and all that I'm going to round it to
two decimal places
so now that I have the interest
um this will still calculate the
interest
and I just put this here for the sake of
the displaying
is that I only want if a
is divisible by 24. you see remember the
modulus a remain a divided by 24 if the
remains are zero then or if a is 359
which is going to be almost the last
month
so these are the ones so rather than
print out every single month I just want
to skip a few normally if and if I put
this in a spreadsheet I want the whole
schedule and I'd print out all 360
months but only for these we're going to
print out a select few so I want a
and then tab so that you know a is going
to be
um what month because that's a in range
and then
um
tab balance
Tab and then interest so there we go
that's what's going to line up month
balance interest
so then
after I do this so
I put this line last because the first
time through I want it to be the current
amount and then I'm going to increase
the balance
so you see what I'm doing to increase
the balance here
all right I'm going to round
balance
plus interest minus payment
so you see that's what's happening every
month so we're manually compounding it
the balance at that month plus the
interest that occurs that month minus
the payment
and then rounded to two decimal places
so when we run this
so we have the payment
is 1362 just so we figured and then here
we have our abbreviated table month
balance interest so month zero we start
out owing 240 000 as we expected but
look at that this is why it makes a
difference
you're paying eleven hundred dollars in
interest
for that month
that's a lot of money
and
you know that's it it's you know it's
almost the whole mortgage payment
you know it's shocking at first after
you do this enough times you come to
terms with it and say yes that's right
I'm paying almost all interest at the
beginning you know
um
and then 1362 pay 1100 so really then
notice that only
262 is going toward the payment now
we could see this really increase
slightly but at month 24 we've paid down
some things but it's probably not as low
as you'd expect it to be you'd think
like oh I'm paying so much I'd expect
this balance to be lower but you see you
really just chip away at it and even
then you're paying less interest but
it's still more than a thousand dollars
and that's you know month 24 so after
two years and you see after a month 48
you're paying a little bit less interest
we do see this moving in the right
direction you're paying this down and
you're paying a little bit less interest
but
probably not is going down as quickly as
you'd want and that's why I just wanted
to skip ahead you know every two years
we check in and see the balance
and you know how much interest we're
paying
you know we take a look at this
um
now you know we take it and we look at
this so if we have
just over 140 so remember we originally
borrowed 240 still a 140 but
at this point now that difference we
start building annuity or start building
um equity in in you know if this is a
mortgage equity in the house which means
the house is work was worth a lot more
than what we owe
and so you could borrow money against
that you know home equity loans that's
where that comes in as you start getting
lower and
you know the the value of the house
is worth a lot a certain amount and then
you only owe a certain amount the
difference you know you can actually
borrow money against that
that'll be a discussion for another time
so we have this and
finally now it's still a lot I mean you
know sometimes it's you know to think
about wow I'm still you know
look at that 20 years in I'm still
paying more than 500 a month just in
interest
you know it but at least that's only 500
a month and you know we're getting the
vast majority of our payments are going
at this point
to paying off the mortgage and now when
we take a look
you know look at that
double digits instead of three digits
thirty thousand
and then
the amount of interest at that point is
141 dollars so
uh I wanted to skip ahead and then just
do month 359
because look at that now the balance at
that point is just under what the
mortgage payment would be
and then the interest is this tiny
amount
and that would be if you know
month 360 when you make your last
payment it ends up being like four or
five dollars more than the normal
mortgage payment but then it's done so
it works out that that that monthly
payment
you know using that formula gave us that
monthly payment 1362 and 69 cents
and that monthly payment
did work out that that exact payment as
you know were look at the amortization
table at 360 months it was you know it
we paid it off and there we go for an
extra five dollars the last month I'm
not gonna stress about that so
these are you know interesting things to
think about seeing how using these
percent interest payments applied to
loans how that plays out how you're
paying off interest how we're making use
of the simple interest and then paying
down this balance
so this mortgage is the most common but
for any large amount of money
over a significant amount of time we
would use this formula does not have to
be a mortgage
car payment's not always because a lot
of times they're a lot lower but if it
was a car payment for like a
particularly expensive car or over that
over a longer period of time then we
might use this
doesn't have to go to 30 years that time
can be anything so we see this you know
paying off this debt over time so let's
use something very similar but let's
turn it around and have something
positive
retirement account estimation
now this one
instead of owing money you know this p
is not money that I'm borrowing it's
money that I'm going to put into an
account
and instead of owing money every month
I'm going to contribute and so there's
no formula for this
that I'm just going to estimate this oh
okay let's say 350 dollars
um
just because uh you'll you'll see how
this plays out I just picked these
numbers here so
let's say the principal is a thousand
and this is just estimation here but
let's say you started with a thousand
dollars now this is where the estimation
comes in most of the time the retirement
account you know any decent fund manager
is going to be able to get you point
eight percent or eight percent interest
so now this is your money growing in an
account this isn't you paying off a debt
it's your money growing in an account so
if you had a thousand dollars and we
estimate that it's growing at eight
percent per year that's great and I made
this time 38 years as you know not
entirely random it was I just thought
like age 22 to age 60.
um 38 years so
you start it put a thousand dollars in
this account and then you start
um saving that you know from that point
like you know your whole career you put
away 350 every month in this account
okay and I'm gonna establish this other
variable annuity which I'm going to
start out the original was p
so now here's my Loop
for the contribution and the percent
growth
so again 38 years so
for a in range 12T
so there you go because every month
we're contributing something
so notice
what we're doing with this annuity
where
taken the annuity that we already have
plus the monthly contribution
and then that's going to grow
1 plus r over 12.
because that's a monthly notice that
percent increase formula but this is
monthly so the exponent if it was NT the
exponent n would be 12 and T would be 1
12 which cancels out to 1.
so I don't need to write the exponent of
1. but that's where this comes from it
is that same formula R Over N to the NT
but NT and it's n is 12 T is 1 over 12
and so that cancels out
so
each month then if we take this and
that's why I wanted to break this down
still monthly
because I want to allow for this
contribution here the annuity plus the
monthly contribution we want that to
happen each time and then it's going to
grow
so in this Loop
now this continues to grow so at the end
we're going to print this out and I'm
going to round because that'll end up
being a weird decimal annuity Okay so
now
the annuity is going to seem like a lot
but this is what we want to break this
down if we're
if our rate is eight percent so at the
end
let's say it's still earning eight
percent
when you start taking so the annual
income from interest
you see
and so that's annuity
times the rate
that's it and yeah I'm gonna two decimal
places
what's that so if I have this um this
amount of money that I'm going to
eventually get to
then the idea is that money now is yours
in the bank or in this in this fund
somewhere
that the annual income
is just that percentage rate
so when we run it
so take a look at this annuity here
so one
zero six one five nine seven yes that's
more than a million dollars
and if it continues to earn that eight
percent the annual income just from the
interest is eighty four thousand dollars
well or almost 85 000.
and that's the idea that this money in
the bank or in some investment
not not in the bank not saving because
nothing in the bank is going to get you
this eight percent interest that makes
this happen
but this retirement investment
if you're you know you have this and you
can contribute something it's you're
constantly contributing and it's growing
so at some point then you retire and you
have this million dollars that earns
this amount of Interest
and
I just picked you know 38 years
um
the earlier you start the better and
the later you stop start uh taking money
out you know it can grow even more
that you could take the money out at um
you know uh age I just I just rough
estimated did age 22 to 60.
you know if you if you start as early as
you can I mean even 18 and you know
until 68 if you look at that that'd be
like 50 years
that really is what makes a difference
because remember this snowball so that
eight percent in those later years
that's eight percent of larger and
larger amounts of money
and then
if you get it to this million then eight
percent
of a million
is more than eighty thousand dollars
so that's that's the idea we want to get
to this larger amount of money that just
the interest on that
you know if this investment keeps going
just the interest on that is enough to
live on and you take the interest and
then you're back to this amount which
will earn interest the next year
so we want to leave you with that that
positive idea of how we can use all this
you know that's that's not what use all
all these you know percent increase
formulas to you know turn that into
money in the bank that's that's the goal
here
all right and
you know hopefully then it works out and
if you have these this code you can
Tinker with this and say you know how
much do you start out with you know keep
this rate maybe change the rate a little
bit oh you know my fund manager is doing
really well change the time monthly
contribution you can Tinker with these
and run it and you know see the results
so you know prepare for uh you know what
what you need to do to invest for
retirement
so let's look at some more ways you can
use these mortgage formulas here now
like we were doing before I'm going to
Define actually the payment
formula as its own function so there we
go Def and then payment and I'm going to
take the arguments P R and T run it
through this formula and I'll just
return the payment
so this you'll see some places we can
use this and all of these you know we're
going to apply these to you know let's
say you know you're looking for a house
you're comparing different things
so
to get this I'm just going to run this
and there we go and I don't need to run
that again now I have that
a formula here so
I'm going to do a similar function and I
get something different
um because I just want to show you this
one I'm just going to Define it PMT and
I'm only taking the principle as the
argument because I'm going to just give
a set rate and time
so with this and then I'll run that
through taking the input as whatever the
principle is I'm going to calculate the
payment and the reason why I'm doing
this and we see these Imports is because
I'm going to make this a slider where
I'm just going to go from 0 to 300 000.
and see how the payment changes based on
that principle
of course the slider shows it somewhere
in the middle
000 the monthly payment would be 899.33
and we can see how this goes up
and here's something you can do you know
again if you're comparing different
mortgages or houses you can see how does
this really affect my monthly payment
you know
um and we look at this oh 221 thousand
should I buy a house that's more
expensive I know my payment will go up
but the question is by how much
you see and we can look at this now
that's great to see these exact numbers
but maybe I want to see the trend maybe
there's I want to graph it
so
notice our standard for graphing and in
this case I just Define my X maximum is
300 000.
and my y maximum 4 000 that's going to
be plenty
all these standard things you would
already have set up you know x-min Max
the points you're going to use for NP
Dot linspace
and everything you're going to do to
graph
um something that I don't always put in
there plt.grid just to show the grid
lines
and
x dot set X label and set y label so the
X will be the amount borrowed and we see
that that goes from zero to three
hundred thousand and the Y will be the
monthly payment
so now that payment function I defined
earlier I can just use that as my y
value
I only need the X
that I'm going to use as a variable here
and I'm still going to give it just a
consistent rate and time
so
you know X is the input all these are
going to given the same rate and time
how does the principle affect the
monthly payment
and when we run this
we can see that the payment change is
actually linear given that same rate and
time
and this would be realistic maybe you
get pre-approved
from the bank so you would know your
interest rate
and you would know the time so just
comparing
different mortgages it is linear how
much would it increase
you know for how much would the payment
increase for increases in the amount
borrowed
well all right this is a good visual of
it but let's get down to the numbers
so it's linear I'm just going to do the
slope formula
and I'm just going to pick two values
you know and you know X1 and then the
payment
and notice this I just put rate and time
here and I Define them up here just a
different way of doing it I'm using the
same numbers consistently throughout
this I feel like that would be good
for the consistent example and just pick
two x values calculate the payment based
on those X values
and calculate the slope formula
and what we'll find
so without rounding now notice this is
you know dollars and cents so
really
um it would go up you know six cents for
every ten dollars of
you know price increase
or we can you know multiply it by a
thousand here and say it would go up six
dollars you know because 5.99 I'll round
up it would go your mortgage rate would
go up six dollars for every thousand
extra dollars you borrow
and now you have that in in mind okay an
extra thousand that's going to be an
extra six dollars in the monthly payment
and you know you can put things in
perspective do I like it that much you
know oh the extra thousands only six
more dollars
so we see some things we can do with
this we can take these formulas that we
we've been working with and we can
Define them as their own functions we
can use them in sliders we can
graph them
and finding aspects of the graph we can
do other analysis this is kind of like
we want to be building upon for our data
analysis so this is all good and I want
to actually then
have like a bonus here beyond the python
I know this is almost all python but I
want to get into showing how you can do
this in a spreadsheet because that will
give you like that full amortization
table
and I want to show you also how to build
that because these are some good
spreadsheet skills you'll want okay so
notice the balance here is a Formula but
we'll get to that in a second
so given that given a home price I
picked this 250
000 that's somewhere around the median
home price in the United States right
now
um I wanted to be some realistic middle
of the road number
down payment it's going to be we want 20
so notice if I click on this this is
cell G3
up here is the formula and I just did
20 times G2 0.02 times G2 so
that way if I change this and I make G
two you know 300 000 instead
click somewhere else then it will
automatically calculate the down payment
I think I do want to go back to 250 000
again that's I feel like that's a good
middle of the road number for us to use
as our example
and click and it'll adjust again now
then the borrowed amount I would
subtract that so I'm going to double
click in this and
equals G2 minus G3 actually that's
exactly what I wanted sometimes
oh sometimes Google will prompt you
will give you that
and notice I can click on this and you
can see the borrowed amount and then up
here this is the formula G2 minus G3
which is the home price minus the down
payment
all right so let's just say the interest
rate you know .06
and time uh 30 years
now I'm going to write the word years
here I'm not going to use this number
for anything else but here the interest
rate
I will
all right now monthly payment we can
always then go right back to this
and calculate the monthly payment
so we see here I just had this
um
monthly payment there you go six percent
um 30 years and
I already have this so what if I just
made it my borrowed amount
which was 200 000 even
and I can just go to this
borrowed amount
up two hundred thousand
now
I could actually also
just make another since I already have
that payment
um
I could actually write under here
right
um print
payment
uh 200
comma 0.06
comma 30.
so you see I could just actually just
put this in here
and I'll put the monthly payment
all right there we go 11.99 and 10 cents
so monthly payment will be 11.99
and 10 sets
so now notice here this is just a good
reference for all the things we want
home price down payment and everything
but these notice I already had to just
populate over here
the monthly payment
and if you'll notice I have these dollar
signs here that's going to be for some
things we're going to do later I don't
need them over here
but
we're going to do some things later
we're going to drag these formulas down
and it's going to adjust for according
to the row and the dollar sign will keep
that
the same
so dollar sign G dollar sign four that
means if I ever adjust this that's not
going to change it's going to stay too
it's going to stay referencing that cell
G4
and same with the payment that's always
going to reference G7 and
that's what that's what I want
now the interest
we've been doing all these fancy
interest formulas but actually this is
going to be monthly each of these is
going to be on each of these rows is
going to be a month so for monthly
interest we can just do simple interest
equals the print that that balance which
is A2
times the rate which is 0.06
times the time which is one month
so one month is 1 12th of a year so I'm
just going to say divided by 12.
and this works out I mean you know
that's very nice but it's not always
going to work out evenly so what I want
to do is
I want to add another function around
here round
open parenthesis
and
I will
put you know so it rounds this and if I
don't put anything else you see It'll
round it to the whole number but I want
to put comma 2 because that'll round it
to two decimal places
and this is Google Sheets if you you do
this in Microsoft Excel you have to have
that comma and then however many decimal
places even if it's zero Google if I
eliminate that it'll just round to the
whole number
so there we go so round
um I have my payment and then my new
balance equals the original balance
which was A2
plus the interest of the crude so that's
B2
minus the payment which is C2
and I want to take this so we see even
you know earned a thousand dollars in
interest
you know just you know just sometimes
it's a lot to stop and think about that
and all that the pages just took a
little bit off because that earned a
thousand dollars in interest and then
the payment was only 11.99 so a little
bit of that like 200 bucks went to
the
paying down the original principle so I
want to take this because then we have
the balance
get accrues interest I make a payment
New Balance and I want to take this and
carry it over here so that was cell D2
so I'm just going to put equals D2 here
and here so
now notice if I drag this down
it changed because it's calculating the
interest now based on this this balance
you see A3 times .06 divided by divided
by 12.
and then here
when I drag that down it's going to be
the same because I put the dollar sign
in there it won't adjust anything
and here I will drag this down one
and we see again doing that it adjusts
it for this row now everything here was
based on row two everything here is
based on Row three
and we got that by
mousing over the bottom right hand
corner you get a little tiny plus sign
and this is magnified but
you know you'll see that that thin plus
sign and you click and drag that but
we're going to do that for the entire
row so I'm going to holding down shift
in the arrow key to highlight the entire
row and I'm going to Mouse over that I
get that thin plus sign and I'm going to
click and drag
and this is how we make our amortization
table now notice
my mouse is down below the bottom of
this
because
for 30 years that's 360 months so
somewhere around there is where I'll
stop
and these are all negatives so
I'm going to take this
highlight all these negative numbers and
then they'll just delete them
so
now here
this is
um
you know after this the balance is a
dollar so
we can just make this
11.99
plus that additional
dollar 13.
and I'm not going to take it to multiple
decimals like that
and
that should be
yes 10 cents
negative 10 cents dollar three
and that should be enough to make that
we're just going to call it that many
zeros we're going to call it zero
and what we have the row number is
always one more because we had the first
row as headings so three given that
mortgage payment
it works out exactly
30 years exactly 360 months
you have a balance of zero
so we're going to take
um
take this and we see this is the
amateurization table and you know you
can look through it and scroll through
it and see how
the payment stays the same but what
happens is the amount of Interest keeps
going down
gradually
because
for such a large amount of money for
such a long period of time every month
the fact that you're
paying interest on just that little bit
less
that really makes a difference
and then that means that look you know
that same payment a little bit less
interest a little bit more of it goes to
the principal so you know you're you're
making some progress
paying this off
but it takes a while
until see look at this I mean
that's almost 1200 so we have to go into
you know
225 months
you know we're coming up on 20 years
until
you know half of your payment goes to
interest or less than half of your
payment goes to interest
so it's just good interesting to see
that whole table
um and then this balance here at any
given month that's the payoff amount you
know supposing you come into some money
and you say I just want to pay off the
rest of it you know that that's the
balance that's your payoff amount
and we have all this
now
besides showing you the spreadsheet and
how you can set this up and how we can
you know grab values from other cells
and how we can add formulas and how we
can drag all this down that's great
amateurization and
um you know mortgage more you know it
does sound like death because you know
it is the same word more
so let's do something more positive with
a very similar
type of
formula so supposing I set up the same
thing balance
um
interest I'll capitalize it
and payment but I'm going to say
contribution
and then New Balance
so
let's look at this in a more positive
way supposing that what this was
this amount that you owed that you're
paying off
but let's talk about a retirement
account that you're adding to
so I don't know let's let's start by
some like round number like five
thousand dollars
and a lot of retirement accounts you
know people managing it could
you know get like eight percent interest
that's pretty reasonable to think of
so
we have equals
um so this is column I
to
2 times
.08
interest and then for one month so then
you know
1 12th of the year so divided by 12.
there we go
and maybe you know
we could do this we could do this with
or without rounding around it that might
that might work out it'll just look
nicer round
and I'll round it to two decimal places
again dollars and cents
okay now monthly contribution so who
knows like you know
um you can contribute a few hundred
dollars
um
let's start with something like this
like let's start with like 200
and we're gonna change that later
um
so
with balance it gains some interest and
you contribute so
it's all plus equals
I2
Plus
J2 Plus
K2
and then we're going to carry that
around so that's L2 equals
L2
and we're going to do the same thing
drag this down one
drag this down one and what we have is
you know given that you know rate of
interest given the contribution you
could always add more different times
um but I want to show you this for about
the same amount of time
so if we drag this down
now
this being a retirement account a lot of
times people will start this earlier so
we don't really even have to stop at
360.
um let's stop with like 400 I see even
number there
um
there we go uh 401 because the first row
is
so what we have is
this
at that point
then
you know this amount that you have is
469 000 and the interest every month is
three thousand
so you could easily like take that
interest and then you're back to
465. you know take that 3106 out every
month and live on that and then you're
back down to this so you know it it you
know goes from this and then back to
this take that out and then you're back
to this that's one way to do it
I just want to show you so let's let's
get even more optimistic here and say
then we contribute something like you
know 400 a month
we're going to drag that down in a
little bit
um
and
this one let's say
you know 0.085 I don't know a little bit
more optimistic on the
there we go drag that down a little bit
and so now that second row again is
correct and we'll drag this down
and the other thing I'm going to do is
take this a little bit longer
um
maybe even like uh 400 and
150 months or something like that
um 40 years would be 480 months
so
we can take this even further
and you'll see that just you know some
of these you know you get
some POS some nice possibilities here
all right and
because look at this final number here
so
yes that one is one million
so you know that's what we're talking
about here you know one million dollars
and
the monthly interest is
9885 dollars
so this is something you know again I
want to you know take this same math and
turn around and make it positive
something that you could be contributing
to and then at this point you have this
money you know in this investment that
you can take this out every month or or
less and you know not have to worry
about it ever running it running out
take that out
and then you're still left with this you
know more than a million boom take that
out live off the interest and you still
have this every month take that out you
still have this to generate interest the
next month
and these are some of the things that
you can look at that you know from the
other side of it you know you owe all
this money to pay off this mortgage but
then you own this house and on the same
time you're contributing and you know
here then you have money that you can
live off of and you know these you know
these are the types of things we want to
do with our math skills look at how we
can manage
um manage money to you know later on in
life than have
this you know property that has equity
and you know
um as value and something else in the
bank that you can live off of and there
you go
you know put putting the math skills to
use and you know seeing how you can make
this work for you're seeing the trends
that you know it seems like now you
might be working hard and owing a lot
and not having that much but you know
over time like many years you build
things and then you have things oh I
have this that I can now you know
they've built over decades and can live
off of it
so that's really good and you know we
were doing some of this with the other
uh
python you know generating just some of
the values but you see like these you
know these are some of the ways you can
make this work for you and you know look
at the trends and
um
hopefully this helps you make some
decisions about Investments you know
whether it be real estate or borrowing
money or other retirement Investments
all right so that was just you know some
bonus and
there we go we're in the home stretch
hopefully you're really seeing this all
come together you know
um skills that you're building
so let's talk about exponents and
logarithms so the exponential form
is this 2 to the exponent 3. 2 to the
third power equals eight so we know how
to do that we've been doing this so far
at algebra then logarithm is the same
information rearranged so
this same information the log base 2 of
8 equals 3.
so the logarithm is always what's the
exponent
that's what we want to that's what we
want to know and
it
in what we've been doing so far and in
most calculators you know two to the
third no problem I know how to put that
into the calculator in Python they don't
even have to import anything but
if I know the base and I know what I
often call the result
um if I know the base I know the result
but the exponent is what I don't know
then that sometimes becomes a problem
especially when it doesn't work out
nicely like this works out but supposing
you know it wasn't a a you know a nice
nice exponent like three supposing you
know two to what exponent gets me nine
or ten
it's going to be some weird decimal but
how do I how do I get that and so you
know we we have to appreciate that you
know uh John Napier you know spent like
about 400 years ago spent like 20 years
of his life figuring this out and making
tables and now we have this at the touch
of a button on a calculator and we're
going to look at also how
to write the code for this now with
logarithms we do have to import
something but you know we'll import a
library you know much quicker than
spending 20 years of your life figuring
this out so if we have you know two to
the third
um you know
the the base is always going to be
whatever you know the same thing with an
exponent what I call the base
so if I have you know log base 2 of 8
you know that's what's the exponent now
what's interesting is
um our calc in our calculators we you
know you can do the log you'll see a log
button now if I have the log
if I just say the log of
um
a hundred
and supposing I don't see any number
there
if I don't see a number then it's
understood base 10 and we call that the
common log because our number system is
base 10 so if it's 10 I don't have to
write that and so the log of 100 is 2
because 10 to the second power is 100.
and we're going to use this a lot of
times for
uh working with scientific notation and
maybe even converting decimals
so that you know that's that's where a
lot of times I I'm going to use the
common log and then I might even if I'm
doing things like scientific notation I
might even do the floor function because
if you know what's the log uh you know
like 150 it's going to be two point
something but then for converting it to
scientific notation I may be just
interested in the two because then that
tells me to move the decimal place two
so then that would be you know 1.5 times
10 to
the second
you see you know different things that
we want to do with uh converting this
for scientific notation
all right other interesting things about
logarithms well
that
exponents and logarithms they're
inverses of each other so if I have
um if I have the log
base 2 of 2 to the Third
then well actually I'm not even going to
put it to a definite number I'm going to
call this x because then anytime the
answer is X you see if I take
the log of the exponent
anytime you have a function of its
inverse it cancels out to X
now notice then
what we're saying here the log base 2 so
2 to what exponent Gets Me 2 to the X oh
X is the exponent
you know makes sense
and the same type of thing works with if
I have 2 to the log
base 2 of x
exponent same thing that's exponent
and log inverse
because remember take a look at this log
base 2 of X so it's 2 to what exponent
gets me X
so remember anytime log we want the
exponent 2 to what exponent gets me X
and whatever the answer is it's an
exponent and I M and then in fact taking
2 to that exponent so I would end up
with x
so we see you know that we're going to
use these inverses and this is where it
becomes very useful you know for
whatever base I have if I'm solving
something
if I have
um 3 to the x equals you know 25. now
that doesn't work out nicely if it was
27 x is 3 that's nice but I know I'm
going to do this on the calculator what
am I going to put on the calculator well
how can I get how can I get it to x
equals something
well
if it's 3 to the X then if I take the
log
the log base 3
of this 3 to the x
and then
on the other side it's going to be the
log base 3 of 25.
so in algebra and the things you know I
do the same thing to both sides what are
the things that I can do well one of the
things I can do to both sides is take
the log of both sides as long as it's
the same base so if I take the log and I
pick base 3 because of this because then
that cancels down to X
and then over here I have the log base 3
of 25 which is what I would do in the
calculator
and we'll see in the code
you know we're going to import a library
and we'll be able to do this
you know no problem on the calculator
um or in the python code
now another thing is if you're on a
calculator or
you know you want to do different sort
of python code
um
I could just do the common log for this
it actually works out also the log of 25
divided by the log of 3.
so the log of this divided by the log of
the base
and again you can use common log or
whatever I'd want for that so you know
that's pretty interesting
um
you know what another way that like that
works
so change of Base formula if you ever
find yourself in a situation where you
don't have the ability to do the log of
any base
you know you can use whatever logarithm
you have and do this so that's where you
know exponents and logs we use that
inverse property when we're solving and
that comes up a lot you know if I want
to look at things you know things that
are growing exponentially anything
continuous growth
um sometimes it's you know radioactive
decay for dating carbon
um all kinds of things sometimes I'm in
this situation exponent my unknowns in
the exponent and so I want to use a
logarithm to figure that out
um the other log is going to be the so
we have all the different bases and
the common log which is base 10 but then
I also have the natural log
um
and if I was writing this uh it's I'm
going to I'm going to write it as Ln
we'll see that a lot of the logarithm uh
functions in Python they actually if I
just say log it actually goes to natural
log not base 10. so that's that's really
interesting in Python the default is
natural log if I don't put another base
there but if I was writing it out it's
Ln for natural log
um and so if I have the natural log
of of anything so the natural log means
that it's base e
and
so and base e
is about equal to that 2.71828
1828 and then after that it's less than
five but then you know it's just that
pattern stops so
um oh 2.71828
so e is about 2.718281828
um and it keeps going
this is used for a lot of continuous
growth formulas so if I have you know
the natural log of you know 2.7
well then my answer is going to be you
know about one it's going to be a little
bit less than one it's like 0.99 or
something like that you know 0.99
and I can you know I can use the natural
log for for some other things and we'll
we'll see some of the applications of
that too when we get to the code but
that that's where
um if I have base e so if if it's base e
i just make this Ln if it's base 10 I
can just write log and if it's any other
base and the bases we usually want to
have them as whole numbers but if it's
any other base
um then I'm just going to actually write
the base
so
okay so we take a look at this we'll see
how
um we can actually calculate a lot of
this in the code and that's going to be
pretty useful for some of the from some
of the applications we have so let's
take a look at the code
so when using logarithms in Python we'll
just import the math library and now we
have math.log
there we go math.log and it takes two
arguments the number and then the base
so this is math.log of 10 000 base ten
so when I run it there we go it'll be
four
this works out nicely for things that we
know are going to be a nice integer
but I also want to show you
that
python weirdness
sometimes even when you think it's going
to be a nice integer math.log of 1000
base 10. so I expect this to be exactly
three but when I run it
it gives me this long decimal
so any of these even when you think it's
going to work out nicely just the way
that this works behind the scenes you
might want to
just build in a rounding
function here
so
I'm going to round all this math.log of
1000 base 10 and I'm going to round all
that to four decimal places
so you just might want to build fill
that in
so that way you're going to get that
answer and notice I still said four
decimal places but because it worked out
not rounding not needing decimal places
it didn't have to give me like four
zeros after the decimal
there we go so that that's just the
usefulness of it that
it's just worth it
um build the round function there
all right so that said I I have a few of
these that I don't have the round
function just to show you what the exact
answer might be so if I have base two
there we go again import math and then
we're going to do math.log
in this case 16 base 2 so when we run it
it's going to be 4
and I don't have the log in there so if
I have something like 15
base 2.
I don't have the rounding so you see it
it'll give you all that if you need
these decimal all these decimals for for
something it will give you that
but there you go just whatever the
number is and then the base
natural log I'm going to import math
again
and notice here I can just do math.log
of a number
and if I don't give it that second
argument of what the base is it'll
default to natural log and E is about
2.7 so if we
we do this we see
you know it gives it that rounding now
what I also want to show you is as we
were talking about before uh so math.e
if I just want to use e for anything
math.e is going to be the most exact you
know it'll give you all those decimal
places you don't have to just
um you know guess at it but also e to
the fourth then
and I store that as variable X
so if I have e to the fourth and then I
take the log which is the natural log
my answer should be 4.
because the log of that exponent or if I
have e to the Third
the answer is 3.
so you know if I use that math.e to get
the most exact
uh approximation of e and then log
without the other
argument
then it will cancel out and that'll
that'll work out the same way if I did
like you know 10 to the fifth and then
log you know base 10 you know that works
too
so
just just to show you this all right so
other you could use the Vlog or
especially natural log answering the
question how long will it take for an
investment to double
and I still wanted to put the algebra in
here so if we have our general
continuous growth formula so I have p
and then I have the annuity what number
P what what it starts out as an annuity
what number it ends up so if it's
doubling then whatever I have for p
doubling would be 2p
whatever the number is so I can divide
both sides by P and then I get this e to
the RT equals 2.
so as we were looking before about
getting to exponents if my unknowns in
the exponent what's my base and then I'm
going to take that log of both sides so
if it's base e I'm going to take the
natural log so on the left I have the
natural log of 2 and on the right
natural log of e to the RT as we just
saw
is going to be that exponent
so that's why we do that if it's BC I'll
take natural log and then they will
cancel out the function of its inverse
and then
if I want to solve for T now I have rt
divide by R so I would have this the
natural log of 2 divided by R gives me
how long it would take money to double
so we can just put this in in some code
I'll just Define r as the rate here
you know two percent you know sort of
like a low inflation rate and natural
log of 2 divided by the rate so I am
going to round this
log 2 so notice no other
argument there log 2 then divided by R
and also the rounding is no other
argument so it'll be a whole number
there we go and we get it to be 35 years
so if something's increasing at two
percent 35 years from now it'll be
double
and like I said as a low inflation rate
something that costs whatever now 35
years from now it'll be about double
that price so we have this or if I have
you know some investment you know 09 you
know nine percent and I say oh this you
know this seems to be doing okay I put
money in this investment how long will
it take for that money to double
in this case eight years
so there we go
so you know some people might make that
determination for what they invest in
and there we go answering that question
write some code so in graphing this I
want to show you this pattern of
graphing the exponent and logarithm so
we're going to do all the usual Imports
for any graph we're going to do all the
usual you know
X Min x max set the dimensions here
and we've done this before when we use
numpy I need the no I need this the
number of points here
because then I'm going to create my
numpy array
np.lin space
from x-mined x max using this many
points so there's my array now for this
I also created a second array
specifically because
my X Min I don't want it to go down to
negative 10. I wanted to start at 0.01
and we'll see that in a second
and then again set up all the all the
graph here so
I'm going to graph this first line here
y1
equals math.e to the X so there we go I
imported a match just for this using
math.e so if I'm graphing e to the X
plot that and then line two so then if
it's e to the X I want to do the natural
log
and so notice it's log and I didn't use
the math one here I wanted to use the n
n p DOT log for use the numpy because
I'm graphing
so numpy has log building also so I want
to use that because I'm graphing that'll
match up with with the numpy array
and that's this is why I wanted X2 as my
argument here because logarithms can't
be zero and they can't be negative
so I didn't I this actually would give
give an error but it would still graph
it just with that error
um and I didn't feel like seeing that so
I I created that other array starting at
0.01 so there we go so now I have e to
the X natural log
and my line three
is just Y equals X
all right so
this is what this looks like and this
blue line that curves upward that's the
exponential function and going to the
left it actually doesn't really touch
zero it just gets really really close
Beyond with this display can show but it
doesn't ever get to zero and then this
orange line that logarithm it the x
value can't be zero and then it goes up
and it has this curve to it as X gets
bigger this increases but
it not so much especially as it goes on
and on
and then the green line is y equals x so
if it looks like these are mirror images
of each other across that line that's
true
like any inverse functions they are
mirror images across the line Y equals X
so kind of cool how that works out so we
see this numpy
arrays of points
e to the X natural log of x
and just as a slight comparison I wanted
to show you that if I have 2 to the X
and I'm going to use this and comment
out this other one
so instead of e to the X if I have 2 to
the X all right there you go 2 exponent
x and then here
I have the
log base 2. and
again I'm going to use numpy and you see
numpy's log instead of a second argument
they have different functions so this is
so log is natural log log 2 is log base
2 and then there's log 10. so those are
the main ones you you'd want to be able
to use
there we go so I'm going to have log 2
here and then the line Y equals X so if
I run that it's going to be slightly
different
because
2 is not as big as 2.7 but very similar
and often you know if but if if it were
my drawing I I wouldn't be able to draw
the subtle differences so I would say oh
they all kind of look the same
you know exponential logarithmic Y
equals X
there we go so we we use these as some
good good estimates here
all right we can also use logs for
scientific notation now here I just had
it print out 3.2 times 10 to the fifth
now I wrote that in scientific notation
but it'll print it out with with all the
zeros here
and here I have it
um as a negative exponent 4.5 times 10
to the negative second
there we go and you might be wondering
about that comment why negative 2 works
fine why that's an important thing
and there we go we see the output here
because
exponent negative 3 gets weird
very interesting because the exponent of
positive 3 10 to the third you know got
a little weird too
and you see just the way it works behind
the scenes
the negative 3 we would think that it
would stop there and that'd be fine but
it gives you all these other zeros and
then a five at the end
unnecessary but as I was mentioning
before the rounding will
will solve a lot of these problems so
you know I just use this with for the
for the negative four so
I have this
10 4.5 times 10 to the negative 4 and
I'm going to round it
to five decimal places so if I have a
negative exponent
let's say negative 4 then I want to
round it to five decimal places and then
that gives all of these because it'd be
4.5 and I want that extra decimal place
to show that
so you see rounding rounding again works
out very nicely
um
and then if I have negative 5 and
greater it forces the scientific
notation so as much as I want to say
that I'm just going to print this out I
already have it in scientific notation I
even say round it to six decimal places
doesn't matter the output python wants
to put in scientific notation
and notice this e is not e 2.7
but it's
4.5 times 10 to this exponent
so python uses this and a lot of
calculators use that notation also
we can convert something to scientific
notation
if I take this
so I want to get the number of decimal
places
so if I take the log so this is variable
a so if I take the log
of a and base 10
so this one I'm just using the math
Library if I take the log but since it's
not
0.001
it's not going to work out to it's going
to be like one point you know it's going
to be like this is four decimal places
it's going to be four point something so
that's why I want to do math.floor
to get just that exponent I want to
chop off all the the extra decimals in
my answer here and then the log of that
the floor of that is going to be the
exponent
so that's what's going to give me that
negative 4. and then if I take n
I'm going to round that 10 divided by
that exponent
and this formula also works for larger
numbers too
but if I see it take that and then round
it
then in this case rounded to two decimal
places that's fine that's n
I could stop there but I have this extra
Loop here just in case there's rounding
errors
um
because it could work out somewhere that
n ends up being greater than 10.
you know that that happens and so in
that case then I then I want to make
sure that I still get true scientific
notation one number than the decimal
so there we go I'm going to just if it's
greater than I'm going to increase the
exponent
now for this one there you go a equals
.0005
and
there we go it gives you
point zero zero zero five equals 5 times
10 to the negative 4.
and then this should work for all kinds
of other exponents and you're converting
it to scientific notation if you wanted
to
so these are some of the uses of
logarithms you know we can see the graph
that's pretty interesting but we can see
the applications the solving sometimes
if my unknown's in the exponent we can
see converting to and from scientific
notation so these are a few applications
of logarithms and I'm sure you will find
even more so
um
you can make use make use of this code
and enjoy
here we have the foundational math three
certification 3 and like the others you
are going to make a copy first of all
and work through this whole notebook
make a copy put it in your Google Drive
and then from your copy
we'll do
first step like before acquiring the
testing library and later on in this
unit uh
or the next unit we'll look at the
mechanics behind this and how you can
set up your own
a virtual your own Library hosted on
GitHub and use that import that into
whatever notebooks you want so you know
as we get through this course you know
you see the mechanics of setting it up
and then you'll learn how to set up all
these things
but for now
I just have the comments here you know
install requests here's the library
and when we run this then it will get
the library
take it uh
as as a new file locally here uh behind
the scenes we won't have to worry about
it
and it's imported
there we go
and this last thing
says that yes it works and so we will go
on to the next step
there we go and remember
the runtime run uh it times out you know
12 hours
consecutively at the most or about a
half hour of inactivity so you just just
get in the habit if you know working on
part of this you leave come back
then you go and run this first cell
again
so we were looking a lot of into
graphing before now we're going to graph
inequalities
so
when I have let's say Y is greater than
or equal to 2x well if I have
then if I I can graph a line but how do
I shade that well we have this argument
here fill between
and so it gives us a range of values so
we're going to go here import matplot
library and import numpy like we were
doing before
and we're going to
set our window like we were doing before
how many points you know numpy dot Lin
space
give our points setting up the graph all
this is very similar
this one got a little fancy put a title
on there
so we have the plot title
y1 just like we would do before
supposing I was graphing this just as a
line
we see all the similarities
there we go here's the code change and
remember
this
um
we have
plot these two and then we have this
third argument
so it if you're working through this
and remember you know this if you're
watching this video maybe hopefully you
already did work through this so this is
going through
um you know double checking anything you
did or if you want any uh deeper insight
about this
but then we have the second arguments or
the fill between
so
this one notice
we have here
um you see it's fill between
so we still have one x value and the Y
values are what we're between so between
y1 and 0.
and I'm just going to run this to show
you
you see it fills between y1 and 0.
so
that doesn't matter you know that's not
a consistent you know over on the left
here zero is up top and over on the
right it's down to zero
but
thinking about the top of the graph
oh what if I just change that to if I
want to shade above what if I change
that to Y Max
without the caps
and
then we're always shading above between
that line and the maximum y value
so you see then shade below you can
change it to Y min
and there we go
and when we do that there we go Code
test passed
so
part two
well we had this one is a nice solid
line and remember then that's greater
than or equal to
um
but
what if I wanted
you know not that solid line so we have
all the rest of the same things here
we know the logic of this
so now if I have y Min now that's going
to change you know to shade below
and this is the only thing we're going
to change
if I have this remember the default
gives me a line until I do the fill
between
but what if I wanted this
to be
a dotted line
so we see
it'll
um see if I have B
Ash Dash
um R dash dash gives it a dotted Red
Line
and we
run this
so now we see and sometimes I'll do that
I'll make the line red so that it really
stands out if I'm either blue just blend
in
so now we know this would be less than
but not equal to
and there we go
yes and knowing now that we can make
some lines you can Define these lines
we can make R for example we can
do that fill between and we can fill
between two different graphs two
different functions oh that might be
interesting
then
this defaulted to notice I didn't even
Define the color blue here
but I can Define that face color what
color do I want to do I want to make
this
so
if you know like a lot of your basic
colors you actually can just get away
with just putting that you know I want
to be green put it in Green in quotes
single quotes yellow
a lot of the common color names this
will work out
um
so that'll work so
the directions here would be run the
code and then reverse the order
so we see
here
like before here's the graph
is the line we're plotting
and remember we defined
the x value up here once
so here's this y value plot this I'm not
worried about making a particular line
so two arguments are fine
and now I have the fill between
and see what I have X y1 and between
that and 10.
or I could just easily make it you know
why Max but that's fine
and then I add the other argument
face color red
line two I have this
and fill between now notice between Y2
and y1
so you know we can always Define it as
you know between other values that's
this is this will come up especially if
you want to make art you can Define your
lines and then fill between these lines
I mean this is really vector graphics
so then change this you know we have
this color
and same thing all these
you know this line Y3 and I'm going to
fill between Y3 and Y2
next one y four notice that function so
between y four and Y3
and so when we run this
either that first one it filled between
there up to the top
and then I did not decide to have
another one to fill down to the bottom
we just left it here
so if we take this and reverse the
colors
so we're just going to take these face
colors and make the first one blue
there we go
and
we'll reverse some blue green yellow and
then red at the end
so the next one will be green
and the next one will be yellow
and the next one will be red
there we go so now we have this
and we see when we run it it reverse the
colors
so there we go interesting things you
can do and if you were making our you
could make these whatever
formulas you want remember you know we
were looking at all the different you
know quadratic you know uh exponential
functions so if you want different
curved lines and you can just Define
that you want it to be between something
and something
and
or I Define this Lin space here once
so that's the reason why all these go to
the edge but you could always for each
of them you could Define
lines you can Define that Lin space as
within certain values
and you can make all kinds of shapes and
then continuing on what we're doing with
other graphing I kept these axis lines
but you could always eliminate them too
there we go you just
change keep your window size but then
you could always eliminate each axis
again you can get creative with this
make some different art
all right and now we get into
looking further into factoring into
representing equations so monomial is
one thing uh we see that mono is one and
then it actually overlaps
nom
his name
that exact word is name in some
languages and then IAL just makes it a
noun
so one thing one term so each term
has
a sign
coefficient n variable
and an exponent we don't think about
that all the time
but
when we see it here definitely I see a
negative sign I see the coefficients
three
x to the second power so but if I have
you know all of these
um
the term X also has that
so this is positive One X to the first
power
just things to think about because that
really comes into play for some other
things that we do with factoring
Etc
um even even a constant
like five is five to the zero five five
x to the zero because x to the zero is
one
and this will help us you know in
thinking about each of these
you can have a monomial and just make
sure that you define each of these even
though sometimes these values might be
one or zero and you might not display
them
so
here we have this now this is just a
very interesting within Senpai we have
EQ which is going to display the
equation
and you see how this equation
is EQ and then in parentheses I'm going
to have
what's on the left
and then what's on the right
so I Define it as an equation and left
and right just gets separated by a comma
so you see what we have here
so
just showing you that this is one way
you could
you could use this within senpai
for some other things that you might
have been doing in in other parts of
this course
you know if you wanted to make sure you
have a nice display at the end you know
bring up EQ
you know use your variables that you
already have and you see we just defined
X as the as the symbol here
so we could do this and then just
display it and then look at that nice
display
there we go
and so we have monomials one thing
binomial the is2
trinomial
is three and after that we kind of stop
counting so polynomial is just many poly
is many
and we'll usually put them in order
so we take X as the variable we'll put
them in order of the highest exponent
and if we want to graph this then it
would be all that equal to y
so there we go here's your example
and it continued on to the next line
so what I can do is if if I know this
like this is the normal standard
standard form setup so you could prompt
for each of these coefficients
and
then display them and so there's what we
have here that's what I'm asking you to
do so
we're going to use this display
and
we're also going to use some math
we're also going to import everything
from Senpai so now we have these symbols
and we want a coefficient and yes I do
want to cast it as an integer
though I mean realistically the
coefficients do not have to be integers
so there's our coefficient and
A and B
continue to prompt for variable C and D
so what you can do is you can copy this
and
make this C input coefficient
C
and then we'll do
for d
input coefficient d
all right so we've done that
and now we want to display the full one
so we have we're going to display
ax to the Third
BX squared
and then
redo the rest Plus
C
X
plus d and notice
we you might have remember this from
before yeah in in writing the math
I just put these right next to each
other a x means I'm multiplying but
remember the python notation I have to
put that multiplying in there
so it is ax to the third BX squared CX
d
there we go now we have this this is
great we have this in Python notation
and
we were just talking about we want to
display this in a nice way oh well I
have to convert that to latex which is
really the
way we're going to you know to display
math
terminal math formulas
um so now we have this
I'm going to convert that python to
there you go so if we have this to
three
for
four and five
so
we see we can take this
and convert it that way you have all
this for things you know we're thinking
ahead we're building things that you can
use
uh you have all this that once you bring
in these coefficients you could do other
math to this here
and then maybe at the very end
display
this this formula in a nice way
so there we go that's what we have
and yes that does look nice
so this is
going through so interactive polynomial
so now we're going to take this
you know here's well quadratic but there
we go and given this polynomial
we're going to adjust each of these
coefficients
so again in doing this this uh
certification notebook you should see
that this is coming up you know
um things that you've done before and
hopefully you've already worked through
this and you know maybe there's just
some of these that you were stuck on or
if you forgot
so remember we were doing before
um matplot Library inline and we're
gonna
bring in the interactive from the
widgets uh there we go all these things
and remember these the function
of a b and so for this one
we're going to change to include a third
slider
so
there we go so my function needs to
include C
because I I need these three inputs
great
and then
all the rest of these are fine ax
squared plus BX I have to add this
plus c
and so that will show the plot
and then we want to make all these
interactive so
I'm going to run this function a B I
just need c
so we can just copy that comma
C
so now we will have three sliders a b
and c and we
have the interactive and then we're
going to display
the interactive plot
so there we go so that that's how we can
and you see how
you know using the same thing you can
modify this to have four coefficients
so now we see n it looks like nothing
because everything's zeroed out but as
soon as a gets to be something
then we have a quadratic you know
negative
all right so that's nice
and then we have B
and it's always interesting to move
these and see what this does to the
graph
so you can Tinker with this
and see
remember that just moves it
up
or down
there we go so you can take these and
you can Tinker with you know once you
have this I mean Code test pass but
these notebooks you can always Tinker
with these you know you pass tests you
know you've learned that step you can go
back in there and
fool around with these sliders and see
see what it looks like
so now we're going to do exponential
functions
and remember our exponential function
y equals a times B to the x
and
there we go as long as a is greater than
zero
then
we'll have an upward uh or as long as a
is greater than one it'll curve upward
and same thing as long as B is greater
than one will curve upward
all right so
because thinking about some of the
exponential functions
the uh so what we're going to do is
we're going to run this code see the
sliders
and then change the slider so that a
actually does have negative values
instead of positive so here we have all
these importing
same Imports and notice I made a y
minimum and Y maximum a lot bigger
things grow exponentially so
kind of need this to display a decent
graph
here we just have a and b and you see
one to nine we just want them to be
positive
so when we run this we're just going to
see what this looks like
there we go and
either one
you see as I increase this
it gets to be steeper
but we see the general shape of this
it just gets to be steeper and then if I
change a
I'll even make this low because it'll it
still will be positive
so that's that's really all these
you know they kind of do the same thing
maybe B has a little more of an effect
but then you see it's kind of that same
upwards upward curve
and then as
the X values get Negative this really
doesn't touch it's you know you can get
it's beyond what the resolution of any
computer screen could do because if you
keep zooming in
you know it looks like it doesn't touch
and then it looks like it does but if
you zoom in then it doesn't
so you know that's the general Trend so
if we make this negative
then
we still need to do one more thing
because this interactive graph takes
this range as lowest to highest so
making it negative negative one is not
the lowest we have to switch these
negative nine is the low value and
negative one is the high value remember
because it's more negative so if we
don't switch those also then we would
get an error so we get this and we can
run this and we see just making the a
value negative
would
make the whole graph go below the y-axis
because B to the X would be positive
still so then a being negative
there you go it just flips it
and just a note making B negative I'm
not going to even worry about doing this
right now but if we did that
it works for integer values of the
exponent but since this is a continuous
graph
it'll be integer it would be work it
would work and it would be you know
positive if it's an even exponent
negative if it's an odd exponent and it
would go up and down like that but all
those in between values because that
would
be mathematically doable also
in this case they would actually be
imaginary they wouldn't they would not
necessarily work out well
um sometimes if we had you know some of
them would and it would just be a mess
so we're not we're not even going to
mess with that uh changing B to negative
it just really it would end up not
displaying anything but behind the
scenes that's what's happening
it works out for some values but doesn't
work out nicely for others and
you know your graph would be a mess
but let's look at stuff that does work
out nicely percent increase
so
hopefully you remember the formula from
working through it uh in the previous
unit
but then we have you know all the
percent increase and if I were to graph
this so we have a equals P times 1 plus
r to the T
and a is annuity and that would be the Y
value if you were graphing this
and you wouldn't know p and you would
know R so T would be time in years but
that would be the x value if you were
graphing it
and so we have all this yes p is the
principal the amount you start out with
r is the rate
converted to a decimal
and T is time in years
and
just the way we often see it P usually
is capitalized so just interesting in in
my variables I kept them all lower case
but a lot of times you'll see that
written you know they're lowercase but P
gets capitalized
um
all right so you have your starting
amount so you can prompt for these and
then
you not have to worry about changing the
code but we are going to change this
here
so you can prompt starting amount as
input and converting all these to float
numbers
percentage rate converted to decimal and
how many years
that'll be T so we're just going to take
this equation and put it down here in
Python terms so we have P which we would
have gotten from here
so p
times and remember I have to put the
times the multiplication in times 1 plus
the rate
and all that to the exponent of time
and there we go just translating that
equation to
to python
and then we'll print out the annuity
so when we run it starting about
one thousand
just pick these nice even numbers all
right and we have .05
as the rate so that'd be five percent
and how many years
then let's see uh
let's say like seven years all right
and I didn't worry about putting in
another function around this but you
probably would but there you go
to two decimal places this is what what
the annuity would be a thousand dollars
at five percent for seven years
and then we have percent decrease
very similar formula except notice we're
subtracting inside the parentheses
because it's one minus three
and this does this does happen we have
car value values of cars or some other
products that might decrease at a
certain percentage rate every year
um the decay of some elements so that
radioactive decay there's certain
elements like carbon 14 that are very
predictable so that decays at a definite
rate
knowing how much that we can measure how
much that is we can figure out the
the age of something
some sales discounts maybe there's
something that decreases at a percentage
you know every week if it's not sold so
you have some applications of this
and notice we're going to do same thing
prompt for PR and T
and then we'll put our formula in here
very similar P times and then in
parenthesis 1 minus r
close the parentheses exponent t
so there we go
and we see you know uh the Jupiter
notebook the collab notebook always
wants to give us tool tips and advice on
what variable and everything
so there we go we have this and
we'll run it
all right so there you go so let's just
say I had my you know 20
000 car
that
uh decreases at .09 which might be
the you know rate of decrease who knows
um
and then uh how many years will decrease
you know let's just say 10.
so there you go that 20 000 car twenty
thousand dollar car
average uh rate of decrease depreciation
um is nine percent so it loses nine
percent of its value every year for 10
years so then 10 years later that car is
worth seventy seven hundred dollars
77.88
that might be the case I mean
you know this is not uh don't quote me
on on this rate but you know we're for
the sake of practicing that that rate's
probably realistic
all right so now we have compound
interest which is very much like the
percent increase
but we're taking it
you know we could use compound interest
we could use that formula before
if it's compounded once a year
so now we have this formula
notice how similar it is but it's r
divided by n and then the exponent is NT
so if it was compounded once per year n
is one so that doesn't that goes back to
that formula we were just using
but
where n is multiple times per year
you know this is the formula that we
would use
and remember that's that's really and
that's why we wanted for any percent
increase
that's why we wanted to convert it to
that formula
that it's something that's a multiplier
and we can then easily
adjust this for
um how many years something you know
increases or decreases and
in this case now we had the other twist
heifer also then for how many times we
are calculating this every year I mean n
being 12 that's pretty common you know a
lot of banks a lot of bills you know
they calculate things you know once a
month
so we're going to do all these starting
about all the rest
very similar and then we're going to add
this line here and
number of times compounded
so using this formula
then we'll do p times and in parentheses
one plus but now I have R Over N I'd
rather use extra parentheses just to
make sure that nothing gets mixed up in
the math uh r divided by n
and all that to the
so
you see R Over N in the extra
parenthesis to the NT but again just to
be sure I'll put that in parentheses
n times T in parentheses
so that way
it stays together that python doesn't
act it python might not but I want to
make sure it doesn't accidentally take
it to the N power and then
you know we'll then multiply by T so
there we go
P times 1 plus r Over N to the NT
and that's going to give us our annuity
so
um just to be interesting let's use the
same one we did uh two steps ago that
one thousand dollars
uh converted to a decimal and we're
saying that that was at five percent
0.05
and we said seven years
and and 12 is pretty common but I'm
going to say 52 let's say it was
compounded
every every week all year
so
what do we get 14 18 and 82 cents
and let's just quick go back and compare
this
to our
increase
1407 and 10 cents
so look at that just that little amount
of money made us another eleven dollars
because it was compounded that often
um
it's a little bit more because
you have that little bit extra Advantage
this is money growing and then
that little bit extra percent for that
little bit more time
you know it gets you a few more dollars
so you might be thinking well okay
52 then maybe 365 would give you a
little bit more
that's true and we can just quick do
that
so remember that was 1418
and if we did this so that same thousand
dollars
uh percent we're going to do the same
0.05
the same seven years but then this is
going to be 365.
compounded every day
so you see
14 19. give you another dollar
so compared to once a year you know you
made about 11 more dollars
doing this every week but from every
week to every day you know give you one
more dollar
so there there is a point to where it
doesn't really
get you that much more and then we start
thinking about well okay can I compound
it multiple times per day
Etc that's when we get into continuous
growth
and continuous growth if I use that
formula and then
compounded it multiple times a day if I
compounded that like three times a day
and who knows maybe I'll just make could
even make n like an even thousand
it starts approaching this other formula
for continuous growth
so to recap so there you go that's
you know money compounding annually
so that's the percent increase but we
take it as annually
and then
n times per year we have this formula
and then as n gets to be really big like
I said like a thousand or something it
actually approaches this other formula
p e to the RT and this is useful because
as we see later
um better ways to even figure out what
the rate or the time would be if I know
these other values so it goes from this
a little more complicated to
I actually think this is a little bit
easier formula
P times e to the RT and that e is not
just a random variable e is this
constant
equal to about 2.718281828
that 1828
after looping through that twice
the next time it's not exact
so it's not just like this you know
keeps repeating that would make it even
easier but it actually after that second
time then it's a little bit different
okay so we give the code that we're
already going to prompt for these and
this time
we're going to add one more import
statement we're going to import math so
that we can use math.e
you know you don't have to worry about
typing in this because actually math.e
is going to take it to even more decimal
places
so we have the same thing here principal
rate time and
um
there you go time
and that can be an integer that doesn't
have to be it can be an integer or a
float
um
n is going to be an integer because you
can you can't like maybe you know how
many times did you compound it you can't
say like oh one time I kind of like
halfway did it that doesn't work
okay so now we're going to use these
um these same formulas we did before
annual
so that's going to be P times
up times
1 plus r exponent T just like that first
Formula and then this one is going to be
P times
1 plus
the extra parenthesis
R over n
all that to the exponent
of
NT
so these are those two formulas and now
this one
we're going to use math.e
so that's going to be P times
math dot e
to the exponent of
r
times t
so there we go we see
p e to the RT
and now we have these three so we can
prompt and let's con let's compare these
compounded annually
compounded end times per year
um
I'm going to put an extra space in there
and compounded continuously
so
let's take something here and let's just
say uh principle of
there we go
um 11
rate point zero six
and time and let's just say you know 15
years
and and we only need that for one of
those formulas but let's say N is a
normal 12.
so
given this compounded annually you would
have this much 2632
compounded 12 times a year look at 26
so
wow that made you know more than 630
more dollars just by compounding it but
look at that
compounded continuously
twenty seven thousand
oh 55.
so
there we go
um
yeah
so you see from here from once a year to
multiple times we're talking about
making you know more than 600
but then from that to compounding
continuously you know compared to the
original it you know we're up to about
700 more and it kind of evens out that
oh
and
this one
I think I
it gave this error
because I use the parentheses so if
you're going through this and if you
know you know these errors methods are
supposed to be hints just to help you
out so it was without the parentheses
and that is okay because python does
know order of operations but
without the parentheses
it should give us not the error
so there we go and should give us the
same same values here so 11
000 rate 0.06
times 15
years
and and we said it was 12.
so we see same values and
the error message saying you know
um
maybe I'll go in and change that that
the parentheses are okay
all right so
there we go
prompting once and comparing these three
different ways of calculating interest
so now some of this comes in
where we have
you know some investment here
and investment often you know something
you might be contributing to for
retirement
and you have
some accumulated value
so
we have any of these formulas but we
also contribute money every month
and this I will say month monthly that's
that's kind of a normal normal thing so
I'm not going to worry about like all
the different values that that could be
okay so we have something that's going
to increase by a percentage and
we're using just that simple interest
formula interest equals principal times
rate times time
so that is just simple interest but for
one month that works out
and for one month T equals 1 over 12
because time time in years but then
over 12 you can just divide by 12.
so here
if I have this we can set up a loop here
so
um PRT but then monthly
we're going to ask for the monthly
contribution
all right
now this
annuity at the beginning it is p what do
you have I have this I have this amount
done
so
we'll keep that but it's the it's the
annuity variable that we're going to
keep updating
so somebody said time in years
so then
our Loop is going to be 12 times t
so monthly contributions for this law
for a in range 12 t
and now
let's see we're just going to say first
of all the annuity equals annuity plus
monthly
all right so now that annuity value is
greater
and then now we want the interest just
the interest
so that's why simple interest is just
the interest equals
um
annuity
which is the times rate
time and then times 1 over 12 and I'm
just going to say divided by 12.
so we see
that
in principal times rate times time and
then 1 12 is divided by 12. so now we
have just the interest and now again I'm
going to update annuity annuity equals
annuity plus interest
and because I'm making this a loop then
uh you know these other formulas are
useful for not having to do a loop but
we also wanted to add in this
contribution
and then there we go so you know we have
a few things going on in this Loop and
then after all the loop it's going to go
through and each time you know
add the contribution increase it by that
percentage for that little bit of time
you know now update annuity
and keep going
so when we have this
so starting amount maybe we can say five
thousand
and annual percentage rate let's be
optimistic for you know some uh you know
retirement account 0.08
and then number of years but then these
are some of the things you might
contribute and then have it uh grow for
years so
we can even take some like long amount
of time 35 years there we go
monthly contribution so
let's say like 400
. there we go so that's that's what we
have if you start out and then
every month you're contributing 400 and
it you know we hope it's growing at that
rate
so given this
notice
how notice what this number is that's a
million dollars so what this is saying
is
and to get some of these the the rate it
it changes that's that's a good estimate
but um
it's a reason a very reasonable estimate
so putting money away you know
start working
put five thousand dollars away
and some good account grows eight
percent for 35 years and
then each you know each each paycheck
you're contributing contributing money
then you retire with a million dollars
there you go
things to think about
that you can
put away this little bit
forget about it for 35 years we'll not
forget but you know and
you know have this because if it's
earning if it still is earning eight
percent as a good estimate eight percent
of that million is eighty thousand
dollars and that way you know eighty
thousand dollars interest you can live
on that
and it still has the million dollars
there to keep generating more interest
so there you go
okay so we go from the positive saving
money and having a million when you
retire to mortgage payments and yes more
um like the word for death
um somebody who originally coined that
as you know like this death payment
um but nonetheless mortgage for any
large amount of money over a long period
of time those other percent increase
formulas won't quite do it
otherwise you you will end up paying a
lot more than is reasonable
so this is the much more complicated
formula
but remember that's the value of you
know setting these up and writing the
code that you you don't have to like
remember this formula or you know plug
the numbers in every time you can again
prompt for just like we were doing
before PR and T
and figure out what your monthly payment
would be
so given that some lar some huge amount
of money and how banks will set up your
mortgage that's
um something else but
knowing how much you're going to borrow
and then
being able to just run it through this
formula and figure out what would your
monthly payment be
that's going to be very useful
you and again this applies to mortgage
or possibly car payments because that's
also
a large enough sum and a long enough
time that
this is a much better formula so this is
the formula and again p is principal R's
rate T is time and this would have n
there but n would be 12.
each time so I just put 12 in there
so it kind of goes along with that
formula but n is 12 each time
you know there's no other
setup you know more daily or weekly
mortgage payments or yearly no it's
always monthly
all right there we go so we have all
these so
now
I gave you a hint to do this use other
variables
um I like other variables
because look at this R over 12
um
comes up a few times
so
you know we can make this
um
there you go R over 12 is uh
you know multiplier or if you don't want
to use other variables you can do this
um
there we go and since I don't have n
because n is 12.
um
I could have
I might have like just like math n for
numerator and D for denominator
and so the payment would be n divided by
D
because that just might simplify this a
little bit
um
and then it would be P times n divided
by D so I could have just my numerator
so equals
R over 12.
times
and then in parentheses
1 over
R over 12.
oh
one oh sorry one
plus r over 12.
and all that
to the exponent
in parentheses 12 times t
so R over 12 times 1 plus r over 12 to
the exponent 12T
there we go so that's the numerator not
bad
and then I can have the denominator
equals
so one
Plus
R over 12.
there we go to the exponent
I'll put this in parenthesis 12
t
and now when I subtract 1
you see then that's definitely not a
part of that
so yeah and again you could add other
variables you could make R over 12 its
own variable or something like that you
could make one plus r over 12.
its own variable
you know different ways to do that I
feel I felt like this wasn't that bad so
but breaking up numerator denominator
and then payment times numerator over
denominator
so
we take a look at this and the amount
borrowed we could just say like 200
annual percentage rate point zero
um seven
you know some of the rates have been
going up so I'm just going to say that
for now
and number of years 30 is pretty common
and so there we go so
13 30 and change and this helps because
then you say okay well
you know what's the cost of the house
and I have a down payment you know you
get down to how much you're borrowing
that's one thing okay but what's really
going to make the difference is knowing
this what would your monthly payment be
that's the important thing
um and you know bonus knowledge
that no matter whatever your income is
the monthly payment should be for
mortgage or rent right it should be
one-fourth of your income or less
so just remember you know
um
if that's your monthly payment
then each month you should be making at
least four times that
or if you're not then that's not the
right house because sometimes you might
say oh yeah I'm making more than that I
can afford it but then you end up being
house poor yeah so you can afford your
your mortgage payment but you can't
afford much else
all right so let's go on to exponents
and logarithms with exponents and
logarithms
their inverse functions they're the same
information uh rearranged so I have this
example here
2 to the fourth power equals 16.
so there you have two base two the
fourth power equals 16 and then the log
base 2 of 16 equals 4.
there we go both of those have the same
information rearranged
and that's what logarithms are
you know picture everything on the one
side of the equal sign oh 2 to the
fourth power I know how to do that
plug that into the calculator but
supposing it's the exponent you don't
know
the log base 2 of 16. the answer is an
exponent you know what exponent gets me
to that
so
uh this guy John Napier like 400 years
ago he realized that that was a missing
piece that that was a situation a lot of
people
wanted to know the exponent for
different things and he spent like 20
years of his life developing this
and it was you know
very useful you know the original
logarithms it was just books you could
like look them up and now we have this
at the benefit of you know calculator
pretty easy and we're going to take it
one more we're going to even write the
code that you can just
um put in a couple numbers and it'll
calculate it
so
if you use the math Library
and we'll also look at the numpy library
um it's another way but if you use the
math Library so it's math.log
and then the arguments are you know the
log of what so 16 and then comma and
then what's the base
so there we go and if you don't have
that first argument or if you don't have
the second argument if you just say the
log of 16 it takes it as base e but
we'll get to that later all right so
there we go the log base 2 of 16.
so here's the code we're going to import
math
and
you know face I always call the the
exponent the result
um
just because it reminds me I'm doing a
logger and that's what I want
so there we go so or you know that's the
the result of
exponential notation so
ask somebody to input the base
and we're going to input cast as a float
and the bass can be a float but usually
it's an integer
and the result
and cast that as a float so
what do we want to do change the next
line okay math
DOT log
and we were just saying result comma
base
there we go and it'll import this for it
and it'll do this for you so that's all
you needed to do for this and we'll run
it
and this should check it for you there
we go base
um 27 oh how about this base
um three
uh result 81
so
it should return four there we go
nice you might be able to do some of
these in your head but if you have
you know base you know three to what
exponent gives you 81. all right you can
do that in your head that's four but
this is useful three to what exponent
gets you like 80 or it gets you 85 you
know when it becomes some weird decimal
all right so natural logs
and we talked about e
so uh
this is the this is another use of the
logarithm so e
and uh just to recap
if you have this formula
um annuity equals p e to the RT
there we go so supposing I want to know
how long it will take for something to
double
and you'll see the logarithm connection
here so
you know whatever I start out with P the
annuity needs to be double so
if the annuity is double then whatever p
is an annuity is twice then I could
cancel it out you know annuity would be
2p so it simplifies to this
and then now one of the many situations
I want to know the exponent
well I have base e so math terms I would
say natural log I do the natural log of
both sides a natural log of 2 on the
left and the natural log of e to the RT
and remember then that cancels the
natural log of e to the RT because that
says e the natural log says e to what
exponent gets me this so e to what
exponent gets me e to the RT well it's
obviously RT
so now we're in this situation we do not
take the natural log of both eyes now
we're in this situation and I get
natural log of 2. good thing I have
a calculator to do this and then if I
want to know how long it takes to double
if I know the rate
then
I would just divide by the rate and then
my answer is time
so in doing that
math.log and you see no other argument
necessary if I don't put the argument as
far as what base it is it takes it as
base e natural law so there we go
and in this one R and put the rate as a
decimal
and
for this one I just put the N just it's
this seemed like a long sentence so the
input comes in as a new lot on a new
line and once the person input the rate
there we go it's just math DOT log of 2
divided by R is time
and we'll print out it will double in t
years
this is pretty useful so
you can run this now this one remember
you just needed to run it
um
so and put the rate so
if
let's say I have some investment growing
at eight percent
and it will double in 8.66 years
so
some of the you know you might say all
right if my investment is growing at
eight percent
and we can even round this down to eight
and a half and you can do things in your
head okay well eight and a half years
it'll double
17 years it'll double from that you know
Etc
and you know you could use this to
estimate some outcomes
all right common logs
so if I have base 10 it's the common log
if you were writing this in math
notation you would just you could just
say log
so uh
with without the little number
because then you know if you don't put
the little number then oh we'll take it
as base 10 because that's our number
system the common log
so this is what we're going to be using
when we want to have you know how many
decimal places do I have or using things
for scientific notation
so
in the code
you see we'll just do math.log n and
then base 10.
so you see
uh if I don't say the base it's e but 10
even though it's common I do have to say
the base
there we go so if we have this and our
number with several digits or several
decimal places
and
this one I just separated into two lines
to show you you can do that also take
the input
um
you know cast it as n the other reason
to put this into two lines is you might
notice this vertical line over here
maybe even before writing python you
know you might have the sense of you
know you only want the lines to be so
long you don't have to scroll over but
python really makes that a design
um decision if I continued Beyond this
line it would still work it wouldn't
just cut off that code but
just as a convention for writing python
code we usually make it I think it's
like 80 characters brings it over to
that line
so
there we go I have this one and then I
didn't want to go further on that line
so I just made it a separate line
casting that as a float
okay so now
all right now we have the
um round the code so
this one
we have
math.floor so I'm going to take the log
of that
but
I'm not gonna
um
round
oops
but instead of run I'm just taking the
floor of this because
I don't want the decimals I don't I
don't want to potentially round it up
and I will just you know drop the
decimals math dot floor
that's going to give me my exponent and
that's actually what what we really want
and
this is a weird python Quirk when the
exponent's exactly three
it sometimes doesn't give you the answer
you want I don't know it's just weird
python Quirk so
just bonus Insight here after doing this
enough times I just added this little if
statement here
um
all right
and we're going to print the exponent
so when we run it
we go several digits so if I have point
you know
zero zero
zero
five all right and
exponent is negative four
yep
there we go and if we remove the math.4
function
then it will just give us it'll be
you know negative four point something
else
and we'll just do that
there we go
so you can see and I'll just to compare
I'll do the same number .0005
all right
and that's it
um now notice
in positive numbers
it would be four point something or
three if this was positive three point
something and it would drop the decimals
and be down to three but with negative
numbers the floor from negative three
point something the floor of that is
negative four so just
interesting insight and again you're
watching this video because if you've
gone through the
the
um
foundational math three and maybe you're
stuck on something you're one or you
want some other insight into some of
these so hopefully you know this helps
all right now all that you know we can
use these logarithms you know how long
to take something to double
um
you know things like this uh number of
decimal places and notice I call that
exp for exponent because
um well first of all that's what we're
asking for in the logarithm but also
that leads to scientific notation
you know how can I write very big
numbers or very small numbers without
all those zeros so if I had like 45
million oh but I can write that as 4.5
times 10 to the seventh
or 0.000 all these
could be 4.5 times 10 to the negative
seventh
and there we go so it's always n times
10 to an exponent and N is always one
digit then the decimal
so that that's what we want you know
um
because 4.5 that's I want that one digit
then the decimal that that's the true
scientific notation
now this
is
just changing
um
you know this one here we're not
actually writing code this is determine
the value by just by Counting
uh
I just want you know just to see so you
know as we count so how many decimal
place how many places one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
because it has to be down to this so
that's why we have A1 is 1.56 that's
where the decimal would go and A2 would
be 11.
and then we're going to print that out a
that that is A1
times 10 to
A2
so then we'll do this for here
so the decimal point would be there
so then
if yeah so then we would move it one two
three four five six seven eight nine
ten
so it would be 4.13
and we have to move it in the negative
Direction so it'd be to the negative 10.
and so then that would print B is 4.13
times 10 to the negative 10.
there we go
and we run it
now
this one works
displays nicely
this one
how we want to display it here is nice
but python automatically and this is
fine you know you go on the next
template python automatically converted
this one a positive 11th power fine it
didn't see a reason to change that but
negative 10 so that's the python
notation 4.13 e negative 10.
so and this is not the same e this is
just indicating exponent so times 10 to
the negative 10.
so there we go in in this you know
hopefully also again if you're watching
this it's you know illustrating like why
there's some of these quirks
in in Python
all right so we can use these logs for
scientific notation
because if I want you know if I want to
convert this to scientific notation in
an easy way
so what do I do so
I did this for
for a
um
putting together the things we did in
the last two exercises
so
for a I'm going to do the floor
of the log
of a base 10.
there we go
and
now
I'm going to round it so
so if it was a I called it X1 for
exponent one
and so
if I have this a times 10
to the negative X1
um
and it rounds it to two decimal places
so if that's the if that's the log then
I'm going to multiply this times 10 to
the negative X1 and it's going to print
this out
so
I'll just show you the code and then
we'll run it and you'll see so now using
that as a model what I want X2 and I
want to show you that this actually
works for
positive or negative exponents
yeah
so if we have
so but this one I want this for B
so
take the log of B base 10
and the floor of that
and if I have this
then I'm going to round that so I'm
going to round that
um
again referencing B this time
to negative
X2
there we go so
it's what exponent got me there but then
when I take that
then
that will divide it out that's why it's
that's why it becomes a negative
exponent because I want to divide it out
to get that
early number there
all right
so
if we run this
and this just took those
so you see we get
a is 2.34 times 10 to the negative 12.
and B is 1.23 times 10 to the 13th
so pretty cool how you could just take
this and whether I wanted to show you
that whether it be
a decimal so a negative exponent or a
huge number with a positive exponent
either way this this works take the log
base 10 and the floor of that
and that's the negative exponent that's
how we get
N1
you know then we're
then multiplying it by that
and we can display so this way
now you have it you can have a code to
convert anything to scientific notation
pretty cool
and that's what we get into step 19.
there we go
now this one very similar to what we
were doing before
and we're just added one more thing of
entering a number to convert to
scientific notation so see this is where
you can make it as your calculator
to uh
convert because I'll just take this
and
it works either way
I'll copy this code that we had from
before
and
paste it here
but
I don't need the number ones because I'm
only doing one thing
and in that case
if we want to print you see I even left
this
that's we want to print
so we can reuse this and this is the key
with copying and reusing code
you can do it just be aware notice these
little things
if you just copy and paste something
there might be little subtle things that
don't line up
you know just copying pasting no good
you have to understand the code well
enough to know these little things that
you need to change okay I needed to
delete the ones here all around
and
you know copy and paste with the
follow-up editing now that works and see
what you can do is now you have this
as a standalone
uh you know input you didn't have to
like Define the variables in the code
here
and
there you go and you're in whatever
number all right so
um one two three
there we go
one two three
oh that's very weird
two three
I got to 1.23 ah look at this
it
see as I was mentioning it I didn't I
didn't delete the one there and
that variable was still in in memory for
that little bit so it gave me this you
know exponent that I was not expecting
one two three
there we go
all right pretty good so anything that
you have now now we have this Standalone
code and then later on what we're going
to do is and then maybe I'll use this as
an example is we can put all of this
code
within one function
and so then now you can just Define a
function that will convert to scientific
notation and all this code is within
that function and we can take that and
then that function we can use wherever
all right
so let's go on to the next one
now we'll get to graphing exponents and
logarithms so
just connecting with the math natural
log is Ln
um putting the adjective first natural
log if I was just writing it on the on
the board it'd be Ln and that would be
base e
and so comparing y equals e to the x
and Y equals natural log of x those two
are the inverse functions and mirrored
over the line Y equals X so when we see
the graph we'll see these and then we'll
see the line Y equals X
so
we were just talking about using the
math Library if I just want to calculate
a logarithm I'll use math.log
but
because when we graph we're using
numpy and we're using the Lin space
function to create an array of values
that we're going to graph so I have to
keep with numpy which I usually import
as NP so then I'll do np.log
math.log as you see if I want to do one
thing yeah that works if I'm using the
math Library I'll use that here I'm
using np.log
and NP has it slightly different NP
uh
has NP DOT log 10. obviously base 10
np.log 2 for base 2.
and if I just do np.log it's going to be
base e
realistically we don't need to do every
other base because we have the change of
Base formula
which I'll talk about in a second
so there we go so we have the positive X
values now
e to the if I was graphing this e to the
x
I have my all my X values whatever I
want but when I do natural log then the
x value will never be zero because
remember they're inverses so in this
case e to whatever exponent the Y value
will never be zero as the inverse here
the x value will never be zero
so when I graph this
hopefully this looks familiar from other
graphing
we might have done
I'm going to Define this
and I'll just use this minimum maximum
you know based on here what I did here
that's fine
but then
when I do
log I needed I'm going to use a
different Lin space I won't do zero I'll
just pick some like really tiny number
0.001
and that should be enough to illustrate
this point
so there we go all right so I'm graphing
these I'll use X1
is my array of X values and Lin space
goes from minimum to maximum and then
within that range I I want a thousand
points
I mean you'll see for this you'll see a
smooth graph even if you don't have a
thousand points all right there we go
and then plot X1 and I'll just write the
Y value here instead of separating it
out
math.e for my e value and then that to
the to that exponent
there we go and I'll make this a blue
line
so then we have the red line for Y
equals X
then
X1 and we see if I have this X1 I just
can put X1 X1 because it's Y equals X so
I don't need to define a new y value
it's I know it's the same
and here now for my log y equals log of
x
I'll do this Lin space and then
np.log X2
so there we go
all right so we're just going to run
this and then change it
so we see I see this Note 8 notation and
there we go so we have
the Blue Line e to the X exponential
function and
graphing that green line y equals x or y
equals the log of x and
there we go
and this works for any inverse function
there are mirror images across the line
Y equals X but this there you go it
illustrates it nicely all right now
change the blue line and the green line
because we want to make these log base
2.
so here
instead of math.e
I'm going to make this just 2 to the X
you know
that's fine and
this one
instead of np.log I'll NP log 2.
now we're not going to notice that much
of a difference here because
I went from a base of 2.7 to a base of 2
but there we go
that's all you need to do for this one
and I want to include some applications
here if you have the hydrogen
concentration
as a decimal number that's really where
the pH comes in
so
um proportion of hydrogen
so the way this this works it's the
negative log of the hydrogen
concentration
so if we have
.007 at scientific notation that would
be 7 times 10 to the negative 3 which
would be a pH of 3.
and then we see that as we got more and
more zeros as placeholders you know a
really tiny decimal number then
that would be 10 to the negative 4 5 6
you know 10 to the negative 10 you know
really tiny number and that really tiny
number then
10 to the negative 10 would be a pH of
10. you know we get the idea
so that's really it I just just taking
this and if you knew the hydrogen
concentration
I was thinking about adding this in as
like going into the chemistry and
um finding hydrogen concentrations but
I'll I'll leave that for those of you
that want to uh
you know pursue the chemistry angle on
this but you can you could actually get
you know various
uh hydrogen concentrations of molecules
and you know work it out from there
okay but nonetheless so what we want to
do is we just want the hydrogen
concentration
so
it's the negative log and for this one I
will use math
uh
so
there we go so we're going to make this
negative
math Dot
uh log and
I'm going to log as
decimal
10.
there we go so that's that's really and
now that log
I get that number base 10
and what do I want to do I want the
ceiling so I'll do math Dot
ceiling of this
there we go
all right
so there we go when we run this end of
the hydrogen concentration
and what if I put the point zero three
four
and
there you go and I'll put I'll just put
the number five
I could put a one there
uh
math.ciling
yes so
I would take this as
we we look at this and
yeah this is the function here we run
the function as is and then do the
math.cealing so that's what we'll do
we'll move our decimal place
and these are the things that I wanted
to put in here as
you know indications
and
you see
we see why this this end up being wrong
because then he gave a pH of four
putting the math dot ceiling in the
wrong spot
all right so I'll do the same same on
your point
I'll put a one that's okay
there we go now that gives it a pH of 5.
you see how that makes a difference
doing the Formula First
with the negative log then doing the
math.sealing
there we go now that gets a pH of 5.
there we go all right so now with
functions here
calc these are some of the things how
could we write a function well if you
want
um a function
you're going to define the function
um
and
calculating mortgage payments okay so
maybe I'll call it more
pay
and
now notice you would think that it when
I hit enter it gave me the indent
automatically but for other things that
I do or I might use this code I am all
about the four spaces so I backspace I
delete that and then
I want to make sure I do the four spaces
so what can I do I can Define this
function here
so and and this is I'll do one and then
you can see how you can do more here
so if I have the mortgage payment now we
also have our
um
table of contents I can jump right to
mortgage payments
so notice
I have
P R and T here
and then I will Define these
in here
so
I'm going to just copy this and actually
um
there we go so I'm going to show you one
way to do this and then maybe we'll do
it a different way
there we go and more Funk functions here
so one of the things that you can do
is just put everything in here
foreign
probably don't need that extra line
and same here so this works
as
the payment maybe that's all you need
you want to be able to then prompt for
these things and then print out the
answer
so that works another way
um
is
what I'm going to do I'm going to copy
this
and I'm going to show you another
function that you can do
and that one
all right so more pay
PRT
and for this one I'm going to require
input input
p r t
and then
I'm going to not need these
and instead of print
I'm going to return payment
so this one's nice
if that's the if
and yeah there we go so this one's nice
if you wanted to
prompt you know this could this could go
a lot of different places
but this one you can put this in
maybe then just put this function in and
return the payment like exactly where
you know
it's going it's going to go so
yeah two different situations and that's
why you know I'll make it you know PRT
so we know what the input would be
and then this one
is different so there we go so that's
that's one one way
and I have here more functions
um now the interactive polynomial graph
we were working with that too
um I'm going to do one more up here
because I wanted to show you
the scientific notation
so here we have
enter a number to convert to scientific
notation
so
if we have this
uh
maybe we want the number to convert so
if I have a as my variable
so
there's my scientific notation there
really just two lines and
if I take that
and
convert this
I could create a function
to
there we go and maybe it just takes
that input of a
there we go
and
return
n
so that could work too
there we go so we take this and
around
um
oh but I would probably have it as a
string here
so
I could go back to that
and
instead of the print
I could
instead of printing it
functions
I could turn this into
there we go uh
answer
and so we make you know I could just
make that a string and then return
answer
so I probably don't need this
a equals
and
it should
give you n times 10 to the
X
so
just to give you some examples this is
where
I want you to be able to you create the
functions
um and then the internet active graph
with sliders
we we have that so
turn that into a new turn that into a
function
but here here's the examples how you can
just take and and that's the whole thing
that we wanted to get to you know
through this course you're learning
you're practicing and then you're
grabbing the parts that now you know and
you can turn just the important parts
that you're going to use later on into
their own functions
and you can you know give them other
names
you know here's more functions and
there you go uh
create a function for
you know how long it would take money to
double
go back to that other one again turn
that into a function and all of this
is going to be
in a financial app that you'll make so
what you can do is you can have
um One display of
all of these
and you could have this work out that
it's within all the code here
or you could have it within
uh who was in Google collab where you
have text that gives you like number one
calculated mortgage payment number two
retirement account balance number three
Etc
you could have the text there and then
require input which option do you want
and
then have all your functions so that's
that's one way to do it defining all the
functions
having the text input that would be like
the menu and then when you pick your
option then it runs that function
so that's really what I want to get to
is that you're putting all this together
and
it becomes your financial app
so that you can use this for other
things
you know calculating your own finances
and this combined with
what you're doing in certifications one
and two
see now where the goal is that you're
getting to the end of this and you have
understand the math and you have all
these functions at your disposal
you know calculate things graph things
solve problems
and then you can apply that later so
the next unit
which I called week 15 is going to be
the
wrapping up and putting all this
together
so we reached the home stretch in our
algebra Journey here and now we're going
to connect all the different things
we've been doing with math we've been
looking a lot at functions taking things
that turn into lists of X Y
values that we can graph and then now
we're going to look at how we can get
though get that data from the web from
the cloud from a spreadsheet from
wherever and bring that data in whether
it be columns in a table or all sorts of
information and pair it up in those X Y
coordinates and then we can do math to
it so really that's that's the
connection we've been working with all
the math content and now pretty much
everything we're going to be doing
Beyond this
we're going to bring that math content
and into the code and do a lot more code
how can I get this data turn it into a
numpy array and then do whatever graph I
can do and you know analyze the data so
let's let's get to it let's get to the
code
so now this is some ways you can bring
in data from other sources and
graph it and do other things so let's
talk about the other sources pandas is
the library that really deals with data
frames tables columns rows everything
like that so we're going to import
pandas
import the matplot library we've done
that before and we're also going to
import from Google codelab we're going
to import files and that's also going to
give our file operations uh you'll see
that and import i o input output
there we go I separate these out because
you can run these once and you know this
takes a few seconds I already did it so
run it once and that saves you a few
seconds each time because we want to go
through you'll see test some things
now we have all those Imports here's
ways that we can get the files all right
here's one option if you have a CSV on
your computer
you can upload it and because we
imported that Google dialog or the
Google files all right so this is all we
need
um
files.upload and we're going to upload
that you know it'll give you that file
dialogue you can search for it on your
computer and that's what the one you
select will will store that as that
variable uploaded
and then
so I have my file name because we have
this we're going to take that uploaded
file
and iteration so iter and the argument
is uploaded and we're going to go to the
next one and what that is going to do is
just one time
you know you selected a file and we're
going to select that and store it as
file name
and here that file name we know the file
name and we know that it's a CSV so
pandas has this
nice building PD dot read CSV that's
what we want to get to
and don't worry about this it's because
I already stored that as file name you
can use this for you know whatever file
you upload so uploaded file name and it
reads that I O DOT bytes IO and it will
store it as this table
so there we go these three lines
from you know uploading something you
know
give you the file dialog upload it from
your computer
and select it
now
when you run this when you select that
file it's stored as table one
awesome
so
we'll we'll do more stuff with that
table in in a minute here
another way is you can get a CSV from a
URL
so maybe you already know you're looking
at different websites and you found you
know this uh URL and you see this one
um
uh yeah this this guy uh seems to put
put out a few good examples
um so
there we go uh faithful.csv
um
Old Faithful geyser
you know erupts for a little you know
briefly but like on such a regular basis
that's why it's called Old Faithful and
that just might be some interesting data
we can look at
so I'll just store it as this variable
URL which is the exact address pointing
right to the CSV
there you go plenty you could also and I
didn't include this here but you could
also if you wanted to you know make your
own like you know input statement you
know prompt you know for somebody else
using you know you made this program for
somebody else you could prompt somebody
else to just copy and paste the URL and
store it you know that works too but you
know this is your code so you just put
the URL here
stored as variable URL now
same type of thing but here so we have
PD dot because we imported Panda as PD
pd.read CSV and I just need to read that
URL and that's enough and I'll store it
as table one
okay and yes those Imports and
everything that you run
um I just even have notes in here to
remind you so that's good for maybe 20
minutes Google collab will uh have this
run time you're running on their server
and you know collaboratory uh has a run
time once we started this it will time
out after about 30 minutes of inactivity
or
um
even if you're active like you know
let's say you have a really busy day I
think it's like about 12 hours of
running it'll time out you know you
could say well wait I haven't been
inactive but there's still an absolute
timeout and then you have to start it
again
so
that gives that gives you time you can
import that and then it gives you time
to go through and then run a few of
these and Tinker with it
Okay so
that way you don't have to repeat those
steps and again you know importing you
know
importing all those that actually takes
a few seconds to run it
um and then prompting you know if we
want to do some different things and
test some things you don't have to
upload it every time that saves you a
few seconds or this even
so there we go now we have this
what do we want to do with it
um you know I have using the notes we're
going to eventually determine what
columns we want and convert them to
numpy arrays and remember numpy arrays
that's what we're that's what we end up
graphing
so
one of the things and I even still
commented this out but you could display
the whole table
um that might be too much
you know especially the the more you get
into Big Data you know that's that's
going to be just time consuming resource
consuming
and so I I include that in there you
know just to show you can do it but
what else might we want to do I might
just want to print out so we've always
stored everything as table one for this
example so I might just want to print
out the headers
all right so table one dot head and if I
don't put a number in parentheses it
will default to five
but I can put a number in there and it's
going to give me the headings and I put
a two so it's going to be give me the
headings in two rows
that might be enough you want to you
know let's say even if you've seen the
column you might want to see the see it
here or you know you got that URL you
want to take a look at it
I want to see The Heading I want to see
the column names and I want to see two
rows give me an idea of what kind of
data because if I start seeing words in
there then I know that I'm not going to
be able to convert that to a numpy array
all right another way I could just store
column names as a variable because if I
have table one
in pandas that this exists table1.
columns
there you go
so now
this column names is a list of the
column names that's great
um and again I can I only need to do
this once
and now that I have the column names
what can I do with them all right
um instead of printing out the heading I
could
and I just put this here you know new
line
column names and then I could Loop
through them
so
I'll count them so a in range length
column names
so column names I'm going to get the
length
get that as range and then each time
I'll print that number
the space and then that column name
that works that's one way to do it
or another way
I could actually just Loop through those
names call and column names
and just print that each time
so let's see what that looks like
all right and so these are the benefits
here so notice
um this is the first one we did
uh
there we go print table header
and that print statement that head
statement gave me these but this table
also had an index column
and notice their index starts at one so
that's just something to remember
And Eruption length
And Eruption wait time
so there we go
and notice these quotes are within the
with within the name of the call
um you know that's something the more
you get into uh working with data and
maybe other people you know creating
columns and everything I'll tell you
this you really want column names
without extra quotes in them and without
spaces
but you know there's ways to deal with
that we can do this but it just it just
usually makes it easier for this stuff
and for like some of the SQL queries
okay so now I get an idea of what I have
um and here again you see the column
names you know index corruption there we
go
and the the other way we did it index
eruption length ruption wait time
so now that I have these exact column
names
so
you know I could
now
this is how I did it here because I had
them right here and I can see them so
table one and then in those square
brackets I'm going to put the name of
that column I want
and then also that name in single quotes
to numpy
so
um that'll convert that to a numpy array
and then eruption length in minutes so
again
table one and then in the square
brackets and remember that extra space
and those quotes were in there so I need
to make sure I include them and convert
that to an Umpire array
so now I have my X and Y values that I
can that I can plot they're you know
going through each of them you know it's
going to be you know my first value X is
3.6 Y is 779
um X is 1.8 Y is 54.
um oh no actually I had it as index so X
is one y is 3.6 x is 2 Y is 1.8 I can
graph the eruption length
or I can do it for eruption wait times
and I I'd like to go back to the index
again X is 1 Y is 79 x is 2 Y is 54.
so I just graphed it for that first one
and we can go back and
do that for the second one also if you
wanted to
so we have X and Y
because they're numpy arrays I can call
that function x dot min
and
this you know if if you haven't really
looked at like the entire table this
just might be a good way I'll just take
the minimum value minus five because
it's just a little bit of a buffer on
the edge and store that is X Min x max
same thing plus five a little bit of a
buffer
why men
why Max so this goes back to things we
were doing a while ago with graphing set
my X Min x max
and
each of these
now notice I don't have some of the
things we were doing in other other
units we were defining the points here
but I already have my X and Y values
defined as num numpy arrays so
when I graph
I can plot I can plot them here as
you know
X revert first that array y refers to
that array and I can do a scatter plot
or a line graph
so I have these here as numpy arrays and
I can do them as a scatter plot or a
line graph
all right let's see what this looks like
now I had it as both and looks like a
huge mess but one of the things I notice
is
I
don't want the line graph is probably
not useful so I'll just go I'll just
comment that out right now
and run it again
and we see it seems to Cluster it's
around here or around here that's kind
of interesting what if
I change my X my y value maybe I'll keep
all these points but what if I change
this
so what I can do is my y minimum and
these are the things this is what we
want to do now
we know how to use your your math
graphing skills to look at this you know
how to get all this data into this graph
and this is now where we get to the
analysis part what can I do I can
look at this and say all right you know
they're all less than six and they're
all greater well actually they're all
greater than zero so I can just make my
y minimum
zero and I'm just going to comment out
the rest of this
and I can make my y maximum six
and I'll just comment out the rest of
that
and when we see that we might see
it seems like it clusters it's
for whatever reason it's really rare for
it to be around three and remember what
are we graphing here we are graphing the
eruption length time
so it really seems to Cluster around oh
about two minutes or about four minutes
yeah interesting
so
we could look at this and then one of
the other things that we can do now
let's look at another Twist on this
you can use variables for the column
names so remember earlier we
made column names this array so I can
have column name zero column names one
and that's my X name and my y name I'll
make these variables so that also
depending on the actual names of your
columns doing that once might save you
some typing because then you can reuse
that variable
here
just yeah I don't have to worry about
all the quotes every time now
I have
my ex
variable is that column to numpy my y
variable that column just like we were
doing before
but again we're using that variable save
you some typing
I went back to this and we'll see why in
a minute
and I just want to show you that that
same scatter plot back to that those
original dimensions are there but you
see
using that as the column name I can also
set the labels for the graph
and again without having to rewrite
so now we have index And Eruption length
there we go
then if I wanted to talk about the
eruption time
or the erupt the wait time so all the
things that we were doing I can just
change this I still want the index but
then columns one was the eruption length
I'll change that to that was the
wait time
and now I have those names everything
else
stays the same
and again going to different columns
that's why I like
giving the dimensions of the graph based
on that
because
these numbers are very different I'll
still have the same index because they
did match but instead of times between
you know zero and five
I will have you know wait wait time in
minutes you know 40 minutes
up to even you know almost 100 minutes
so
we see that
now again let's get to some analysis
here this looks like a mess it looks
like maybe I have this range of 40
minutes to you know more than 90 minutes
and this is key like let's say this is
in Yellowstone let's say you go to visit
and you say okay how long should I have
to wait it just erupted I want to go do
other things when should I come back
well should I come back in 40 minutes
should I come back in 90 minutes
you know that's a huge range you know
could keep you you know waiting there
almost an hour
but
let's let's start looking at other
patterns here again the default I keep
this index I want to zoom in on some
range here
so I'll go to that index that x value
I'll keep the same minimum but what if I
change that maximum value
instead of that plus five maybe I'll
make it like 50.
and comment out the rest of this
so
that's interesting
um I'm just going to run this
again doesn't help you but it spreads it
out you see
now
instead of a scatter plot
actually I'll keep the scatter plot
because that looks nice but
I'll also make it a line graph and I'll
make the dots red and the line blue
so look at that
and you see that just looks nice
um
and if we don't you know there's my
y-axis at zero but if I don't want that
then I can just make my x x minimum you
know one
that way
and comment that
that way I
don't even get distracted by that
there we go so
we take a look at this
now besides seeing the scatter pot that
was a mess the line graph actually
shows us some interesting things with
very few exceptions
if it was a shorter weight like 50
minutes
the next one's a longer wait closer to
90. and then the next one's a shorter
minute a shorter weight longer weight
you see every so often you get one that
it was another long wait
but we get a shorter weight a longer
weight a shorter weight you know
exception longer weight that happens
most of the time
so what we can do is we could
look at this and say oh well how long
was it last time and then therefore I
can use that to predict
and
we get that from you know we get that
from looking at the graph here
so yeah really interesting I mean you
could probably then now connecting this
to you know real-time data science
doing this then we could
graph you know a certain amount of this
and always you know have another table
that always just updates you know
um
when it erupted and how long that would
require somebody each time you know just
you know maybe even we could get this to
clicking a button okay it erupted it
stopped erupting and then do the
calculations what was the wait time what
was the eruption time
add that new data and
we could be looking at this and doing
some sort of analysis to give people you
know real-time estimates of
it just erupted when can you expect the
next eruption and get it down even
probably to some like you know uh
confidence interval that
you know the point is that you would
want to be able to say instead of should
I get there 50 minutes later or 90
minutes later I want to be able to have
I don't know like a few minutes
um
you know if it just erupted and it was
an 80 minute wait
then
you know would it be
you know 50 minutes so
you get some range that you you know
when to show back up and you know you
don't have to wait too long and that's
really what we want to get this down to
we want to look at these patterns
and
be able to then you know predict the
next one you know that's really the goal
you know if I go to here and I want to
be able to predict and say oh all right
at 50 that was a wait time of 60 minutes
so I'm gonna just predict that the next
wait time is going to be more than 80.
and if we really want we can just change
this to like 55
. so with the wait time of 50 minutes
then the next one wasn't quite 80.
and so that's like your range of well I
wouldn't go I wouldn't wait more than 80
minutes I might wait almost 80 and it
would show up
so there we go
because remember the other graph the
eruption time it's you know
three to five minutes you or two you
know two minutes
and it could be two minutes and you
missed it it could be five minutes
that's not even that long so you don't
want to be you know
five minutes late you're gonna miss it
all
so yeah just interesting we can use this
to predict and again looking at the math
of it we have we you know once you have
those column names
um
so once we have
we we get that table
what once you have that table
and we get table one dot columns we have
those column names and then we can do
other things with that whatever we want
you know
um number of them you know just Loop
through them or then
pick certain ones and
I'll use that as my X and Y
so that's the advantage of then having
the graph minimum maximum
we can try this because we want to make
this template that you're going to have
this and maybe certain things you can
comment out and certain things you keep
in certain things you modify just a
little bit
that what you can use the same code for
whatever graph you have you know
whatever table you have this is a good
start you start getting some analysis
what what am I trying to compare what am
I trying to graph
and then
as you get into it then you can modify
it you know you can always then copy all
this and then you know do in here then
copy all this do a new code cell some
text to give you know yourself or
whoever reads this some uh some notes on
what's going on in this code cell
and you know that that's the beauty of
the collab notebooks you know you don't
have to like you you can delete things
and retry things or you can keep that
and then just you know oh this is this
is interesting information keep that and
then just do a new code cell or new text
and
you know let's do the next next analysis
so here's another way to get data into
collab and then graph it this particular
Library so not a CSV but the full
Library Medio stat it's a lot of weather
data so yes may install need to only
install once right once per one run time
and
I just have this as its own cell there
you go pip install meteostat
to install the library
doing that I mean this actually might
take almost 30 seconds so sometimes that
seems like forever so I already did that
and here we go
um
successfully installed and then we go on
to the next one
and for your own organization or anybody
else working with this you put put in
some text areas here so now I know and
it reminds me what columns I have in
this Library
so time
uh and all the other these other T's are
temperature average temperature minimum
temp maximum temperature the amount of
precipitation amount of snow wind
direction wind speed
the pressure so
um average you know air pressure uh air
pressure
uh
the wind gusts
so uh after wind speed we have wind
gusts air pressure and the last one is
uh time in the Sun so you know how many
minutes of sunlight
would you get
and these are really good I I picked
these because it might be useful
you know you could things like wind
speed you know plan your uh
uh wind turbines and where where to put
them uh time in the sun plan for your
solar panels and where to put them
so
I have these to remind me and then the
reminder change start and end date time
and you know point we're going to use
this a lot so what arguments is this
expecting Point latitude longitude
meters above the ground
so now we have these notes you know
maybe you set this up for yourself and
you don't use it for a while and then
you forget you know
what you can what variables you can use
so all this you know we can just keep
the same
um I just have the notes here so because
you have
from numpy we're going to import mean
because we're going to use that
and then the rest of these
are from you know the medio stat Library
we definitely want daytime plot and for
Medio stat
we're going to just import these couple
things
also it's just
it's useful with the documentation in
you know that here's the website where
all the documentation is you know put
that in there as a comment
again just like the other notes for
yourself or for other people
good to keep track of these things so
now we know what we're expecting we can
set the time period
and what I wanted to do is I just picked
you know some time you know one month in
the summer
start and end so I have eight time there
we go year month day your month start
and end and
so the person who put out this one
example online
um
did this for Vancouver so
you know I just commented that out and I
did one for Philadelphia
and I picked a random point in the
middle of the city because it the uh if
you want to click places and you get
latitude and longitude you get a lot of
decimal places so I just wanted to round
it to two decimal places and see where
you know you know in Philadelphia in
general and then rounded to two thousand
places and see where we got so it's a
some random uh Street Corner in the city
and remember that third argument is how
many meters above the ground so I put 10
because this could be
um a wind turbine you know on top of a
building
and I wanted to compare this to
somewhere in the suburb so
you know are the closely uh packed
buildings does that affect wind speed
well we're still talking 10 meters above
the ground so
um this is in you know residential
neighborhood that is probably above all
the buildings
but I picked a point in the suburbs and
I picked a point that seemed to be like
a relatively open field
as something to compare
so now I have these two points
and
I can get this daily data
so daily so that's the function in
in meteostat and there we go I get this
particular point you know these are the
arguments that point and then start time
and end time
and then we go to this daily data dot
Fetch and I'm going to store it as my
data
now
we want to take this
my data
and which one do I want I want wind
speed for this one and remember our
function dot two numpy and I'm going to
store that
so now num data is my array and you see
the these layers that we want to do this
Library requires
this function here I'll store that as a
variable now that variable uh dot fetch
that's also from mediostat I'll store
that
but then I that's not a numpy array so I
want to make that a number I want to
take that
calculate you know wind speed that
column and make that a numpy array
so I'll print that you know City mean
equals and I wanted to get the mean
to compare so now I have the second one
again I'll do the same thing that daily
function
fetch the data
convert it to a numpy array and in this
case I'll do the suburbs mean but
remember
um num data and num data 2 they're my
two numpy arrays so I can use them to
plot
so we can plot the line plot the line
there we go
and
so I have this
you know these two things I have you
know
the x value is
since I know that I made my
since I know that I made my start and
end time you know 30 you know 30 days
I wanted to make the x value
there you go same thing 1-31
uh 31 instances because it include the
first one
so there we go and then I can plot these
wind speed and run it
all right now I'll tell you why I have
that commented out I'll tell you now
that I have these because this works
like uh I wanted to again connect it
with
the same type of plot you know matplot
library that we use
um I wanted to connect it to that same
matplot library that we've been using
and show you that that's what you can do
you know get those arrays and plot them
here
plot.show but I commented this out this
works also just a unique feature of this
Library
um
you can just take that my data Dot Plot
and then in parentheses you know what
the Y value is so these two work
um so I just wanted to show you I'll
leave them in there they work but in
order to connect this with the same type
of math and plotting we're using I
plotted them this way
and so I had it calculate and then just
display you know the city mean and
suburbs mean
I could have rounded it but
and quite honestly this is why we do
data analysis this totally surprised me
I really thought the average wind speed
in this suburban area that was like a
relatively open field would have been
significantly higher and it was
definitely higher in the city
yeah interesting
um maybe you know a little bit of a
tunnel effect maybe there is some
something going on with uh
you know the buildings maybe that wasn't
high enough also uh at least in
Philadelphia that City and if it's high
enough that's a little bit closer to the
river Delaware River is you know any
River gives off a little bit more wind
and this was a little bit closer so that
might have had an effect
but there we go so then we see the mean
but beyond that we can see
the tracking you know day to day and
you know there's still these two points
that I picked are not that far apart so
it tracks they're in the same area the
wind speeds go up and down you know in
very similar patterns
but we see that not just the mean but at
every single point that City location
was higher
so there we go
and
you know we could take a look now I made
this so that's good and we can just pick
that and we can pick like any number of
days so I could
since all the rest is already in there I
could just pick this and say well what
about
um over the course of the year
so maybe I make that like one one
and maybe I make that 12
31.
and
there we go so
if it would include
then
um there we go so 365.
and
365. so
I want to graph it this way so from 1 to
and 365 points if that doesn't line up
perfectly then
I might have to do one more or one less
but we can take this and we can run this
oh value error
and it was
365 357.
oh that's really interesting
all right
so
357.
and
three
57.
and so we can see you know the
scattering but also I liked this
now why
what what I picked was uh you know not
365 days that seemed like that would be
it
um I'm not really going to overthink
that right now maybe there were some
days that were missing
um
but
you know maybe that some sometimes that
happens we go and we can uh go through
and you know take out missing
information or incomplete information
but now we take a look that over so the
the day that I picked happened to be
slightly lower than average
so in both it was up a little bit you
know
14 miles an hour eight miles an hour and
then we can see the patterns here
so if this was wind speed you know the
average
then
what you could do is you know
you could count based on that average
you actually don't need to plot it out
because it works out given the given
those averages
um you can work on that so if your wind
speed
is you know in the city and it's you
know almost it's like 14 miles an hour
throughout the year then
you can look up well what size wind
turbine and it would be actually
relatively small but what size wind
turbine
you know
would you need for 14 mile an hour winds
and you can do some calculations given
that size of the turbine how much
electricity would that generate for you
over the course of a year
yeah so pretty cool
and again you can you know you can do
that with you know any other aspect of
this the temperature you know maybe you
know you're trying to plan something you
know you can get you know temperatures
just one other thing I did just was you
know different so I ca I Loop it through
for you know a month
just to show you and and all the rest of
this is the same documentation link and
what I did is I just made it a loop so
you know range one to eleven
um
and so that would be the month
and I have you know what month
um there we go
and
you know there we go I think I picked
just this
because I thought oh well is that is
that change and these monthly loops
um
yeah the way that the x value displays
sometimes it seems like a little cut off
but we can see we have you know wind
speed and we can just see you know a few
different months over the course of it
um
and you see each month I have the mean
and then and then the graph
so we can just see it's just interesting
um
you know the mean and the graph for each
month
the display
this might be a little clunky this might
just be for your own
interest or you could have something
that displays them all in some nice
little you know three by four
the grid it gets to be small graphs
though but nonetheless
we see
that there's times when the
when it goes down so
I just wanted to show you some of these
things that you can do with this with
this with this graph
and
yep beyond that
that there's other ways and what you can
do
in you know any other
data you find if you you know you're
looking up some things you might find
them maybe it's a CSV but maybe somebody
you know put together an entire library
and with that they not only have the
data and then that's stored somewhere
but you know somebody also wrote These
functions so that you have all these
already how can I get a point
and how can I get all this different
data from any of those points
so
things that you can make and things that
you can find online that somebody else
made you know different ways that you
can find this data and then graph it
so trying to give you some more tools
now you know now that you know math and
Python and can use this to graph you
know some more tools and some more
sources of data
so what I want to show you here is just
a few more things that you can do right
within collab and
we already looked at over here on the
left the
table of contents that you can get to
appear disappear
then we have the search you could even
search for directly for variables here
and then we have this folder icon where
you can click to Mount Your Google drive
directly
and then once you do that then you can
also say give it permission
and down here we see it's mounting the
Google Drive
once you do that
then you'll see it as the slash through
it now so you can unmount the Google
drive if you want if if you wanted to do
that so this makes it easy to find
things and move things back and forth
within your Google Drive
then the really big thing down here is
the look at these tags you can get all
these code Snippets that are already in
the Google collab you see adding form
from Fields oh I want to add a form
get the code right here you can copy it
or even click it you know if you happen
to be right in the place where you want
to put it you click insert
all these other things camera capture
and notice this even
um uses JavaScript within python
interface is this so it's pretty cool
um again all these
and some of these you know downloading
files
um you from Google Drive from GitHub all
kinds of things
um importing libraries that you know
that aren't in code Laboratory
all of these zipreader there's a lot of
other things that you can do open files
from GitHub from your Google drive from
your local file system how you can just
upload those so
it even gets down in here into pandas
data frame and that's kind of where we
want to get our math skills too that we
can take data from wherever well that's
the pandas part and then bring it in and
then do some different math to it what
can I graph can I display it in
different ways and that's what we want
to take this uh to so what I'm going to
do is you'll see below this video
there's
other code that I'll include but I'm not
going to go through every one of these
but check these out I mean there's so
many different things already built into
collab that you can you can do you know
open up a sample you know and Tinker
with it I I have a collab notebook I
just call it code tester and I just have
different things that I can go through
and you know let's try this let's try
that and then you know you put together
in your notebook of stuff that works but
here's all these things available and
then I'm gonna
put together another collab notebook of
just a few other things you know to
tackle on this CL end of this class to
continue
you know some things that you can do
with math and with code and you know
we're building upon this leading to you
know working with data and doing some
other interesting things with that so
check these out and you know Tinker with
them and enjoy
wow you made it so
now having gone through this now you
should have
a good understanding of algebra you
should be familiar with all the key
Concepts
and how to write the code to do all of
your algebra you should have
your at least one or however you
organized it collab notebook that's
ready with all of your scripts for
solving all different sorts of algebra
problems
you
made it through certification one two
and three
and
you have the ability to solve a lot of
different problems and you know write
the code or reference code you've
already written to solve these problems
so there you go you should be you should
be all set this is the foundational math
because it is the math that we're going
to use and that you'll be able to use
for
so many other things in math including
data science data science we're going to
bring up formulas like this functions
like you've been working on you know
algebra level solving some graphing
so now you have an understanding of all
that and then you can apply it to other
things
for yeah statistics data science and
a few other subjects too
so
if you continue on with the next step we
we will do a pre-calc trig
um
that type of topic so
you know some other deeper understanding
of other graphs we didn't get to in in
algebra because they're a little bit
different other sorts of patterns
dealing with
locations of of things and circles and
more angles and a lot of triangles so
that'll be something that we'll do next
and again that's going to also build to
help you with statistics and data
science because
as you represent data on graphs or
use different sort of mathematical
analyzes to see relationships among data
points you know the deeper math will get
you to be able to detect
more and more complex relationships
among data
so this is the foundation
I feel like you have a good foundation
hopefully you're feeling the same and
there we go you made it and onto onto
the next adventure